hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor exam pro bringing you another
complete study course and this time it's
the aws certified cloud practitioner
made available to you here on free code
camp and if you think you've seen this
course before that's because this is a
major update from the very popular
2019-20
course that had over 2 million views and
this time around we have three times
more content so this course is designed
to help you pass and achieve it was
issued certification and the way we're
going to do that is by going through
lecture content doing labs in our own
account utilizing a practice exam
downloading the cheat sheets on the day
of the exam and then once you pass you
can improve on your resume and linkedin
you have that either business knowledge
to get that cloud job or to get that
promotion to tell you a bit about me i
was previously the cto of multiple
edtech companies with 15 years industry
experience five years specializing in
the cloud i'm ava's community hero i
publish multiple free cloud courses i
love star trek and coconut water and i
just want to take a moment to thank
people like you because it's you that
make these free courses possible and if
you want to know how to support more
free courses like this one the best way
is to buy or extra study materials and
so for this course it's at exam pro dot
co four slash clf hyphen c01 this is
where you'll get study notes flash cards
quizlets downloadable lecture slides
downloadable cheat sheets uh prax exams
you can ask questions and get support
and i also just want to tell you if you
do sign up you're going to get
additional stuff
already so you'll get the free practice
exam and cheat sheet there's no credit
card required required and there's no
trial limit so there's no reason not to
sign up
and if there are course updates check
the description in the youtube to see if
there are any updates okay so there
might be corrections additions
modifications and this is just going to
ensure that you're using utilizing the
latest version of this course and so to
keep up to date with upcoming courses
follow me on twitter at andrew brown and
if you are over there i'd love to hear
if you have passed your exam and what
you'd like to see next so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're at the start of our journey
asking the most important question first
which is what is the aws certified cloud
partitioner so the cloud partitioner is
the entry level aida certification
teaching cloud fundamentals such as
cloud concepts architecture deployment
models it will take a close look at
database core services a quick look at
the vast amount of data services and
will cover topics like identity security
governance billing pricing support of
aws services the course code for this
exam is the clf c01 but it's commonly
referred to as the ccp
and aws is the leading cloud service
provider in the world and that makes the
certified cloud petitioner the most
common starting point for people
breaking into the cloud industry no
matter what their path is
so who is this certification for well
you should be considering the aws cloud
partitioner if you are new to cloud and
need to learn the fundamentals if you
are in the executive management or sales
level and you need to acquire strategic
information about cloud for adoption or
migration
or you are a senior cloud engineer or
solutions architect who needs to reset
or refresh their aws knowledge after
working for multiple years and just
seeing how the landscape has changed
so what value does this certification
bring well the aws certified cloud
practitioner provides the most expensive
view possible
of cloud architectures and advanced and
when we're talking about that expansive
view what you should be thinking about
is
it being a bird's eye view or a 50 000
foot view
looking onto a panoramic landscape where
you can see everything and the idea of
this expansive view is to promote big
picture thinking so the idea here is
you're zooming out and assessing the
cloud it was landscape for changes
trends opportunities and being strategic
about the approach and process for our
cloud journey
the innovations cloud practitioner is
not a difficult exam it will not
validate that you can build cloud
workloads for technical implementation
roles like a developer engineer
devops role it will not be enough to
obtain a cloud role but it can help
shortlist your resumes for interviews
the exam covers content not found in
other certifications and it is
recommended as an essential study for
your aws journey
so now let's take a look at the awesome
certification roadmap to see where we
would go after the cloud petitioner and
what kind of uh cloud roles
would be associated with those
certifications so at the start you get
your cloud practitioner which is at the
fundamental level after that we have the
associate level such as the sysop
administrator the developer and the
solutions architect followed by the
professional level the devops engineer
the solutions architect professional and
then the specialties such as security
advanced networking database machine
learning data analytics and sap which
just is not on here yet because it's
such a new certification so after the
cloud practitioner generally people will
go for an associate and it's up to you
to choose one of the three
because they're all great routes but the
most common one is the solutions
architect associate
because the most common role in the
industry is a cloud engineer so even
though it's called solution to architect
they really should have named it cloud
engineer because that is really what it
is uh if you were to go the developer
route you're basically becoming a cloud
developer and then if you are going the
sysops admin route you are becoming a
junior devops engineer
and it's not uncommon for people to
obtain all three associates and a lot of
times the order will be the solution
architect first because it's the easiest
and and has the broadest services
followed by the developer
um which adds uh
practical programming skills and um
life cycle stuff of like deployment for
apps followed by the sysops
administrator which is considered the
hardest of the three in the associate
tier
from there you can go for the solutions
architect professional and that would be
associated with a solutions architect or
cloud architect role that's basically
like a harder version of the cloud
engineer with a lot more
responsibilities if you were going to
devops route you'd go for the devops
engineer professional and so this would
open you up to roles such as the devops
engineer or the site reliable
reliability engineer an sre
and some people like to get both of the
professionals
and that could be if you want to be a
cloud architect or devops engineer
because having adjacent skills and the
professionals is always very useful now
you don't have to go for a professional
after the associate a lot of people will
jump over to the specialties and so when
we're looking at the solutions architect
you basically have any pic after that
but generally what i see are people
going for data analytics or machine
learning so for data analytics this
would be if you want to be a data
analyst
or if you're doing machine learning this
is where data scientists will go through
the solutions architect route
okay
for the junior devops you could jump
over to security and become a
cloud security engineer if you want to
go into devsecops so the automation of
security operations you probably want to
get the devops engineer um or you may be
if you're after the devops engineering
you might be transitioning to the
advanced networking for roles like in
netdevops where you're specializing in
migration or hybrid
engineer for architectures that both use
on-premise and the cloud from the devops
engineer position you can still go for
the database or machine learning
certification if you want to become
either a data engineer or an ml ops
engineer so there's a lot of
opportunities here
and there is no perfect route but just
these are suggestions for you to decide
on your own okay so how long is it going
to take to pass this certification well
it's going to really depend on your
background but if we had to generalize
it we can look at it uh as kind of a
scale and so if you are at the beginner
level you're looking at 30 hours of
studying and when we say beginner we're
saying someone that has never used aws
or any cloud provider i have never
written code or held a tech role and
when we're looking at the other side of
it someone that is experienced we're
looking at a six hour study time and
when i say that i'm talking about
somebody that's watching on two times
speed and are able to absorb this
information uh very quickly so they have
practical working experience with aws or
they have equivalent experience in
another cloud service provider like
azure gcp where they can translate that
knowledge or they have a very strong
background in uh technology where
they've worked in the industry for many
years and so you know their study time
is going to be a lot shorter
and so on average most people are going
to take about 24 hours to study for this
course and when we talk about the kind
of stuff that you'll be doing it's going
to be 50 lectures and labs and we call
our labs follow alongs where the idea is
you follow along in your own account and
then 50 is the practice exams so if you
look at the length of the content which
is around uh 12 hours then you know you
should expect to spend as much time
doing practice exams uh to pass okay and
the rem recommended time to study is one
to two hours a day for 14 days okay
so what kind of effort are we going to
have to put in to pass this exam well
you have to watch the lecture videos and
memorize key information you'll need to
do hands-on labs and follow along with
your own account and you will need paid
online practice exams that simulate the
real exam and the last two here were
things that i used to never suggest
because you could literally just watch
the videos and pass however edibus has
made this exam a lot more difficult and
so for these last two points you do have
to do these two things for the paid
online practice exams uh that can be a
hard for some people so i've made it
easier for you by providing you a full
free practice exam on exam pro at four
slash clf c01 and so you just have to
sign up no credit card required and
you'll get a full set of 65 questions
that simulate the real exam okay
so for the contents of the exam it is
composed of four domains and each domain
has its own weighting which determines
how many questions in the domain that
will appear so for domain one which is
cloud concepts we're looking at 26
percent for domain 2 security and
compliance we should expect to see 25
percent of the questions from there for
domain 3 which is technology and where
we will see the most amount of questions
that we're sitting at 33 percent for
domain four billing and pricing we have
16 of the exam there so just to
emphasize for domain 3 you need to know
a wide range of services but you also
need to know
in-depth the core services
so where do you take the exam well at an
in-person test center or online from the
convenience of your own home aws is
partnered with two different test center
networks the first being psi and the
second being pearson vue and they both
offer in-person or online and these
exams are proctored meaning there is
somebody watching you to ensure that you
are not cheating okay
in order to pass this exam you have to
score 700 points out of a thousand and
so 700 generally equates to 70 percent
but it's around 70 percent because aws
uses scaled scoring meaning that they
could adjust it based on how many people
are passing or failing so always aim to
uh get higher than 70 percent the exam
contains 65 questions 50 scored and 15
unscored and you can afford to get about
15 questions wrong there is no penalty
for wrong questions so you should always
choose an answer and the questions come
in two formats multiple choice and
multiple answers for these unscored
questions there are 15 on the exam they
will not count towards your final score
why is there unsword questions on the
exam well unscored questions are used to
evaluate the introduction of new
questions
they can determine if the exam is too
easy and the passing score or question
difficulty needs to be increased and
they can discover users who are
attempting to cheat the exam or steal
dump exam questions so if you encounter
questions you've never studied for that
seem really hard keep your cool and
remember they may be unscored questions
the duration of this exam is 1.5 hours
so you have about 1.5 minutes per
question the exam time is 90 minutes but
the seat time is 120 minutes seat time
refers to the amount of time you should
allocate for the exam so that means
including things like time to review
instructions show online proctor your
workspace read and accept the nda and
complete the exam and provide feedback
and when you do pass this exam is valid
for 36 months and that equates to three
years before re-certification
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i'm on the aws certified cloud
partitioner page because what i want to
show you here is the exam guide if
you're wondering how to book your exam
you go to schedule exam there and that's
the way you can do it but if you scroll
on down there's this download exam guide
and this will download a pdf that will
tell you everything about the exam and
so just make note of the course code
this is the clf c01
because if this exam has a major major
change they'll call it the co2 okay and
then you'll know that this exam might
not fit for the new uh
the new exam guide okay so if we scroll
on down there is a basic introduction
they'll say you have to have six months
which is totally not true you can get in
the cloud with no experience uh and uh
be passing this exam within two to three
weeks so you can just kind of ignore
that so it will just state that there is
multiple choice multiple responses also
known as multiple answer there are 50
questions of the exam with 15 unscored
questions so you'll get 65 questions in
total
uh it's scored between 100 to 1000. the
passing grade is 700 it explains about
scaled scoring there then it goes onto
the course our content outline where we
have the four domains and it has a big
breakdown of all the things that could
appear on the exam and the thing about
this is is that um
you know there's only 65 questions but
there if you break down all these points
there's like three times more
information than could possibly show up
on the exam so just understand that you
are going to be studying a lot of
information but only one third of it's
going to show up on your exam so what i
did is i went through every single one
of these things and i made sure that we
are covering them some stuff i just
never saw an exam and also other people
i never saw were design principles um i
mean they are generally covered in the
well architected framework but it's
unusual because some of the things in
here i just feel they aren't actually on
the exam and they just kind of cram this
exam guide together but i was very
thorough to make sure to add everything
here um so for security and compliance
it's just knowing a collection of um
database security services and some
security concepts
for technology this is our largest
section you need to know so much stuff
but we spent a lot of time in the course
just covering technology then you have
your billing and pricing and you could
also say support
and so that covers a lot of interesting
thing a lot of stuff around ec2 pricing
and then they just have a big list of
stuff so this is a bit a bunch of
random
technologies and concepts that might be
covered and then they talk about
services and so again we cover basically
everything just in case for you
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what we're looking at here is a free
practice exam that i provide with you uh
for this course and all you have to do
is sign up on exam pro you don't even
need a credit card and you can redeem uh
the free available content here and this
is really up to date and very well
simulates what you will see on the
actual exam and it's a full set full 65
questions so you're getting a real
simulation here but what i'm going to do
is just start it off here we're not
going to do the whole thing i'm just
going to click through and show you a
couple of them so you have an idea um
the level of difficulty these questions
are so the first question we got
presented with here is which support
plans provide access to the seven core
trusted advisor checks and so that is a
question that you might need to answer i
don't want to spell this for you so i'm
not going to tell you the answer i will
go to the next one so a large accounting
firm wants to utilize aws to store
customer accounting information in
archive storage and must store this
information for seven years due to
regulatory compliance which database
service
meets this requirement so the first one
you'll notice this one is multiple
choice or sorry multiple answers so you
have to select multiples before you can
submit your answer
and the next one here is just a single
choice so those are the two types of
questions you will see on the exam
they're not going to ask you anything
about coding you're not going to see any
kind of code
in terms of length that's pretty much
what we'll see in terms of the questions
i think in many cases i wrote a little
bit more more like um in the style the
solutions architect associate to make it
slightly more difficult just so that
you're a little bit over prepared so if
you do well on these practice exams
you're going to do a well on the real
exam okay so i just wanted to kind of
get you that exposure there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
asking the most important questions
first which is what is cloud computing
so cloud computing is the practice of
using a network of remote servers hosted
on the internet to store manage and
process data rather than a local server
or personal computer and so when we're
talking about on-premise you own the
servers you hire the i.t people you pay
or rent the real estate you take all the
risks but with a cloud provider
someone else owns the servers someone
else hires the it people someone else
pays or rents the real estate and you
are responsible for configuring cloud
services and code and someone takes care
of the rest of it for you okay
[Music]
so to understand cloud computing we need
to look at the evolution of cloud
hosting going all the way back to 1995
where if you wanted to host your website
or web app you'd have to get a dedicated
server so that would be one physical
machine dedicated to a single business
running a single project a site or an
app
and as you can imagine these are
expensive because you have to
buy out write the hardware have a place
to store it the network connection
having a person to maintain it
but it did give you a guarantee of high
security
and they still do as of today so this
model hasn't gone away but it's been
specialized for a particular use case
then came along the virtual private
server so the idea is we still had one
physical machine but now we were able to
subdivide
our machine into submachines via
virtualization and so essentially you're
running a machine within a machine and
so you had better utilization of that
machine
running multiple web apps as opposed to
having a physical machine per project so
you got better utilization and isolation
of resources
and so
these two options still required you to
purchase a machine a dedicated machine
and so that was still kind of expensive
but then came along shared hosting and
so if you remember
the mid-2000s like with godaddy or
hostgator or any of those sites where
you had really cheap hosting the idea is
that you had this one physical machine
shared by hundreds of businesses and the
way this worked it relied on tenants
under utilizing their resources so you
know you wouldn't have a sub machine in
there but you'd have a folder with
permissions that you could use
um and so you would really share the
cost and this was very very cheap
but you were limited to whatever that
machine could do and you were very
restricted in terms of the functionality
you had and there was this poor
isolation meaning that you know if one
person decided to utilize the server
more they could hang up all the all the
websites on that single server then came
along cloud hosting and the idea is that
you have
multiple physical machines that act as
one system so this is distributed
computing and so the system is
abstracted into multiple cloud services
and the idea is that you basically get
the advantages of a lot of the things
above so it's flexible you can just add
more servers um it's scalable it's very
secure because you get that virtualized
isolization you get it extremely at a
low cost because you're sharing that
cost with the users where in the shared
hosting it might be hundreds of
businesses we're looking at thousands of
businesses and it was also highly
configurable because it was a full
virtual machine now
cloud actually
still includes all of these types of
hosting they haven't gone away but it's
just the idea that you now have more of
a selection for your use case uh but
hopefully that gives you an idea uh what
cloud hosting looks like and it really
has to come down to distributed
computing okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and before we talk about aws we need to
know what is amazon so amazon is an
american multinational computer
technology corporation headquartered in
seattle washington and so this is the
seattle skyline with the space needle
and amazon was founded in 1994 by jeff
bezos and the company started as an
online store for books and expanded to
other products
so as you can see this is jeff bezos a
long time ago and he has this
interesting spray painted sign and his
desk is held up by cinder blocks and it
looks like his uh desk is like an old uh
table or something and he's working
really late and he used to be a
millionaire at this time and he would be
driving into work in his honda accord
because you know he just his motivation
was always to put all the money back
into the company so it really shows that
he worked really hard and it did pay off
because amazon has expanded beyond just
an online commerce store into a lot of
different things
such as cloud computing which is amazon
web services digital streaming such as
amazon prime video prime music they
bought twitch.tv they own the whole
foods market grocery store they have all
this artificial intelligence
they own low orbit satellites
and a lot more stuff it's hard to list
at all and so jeff bezos today is not
the um the ceo it's actually andy jassy
is the current ceo of amazon he was
previously the ceo of aws so jeff bezos
can focus on space travel so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at amazon web
services and this is the name that
amazon calls their cloud provider
service and it's commonly referred to
just as aws so here is the old logo
where we see the full name and here is
the new logo but i like showing the old
logo because it has these cubes which
best represent what aws is and it is a
collection of cloud services that can be
used together under a single unified api
to build a lot of different kinds of
workloads so aws was launched in 2006
and is the leading cloud service
provider in the world i put an asterisk
there because technically
aws existed before 2006 and a cloud
service provider
which is what aws is is often
initialized as csp so if you hear me
saying csp i'm just saying cloud service
provider okay
so just trying to look at the timeline
of when services rolled out the first
one came out in uh 2004 and was simple
queue service sqs and this service still
exists as of today but at the time it
was the only service that was publicly
available so it wasn't exactly a cloud
service provider at this time and it was
neither aws it was just sqs but then a
couple years later we had simple storage
service also known as s3 which was
launched in march of 2006 and then a
couple months later we had elastic
compute cloud also known as ec2
and ec2 is still
like the most used service within aws
and is like the backbone for pretty much
everything there
then in 2010 it was reported that all of
amazon.com's retail sites had migrated
to aws so even amazon was using aws full
steam and to support industry-wide
training and and skill standardization
it was began offering a certification
program for computer engineers on april
and this is the type of certifications
that we are doing as we speak um so i
just want you to know that aws was the
one leading uh cloud certifications and
we just want to take a look here at the
executive level as of today the ceo is
adam he's the former cto of tableau and
he spent a decade with aws as a vp of
marketing sales and support so he was
there he had left for a bit and now he
is back then we have uh werner and he's
the cto of aws he's been uh the cto for
pretty much
the entire time it was existed with the
exception of some time of the first year
he's famous for quoting everything fails
all the time and then there's jeff barr
who's the chief evangelist so um if
you're ever wondering who is writing all
the blog posts and talking about databus
it's always jeff barr okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do here is
expand on what is a cloud service
provider also known as a csp just
because there's a lot of things out in
the market there that might look like a
csp
but they actually are not so let's go
through this list and see what makes a
csp so this is a company which provides
multiple cloud services ranging from
tens to hundreds of services those cloud
services can be chained together to
create cloud architectures those cloud
services are accessible via a single
unified api so databases cases that is
the aws api
and from that you can access the cli the
sdk the management console those cloud
services utilize metered billing based
on usage so this could be per second per
hour
vpcus memory storage things like that
those cloud services have rich
monitoring built in so you know every
api
action is tracked and you have access to
that so in aws's case it's ableist
cloudtrail
and the idea here is those cloud
services have infrastructure as a
service offering so iaas that means they
have networking compute
storage databases things like that
those cloud services offers automation
via infrastructure as code so you can
write code to set everything up and so
here's just kind of an example of an
architecture where we have a very simple
uh web application running on ec2 behind
the load bouncer with the domain with
rough d3 but the idea is just to show
you that you know you're chaining these
things together if a company offers
multiple cloud services under a single
ui but do not meet most or all of these
requirements it would just be referred
to as a cloud platform so when you hear
about twilio or hashicorp or databricks
those are cloud platforms and aws azure
gcp are cloud service providers okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the landscape
of cloud service providers and the
industry likes to break these down into
three tiers so we have tier one so this
is top tier
these were early to market they have a
wide service offering they have strong
centers used between services and
they're well recognized in the industry
and in the leading spot is amazon web
services and there's no surprise to this
because they were the first to develop
the technology and so they pretty much
dominated the market for multiple years
before anyone entered and so it's going
to be very hard for anyone to catch up
or even overtake them but right behind
them is microsoft azure then we have
google cloud platform and these three
are known as the big three because
they're the most used around the world
and we actually have a fourth one that's
in the tier one and that's alibaba cloud
you might not know about it just because
it really is based in mainland china and
in the asia region so it is really big
but it's just the fact that there's that
divide between mainland china and the
rest of the world okay
you have tier two so these are the
mid-tiers so at one point you know they
could have been topped here but um you
know they were just slow to innovate and
so they had to turn to specialization
but they're all backed by well-known
tech companies have been around for a
long time well before aws existed so we
have ibm cloud oracle cloud or rackspace
and so rackspace is offering is actually
their software called openstack which
allows you to run a cloud service
provider-like environment uh on your
on-premise okay
and so you know these are still in use
so oracle cloud what they usually do is
they try to fight on price and ibm cloud
they they fight on ai and ml uh
solutions against the top tier then you
have the uh tier three the light tier
and so these were virtual private
servers that turned to offer core iias
infrastructure as a service offerings
and so they're simple and cost effective
and a lot of people that are getting
into cloud or even just trying to deploy
apps are probably using these and not
realizing their cloud service providers
so we have a
vulture digital ocean and lynnoids so
they started with a single offering just
virtual machines then they added a load
balancer and so they're starting to get
more so like digitalocean i think is
getting a serverless
offering and then linoid
or sorry
vulture is getting a kubernetes managed
service and so you know they kind of
live in this realm of are they csps and
i would classify them as they are i
would say they are a tier three they're
just a light tier and i'm sure they'll
expand their services to have more of
the core but they're just going to stay
i think very small in general okay
[Music]
so how do we know who is the leader in
the market well all comes down to the
madric quadrant and this is a series of
market research reports published by it
consulting firm gardner that rely on
proprietary
qualitative data analysis methods to
demonstrate market trends such as
direction maturity and participants
people take these
graphs very seriously and so
this is what it looks like and as you
can see amazon web services is marked as
the leader and the closer you are to
this
top corner here is the better you are
off as you can see microsoft is not too
far behind followed by google then
followed by alibaba cloud then by oracle
ibm tencent which we don't uh ever talk
about and then there's the other ones
that just don't show up because they're
so small like digital ocean and linoid
there so generally that gives you kind
of an idea how the market is growing and
stuff like that um but as you can see
you know there's still
a lot for the other ones to do to catch
up to aws okay
[Music]
so a cloud service provider can have
hundreds of cloud services that are
grouped into various types of services
but the four most common types of cloud
services for infrastructure as a service
uh and i call these the four core would
be compute so imagine having a virtual
computer that can run applications
programs and code networking so imagine
having virtual network defining internet
connections or network isolation between
services or outbound to the internet
storage so imagine having a virtual hard
drive that can store files
databases so imagine a virtual database
for storing reporting data or a database
for general purpose web applications and
aws in particular has 200 plus cloud
services
and i want to clarify what cloud
computing means because notice that we
have cloud computing cloud networking
cloud storage cloud databases
but the industry
often just says cloud computing to refer
to all categories even though
it has computer in the name so just
understand when someone says cloud
computing
they don't just generally mean the
subcategory they're talking about all of
cloud okay
[Music]
so awes has a lot of different cloud
services and i just want to kind of go
quickly over the types of categories
that we can encounter here and just
mention the four core so any csp that
has ias will always have these four core
service offerings we have compute so
nato s this would be ec2 vms storage
this could be something like ebs virtual
hard drives database so that could be
rds sql databases networking and content
delivery but really it's networking uh
and this would be vpc so private cloud
network okay so
uh let's just look at all the categories
that are outside the four core so there
could be analytics application
integration ar vr it was cost management
blockchain business application
containers customer engagement developer
tools and user computing game tech iot
machine learning management governance
media services migration
and transfer mobile quantum technologies
robotics satellites security identity
and compliance if there was more i would
not be surprised but you can see there's
a lot of stuff that's going on here
[Music]
so let's take a look at all the services
that are available to us so if you're on
the marketing website which is
adabus.amazon.com
what you'll see in the top left corner
is products and so these are all the
categories and for whatever we want if
it's like ec2 we can go into here
and we can read all about it so usually
we'll have our overview all right and
that's not very useful and then we'll go
over to features and so this is can be
kind of useful to get some basic
information and pricing which is
something you'll do a lot in aws is
you're always going to be going to a
service and looking up its price and so
you'll make your way over here every
single one is different a very important
page would be like getting started so
this will give you basic information but
what i do is i like to go all the way
down to the bottom here and find my way
over to the documentation so i'll go
here to documentation to get that deeper
knowledge about that service and as you
can see things get pretty deep with aws
in terms of the information they have so
hopefully that gives you an idea of the
scope also when you're logged into aws
and this will be when we create our
account
you can explore all the services this
way as well so these are all the awesome
services
but you just notice that there's two
ways to explore them where this is
actually you just actually utilizing the
services and then the marketing website
is you reading about them and learning
all about them okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the evolution of
computing your cloud service provider
has all of these offerings and the idea
is that you need to choose the one that
meets your use case a lot of times this
all has to come around the utilization
of space that's what we're trying to
illustrate here in this section here and
the trade-offs of why you might want to
use some of these offerings okay
for dedicated we're talking about a a
physically a physical server wholly
utilized by a single customer that's
considered single tenant
and uh for google cloud we're talking
about
single node clusters and bare metal
machines where you have control of the
virtualization so you can sell any kind
of hypervisor or virtualization you want
the system the trade-off here though is
that you have to guess up front what
your capacity is going to be and you're
never going to 100 utilize that machine
because it's going to have to be a bit
under in case the utilization goes up
that's you choosing the cpus and the
memories you're going to end up
overpaying because you're uh you'll have
under underutilized server uh it's not
going to be easy to vertically scale
it's not like you can just say resize it
because the machine you have is what you
have right you can't add more i mean i
suppose they can insert more memory for
you but that's a manual migration so
it's very difficult um and replacing the
server is also very difficult okay so
you're limited by the host operating
system it's not virtualized so whatever
is on there is on there
and that's what your apps are going to
have access to
if you decide to run more than one app
which is not a good practice for these
kind of machines you're going to end up
with resource sharing where one machine
might utilize more than the others
technically with a dedicated machine you
have a guarantee of security privacy and
full utility of the underlying resources
i put an asterisk there because yes it's
more secure but
but it's up to you to make sure that
it's more secure so you have that's up
to your skills of security right whereas
if you had a virtual machine or anything
above that there's more responsibility
on the cloud service provider to just
provide a circuit secure machine and
they can do a better job than you so why
would you use a dedicated machine well
maybe you're doing high performance
computing where you need these machines
like very close together and you have to
choose what kind of virtualization you
need to have okay
so then we're looking at virtual
machines the idea here is you can run a
machine within a machine the way that
works is we have a hypervisor this is a
software layer that lets you run the
virtual machines uh the idea here is now
it's a multi-tenant you can share the
cost with multiple customers you're
paying for a fraction of the server uh
you'll still end up overpaying for the
unrealized virtual machine because a
virtual machine is just like you have to
still say how many vcpus how much memory
and your app is you know you don't want
an app that uses 100 right you want to
use exactly the amount you need but you
can see here you know there's still
going to be some underutilization
uh you're limited by the guest operating
system now but now it's virtualized so
at least it's very easy to uh
possibly migrate away if you choose to
run more than one app on a virtual
machine it can still run into resource
sharing conflicts
it's easier to export or import images
for migration it's easier to vertically
or horizontally scale okay and virtual
machines are the most common and popular
offering for compute because people are
just very comfortable with those then
you have containers and the idea is you
have a virtual machine running
these things called containers the way
they do that is similar to a hypervisor
but instead you have um like here is a
docker demon so it's just a um
a container uh software layer okay to
run those containers there's different
kinds docker is the most popular
and the great thing is you can maximize
the uh the capacity because you can
easily add new containers resize those
containers use up the rest of the space
it's a lot more flexible okay
your containers will share the same
underlying os but they are more
efficient than multiple vms
multiple apps can run side by side
without being limited by the same os
requirements and not cause conflicts
during resource sharing so containers
are really good but you know the
trade-off is there a lot more work to
maintain
then you have functions
functions go even step further and the
idea is that you uh the the containers
where we where we talked about that's a
lot of work to maintain now the cloud
service provider is taking care of those
containers generally sometimes not it
depends if it's serviced or not but the
idea is that you don't even think about
this is called service compute but you
don't even think about
uh the os or anything you just know that
what your runtime is you run ruby or
python or node and you just upload your
code and you just say uh i want this to
be able to run
for this long
and use this amount of memory okay
you're only responsible for your code
and data nothing else it's very cost
effective you only pay for the time the
code is running
and vms only run when there is code to
be executed but because of that there is
this concept of cold starts and this is
uh where the virtual machine has to spin
up and so sometimes requests can be a
bit slow so there's a bit of trade-off
there but functions or serverless
compute is generally one of the best
offerings as of today but most people
are still getting kind of comfortable
with that paradigm okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the types of
cloud computing and the best way to
represent this is a stacked pyramid and
we'll start our way at the top with sas
also known as software as a service so
this is a product that is run and
managed by the cloud service provider
you don't have to worry about how the
service is maintained it just works and
remains available so examples of this
and actually uh the first company to
coin this was actually salesforce uh
then there's things like gmail office
365 so i think microsoft word excel
things like that and they run the cloud
okay and sas is generally designed for
customers in mind
then came along platform as a service
also known as pass and these focus on
the development or sorry the deployment
and management of your apps so you don't
worry about provisioning configuring or
understanding the hardware or operating
system
and so here we'd have things like
elastic beanstalk heroku which is very
popular among developers that just want
to launch their code or google app
engine and that is the old logo but
that's the logo i like to use because i
think it looks cool and so these are
intended for developers the idea is that
you just deploy your code
and the platform does the rest
then there is infrastructure as a
service
there's no way to say that like it's
easy to say sas or pass but there's no
easy way to say iaas
so this is the basic building blocks for
cloud it it provides access to
networking features computers and data
storage space and the idea here is you
don't worry about the it staff data
centers and hardware and so that would
be like microsoft azure aws
oracle cloud things like that and these
are for administrators okay so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at cloud
computing deployment models starting
with public cloud and the idea here is
that everything when i say everything
i'm talking about the workloads the
projects the code is built on the cloud
service provider so here is a diagram
where we have a ec2 instance a virtual
machine running our application and then
we have our database in rds and we have
the internet coming into our aws account
and so everything is contained all of
our infrastructure is within aws all
right
and so this is known as being cloud
native or cloud first and i put an
asterisk beside cloud native because
that was a term uh that was uh used
prior to classroom providers to refer to
containers or open source um
models being deployed and being mobile
other places so just understand that it
has two meanings but in the context of
this cloud native just being like native
to the cloud like using cloud to begin
with okay
then we have private cloud so everything
built on a company's data center uh and
being built on a data center is known as
being on premise because that is where
the data center resides near where you
work
and so here you could be using cloud but
you'd be using openstack which would be
a private cloud so here we have our
on-premise data center and the
internet's coming into our data center
and we're running on openstack where we
can launch virtual machines and a
database okay
then there's the concept of a hybrid
cloud so using both on-premise and a
cloud service provider together and so
the idea here is we have our on-premise
data center and then we have an
established connection maybe it's a vpn
connection maybe it is a direct
connection um but the idea is that we're
bridging that connection and utilizing
both our private and our public uh stuff
to uh create a cloud workload then there
is a fourth one called crosscloud
sometimes it's known as multi-cloud
and sometimes it's erroneously referred
to as hybrid cloud but it generally is
not uh hybrid cloud okay the idea here
is when you're using multiple cloud
providers and so one example here could
be using services like azure arc so
azure arc allows you to extend your
control plane uh so that you can deploy
containers for kubernetes in
azure
within amazon eks within gcp kubernetes
engine but you know being cross cloud
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
running a
using a service that used works across
the cloud and manages it it could just
mean using multiple providers at the
same time
another service that is similar to azure
arc but is for a google cloud
platform is also known as anthos
aws has traditionally not been um
cross-cloud friendly and so we haven't
seen any kind of developments there
where we see uh these other services
that are or cloud service providers
behind aws trying to promote it to
grab more of the market share okay
[Music]
so let's talk about the different
deployment models and what kind of
companies or organizations are still
utilizing uh for these particular
categories so for cloud again this is
where we're formally utilizing cloud
computing hybrid is a combination of
public cloud and on-prem or private
cloud and then on-prem is deploying
resources on-premise using
virtualization resource management tools
sometimes called private cloud or it
could be utilizing something like
openstack so for companies that are
starting out today or are small enough
to make the leap from a virtual private
server to a cloud service provider this
is where we're looking at cloud so we're
looking at startups sas offerings new
projects and companies so maybe this
would be like base camp dropbox
squarespace then for hybrid these are
organizations that started with their
own data center but can't fully move to
cloud due to the effort or migration or
security compliance so we're talking
about banks fintech investment
management large professional service
providers legacy on-prem so maybe cibc
which is a bank deloitte
the ccp or cpp investment board
and then for on-premise these are
organizations that cannot run on cloud
due to strict regulatory compliance or
the share size of the organization or
they just have like an outdated idea of
what cloud is so they just have a lot of
difficulties in terms of politics
adopting cloud
so this would be public sector like
government super sensitive data like
hospitals large enterprise with heavy
regulation insurance companies um so
again hospitals maybe aig the government
of canada
and so i shouldn't say that they aren't
using cloud but um
you know because uh aws and all the
cloud providers have um uh public sector
offerings so
um you know i'm just trying to stage as
an example of things that could be still
using on-premise so you know i know the
government canada definitely uses uh
cloud in a lot of ways same with aig and
hospitals but you know generally these
are the last holdouts of on-prem because
there really isn't a a good reason to be
fully on premise anymore
but again there are some things that are
still doing that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
creating ourselves an aws account so
what you need to do is go to
aws.amazon.com
if you don't have a lot of confidence
how to get there just type in adabus
into google and then click here on the
link where it says adabusamazon.com
it'll take you to the same place now
notice we have a big orange button in
the top right corner so it says sign
into the adwords console
it's the if it's the first time you've
ever been to this website so if i go to
adabus.amazon.com
incognito it will have the create
enables account button
i don't know why they don't keep this
consistent across the board but i wish
they did but if you are on the screen
you can click here or there um but if
you do see something that doesn't say uh
you know create an account or or et
cetera you can just sign in
okay and then down below you can hit
create a new aws account so that's the
way you're going to get in there and so
you're going to put an email a password
and create a database account name
i've created this so many times and it's
so hard to set up new emails i'm not
going to do this again it's not
complicated but one thing i need to tell
you is that you do need to have a credit
card you cannot create an account
without a credit card um and for those
who are in places where maybe you don't
have a traditional credit card maybe you
can get a prepaid one so up here in
canada we have a company called coho and
so coho is
a visa debit card and so it's basically
a virtual prepaid credit card and so
these do work on the platform as well so
if you have a traditional credit card or
possibly could find one of these you
still have to load up with money but it
does give you a bit more flexibility to
create that account so
what i want you to do is go through that
process yourself it's not complicated
and i'll see you on the other end okay
[Music]
so once you've finished creating your
account you should be within the adwords
management console and this is the page
you're always going to see when you log
in it's always going to show the most
recent services here
and you'll notice in the top right
corner that i have my account called
exam pro if you're wondering how do you
change that name what you do is to go to
my accounts here and once there you'll
have your account settings up here if
you go to edit
you can change that name here okay so
you know sometimes when you create your
account you don't like the account name
that you gave it and so that's your
opportunity to fix it
but once we're in our account what i
want you to do is immediately log out
because i want you to get familiar with
the way you log into aws because it is a
bit um different than other providers
and so i don't want you to
get hung up later on with your account
so i've logged out i'm going to go ahead
and log back in so you can click the
orange button or what i like to do is
drop down my account
and go to aws management console
it's a lot more clear and you'll notice
we're going to have two options root
user and iam user so
this is what i'm talking about for the
confusion so when you log into your root
user account you all are always using an
email and when you're logging as an
imuser you're actually going to be
entering the account id or account alias
but what we'll do is go to the root user
and this is the email you use to sign up
with the account so for me
i
called this one andrew plus sandbox at
exam pro dot co i'm gonna go to next
sometimes you get this character box
it's very annoying but it happens time
to time and so what i'm gonna do is just
go ahead and type that in
okay and hopefully it likes it and then
i'm just going to enter in my password
all right
and i'll be back into my account and so
notice it takes me back to about
management console so the root account
is not something we want to be generally
using except for
very particular use cases and we do
cover that in the course but what i want
you to do is go set yourself up with a
proper account and so
what we'll do is go to the top here and
type in iam and this stands for identity
and access management and we'll click on
iem here
and on the left hand side we're going to
see a bunch of options here
and so notice right away we get to the i
am dashboard where it's going to start
to make some recommendations for us the
first one is always to add mfa
multi-factor authentication
another thing you can do is set an
account alias so you can see that i've
set one here prior so if i just go ahead
and remove it the way we'd have to log
in is via the account alias
which is the same as the account id and
so i don't really like that so i can
just rename it to deep space nine
and these are unique so you have to pick
something that is unique to you so it
could be your company name or things
like that it's gonna make it a lot
easier to log in
when we create our additional user here
so we'll come back to mfa at some point
here what i want you to do is go over to
users and go ahead and make yourself a
new user
and so i'm going to call this one andrew
brown
and i'm going to enable programmatic
access i'm going to enable aws
management console so this one's going
to allow me to use the apis to
programmatically work with aws and this
one here is going to allow me to just
log into the console which is pretty
fair here so now that i have this we can
auto generate it or give it a custom
password i'm just going to auto generate
it for the time being and here it says
you must create a new password at the
next sign in which sounds fair to me
and we go ahead and create ourselves a
new group so it's pretty common to
create a group called admin and notice
here this is where we're going to have a
bunch of different policies so the first
one here which is admin and access
provides full access to able services
and resources and this pretty much gives
you
almost nearly almost the same
capabilities as the um aws root user
account
and so that's going to be okay because
we are an admin in our account so i'll
check box that on but i just want to
show you here if you drop down filter
policies and you went to invest manage
job functions these are a bunch of
pre-made
aws
policies that you could apply
to different users so what's really
popular after the administrator access
is to usually give the power user access
and so this one allows
a user to do basically anything they
want with the exception of management of
users and groups so you know it could be
that that's something that you'd want to
do for some of your users i just don't
want to have any trouble so i'm going to
give us
admin access here and we're going to go
ahead and create this group
and so here is the group that we are
creating we're going to go next we can
apply our tags if we want i'm not going
to bother we hit next review and then
hit create user
all right and so now what it's doing is
it's showing us the access id and the
access key secret that we can use to
pragmatically access aws and then
there's a password here so i'm going to
go ahead and show it and what i'm going
to do is just copy this into a clipboard
anywhere
and so i'm just copying that off screen
here because i'm going to need it to log
in and i'm just going to remember my
username as well alright and so what
we'll do is go ahead and hit close
so what i'll do is go back to my
dashboard here and remember i set my
account alias as deep space 9 but we
could also use the account id to log in
i'm just going to grab my account id off
screen here and what i want to do now is
go ahead and log out and now log into
this im user and this is the one that
you should always be using within your
aws account you shouldn't be using your
root user account so what i'll do is go
over to i am user here and notice now
that it says account id so 12 digits or
the account alias so here i can enter in
these numbers here or i can enter in my
alias which is deep space 9 and again
you'll have to come up with your own
creative uh one there for yourself and
we'll go ahead and hit next and so
notice what it's going to do is now ask
me what my imuser name is so i defined
mine as andrew brown
and then we had an auto-generated
password there so that we had saw and so
i'm going to place that in there we'll
go ahead and hit sign in
and so now right away it's going to ask
me to reset the password so i'm going to
put the old password in there and so now
i need a new password i strongly
recommend that you generate out
your passwords to be very strong i like
to go to password generator and i'll
drop this down and i'll do something
really long like 48 characters and
if you don't like uh weird characters
you can take those out there sometimes
it loads here so you gotta try it twice
um and we're gonna go down to whoops 48
there we go and so that's pretty darn
long so i'm going to copy that off
screen here so i do not forget
and you probably would want to put this
in a password manager something like
dashlane or some sort of thing like that
and we'll go ahead and we will paste
that in and we'll see whoops i don't
want google to save it
and we'll see if it takes it and so
there we go so what i'll do is now log
out
and i'll make sure my new password works
because you really don't want to have
problems later so we'll type in deep
space nine
andrew brown again this is going to be
based on what your
what you have set
and we'll go ahead and log in and there
i am and so now notice that it doesn't
say
example or whatever it says andrew brown
at deep space nine so it's using the
account alias and showing the name and
that's how i'm going to know whether i'm
the root account user or whether i'm
logged in as an iam user all right
so there we go
[Music]
okay so now that we have the proper user
account to log in i just want to point
out
about regions so in the top right corner
you'll notice it says north virginia
here it possibly will say something
completely else for you but what you'll
do is you'll click and drop that down
and you'll see a big list of regions and
so sometimes when i log into aws it
likes to default me to u east uh us east
ohio but i honestly like to launch all
my stuff in u.s east north virginia even
though i'm in canada i probably should
be using the canada central region down
here
but the default region is going to be
based on your locality okay so just
understand that it might be different i
strongly recommend for
all of our follow alongs you run in u.s
east one because usc swan is the
original
the original region and it also has the
most access to aws services and some aws
services um such as like billing and
cost and things like that are only going
to show up in u.s east north virginia so
just to make our lives a lot easier
we're going to set it there but i want
you to understand that some services are
global services meaning that it doesn't
matter what region you're in it's going
to default to global and one example
could be cloudfront so if i jump over to
cloudfront here for a moment
and we do seem to have uh some
cloudfront distributions here from a
prior
follow along but notice up here that it
now says global so cleft front does not
require a region selection let's make
our way over to s3
all right and this one's also global so
again this one does not require a region
selection but if you go over to
something like ec2
okay this has a region dependency so
just be really careful about that
because a lot of times you'll be doing a
follow along and you'll be like why
aren't these resources here or whatever
and it's because this got switched on
you and it can happen at any time so
just be
cautious or aware of that okay
[Music]
so one of the major advantages of using
aws or any cloud service provider is
that it utilizes metered billing so that
is different from a fixed cost where
you'd say okay i want a server for x
amount of dollars every month but the
way nms works is that it's going to bill
you on the hour on the second based on a
bunch of factors and so you're going to
be able to get services at a lower cost
however if you choose an expensive
service and you forget about it or if
there's misconfiguration where you
thought you were launching something
that was cost effective but turned out
to be very expensive you could end up
with a very large bill very very quickly
and so
that is a major concern for a lot of
people utilizing cloud but there's a lot
of great toolings built into aws to
allow you to catch yourself if you
happen to make that mistake and before
we go ahead and learn how to do that i
want to show you
some place where you could end up having
excessive spend without knowing it so
one example and this is actually
happened to me when i first started
using aws
before i even knew about all the billing
tools is i wanted to launch a redis
instance and so you just have to watch
you don't have to do this but
elasticash is a service that allows you
to launch either a memcache or redis uh
database and i just wanted to store a
single value and so i went here and i
scrolled down it looked all good and i
hit create but i wasn't paying attention
because apparently it was like the
default the node type here to the cache
r6g.large all right and
you know you might think that a bus has
your best interest in play and most
services are pretty good they make sure
that they're either free or very low
spend but some of these and elastic is
an older service where they just have
these weird defaults so
um you know if we were to go look up
this the rg6
large
all right and look at its spend
all right and we would go over here
whoops
i think i went to the china one
but if we were to go over here and look
for that instance i'm just trying to
find it here for cost
this one down below
um this doesn't say pricing does it say
our pricing here
here it is so this one cost
um
this one costs about two cents per hour
it doesn't sound like a lot but if we go
here and we do the math we say 7 30 7 30
is the amount of hours in a month that
is 150
okay so if you don't know about that and
forget about that that's gonna be 150
and i'm going to tell you that it used
to be a lot higher i'm pretty sure they
used to have it defaulted to something
like
like this or that because i remember i
did this
and i had a bill that came in that was
like 3 000 usd dollars and i'm in canada
so like 3 000 usd is like a million
dollars up here and so i remember um it
was a big concern and i freaked out but
that was okay because all i had to do
was go to support
and what i had done is i went to the
support center
and i had opened a support case and i
just said hey i have this really big
bill so you go here right
and you look for billing
and
you look for something like charging
query or misspend and you say you know
um
you know like help
my bill's too high
and you just say like you explain the
problem saying hey you know i was using
elastic cash and it was set to a large
default and i wasn't aware about it can
you please give me back the money and
the great thing is that aws is going to
give you a free pass if it's your first
time where you've had a misspending they
generally will say
okay you know don't do it again and if
it happens again you will get billed but
go ahead and learn how to set up billing
alerts or things like that okay so just
so you know don't freak out if you do
have a really high bill you're going to
get a single free pass but now that we
know that let's go learn how to set up a
budget okay
[Music]
all right so now that we've had a bit of
a story about
over span for misconfiguration let's
learn how to protect ourselves against
it and we're going to go ahead and set
up a budget so go to the top here and
type in budget
and what that will do is bring us over
to the billing dashboard another way to
get here is to go click at the top here
and go to my billing dashboard and then
you'll see the left-hand menu here
and so the great thing about budgets is
that the first two are free it says
there is no additional charge for any of
his budgets you pay for configured use
usage but i'm pretty sure that that's
not true
because it used to be
abs budget reports okay so that costs
something
it used to be that aws budgets um after
subscription enabled will occur 10 cents
daily so in addition to budget monitor
you can add actions to your budgets
the first two action-enabled budgets are
free okay so just be aware that just
because it says there's no additional
charge read into it because sometimes
the fine line will tell you it does cost
something but i know that the first two
are free what we'll do is go ahead and
create a budget i'm going to close these
other tabs here since we have no need
for them and we're going to be presented
with a bunch of budget types
we're concerned about cost today so
we're going to go with a cost budget
and notice we can change the period from
monthly to daily to quarterly to
annually if you change it to daily um
you won't get forecasting so i don't
want that today but a monthly is pretty
good you can have a reoccurring which is
strongly recommended and then you can
put a fixed cost notice that i already
have some spend on this account so it
was like 25 bucks last month i'm going
to set it my budget here to a hundred
dollars
and you can add filters here to um
filter that cost out so if you want to
say only for this region or things like
that you could do that
uh notice that this is my spend over
here um so this is my budget and that's
the actual cost notice my cost has been
going up the last few months because
i've been doing things with this account
and so i'll do is say simple budget here
we'll hit next
and so now it's asking us if we want to
configure alerts we probably do so you'd
hit add alert and then you'd set a
threshold like 80 percent
or you could say an absolute value
and then you put in your emails like
andrew exam pro dot co
and i want to point out that this is
using um
it was sns
or it should be anyway so amazon sns has
no upfront cost based on your stuff here
so even though you're filling out an
email
you know
and maybe it doesn't show it but i'm
pretty sure that this would create an
sns
topic but what we'll do is hit next here
we have an alert so we're just
reviewing actually this is for attaching
any action so maybe we want some kind of
follow-up thing to happen here so we say
add action
and
uh
requires specific i am permissions on
your behalf
okay sure
so i guess you could follow up actions
that's no different than
um on a building alarm but we're not
really worried about that right now
i'm not going to bother with an action
we'll go ahead and create a
budget and so here it's going to say
that our budget is 100 it's going to
show us the amount used forecast amount
current budget sometimes this takes time
to show up so i'm going to hit refresh
and see if it shows up yet
there we go so notice we have forecast
amount 23 current budget etc forecasted
budget
uh forecasted versus budget so it's
pretty straightforward on how that works
i'm just curious if it actually created
an sns event so i'm going to go over
here
because a lot of services utilize sns so
if i go over here
default cloud watch alarm um
so i think this is something i had
created before so i'm gonna go ahead and
just delete it
so default cloudwatch alarms
actually i'm going to just click into
here and see what i have
confirmed
so i think it might have used this when
we created it but um the reason i'm
bringing up sns is that there's a lot of
services that allow you to
email yourself for alerts and it always
integrates with this service and so i
just want kind of want to point that out
so that you remember what sns is for
but yeah so setting up a budget is not
too hard so there you go
[Music]
all right so now that we've set a budget
what i want to talk to you about is the
free tier and the free tier is something
that is available to you uh for the
first 12 months of a new abs account and
allows you to utilize the services
without incurring any cost to you and so
it's in your advantage to utilize this
free tier
as you are experimenting and learning
cloud so if you want to learn about all
the offerings what you do is go to
google type in aws free tier and you'll
get this page that explains all the
sorts of things here so you can get
750 hours on ec2 rds things like that
there are stipulations in terms of what
it would be so here this is a t2 or t3
michael mic
micro running linux red hat
or other type of os's okay
so there are details you have to read
the fine print some services are only
available for the first two months
things like that so it's going to highly
vary based on service but it's worth
giving us a read in areas that you are
interested in now the thing is is how do
you know that you are still in the free
tier or you go outside of it and that's
what i want to talk to you about right
now so i am actually in another aws
accounts that knows in the top right
corner says brown.lap or hyphen laptop
exam pro dot co sometimes i will switch
into different abs accounts during these
follow along so i can best show you
um you know these settings so if you
make your way over to billing
and actually i should show you up here
if we go to my dealing dashboard just
trying to be consistent here and you go
to the left-hand side to billing
preferences what you can do is enable
receive free tier usage alerts and then
put your email in there and save that
and so turn on this feature to receive
email alerts a when your abs service
usage is approaching or exceeded
database free tier usage limits if you
wish to receive these alerts etc etc etc
right
and while you're there
i want you to also check box receive
billing alerts
so i can show you how to set a billing a
billing alert and adabas says you know
budgets are a new thing but billing
alerts are still something that we use
as of today so if you checkbox that on
we'll be able to see your cost if we go
back here
it should show you
um it's because i'm out of the free tier
on this account but it would show you in
the alerts you know your usage there so
example here is if we scroll down this
is the documentation tracking your image
free tier usage you would see like a box
like this and would say hey your free
tier usage limit is here and you're over
it okay so that generally would show up
on this panel here but again i'm outside
of the free tier so i'm not seeing it
here
today okay
so you know hopefully that is clear
um but yeah there you go
[Music]
all right so we created ourselves a
budget we're monitoring our free tier
but there's another way that we can
monitor our spend and that is through
building alerts or alarms and it is the
old way before we had it was budgets
this was the only way you could do it
but i still recommend it because there
is a bit more flexibility here with this
service and so i wanted to teach you
early on so that you know what's
available to you or if you want to play
around with it in the future so what
you'll do is go to the top here and type
in cloudwatch
and cloudwatch is one of those services
where it's actually a collection of
services so there's cloudwatch alarms
cloudwatch logs cloudwatch metrics those
are all individual services and animus
loves to update
their interface so sometimes you'll be
presented this option to
change the latest interface i'm going to
try out the new interface here
and that is one challenge with databases
you always have to expect that they're
going to change the ui on you and you're
going to work through it so just
understand that i try to keep my videos
up to date as best i can but part of the
challenge is getting used to that so
this is what they have today i don't
know if they're going to stick with this
but this is what it looks like but what
i want you to do is make your way over
to alarms on the left hand side
and notice that we actually have a
section just for billing which is
interesting i remember them having that
before so it's new so uh here it says it
was cloudwatch help can help you monitor
the charges of the spill remember that
we had to turn that on get 10 free
alarms with a thousand free email
notifications each month as part of the
free tier so understand that if you
create billing alarms they do cost money
um as well if you go over that limit but
you sure get a lot 10 free alarms is
quite a bit but we'll do is go ahead
here and create our sales alarm we're
going to go and choose a metric and so
here are the options we could choose
from and so we i think would like um
billing
and so we can do by service or total
estimated charge we're going to do a
total estimated charge we can only
select usd i've never seen any other
currency ever there and so here we kind
of get this little graph where we can
see stuff
but this is a lot more powerful than
budgets because you can do anomaly
detection uh so like here it will
actually check base between a range as
opposed to just going through a
particular value but what i'll do is
just set a value here like
fifty dollars right
so notice that it sets the line up here
and this is my current spend here right
and so back to anomaly detection this is
a lot smarter so
the idea is that if something is outside
this band of a certain amounts then it
would alert okay
but i'm going to go back here i'm just
going to set this to 50
and that looks okay to me you can change
the period six hours is fine um
there's additional configuration that's
fine as well we're going to go ahead and
hit next
and so the idea is that you know if it
passes that red line it will go to an in
alarm state and then what it will do is
uh we want to
have it to trigger an sns topic so i
would generally just create a new one
here and we'll just say my billing alarm
okay and then here we'll just set the
email
and your exam pro.co
and we'll go ahead and create that topic
and so that is now set i don't know if
it would confirm it we might have to go
to our email to confirm it so notice it
says pending confirmation so what it has
done is it sent me out an email and it
wants me to click that link to confirm
that i want to subscribe to it so i
might just do that off screen to show
you here okay
so i'm just going to pull up my email
here just give me a moment
okay and so if i come back here this is
the email that came in so i'm just going
to confirm that subscription says i'm
confirmed good
and if i refresh this page
we can now see that that is confirmed
all right
so we'll scroll down here so we can
trigger an auto scaling action so maybe
you know if you have too many servers
you say hey the cost is too much shut
down those servers there's ec2 actions
things like that so these are kind of
similar to
budgets right
they're system manager actions i imagine
all these things are available in
budgets as well but budgets just makes
it a little bit easier to look at so i'm
going to say my simple building alarm
here
we'll hit next
all right
we'll hit create alarm
and there you go so billy alarms don't
have like forecasting things like that
um but you know they are they do have
their own kind of special utility and so
i utilize both okay so there we go let's
go back to our management console move
on to the next one
[Music]
so one of the strongest recommendations
that abuse gives you is to say to set
mfa on your database root user account
so that's something we're going to do
right now so make sure you're logged
into the root user account so i'm going
to go log out as my im user i'm going to
go back and log in
and i'm going to log in as my root user
here so to do that no sometimes it will
be expanded as the imuser click and sign
into root user here we'll have root user
i'm going to go ahead and enter my email
that i used
and if you do switch accounts frequently
they will ask you these silly captchas
which drive me crazy but uh you know it
happens you probably won't encounter it
as much as i do and so i'm going to go
ahead and grab my password here and
paste it on in
and so now that i'm in what i want to do
is make my way over to iam
and i'm going to go and look for
users actually sorry just right here add
an mfa root user we're going to go ahead
and hit add mfa
all right so that's going to bring us to
this screen and so here we can activate
our mfa and so we have a few options
here so we have virtual mfa device u2f
security key other hardware like a
gem gym
gemalto token so you know i generally
use this because i have a security key
and i want to show you what i'm talking
about so this
is how i log into my machine or my aws
account
this is a security key an ubi key that
sits on my desk i tape it so it doesn't
fall fall off the cord but the idea is
that when i log in i have to press this
little button here to double confirm
before i get into my account but if you
don't have a security key you can just
use a virtual mfa and all that means is
you're going to
use something on your phone to log in so
we'll click continue here
and so it says install a compatible app
on your mobile phone or device and so if
you click and open this what it will do
is tell you about some things that you
can use
um so if we scroll down to virtual
here this suggests uh if you have
android iphone so authy dual mobile last
path microsoft authenticator google
authenticator so google authenticator
microsoft authenticator and authy i have
all those three installed um honestly
authy has the the nicest simplest
ui
but i'm using microsoft authenticate
authenticator quite a bit so anyway
whichever you want to do it's fine but
what we'll have to do is go back here
and then it says use your virtual mfa
app on your device camera to scan your
qr code so once you have one of those
apps installed like authy or whatever
one you want
what you're going to do is open up the
application and i can't tell you exactly
where it is but you'll have to hit add
account in your in your app and then
from there it will ask you to scan your
qr code and so
once you're ready you hit show the qr
code you hit scan the qr code on your
phone i'm holding my phone up to my my
um
my computer screen here and it's going
to find it and i'm just going to take a
moment here to rename the account so i
can tell what it is
so i'm just naming it aws
sandbox because that's what i call this
account
and i'm gonna go ahead and save that and
so now what i can do is enter uh two
consecutive mfa codes now this always
confused me what they wanted here but
the idea is that you're gonna see one
code
right whatever's on the screen right now
so i'm gonna type in it it says seven
and i'm going to wait
until the new code shows up
so there's like a timer in all these
apps and they go across the screen or
they count down and so you have to wait
for that to happen and so i'm just going
to wait here a little bit
and once i get the new number here this
one is zero seven one
five three zero i'm gonna hit assign mfa
and there we go and i can't tell you how
many times i like messed that up because
i didn't understand the consecutive
numbers but you're just waiting for uh
the number that's on the screen it
entered in and then entered the next one
in to turn on mfa and so now your
account is protected and every time you
log in you're going to have to enter in
mfa so let's log out and see what that
looks like
so we'll go ahead and sign in
and
again we'll put in our root user account
here we'll type in
74m32t
submit
and i need to go grab my password so
that's in my password managers just give
me a moment here
and now it wants the mfa code so this is
in my phone
and so i'm going to go enter it in so
this one says four seven five
eight four one all right we'll hit
submit
okay there we go so that's gonna happen
every single time we want to log in
i'm going to tell you that if you get
one of these they're so much easier to
use because you just press the button
okay so that's why i have this because i
cannot stand entering the code in time
and time again
but you know those are your options
there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of
innovation waves so when we're talking
about innovative waves we're talking
about chondrativia or k waves which are
hypothesized cycle-like phenomena in the
global world economy and the phenomenon
is closely connected with technology
life cycles so here is an example where
each wave is irreversibly changes the
society on a global scale and if you
look across the top we can kind of see
what they're talking about so we have
steam engine cotton
railway and steel electric engineering
chemistry petrochemicals automobiles
information technology
and so the idea is that cloud technology
is the latest wave and i'm not sure if
you'd fit web 3 in there as well ml ai
but maybe they're all part of the same
wave or their separate waves but
generally they're broken up based on
this p r d e here where it says
perspective recession depression and
movement uh improvement sorry and so
this is the common pattern of wave where
we see a change of supply and demand and
so if we're seeing this we know that we
are in a wave in where we are in a wave
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the concept of a
burning platform so burning platform is
a term used when a company abandons old
technology for new technology with the
uncertainty of success and can be
motivated by fear the organization's
future
survival hinges on digital
transformation and just to kind of give
you a visualization here is a literal
burning platform so imagine you have to
jump to it uh jump from it to make a
change so
um you know burning platform could be
you know
stop using on-prem and start using cloud
or maybe going from cloud to web 3
and that's generally the idea when we
talk about a burning platform
[Music]
so i just want to quickly show you that
digital transformation checklist that i
mentioned and the way you can get to it
is by typing in digital transformation
aws and so it should bring you to the
public sector page and here it is so we
click there and all it is is a pdf uh so
it's not news from 2017 but that doesn't
mean that it's not valid anymore uh it's
just that that's when it was made so we
scroll on down and we can see
transforming vision and so we have a
checklist there so if we click into this
uh we can see things like communicate a
vision of what success looks like define
a clear governance strategy including
the framework of achieving goals uh
build a cross-functional team identify
technical uh partners they talk about
shifting the culture and then down below
i assume that this one is related to
that one it's unusual because
you know they just have a checklist here
but then they have a sub checklist which
must be clear to that so reorganize
staff into smaller teams things like
that so it's not super complicated
you'll see each category go go cloud
native they'll have a checklist
um you know and if you are at the
executive level or the sales level or
trying to convince your vps and stuff
like that give this a read it might give
you something useful in the end
to help better communicate that
transformation for you okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the evolution of
computing power so what is computing
power it's the throughput measured at
which a computer can complete
computational tasks and so uh what we're
pretty much used to right as of these
days is general computing so a good
example here would be a zeon cpu
processor uh that's more of a high-end
processor not something you'd find in
your home computer but we're talking
about data centers specifically uh um
you know innovative data centers xeon
cpu processors are what you're going to
come across uh then came along a new
type of compute which is gpu computing
um when we're talking about google cloud
they have tensor computing and so this
is where i get the 50 times faster based
on that metric and so i didn't have an
exact metric here for aws as a solution
for this mid tier of computing power so
i just borrowed that 50 times there but
the idea is that gpu computing or tensor
computing is is 50 times faster than
traditional cpu and generally that's
going to be used for very specialized
tasks when you're doing machine learning
or ai so it's not something you're going
to be doing for your regular
web workloads but just understand that
all these fit so we're not getting rid
of general computing we're just adding
new levels of compute then there's the
latest which is uh quantum computing and
so here we have an example of the rigid
rig
right getty 16q aspen 4 and so it
literally looks like it's out of um
science fiction and this thing is like a
hundred million times faster it is super
cutting edge and we don't even know
exactly how it works and there's not
even anything that's very applicable
that we can use this for but the idea is
that we're not done with the evolution
of computing power things are going to
get a lot faster once we solve this last
one here
and so above service offering here would
be for general computing you're looking
at elastic compute cloud ec2 so we have
a variety of different uh instance types
and they're all going to have different
types of hardware with different types
of general computing
for gpu computing this is a specialized
chip that aws has produced called the
edibus and i don't know how to say it
but we'll just abbreviate it to infer so
aws infer chip
and this was designed as a direct
competitor to gcp's
tensor computing uh unit the tpu um and
so this is intended for ai ml workloads
but it works with not just um tensorflow
but it works with any
machine learning framework so that is
one advantage it has over uh tpus um and
then the last one here is aws brackets
so you can actually use quantum
computing as a service on your bus you
uh as of even today um the way aws is
able to do this is they work with
caltech so that's the california
technology university or institute i'm
not sure the name of it there
so it's not exactly aws producing this
but itabus is doing this as a
partnership to give quantum computing
accessible to you okay
[Music]
so i'm here in the aws console because i
just want to prove to you that you can
use quantum computing on aws it's that
accessible so all you'd have to do is go
to the top here type in bracket
and then you make it over to amazon
bracket and so here you can like set up
quantum tasks the first time you set it
up you've got to go through this process
here
i think i have to go through this
onboarding to be able to show you the
next step so i'm going to go ahead and
enable bracket in this abs account
okay and i'm not going to launch
anything i'm just going to try to just
kind of show you a little bit of what is
accessible to you because it's not super
exciting but the fact that you can do it
is kind of interesting so here i am on
the inside here and we have all these
different types of quantum computing so
d wave i know i i o n q
righty things like that and then down
below these are the quantum processing
units the q q p u's and then down below
you have the simulator so you can kind
of simulate uh these things here um so i
think that's kind of interesting
but in terms of the cost like if you
scroll on down here
um so it was bracket is part of that it
was free tier it gives you one free hour
of quantum circuit simulation time per
month during the first 12 months so
it's free to do a circuit simulation but
if you actually want to run it on the
actual hardware you can see the cost
there's the per task price the per shot
price things like that
what could you do with this i don't know
there's things called like quad bits or
something like that and i can't imagine
that you're going to be doing anything
useful but i think it's just more so
like you are sending out quad bits or
whatever they are and you're observing
them but what you can do with them i
have no idea but it's just exciting that
you can do that
i didn't have any spend just by
activating that i'm just kind of just
showing you there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the benefits of
cloud and this is a summary of reasons
why an organization would uh consider
adopting or migrating to utilizing
public cloud and so we'll quickly go
through the list here uh because in the
follow-up slides we actually go into
them a bit more detailed so we have
agility page ago economy of scale global
reach security reliability high
availability scalability um and
elasticity so the thing is is that eight
of us had this before it was called the
six advantages of cloud but they have
reworked it to include additional items
um and so where you see these uh sub
bullets here those are the original six
as you see one two three four five six
and so i kind of just put them where
they kind of fall under the new
categories there and you'll notice that
database has included high availability
elasticity reliability and security as
uh new ones here okay and so the thing
is is that
um i have always always even in my
original uh i think my original cloud
practitioner had cloud architecture as a
separate section and included all these
things in here so it's a great thing to
see that ableist has included it
but
in terms of how i organize this course
we're not going to cover them in this
section because i have the cloud
architecture section so just understand
that we will come to those eventually
and i would just say that aws is still
missing something on this list which is
fault tolerance so you know my list
looks like this except i would add fault
tolerance to it so you have everything
there
and disaster recovery okay so the
benefits of cloud is a reworking
expansion of the six advantages of the
cloud and we will look at the original
six advantages um and then look at
another one that is more of a
generalized one that i i've used across
my courses so that we fully understand
the benefits okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
six advantages to cloud defined by aws
and so these are still uh part of aws
marketing pages um but you know it's
interesting because you can't find the
benefits of the cloud in a single page
on any of this at least the time of
making this so there's a bit of
disconnect between the um exam guide and
the actual marketing material but that's
okay i fill it all in for you so you
know i'm just again noting that the
sixth advantage of cloud was the
original description for cloud benefits
and we'll go through them okay so the
first is trade capital expense for
variable variable expense so you can pay
on demand meaning that there is no
upfront cost and you pay for only what
you consume or you pay by the hour
minutes or seconds so instead of paying
for upfront costs of data centers and
servers the next is benefit from uh
massive uh economies of scale so
you are sharing the cost with other
customers to get unbeatable savings
hundreds of thousands of customers
utilizing a fraction of the server stop
guessing capacity so scale up or down to
meet the current needs
launch and destroy services whenever so
instead of paying for idle or
underutilized servers we have increased
speed and agility so launch resources
within a few clicks and minutes instead
of waiting days or weeks of your it to
implement the solution on premise we
have stopped spending money on running
and maintaining data centers so focus on
your customers developing and
configuring applications so instead of
operations such as racking stacking and
powering servers the last is go global
in minutes so deploy your app in
multiple regions around the world with a
few clicks provide low latency and a
better experience for your customers at
minimal cost the six advantages of cloud
still apply and i like to include them
here because they just have a different
kind of lens or
or or
angle when you're looking at this stuff
and so we've looked at the six
advantages of cloud and now let's take a
look at the next slide my reworking of
the sixth advantage of the cloud to be
more generalized okay
[Music]
all right i just wanted to show you
where that sixth advantage of cloud
computing comes from it's part of it it
was documentation so i typed it in here
and you can see that it is still around
and so it's unusual because this used to
be part of the marketing website it had
those nice little graphics
but for whatever reason it's over here
now in the overview of amazon web
services and by the way if you're
starting starting out with databus this
is a very light read but it is a good
read to get started with we obviously
cover all this stuff in the course um
but you know maybe you'll get something
different here but the idea is that it
was definitely expanded on this but for
whatever reason this documentation
hasn't changed so just understand that
i've polyfilled that for you in this
course okay
[Music]
all right so this is the seven
advantages to cloud i said six but i
meant to say seven and so um you know
since i've created fundamental courses
for all these cloud service providers i
started to notice kind of a trend and so
what i did is i normalized it into my
own seven advantages and this actually
maps up really well to the new benefits
of the cloud so it looks like invoice
was thinking the same as i was um with
the exception of those cloud architect
stuff which i keep in a separate section
but let's go through it and see what is
here so the first is cost effective you
pay for what you consume no upfront
costs on demand pricing so pay as you go
p-a-y-g with thousands of customers
sharing the on uh sharing the cost of
resources any of us used to refer to
this always as on-demand pricing and
azure always said pay as you go and so
it looks like aws now uses both
on-demand and pay-as-you-go to describe
them which is great um but there you go
then we have global so launch workloads
anywhere in the world just choose a
region it's secure so cloud provider
takes care of physical security cloud
services can be secured by default or
you have the ability to configure access
down to a granular level uh it's
reliable so data backup disaster
recovery data replication fault
tolerance it's scalable increase or
decrease resources and services based on
demand elastic so automate scaling
during spikes and drop in demand current
so the underlying hardware and and
managed uh software is patched upgraded
and replaced by the cloud provider
without interruption to you so i think
this is one that isn't on the benefits
of the cloud which is a really good one
um but uh yeah that's the seven
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at what is
able's global infrastructure so global
infrastructure is globally distributed
hardware and data centers that are
physically networked together to act as
one large resource for the end customers
so if you see here on the right hand
side we have a picture of a globe and
the idea is that we have a bunch of
these regions and these regions are
containing a bunch of data centers and
then you have those lines going in
between them which kind of represents
the network okay so the global
infrastructure is made up of the
following resources so they have regions
availability zones direct connection
locations point of presence so those are
pops local zones wavelength zones and
we're going to cover all of these in
this section here
and one thing i want to note is that
airbus has millions of active customers
and tens of thousands of global partners
that are constantly using this
infrastructure so you know that it is
rock solid okay
[Music]
all right so i'm over here on the global
infrastructure page if you type in aws
global infrastructure you'll make your
way here and so i just wanted to point
out that aws is always updating their
global infrastructure so these numbers
are increasing all the time but if
you're over here what you probably want
to do is make your way to regions and
azs so you can kind of see what's in
your area
so i'm in canada and we have canada
central region here and it has three
availability zones have launched in
2016.
you'll notice that it has a couple
asterisks if you scroll on down here
explain that it's in the montreal
metropolitan area so saying it's in the
downtown it's in the city uh that could
matter to you for whatever reason um but
just kind of pointing out where that
stuff is you can read about all this
stuff but of course we cover this all in
the course but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at above
regions and regions are geographically
distinct locations consisting of one or
more availability zone and so here is a
world map showing you all the regions
that abuse has in the world and the blue
ones represent regions that are already
available to you and the orange ones
represent ones that ableis is planning
to open so aws is always expanding their
infrastructure uh in the world so always
expect there to be more upcoming ones
every region is physically isolated from
independent of every other region in
terms of location power and water supply
and the most important region that you
should give attention to is u.s east one
uh in particular so this is northern
virginia it was italy's first region
where we saw the launch of sqs and s3 uh
and there are a lot of special use cases
where things only work in u.s east ones
and we'll find that out here in a moment
what i do want to show you is what it
looks like for an architectural diagram
when you are seeing a region so notice
that we have this
little flag here it says us east one us
west one and inside of it we have an ec2
instance so that is going to represent a
region in our architectural diagrams uh
but let's look at some of the facts here
and understand why u.s east or u.s east
1 is so important
so each region generally has three
availability zones and that is by
intention and we will talk about that
when we get to the availability zone
section some new users are limited to
two or uh to two uh but generally
there's always three okay new services
almost always become available first in
u.s east and specifically u.s east one
not all services are available in all
regions all your billing information
appears in u.s east one so that's a usc
one particular thing uh the cost of
aidable services vary per region and so
if you're on the marketing website or uh
for with global infrastructure you can
see uh
here in north america they'll say like
when it launched how many availability
zones and there might be some conditions
so you'll notice there's like asterisks
uh beside these things here or um in
this one particular there's an asterisk
saying hey there are three zones but
generally you're limited to two okay
when you choose a region there are four
factors you need to consider uh what are
the regulatory compliance does this
region meet what is the cost of this
enable service in this region what input
services are available in this region
and what is the distance distance or
latency to my end users and those are
those four factors that you should
remember okay
[Music]
all right so we just talked about adabus
regions now let's talk about uh how that
affects our services versus regional and
global services so regional services are
scoped based on what is set in the
database management console on the
selected region so you have this drop
down and that's what you'll do you'll
say okay i want to have resources in
canada or in europe
so this will determine where a native
service will be launched and what will
be seen within the airbus services
console you generally don't explicitly
set the region for a service at the time
of creation i explicitly mentioned this
because when you use something like gcp
or azure when you create the resource
that's when you select the region but
aws is it has this kind of global thing
which is unique to their platform
then there's the concept of global
services so some aw services operate
across multiple regions and the region
will be fixed to the word global and for
these that's services like s3 cloud
front row 53 iam
so the idea is if you were to go over to
cloud cloudfront and go into the
cloudfront console you'll notice that it
will just say global and you can't
switch out of that
for these global services at the time of
creation it's a bit different so we were
saying up here for regional ones that
you don't select the region but when you
are clearing global services if you're
using something like iam there is no
concept of region because they're just
globally available so you don't have to
determine
a subset of regions if you're using s3
bucket that has to be in one region so
you actually do have to select a region
at time of creation um and then there's
something like cloud form distributions
where you were choosing a group of
regions so you either say all of the
world or only north america which is
more like geographic distribution so you
don't say the region in particular but
you know hopefully that gives you a
distinction between regional services
and global services
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at availability
zones so availability zones commonly
abbreviated as a z and i'll frequently
use b using the term a z is physical
locations made up of one or more data
centers so a data center is a secured
building that contains hundreds or
thousands of computers and this is one
of my favorite graphics i like to show
of course uh you know aws would never
have a dog um in their data center but i
just thought that would be fun a region
will generally contain three
availability zones and i say generally
because there are some cases where we
will see less than three so there might
be two
data centers within a region will be
isolated from each other
so there will be different buildings but
they will be close enough to provide low
latency and that is within the
10 milliseconds or less so it's very
very low uh it's common practice to run
workloads in at least three azs to
ensure services remain available in case
one or two data centers fail and this is
known as high availability and this
generally is driven based on regulatory
compliance so a lot of companies uh you
know they have to at least be running in
three az's and that's why aws tries to
always have at least three azs within a
region uh azs are represented by a
region code followed by a letter so here
you know you'd have us east one which
would be the region and then the a would
represent the particular availability
zone in that region
um so a
subnet which is related to availability
zones is associated with
two availability zones so you never
choose an az when launching resources
you always choose a subnet which is then
associated uh two and a z a lot of
services um you know
don't even require you to choose a
subnet because they're fully managed by
aws but in the case of like virtual
machines you're always choosing a subnet
okay so here is a graphical uh
representation or a diagram that's
representing two availability zones so
here we have the region usc 1 and us
west 2 and then we have our 2az so here
is 1a and 1b and so these are
effectively the subnets okay
and so within those subnets then you can
see or availability zones you will see
that we have two virtual machines okay
so the usc s1 region has six azs and i
thought that's just kind of like a fun
fact because it is the most out of every
single one um i don't think anyone comes
close to usc 1 but of course it is the
most popular it is the first uh
region or so it's not a surprise that
that one has that many a
[Music]
okay so we just covered regions and
availability zones but i really want to
make it clear what they look like so i
kind of have a visual representation so
let's say we have our aws region and in
this particular one we have canada
central which in particular is montreal
so ca central one
and the idea here is that a region has
multiple availability zones so here you
can see that we have uh one a one b and
one d for some reason aws decided to uh
not launch one c maybe it's haunted who
knows you know
and then within your um availability
zones they are made up of one or more
data centers so just understand that az
is not a single data center but could be
a collection of buildings
and that these azs are interconnected
with high bandwidth low latency
networking they're fully redundant
dedicated to metro fiber providing high
throughput low latency networking
between so just very fast connections in
between
and all traffic between azs is encrypted
and these azs are within a hundred
kilometers so about 60 miles of each
other okay
[Music]
so what i want to do here is just show
you uh how regions and availability
zones work with some different database
services so you have a general idea when
you are selecting a region or a z and
when you're not so within aws when you
want to select a region you're going to
go up here and change it and this is
going to apply to regional services a
very famous example of a regional
service would be ec2 so we go over to
ec2 which is elastic
cloud computing or compute whatever
let's forget the name of it and what we
can do is go over to instances
i'm going to launch an instance i'm not
going to complete the process i just
want to show you
what would happen when you go select
some things here so i'm going to go with
amazon x2
we're going to just go to
next here and so here is where we're
going to select
our availability zone so up here we have
north virginia that's our region and
when i say we're selecting our
availability zone we're actually
selecting the subnet so so here we are
choosing a subnet and a subnet is
associated to a availability zone and
every single
um
region has a default vpc and that vpc
has
subnets set up and the subnets are
defaulted to each of the availability
zones available so usc 1 has six of them
so this server is going to launch in u.s
east 1b
so this is a regional service okay
then we have global services like s3 so
we go over to s3
and it says it's global right and so
we're going to go ahead and create our
bucket
and so here we choose the region so we
go down we're going to say the region we
want to be in but we don't choose the
availability zone because there's
nothing to um
choose because aws is going to run these
in
multiple azs and it doesn't matter to
you what it's doing there okay
so there's that and then there's
something like cloudfront so
cloudfront's a little bit different here
so we go over to cloudfront
and we create ourselves a distribution
um and so yeah if you don't have that
option there because sometimes database
has like a splash screen just click on
the left hand side then go to
distributions
okay and so here well they changed it
again on me they're always changing this
ui but if we scroll on down it should
allow us to change
um change where this is going to launch
it's like global stuff like that
literally they just recently changed
this and that's why i'm confused
ah we'll scroll on down here
it used to be
maybe it's under legacy
additional
customized
oh it's here sorry okay so notice here
the price class that says use the edge
locations for best performance north
america and europe north america europe
asia middle uh middle east and africa so
we're not choosing a particular region
we're picking a geographical area and so
those are pretty much the major um uh
examples of that uh then there's of
course things like in iem where you
don't even say where it is so you go to
i am
you know if i create something like a
group
over here a user group whoops
here
i say create group you know i'm not
saying oh this is for this particular
region or something like that okay
so yeah hopefully that makes sense
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's take a look here at fault
tolerance specifically for global
infrastructure and so before we jump
into that let's just define some fault
terminology here uh so let's describe
what a fault domain is so a fault domain
is a section of a network that is
vulnerable to damage if a critical
device or system fails and the purpose
of a fault domain is that if a failure
occurs it will not cascade outside that
domain limiting the possible damage and
so there's this very popular meme called
this is fine where there's obviously a
serious problem but the person's not
freaking out and i gave it some context
to say well the reason they're not
freaking out because they know that
there's a fault domain and nothing
outside of this room is going to be
affected okay
so you can have fault domains nested
inside of other fault domains
but generally they're grouped in
something called fault level so a fault
level is a collection of fault domains
and the scoping of a fault domain could
be something like a specific specific
servers in a rack an entire rack in a
data center an entire room in a data
center the entire data center building
and it's really up to the cloud service
provider to define those boundaries of
the domain it's abstracts it all away so
you don't have to think about it but
just to compare it against something
else when you're using azure you
actually define your fault domain so you
might say like okay uh make sure that
this workload is never running on the
same vm on the same rack for these
things uh and you know you might like to
have this level of control but i really
like the fact that it was just abstracts
it away i'm not sure how they segment
their uh their their fault domains but
they
definitely are some broader ones which
we'll describe right now so when we're
looking at an enables region
this would be considered a fault level
and then within that fault level you
would have your availability zones and
these would be considered fault domains
and of course those data centers can
have uh fault domains within them okay
like maybe you know they have everything
in a particular room and that room is
secure so like if there's a fire in that
room it's not gonna affect the other
room things like that
um so each amazon region is designed to
be completely isolated from the other
amazon region
they achieved this with the greatest
possible fault tolerance and stability
uh each availability availability zone
is also isolated but the availability
zone in a region are connected through
low latency links each availability zone
is designed as an independent failure
zone and so here we have some kind of
different language that database is
using
i've never experienced this terminology
in other any other cloud service
providers so i kind of feel like it's
something that it was made up but
basically a failure zone they're just
basically saying a fault domain but
let's kind of expand on their fault
failure zone terminology so availability
zones are physically separated within a
typical metropolitan region and are
located in lower risk flood plains
discrete uninterruptible power supply so
ups and an on-site backup generation
facilities uh data centers located in
different azs are
designed to be supplied by independent
substations to reduce the risk of an
event on the power grid impacting more
than one availability zone
availability zones are all redundantly
connected to multiple tier one transit
providers and we'll talk about what
those are
in an upcoming slide
and just one thing i want to note here
is that when you adopt multi-az you get
high availability so if an application
is partitioned across azs
companies are better isolated and
protected from issues such as power
outages lightning strikes tornadoes
earthquakes and more so that's the idea
behind you know why we want to run in
multi-az okay because of these fault
domains
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're talking about the global
network so the global network represents
interconnections between aws global
infrastructure and it's commonly
referred to as the backbone of aws so is
ec2 so just understand that that could
be used in more than one way but think
of it as a private expressway where
things can move fast between data
centers and uh one thing that is
utilized a lot to get data in and out of
aws very quickly is edge locations they
can act as on and off ramps to the abs
global network of course you can get to
the network through pops which we'll
talk about um you know in the upcoming
slides here but let's just talk about
edge locations and what services use
them so uh when we're talking about
things that are getting on to the
database network we're looking at things
like abus global accelerator aws s3
transfer acceleration and so
these use edge locations as an on-ramp
to quickly reach able's resources and
other regions by traversing the fast
away global network notice that the
names in it's a accelerator acceleration
so the idea is that they are moving
really fast okay
on the other side when we talk about
like an off-ramp we're looking at amazon
cloudfront which is a content
distribution network this uses edge
locations to as an off-ramp to provide
an at the edge storage and compute near
the end user
and one other thing that is kind of
always utilizing the global network are
vpc endpoints now these aren't using
edge locations but the idea here is that
this ensures your resources stay within
the aws network and do not traverse over
the public internet so you know if you
have uh you know a resource running in
u.s east one and one in uh eu it would
and they never have to go to the
internet it would make sense to always
enforce it to stay within the database
network because it's going to be a lot
faster so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at point of
presence also known as pop and this is
an intermediate location between a
database region and the end user and
this location could be a data center or
a collection of hardware so for aws a
point of presence is a data center owned
by aws or trusted partner that is
utilized by itabus services related for
content delivery or expedited upload so
a pop resource could be something like
an edge location or a regional edge
cache so as an example over here we see
an s3 bucket and it has to go through a
regional edge cache and then cut to an
edge location let's go define what those
are so an edge location are data centers
that hold cached copies on the most
popular files so web pages images and
videos
so that the delivery of the distance to
the end users are reduced then you have
regional edge locations and these are
data centers that hold much larger
caches of less popular files to reduce a
full round trip and also to reduce the
cost of transfer fees
[Music]
so to kind of help put pops more in
presence just in the general sense here
is a uh diagram i got from wikipedia
that kind of just shows a bunch of
different networks and notice where the
pop is it's on the edge or the
intersection of uh two networks so here
you know we have
um you know tier three and then there's
tier two and there's this pop that is in
between them okay
so tier one networks is a network that
can reach every other network on the
internet without purchasing iptransit or
paying for peering and so the innovas
availability zones or azs are all
redundantly connected to multiple tier
one transit providers okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at some
state of the services that are utilizing
pops or edge locations for content
delivery or expedited uploads so amazon
cloudfront is a content delivery network
service and the idea here is you point
your website to cloudfront so it will
write requests to the nearest edge
location cache it's going to allow you
to choose an origin so that could be a
web server or storage that'll be the
source of the cache and caches the
content of what origin would return to
various edge locations around the world
then you have amazon s3 transfer
acceleration this allows you to generate
a special url that can be used by the
end users to upload files to a nearby
edge location once a file is uploaded to
an edge location it can move much faster
within the aws network to reach s3
then at the end here you have aws global
accelerator you can find the optimal
path from the end user to your web
servers so global accelerators are
deployed within edge locations so you
send user traffic to an edge location
instead of directly to your web
application this service is really
really great for if let's say you're
running a web server usc 1 and you just
don't have the time to set up
infrastructure in other regions you turn
this on and you basically get a boost
okay
[Music]
this is andrew brown from exam pro and
let's take a look at it was direct
connect so this is a private or
dedicated connection between your data
center office co-location and aws and so
the idea here is imagine if you had a
fiber optic cable
running from your data center all the
way to your aws so that it feels like
when you're using your stuff on your
data center like your local virtual
machines that there's like next to no
latency okay so direct connect has two
very fast network connection options we
have the lower bandwidth which is at 50
to 500 megabytes per second and then you
have the higher bandwidth which is one
gigabytes to 10 gigabytes per second so
using direct connect helps reduce
network costs increase bandwidth
throughput so great for high traffic
networks it provides a more consistent
network experience than a typical
internet-based connection so reliable
and secure
i do want to point out the term
co-location if you never heard of that
before a co-location or a carrier hotel
is a data center where equipment space
and bandwidth are available for rental
uh to retail customers i do want to also
point out that even though it says
private up here and this is the language
that aws used i usually just say
dedicated but the connection is private
but that doesn't necessarily mean it's
secure okay so uh we'll talk about that
when we reach above vpns and how we can
use that with direct connect to make
sure our connections are secure okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at what a
direct connect location is so a direct
connect location are trusted partner
data centers that you can establish a
dedicated high-speed low-latency
connection from your on-premise to aws
so an example of a partner data center
would be one like here in toronto the
allied data center so you can tell
that's right down in uh the toronto
center and so you would use this uh uh
as part of direct connect service to
order and establish a connection okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at local zones
which are data centers located very
close to densely populated areas to
provide single digit millisecond low
latency performance so thinks like seven
milliseconds for that area so here is a
map of uh local zones that exist and
ones that are coming out i believe the
orange ones are probably ones that are
on their way and so to use a local zone
you do need to opt in so you gotta go
talk to aws probably open a support
ticket to get access to it the first one
to ever be launched was uh the la one uh
and so
um you know when you want to see it it
looks just like a
availability zone it's going to show up
under whatever region that is because
these are always tied to existing
regions so the la-1 is tied to u.s west
uh region and the az would look like u.s
west 2 hyphen la x hyphen 1a okay so
only specific ab services have been made
available so there's a particular ec2
types ebs amazon fsx application load
balancer amazon vpc
they probably have extended it to more
services do you need to know that for
the exam no but you know the point is is
that there's a limited subset of things
that are available the purpose of local
zone is to support highly demanding
applications sensitive to latency so
media and entertainment electronic
design and automation ad tech machine
learning so it kind of makes sense like
you look at la they're in the media
entertainment and so they're dealing
with lots of media content so it has to
be really low for them okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abus
wavelength zones and these allow for
edge computing on the 5g networks and
applications will have ultra low latency
being as close as possible to the users
so abus has partnered with various
telecom companies to utilize their 5g
networks so we're looking at verizon
vodafone kddi sk telecom and so the idea
here is that you will create a subnet
tied to a wavelength zone
and then and just think of it as like an
availability zone but it's a wavelength
zone and then you can launch your vms to
the edge of the targeted 5g network so
that's the network you're using aws to
deploy an ec2 instance and then when
users connect to you know those radio
towers those
cell towers they're going to be routed
to
you know nearby hardware that is running
those virtual machines okay and that's
all it is it's just it's just ec2
instances um but you know the advantage
here is that it's like super super low
latency okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at data
residency so this is the physical or
geographical location of where an
organization or cloud resources reside
and then you have the concept of
compliance boundaries so a regulatory
compliance so legal requirement by
government or organization that
describes where data and cloud resources
are allowed to reside and then you have
the idea of data sovereignty so data
sovereignty is the jurisdictional
control or legal authority that can be
asserted over data because its physical
location is within a jurisdictional
boundary and so the reason we care about
this stuff is that if we want to work
with the canadian government or the us
government and they're like hey you got
to make sure that you know if you want
to work with us all the data has to stay
in canada and you need to give them that
guarantee so data residency is not a
guarantee it just says where your data
is right and compliance boundaries are
those controls that are in place to say
okay this is going to make sure that
data stays where we want to be and date
of sovereignty is just like the idea of
the scope of the legal the legal stuff
that ties in with compliance boundaries
so how do we do that on aws well there's
a few different ways but um let's just
take a look at some ways that we can
meet those compliance boundaries one
which is very expensive but also very
cool is aws outposts so this is a
physical rack of servers that you can
put in your data center and you'll know
exactly where the data resides because
you know it's physical if it's in your
data center and you're in canada that's
where it's going to be okay
and i believe that you know there is
only a subset of aws services that are
available here but you know that is one
option to you another is using like
services for governance so like one
could be abs config this is a policy as
a code service so you can create rules
to continuously check database resource
configuration so if they deviate from
your expectations you are alerted or
image config can in some cases auto
remediate so if you were expecting you
know um you know you had an aws account
and you're saying this account is only
to be used for candid resources and
somebody launches let's say something in
another region then you could get an
alert or to tell it was config to go
delete that resource okay now if you
want to prevent people from doing it all
together that's where i am policies come
into play so these can be written
explicitly to deny access to specific
aws regions and you know this is great
if you're applying it to users or roles
but if you wanted to have it
organizational wide across all of your
abus accounts you can use something
called a service control policy that is
just an i am policy that is used within
its organizations that makes it
organizational wide okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at it for government
so to answer that we first have to
understand what is public sector so
public sector includes public goods and
government services such as military law
enforcement infrastructure public
transit public education health care and
the government itself so abus can be
utilized by the public sector or
organizations developing cloud workloads
for the public sector enables achieves
this by meeting regulatory compliance
programs along with specific governance
and security controls
so this could be i meet the requirements
with hipaa fedramp um cjis and fips okay
so amaz has a special regions or special
regions for us regulation called
govcloud which we'll talk about next
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at govcloud and
to understand what govcloud is we need
to know what fedramp is so fedramp
stands for federal risk and
authorization management program it's a
u.s government-wide program that
provides a standardized approach to
security assessment authorization
continuous monitoring for cloud products
and services so that we know what
fedramp is
what is govcloud well
and again it's not particular to aws
because azure has govcloud as well but
a cloud service provider like aws or
azure general will offer an isolated
region to run fedramp workloads and so
in aws it's called govcloud and these
are specialized regions that allow
customers to host sensitive controlled
unclassified information and other types
of regulated workloads so govcloud
regions are only operated by you by u.s
citizens on u.s soil they are only
accessible to u.s entries and root
account holders who pass a screening
process
customers can architect secure cloud
solutions that comply with fedramp uh do
the doj's
credible justice information systems uh
security policy the u.s international
traffic and arms regulation
export administration regulations the
department of defense cloud computing
security requirements and guides so if
you want to work with the us government
you want to
engineer and use govcloud okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at uh running
ada bus in china so eight of us china is
the ito's cloud offering in mainland
china enemies china is completely
isolated intentionally from adamus
global to meet regulatory compliance
from mainland china so that means that
if you make a workload on the awesome
global you can't
interact with it within the aws china
one okay it's basically treated like a
completely separate service like adabus
has its own chinese version uh and so it
was china is on its own domain at amazon
aws.cn and for everybody else that's
what's considered it is global so when
i'm using adabus from canada or use it
from the u.s or from india or from
europe or wherever that is the adabus
global okay
so in order to operate in aws china
regions you need to have a chinese
business license so icp license not all
services are available in china so
you will not have the use of route 53
and you might say well why not just run
in
singapore and it was global and you
could do that but the advantage of
running in mainland china means that you
would not have to traverse the great
firewall okay so all your traffic is
already within china so you don't have
to
deal with that airbus has two regions in
mainland china so uh there's this one
here which is the northwest region
operated by nswc
and then you have the one in beijing
north one operated by uh synnet so you
know itabus just could not meet the the
compliance requirements so they had to
partner with local providers uh or data
centers and so that is how that works
okay
[Music]
all right so i want to show you how you
get over to the
chinese database management console so
this one is
adabus.amazon.com that is the global one
for everyone outside of mainland china
but if you want to run resources uh on
data centers within mainland china this
is at amazon awesome.cn
and so it looks very similar if you go
to create a free account you're going to
fill in this stuff but notice that you
need to have your business registration
certificate uh and additional
information in order to run these data
centers down below that aws is partnered
with also notice that the logo doesn't
say aws in it and there's a good reason
for that if i type in aws trademark
china
inbus is actually banned from using the
aws logo in china uh for whatever reason
it's a weird reason if you ever want to
read about it but that's why you don't
see aws here all right
so yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at sustainability for
aws global infrastructure and before we
talk about that let's talk about the
climate pledge so amazon co-founded the
climate pledge to achieve net zero
carbon emissions by 2040 across all of
amazon's businesses which includes aws
if you all want to find out more
information go to
sustainability.about amazon.com there's
a lot of great information there and
you'll learn exactly how
uh aws is achieving this in particular
like their data centers it's very
interesting okay so aws cloud
sustainability goals are composed of
three parts the first is renewable
energy so eight of us is working towards
having their abs global infrastructure
powered by 100 renewable energy by 2025
and abbas purchases and retires
environmental attributes to cover the
non-renewable energy for abyss global
infrastructure
so they would purchase things like
renewable energy credits also known as
recs guarantees of origin so gos the
second point here is cloud efficiency so
abyss infrastructure is 3.6 times more
energy efficient than the medium of u.s
enterprises data centers surveyed so
that's going to really rely on that
survey surveys are not always that great
so you know take that with a grain of
salt okay then we have water stewardship
so
direct evaporative technology to cool
our data centers use of non-uh potable
water for cooling purposes so the
recycling water on-site water treatment
allows us to remove
us them to remove scale forming minerals
and reuse waters
for more cycles water efficiency metrics
to determine and monitor optimal water
use for each adibus region and you'll
find that water plays a large part on
making these
um
these data centers very efficient okay
[Music]
so i just wanted to show you where you
get to that sustainability information
so i just went to itabus global
infrastructure you click sustainability
and that's going to bring us over to
oops i have my twitter open there to the
sustainability in the cloud so if you
want to read a bunch of stuff here about
things that are going on that database
is up to see
how they are progressing with renewable
energy
there's cloud efficiency up here so you
know how they being efficient it's worth
the read to really understand that
there's a lot of water involved like
reducing water and data centers i
thought that was really interesting
um i mean they have native podcasts but
i don't think there's really much to it
a bi-weekly podcast of bite-sized
stories about how tech makes the world
better that's not necessarily a
sustainability podcast it's just the
endless podcast in general there's a
download center
um amazon's 2020 sustainability reports
so i guess you can download the reports
to see what is going on there so we
could download the progress here and see
what they've been up to
okay so there's a bunch of numbers
things like that okay very short reports
but hey at least you can download them
okay so just in case you're
very interested in sustainability all
right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abus ground
station so this is a fully managed
service that lets you control satellite
communications process data and scale
your operations without having to worry
about building or managing your own
ground station infrastructure and so
when we're talking about ground station
a really good way to cement what the
service is is just think of a big
antennae dish that's pointing to the sky
trying to communicate with satellites
because that's essentially what the
service is doing so the use cases here
could be for weather forecasting surface
imaging communications video broadcasts
and to use ground station the idea is
that you would schedule a contact so
that's where you're selecting a
satellite a start and end time in the
ground location and then you use an
abuse ground station ec2 ami and amazon
machine image to launch ec2 instances
that will uplink and downlink
data during the contact or receive
downlink data in an amazon s3 bucket a
use case could be something like you are
a company you've reached an agreement
with a satellite image provider to use
their satellites to take photos for a
specific region or time or whatever and
so the idea is that you are using aws
ground station to communicate to that
company satellite and download that as
that image data to your s3 bucket okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown and we are
looking at able's outposts and this is a
fully managed service that offers the
same ableist infrastructure services
apis tools to virtually any data center
co-location space or on-premise facility
for a truly consistent hybrid experience
and just to kind of summarize it it's a
rack of servers running aws stuff on
your physical location okay
so before we jump into the service or
technology itself uh let's talk about
what is a rack server or just a rack so
it's a frame designed to hold and
organize it equipment so here's an
example of a four to u rack
and there's a concept of rack heights so
the u stands for rack units or u spaces
uh with it equal to 1.75 inches and the
industry standard rack is a 4 8 u um so
that is a seven foot rack so um a full
uh size rack cage is commonly the four
two high
okay and uh in it you might have
equipment that is of different sizes so
there could be one u two u three u or
four u high so here's an example of you
know of an interior of a rack and notice
that like one u two u for u they're all
a little bit shaped differently uh but
they give you kind of an idea of um you
know what those are
so it's outpost comes in three form
factors the four to you the one you and
the two you so the uh the first one here
the four to you this is basically a full
rack of servers provided by aws so
you're not just getting the frame it
actually comes with you know servers uh
and so abs delivers it to your preferred
physical site fully assembled and ready
to be rolled into the final position it
is installed by aws and the rack needs
to be simply plugged in to the power and
network and there's a lot of details
about um the specs on this on the adabus
website so you know i'm not going to go
through them all here um then there are
servers that you can just place into
your existing racks so we have the 1u so
this is suitable for 19 inch wide 24
inches deep cabinets it's using it with
gravitron 2
cpus and you can have up to 64 virtual
cpus we have 128 gigabytes
4 terabytes of local nvm
storage um and then you have the u or
sorry the 2u
so suitable for 19 inch wide 36 inch
deep intel processors up to 128 virtual
cpus 256 gigabytes of memory eight
terabytes of local nvme storage so there
you go
[Music]
let's take a look at cloud architecture
terminologies before we do let's talk
about some of the roles that are around
doing cloud architecture so the first is
solutions architect this is a role in a
technical organization that architects a
technical solution using multiple
systems via researching documentation
and experimentation and then you have
the cloud architect this is a solutions
architect that is focused solely on
architecting technical solutions using
cloud services understand that in the
actual marketplace a lot of times
solutions architect is used to describe
both a cloud architect and a solutions
architect
and you know
these are going to highly vary based on
your locality and how companies want to
use these terms but this is just me
broadly defining them here so just don't
take them as a perfect word in terms of
what they're representing so a cloud
architect needs to understand the
following terms and factors
and factor them into their designed
architecture based on the business
requirements so we have the idea of
availability your ability to ensure
service remains available scalability
your ability to grow rapidly or
unimpeded elasticity your ability to
shrink and grow to meet the demand fault
tolerance your ability to prevent a
failure disaster recovery your ability
to recover from a failure and there are
a couple other things that uh you that
should be considered they're not
terminologies but they're definitely
important to a solutions architect or
cloud architect
and uh these are things you always need
to consider
as well and this is just me talking to
my solutions architect friends where
they'll always ask me these two
questions after presentation they'll say
how secure is the solution and how much
is this going to cost all right and so
for the terminologies up here we're
going to define these right away and
we're going to figure these out
throughout the course we have two giant
sections just on cost and security alone
uh so there we go
the first term we're looking at is high
availability and this is your ability
for your service to remain available by
ensuring there is no single point of
failure
and or you ensure a certain level of
performance so the way we're going to do
that on aws is you'd want to run your
workload across multiple availability
zones to ensure that if one or two
availability zones became unavailable
your servers or applications remain
available because those other
those other servers are going to be
there and the way we would accomplish
that is via elastic load bouncer so a
load balancer allows you to evenly
distribute traffic to multiple servers
in one or more data center if a data
center or server becomes unavailable or
unhealthy the load bouncer will route
the traffic to only the available data
centers within the server and understand
that just because you have additional
servers doesn't mean that you are you're
available you have to you might need to
meet a particular threshold of
availability so you might need to have
at least two servers always running to
meet the demand so it's based on the the
demand of traffic okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at high scale
abilities so this is your ability to
increase your capacity based on the
increasing demand of traffic memory and
computing power and we have the terms
vertical scaling so scaling up
this is where you upgrade to a bigger
server and then there's horizontal
scaling scaling out this is where you
add more servers of the same size and
the great thing about scaling out or
adding additional servers is that you're
also going to get high availability so
if you do need two servers it's always
better to you know add an additional
server as opposed to having a larger
server but it's going to be very
dependent on a lot of factors okay
[Music]
so scalability and elasticity seem very
similar but there is a crucial
difference and this is your ability to
automatically increase or decrease your
capacity based on the current demand of
traffic memory and computing power again
it's the it's the fact that it happens
automatically and you can go both ways
increase or decrease so for horizontal
scaling we have the concept of scaling
out so add more servers of the same size
and then scaling in removing
underutilized servers of the same size
and vertical scaling is generally hard
for traditional architectures so you'll
usually only see horizontal scaling
described with elasticity
and the way we would accomplish uh being
highly elastic is using auto scaling
groups asgs and this is a database
feature that will automatically add or
remove servers based on scaling rules
you define based on those metrics okay
[Music]
let's talk about being highly fault
tolerant so this is your ability for
your service to ensure there is no
single point of failure preventing the
chance of failure and the way we could
do that is with failovers so this is
when you have a plan to shift traffic to
a redundant system in case the primary
system fails a very common example is
having a copy or secondary uh
of your database where all ongoing
changes are synced the secondary system
is not in use until a failover occurs
and it becomes the primary database so
when we're talking about databases on
abs this is the concept of rds multi-az
so this is when you run a duplicate
standby database in another availability
zone in the case your primary database
fails
[Music]
and last here is high durability so this
is your ability to recover from a
disaster and to prevent the loss of data
so solutions that recover a disaster uh
from a disaster is known as disaster
recovery so do you have a backup how
fast can you restore the backup does
your backup still work how do you ensure
current live data is not corrupt and so
maybe a solution aws would be using
cloud endure which is a disaster
recovery service which continuously
replicates your machines in a low cost
staging area in your target apes account
and preferred region enabling fast and
reliable recovery in the case of an i.t
data center fails okay
[Music]
so to understand disaster recovery we
need to know more about uh things around
it like business
continuity plans bcps and rtos and rpos
so a bcp is a document that outlines how
a business will continue operating
during unplanned disruption in services
so it's basically the plan that you're
going to execute
if that happens and so here we have a
disaster and you can see that there's a
chance of data loss and downtime and
these two
factors as rpo and rto are going to
define the length of these durations so
recovery point objective is the maximum
acceptable amount of data loss after an
unplanned data loss incident expressed
this amount of time so how much data are
you willing to lose
and then recovery time objective so the
maximum amount of downtime your business
can tolerate without incurring a
significant financial loss so how much
time you're willing to go down okay
so those are the two there and now let's
go take a look at the disaster recovery
options that we can use to define in our
our bcp
[Music]
so let's take a look at our disaster
recovery options uh and based on what
you choose they're going to be a trade
of cost versus time to recover based on
the rpos your rtos of course and so
sometimes this is re represented
vertically like a a thermostat or you
can do it horizontally here both are
valid ways of displaying this
information but i just have it
horizontally here today and so we have
low or high or you could say
even though i don't have it written here
this could be cold or this could be hot
okay
so um on the left hand side we got back
up and restore pilot light warm standby
multi active site notice we're using the
like the words like pilot light warm
things that are relating to temperature
so again cold and hot all right
so let's just walk through what each of
these things us conceptually do uh in
terms of architecture so when you're
doing a backup restore you're back you
basically back up your data
and at the time of disaster recovery
you're just going to restore it to new
infrastructure
for a pilot light the data is replicated
to another region with the minimal
services running to keep on replicating
that data and so you might have some
core services running a warm standby is
a scaled down copy of your
infrastructure so you basically have
everything that you would absolutely
need to run an application but the idea
is it's not at scale and so at any time
when there's an incident you're going to
scale up to the capacity that you need
and then you have multi-site active
active where you you have a scaled up
copy of your infrastructure in other
regions so basically everything you have
identically in another region and so in
terms of the rpos and the rtos for back
and restore you're looking at hours uh
with the pilot light you're looking at
10 minutes with a warm standby you're
looking at minutes and multi-site active
active you're looking at real time so
you know hopefully that gives you an
idea of you know the difference in terms
of scale but let's just look at more
detail so for a backup and restore this
is for low priority use cases restore
data after event deploy resources after
an event and it's very cost effective
for pilot light you this is where you
have less stringent rtos and rpos so
that you're going to be just running
your core services
you're going to start and scale
resources after the event and this is a
little bit more expensive this is
very good for warm standby is good for
business critical services so you scale
resources after the event uh and it's
almost very it's very it's costly but
it's not as expensive as a multi-site
active active so you get zero downtime
near zero loss uh you have it's great
for mission critical services and it's
just as expensive as your original
infrastructure so you're basically
doubling the cost there okay
[Music]
so we already defined rto but let's
redefine it again based on what aws
describes in their white paper and just
look at how it maps against the disaster
recovery options so
recovery time objective is the maximum
acceptable delay between the
interruption of service and restoration
of service this objective determines the
what is considered an acceptable time
window when service is unavailable and
is defined by the organization and so
this is the diagram found in the white
paper and so on the left-hand side we
have cost and complexity here and then
lengths of service interruption and what
you can see here is that the cost and
complexity for a multi-site active
active is very high but the length of
service interruption is zero
and then as we go down we have warm
standby so it's significantly like at
least half the complexity of that one
then we have our pilot light down here
and backup and restore but notice backup
restore takes the longest amount of time
and notice here we have a recovery time
objective so in your bcp you kind of
define where that is based on the cost
of business impact so you might have to
calculate that saying okay what is our
cost over time based on the length of
service interruption where do we want
our rto to be what is the acceptable
recovery cost and this is where you're
going to decide uh what you want to do
so here we have pilot light and backup
and restoring so this company
he has to decide whether they want to do
a pilot light or they're going to do a
back and restore but it sounds like this
is where they're going to be which is at
the pilot
light for what is acceptable in their
business use case okay
let's do the same for rpo so recovery
point objective is the maximum
acceptable amount of time since the last
data recovery point the objective
determines what is considered an
acceptable loss of data between the last
recovery point and the interruption of
service and is defined by the
organization again we pulled this from
the aws white paper for disaster
recovery and uh we have cost and
complexity but this time it's replaced
with data loss before service
interruption
so uh for multi-site again it's going to
be very expensive and high up here as
you notice it's not like a perfect um
curve it's just it's a bit different in
terms of what it looks like so here we
have warm stand standby pilot light and
so you'll see that the data loss is um
not a big deal but for backup and
restore it really juts out there so you
can see that you can get pretty good
results just with the pilot light and
the cost and complexity is very low
again we have to look at our cost and
business impact so we got to follow that
line and we need to see where our
acceptable recovery cost is
and so
you're going to notice that we have a
bit of an intersection here
okay and so we need to determine you
know like are we going to be doing a
warm standby it looks like we have the
cost to do it
um
but you know it just really depends you
know do we want to be down here or down
there okay so
hopefully that helps and visualize that
information for you
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to show you here is a
real world architectural diagram i
created this a while ago this is a
previous version of the
example or technically teacher see
platform that powers the learning
experience for my cloud certifications
and so i'm hoping that by giving you
some exposure you'll absorb some
information here
and that will carry through to really
help you cement what these services do
and how they work together
now you might be asking how did i make
this well i'm in adobe xd it's by
photoshop or sorry adobe it's free to
download but there's a lot of options
out there and but the first thing you'll
need is those aws architectural icons so
these are free on aws you can download
them in powerpoint download those assets
as svgs and pngs which is what i have
done and start using them in your um
whatever software you like there's also
third party providers out there so like
there's lucidcharts i love lucidcharts
but i don't use it to make architectural
diagrams for aws um but you know you can
drag drop and stuff and they already
have the library there and there's a
bunch of them that you can choose from
so
uh you know that's interesting but let's
take a look at one that we can download
maybe everyone's familiar with
powerpoint so here is the aws
architectural icons and the reason i'm
showing you this is not because it just
contains icons but it also suggests how
you should build them so if i go through
here they'll give you a definition of
those system elements uh how they would
look like here so we have our group
icons our layer group our service icons
resource icons where they should go
and then they have some interesting
guidelines of like do's and don'ts so
here's like a simple example of a get to
an s3 bucket
here's an example of using vpc subnets
and things like that on the inside
um and then
you can see kind of like all the groups
that we have
and they'll show all like the uh the
arrows it's a big faux pas to make a
diagonal arrows that's just something
that it was defined but you'll see a lot
of people do them anyway
and then you'll see all the icons so do
you have to make them like eight of us
suggest no but you know if you like the
way they look that is fine everyone just
does whatever they want honestly so
anyway now that we've seen you know how
we can go get the resources to make our
own i have adobe xd opened up here and
so i just kind of want to walk you
through what's going on here so again i
said this is a
traditional
architecture meaning that it's powered
by virtual machines and so what we need
to look for uh is ec2 because that's
where it's going to start that's our
virtual machine and you'll notice we
have one here so there's a t2 um
that's running over here and then over
here we have a t2 okay so
we have a blue and a green environment
so this is our running environment so
i'm just going to zoom on in here
okay so the web app would be running on
this
and
and then on the outside here we have an
auto scaling group and so auto scaling
groups allow us to
manage a group of ec2 instances and they
will automatically scale if the demand
increases or
or decline so if this machine can't
handle it it will just automatically
provision a new one and so i've
contained it in this environment here
because i'm representing a blue green
deploy meaning that when i deploy this
will get this will be the environment
that replaces things and so you can see
i have a lot of lines being drawn around
here so
over here we have uh
parameter store so parameter store is a
place where we can store our environment
variables
um or application configuration
variables and so i have this line going
here and it's just saying we're going to
take these environment variables and put
them into the application okay
and then there's also uh the database
credentials so here we are using
postgres over here so
and then we need the database
credentials so we're grabbing those
database credentials those are stored in
secrets manager and we're giving to the
application so the app knows how to
connect to the database and this one
knows how to uh configure it okay
then we have a bunch of
uh buckets here for different
organizations and so you know s3 is for
storage so this is a way we're going to
um store a variety of things so like
user data assets artifacts
cloudformation templates so some of this
is for the app some of them is for the
infrastructure so that's one thing there
okay then over here we have a ci cd
pipeline so
we have code pipeline and so code
pipeline is triggered by github so we
put our code in github and when that
happens it's going to do a code build so
that's going to build out a server
and then from there it's going to run
another code build server and then from
there it's going to then um
use codeploy and so codeploy is going to
trigger a deploy what it will do is
create a new environment so it's going
to create a copy of this
um
sorry it's going to create a cop this is
actually the environment that's running
so we'll copy that and that will be our
new environment right
okay
and so when the deploy is done it will
swap and that environment will become
this new one
um and so you know again this is
actually really the the running server
it's just kind of easy to get hung up on
this one
but the idea here is that um you know
that's how deployment works but let's
say
you know we want to get uh
traffic to this actual instance this is
going to come through the internet
and the internet is going to probably go
to revit three so reference three is
used for domain names so this would be
like example teacherseek.com
we pass that over to our elastic load
bouncer which in this case is an
application load bouncer that's why it's
called alb and that's going to
distribute the traffic there if we
wanted to run the server in another
um
in another availability zone so that we
make it highly available
you know alb the elastic load balancer
application load bouncer is going to
have some traffic go here and some
traffic go there so this is just
the blue environment or whichever the
current environment is over here
now when we want to deploy new versions
we're going to use launch templates and
launch templates um
uh are necessary when using auto scaling
groups so um you know you do have to
define launch template it just says like
what is the shape of this instance type
like what's this family what should it
be
and then we need an amazon machine image
so our amazon machine image is custom
built because we are installing all the
stuff that we want on it and so in order
to automate that process we are using um
ssm automation documents so ssm stands
for systems manager and automation
allows you to automate that step so what
it's going to do is launch an instance
install ruby install postgres download
the code base then it's going to create
that ami
and then um it will do a bunch of other
stuff here as well
and this is going to run weekly or
actually at the time uh it was running
nightly so we're doing nightly builds so
that we would always get the latest um
updates to our server
because it's a virtual machine there
could always be uh new updates for that
linux version or amazon machine limit
next version we were using
and then there's a bunch of other stuff
here so you know hopefully that kind of
gives you an idea of like the complexity
of it and you know this is how i like to
make my architectural diagrams very in
detail so that we can um look at them
but yeah if that was too much that's
fine but you know that's just the
complexity of it if you build your own
you'll start to really grasp the stuff
pretty well okay
so what i want to do is just show you
how high availability is built into some
aws services where in other cases you
have to explicitly choose that you want
something to be highly available so what
i'm going to do is make my way over to
s3 and so with s3 this is where you can
create s3 buckets and this allows you
to store things and so the great thing
about s3 is that it's basically
serverless storage so the idea is that
you're just going to choose your region
and by default it's going to replicate
your data across multiple
um uh data centers or azs and so this
one's already highly available by
default with the standard tier and so
that is something that's really nice but
other services uh you know like ec2 the
idea is that you are going to launch
yourself an ec2 instance so we would
launch that one and the problem with
this is that if you launch a single ec2
that is not highly available because
it's a single server running in a single
um a z so here you know we would choose
our subnet our subnet is our
availability zone but you'd have to
launch at least two additional servers
and then you'd have to route um
you'd have to have something that would
balance uh the traffic to the to the
three which is a load bouncer and so in
this case you have to construct your
high availability then you have services
like elastic bean stock this is a
platform as a service
um and we'll go to environments here i'm
not sure it wasn't showing up there uh
and so the idea is that with elastic
bean stock
i'm just going to click on the main
service here you're going to go ahead
and
create your application or create your
environment you probably want to create
environment first here
okay and so i would choose a web server
and then the idea is i'll just name it
so my application here my
environment and then down below you go
configure more options whoops wants me
to choose everything that's totally fine
and we say configure more options we're
not going to create it because um we
don't want to create one but the idea is
that you'd you could choose whether you
want this to be highly available or not
so see it's a single instance of free
tier and then if you choose this what
it's going to do
is set up a bunch of stuff for you so
it's going to set up an application load
balancer for you it's going to set up
auto scaling groups for you to make it
highly available it's going to run at
least between one to four instances so
this does everything that ec2 you'd have
to do manually setting up so that's
really nice
okay so you know some options have that
if we make it our way over to rds and
again we're not creating anything we're
just looking at the options it gives us
when we start things these up here
we'll make our way over to rds and it
gives us a moment here
and if we go ahead and create ourselves
a new database
and we look at something like a postgres
database
notice that we have a production option
and a dev test option and so i i mean
usually it shows us the price down here
so even test dev is 118 which is not
true it can get cheaper than that but
the idea is that when you choose between
these two options
um it's going to set up a multi-az it's
going to that means that it's going to
run an additional
database and another availability zone
replicate that data over so that it
stays highly available um you know it's
going to have auto scaling uh
part of it and so some services you just
choose it abstractly so you just have to
understand what highly availability is
going to mean underneath so hopefully
that kind of gives you a picture of high
availability on aws
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at abuse application
programming interface also known as
database api
so before we talk about the api let's
describe what application programming
interface is so an api is software that
allows two applications or services to
talk to each other and the most common
type of api is via http requests and so
the aws api is actually an http api and
you can interact with it by sending
https requests using an application
interacting with apis like postman
and so here's kind of an example of what
a request would be that would be sent
out and so the way it works is that each
database service generally has a service
endpoint so see where it says monitoring
that's going to be cloudwatch so
sometimes they're named after the
services sometimes the name is a bit
obscure and of course you can't just
call and uh call a api request without
authenticating or authorizing and so you
have to sign your request and so that's
a process of making a separate request
with your idioms credentials to get back
a a temporary token in order to
authorize that and i don't have room to
show it but the thing is is that what
you'd be
also going along with those requests
would be to provide an action so when
you look at um
the aws api it will show you a bunch of
actions that you can call they're
basically the same ones you'll see in
the in policies so it could be like
describe ec2 instances or list buckets
and they can also be accompanied with
parameters okay
so you know we're probably not going to
show you how to make an api request
directly because that's not something
that you would generally do
um but what you would do
is you probably use the aws management
console which is powered by the api use
the abyss sdk which is powered by the
api or using the aws cli so we'll cover
all those three okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do is just
point you to where you'd find the
resources to use the api
programmatically uh we're not going to
actually use the api because there's a
lot more to it uh than what i'm going to
show you here but at least you'll be
familiar with how the api works so i'm
on the
aws.amazon.com website if you type in
docs the type top there it's going to
bring you to the main documentation and
what we're looking for if we scroll on
down there should be a general reference
area where we have service endpoints if
we click into here it's going to talk
about
how a server's endpoint is structured
and if we go down to ibis api we can see
some additional information of course to
use um the api you're going to have to
sign api requests first which is not a
super simple process but you have to use
an authorization header
and send along some credentials and
things like that so if you want to know
what service endpoints are available to
you if you search service endpoints list
for aws this is the big list and so if i
was to go down here and look for ec2 uh
might be a common example here it's
going to tell us what the endpoints are
and as you can see they are regional
based but the idea here is that i could
take something like this okay i could
grab that and using something like
postman
i could go and create a new request and
it's probably a post i'm not sure what
it's supposed to be it's probably a post
and then you'd set your authorization
header there might even be one in here
for aws see where it says adab signature
so you can go here and put your access
key and secret within here um
so that's something nice about postman
so it's going to do the signing requests
for you so it makes your life a lot
easier and then from there what you do
is you go to your body and you'd want to
enter in json so to do json would
probably be raw you drop down the format
json and then you'd send your payload
whatever it is so again i haven't done
this in a while because it's not a very
common uh thing that i have to do like
describe ec2 instances but there
probably is like an action and some
additional information that you would
send along um so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea how the api
works but you know you should never pro
in practice ever have to really work
with the api uh this way directly okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the database
management console so the italo's
management console is a web-based
unified console to build manage and
monitor everything from simple web apps
to complex cloud deployments so when you
create your apps account and you log in
that is what you're using the aws
management console and i would not be
surprised if you're watching this video
and they've already changed um the
default page here since adobe's loves to
change the ui on us all the time
but uh the way you would access this is
via console.ableis.amazon.com
when you click sign in or go to the
console that's the link that it's going
to
uh and so the idea here is that you can
point and click to manually launch and
configure aws resources with limited
programming knowledge this is known as
click ops since you can perform all your
system operations via clicks okay
[Music]
let's talk about the aws management
console in brief here so you know of
course when you're on the home page you
go to aws management console and you
will end up logging in and from there we
will make our way over to the edwards
management console when i say [__]
management console i'm referring to
this homepage but i'm also referring to
anything that i'm doing in this web ui
whether it's a sub service or not so you
know a lot of times people just call
this the dashboard uh or the home page
but you know it is technically the us
management console but everything
is the aws management console you can
drop down services here if there's some
that you like you can favorite them on
the left hand side i don't find that
particularly useful you can see the most
recent ones here they'll also show
recently up here as well we have the
search at the top notice that there's a
hotkey for alt s i don't think i ever
use it if i was to type in a service
like ec2 it's going to get me the
services and then down below it's the
sub features of it so if i just click
into that there into this use this is
the main this is a service console so i
would call this the ec2 console or the
ec2 service console
so if you ever hear me saying go to the
ec2 console that's what i'm saying and
you'll notice here like there is stuff
on the left hand side so i come back
here ec2 image builder you see two
global views these are considered
services but if you drop down it says
top features or you go down here it says
dashboard limits amis you go over here
the ec2 dashboard limits amis are here
and limits are somewhere here right
there so okay so those kind of map over
pretty well polls and documentation
knowledge based articles marketplace i
don't think i've ever touched those in
my life
this here is the cloud shell so if you
click it it will launch a cloud shell
we'll cover that when we get to that
section here we have this little bell it
tells us about open issues i think this
is for the personal health dashboard
yeah it says phd in the bottom left
corner or left corner so if i open that
up it'll bring up the phd the personal
health dashboard all right
our region selector our support so
nothing super exciting here but just
kind of giving you a bit of a tour so
that you know there are some things you
can do
um can you change the look of this i
don't think right now as of yet um there
is any way i'm sure it was thinking
about it because it's been a high
request that's in demand but this is
what it looks like as of today okay
[Music]
all right so i just want to describe
what a service console is so an aws
service each have their own customized
console and you can access these
consoles by searching the service name
so you would go ahead and type in ec2
and then what we refer to this screen as
as the ec2 console the reason i'm
telling you this is that when you're
going through a lot of labs or follow
alongs you'll hear the instructor say go
to the ec2 console go to the sagemaker
console go to the rds console what
they're telling you is to go type the
the name of the service and go to
that particular services console okay
some interest service consoles will act
as an umbrella console containing many
aws services so uh you know vpc console
ec2 console systems manager console
sagemaker console uh cloudwatch console
these all contain multiple services so
you know for um
for ec2 you might say okay well i need a
security group there's no security group
console it's under the ec2 console okay
so just be aware of that
[Music]
so now i want to show you some of these
service consoles to kind of distinguish
how they might vary per per service okay
so if we were to look up ec2
um and we just did look at this but the
interesting thing is that some consoles
the ec2 console
is the home for other database services
and you just have to learn this over
time to know that so for instance
elastic block store is its own service
but it's tightly linked to ec2 instances
so that's why they always have it here
same thing with amis
security group same thing with that so
these are interesting because these are
basically part of virtual networking
and so you'd think they'd be under the
vpc console but they're actually under
here with ec2
and so load balancing auto scanning
groups tightly coupled to
to ec2 if we make our way over to vpc
you know here it's going to contain all
the new stuff does it have a new
experience no i guess this is the newest
one
it looks a bit old and a little bit new
here but you know we have a lot of
different things here like firewalls
vpns transit gateways traffic mirroring
we make our way over to cloudwatch
okay and cloudwatch has
uh
very uh focused services they're all
actually named and this is more like a
feels more like a single service where
you have these very focused
services where you have alarms logs
metrics events insights right but you're
going to notice that like the ui highly
varies so we had looked at cloudwatch
and then we had looked at
vpc and it looks like this
and then we looked at ec2 and it looked
like that and so there is
inconsistencies because each um service
team like that work on per service or
whatever they have full control over
their ui and so
some of them are in
different states of updating so some
people might have updated the left-hand
column but this part is old or you might
click around like under something else
like the ec2 dashboard
or maybe a better example might be amis
i remember we're in here and something
looked old here yeah see these are the
old buttons and that's just how it is so
everything is very uh modular and so
they get updated over time so that is
the challenge that you're dealing with
you're always having like three
different versions that are cobbled
together in each uh
ui one thing that i found really
interesting is that um vpc has its own
console management console but if you
were to look up this in the uh the sdk
so if i was to look up abs sdk
ec2
okay i'm just looking up ruby here as an
example because that's what i know how
to do
if you look under here let's say you
want to pragmatically work with vpcs
you'd think that it would have its own
top-level vpc because it has in the
console its own
its own
management console but actually vpc is
tightly coupled ec2 and so when you want
to pragmatically use vpc you're going to
be um using actually ec2
as as how it was built so
the the the what i'm trying to get is
the apis don't one-to-one match with
this kind of stuff and so it's just kind
of interesting that there's those kind
of uh differences uh but again it's not
that big of a deal i'm just trying to
say like you know keep your mind open
when you look at the stuff okay
[Music]
so every aws account has a unique
account id and the account id can be
easily found by dropping down the
current user in the global navigation so
what i'm going to do is pull up my pen
tool here and just show you it's right
there uh the imbus account id is
composed of 12 digits and so it could
look like this or this or this the
universal account id is used when
logging in with a non-root user account
but generally a lot of people like to
set their own alias because it's tiring
to remember your account id the you use
it when you're creating cross account
roles so you'd have the target account e
the source account id to gain access to
resources in another's account when
you're
dealing with support cases
awast will commonly ask you what your
account id is so they can identify
the account that they want to look at
and it is generally good to keep your
account id private as it is one of the
many components used to identify an
account for attack by malicious actor
so you don't have to be overly sensitive
with it but you know try to hide it when
you can when it's easy okay
[Music]
all right so let's talk about the
account id which appears up here in the
top right corner uh where you can get
the account id it also appears in im so
if we go over to iam
and you look on the right hand side it
should show you the example here it
keeps on trying to take us to the old
dashboard that's fine
but you'll notice that it's over here
and
i don't have mfa turned on because i'm
in my imuser account but it should be
turned on on everything that's a given
but you know i just want to show you
where it is and also where you might be
using it so one example where you would
use
you would need to know your account id
would be something like creating a cross
account policy so i went here and went
to policy and went create policy
um
and we
went to maybe it's a role i think we
actually sorry we want to cross account
roles not the policy sorry
we go here
and
we say i want to access something in
another abs account what we have to do
is specify the account id specify the
accounts that can use this role so you
give i think the
the id of the other account
okay and so that is one place where
you'd use it another place would be when
you're creating policies
so if i go back to policies here i can
create a policy here
and i can just choose something like s3
okay
and i'll just choose list
and under the request conditions
i might specify i think the account id
it should be in here
um
i know i can limit
based on account id
principal account
you could do principal account so if i
just looked up this here
address principal account
and you just got to get used to google
and things because that's always what's
happening here
and so we should be able to specify an
account id yeah like that so that would
be the principle there so if i just took
that and it doesn't matter what it is we
just put the value in here
um string equals this
add
i should be able to go over here and now
see the full statement nope sometimes
that happens because we don't have it
fully filled out
but um yeah so that pretty much
that's pretty much how we use it like it
would normally show up as that so if i
just go ahead and go next the policy
contains an error you are required to
choose a resource
what do you mean the resource is this
right oh down here okay sorry
so we'll just say all resources then we
flip over now it's valid and so here we
can see our condition saying only from
this account id that it is allowed
um other places we're going to see
account ids are in um
arn's right so if we had an ec2 instance
we don't have one launched right now
but if i was to go ahead and
oh maybe we have some prior ones yeah so
if i was to check box this here
and you might not have any prior ones so
there might not be nothing for you to
see but if you look for the arn
where is our iron
sometimes it doesn't show the iron in
the services sometimes it does
i wish that abuse always showed the iron
to make our lives a bit easier but it
could be because of other reasons why
but
even though we don't have the rn i think
it shows it shows us the owner id
and so that's the account the count id
number you can tell because it's 12
digits so hopefully that gives you kind
of a tour of the account id and what its
purpose is in the account okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at aws tools
for powershell so what is powershell
powershell is a task automation
configuration management framework is a
command like shell and a scripting
language so here it is over here uh if
you're a windows user you're used to
seeing this because it has a big blue
window so unlike most shells which
accept and return text powershell is
built on top of the dot net common
language runtime clr accepts and returns
the dotnet objects so
aws has a thing called the interbus
tools for powershell and this lets you
interact with the aws api via powershell
commandlets
is a special type of command in
powershell in the form of the
capitalized verb and noun so in this
case it'd be new uh hyphen s3 buckets so
you know we looked at the awcli and that
is generally for bash um you know shells
and so powershell is just another type
of shell that's very popular and i just
wanted to highlight it for those people
that are uh you know used to using
microsoft workloads or azure workloads
uh that this actually exists okay
all right let's take a look at the
powershell tools um i actually haven't
used this one yet so i'm kind of curious
i am on a windows machine so if i was to
open cm or
powershell
and you probably can't see this but if i
just bring this over here if i type in
powershell on my computer
you'll notice that i have it um so
that's how you would launch it looks
like a blue screen here
okay um if you're on a mac you're not
going to have that but that's totally
fine we don't need to have a windows
machine to use powershell because we can
go ahead and use cloud shell so make
sure you're in a region that supports
cloud shell so i switch back to north
virginia
this is not important for the exam but
it's just kind of fun for me to go
through this with you if you just like
want to watch uh here and so i want to
change this over to powershell so i
imagine that it must be over here
um so
how do we change to powershell so we'll
type in
advanced power or aws cloud shell
power shell like how do we do it
okay and so we're just going to scroll
down here
so the following shells are
pre-installed uh the bash the powershell
the z-shell you can identify them by
that yeah of course
to switch to new shell enter the shell's
program name in the command line prompt
oh wow that's easy so um if we want pwsh
do we just type pwsh let's find out
give it a moment to think oh there we go
okay so now we're using powershell and
so i would think that databus would give
this pre-installed for us so if we go
over here to the instructions and we
scroll on down there's probably like oh
wait like i don't use powershell a lot
it's very easy to install modules i've
done it before
but i never remember how to do it but
let's just see what we can find here so
i want
the documentation for powershell here
and i'm going to go to the um
the maybe the reference here
because i just want to see some examples
for the commandlets and so we'll look
for s3 again never done this before but
i'm always great at jumping into these
things and all i want to do is just list
out the buckets so i'm going to just
search for the word list
and just see if i can find something
very simple here
and calls to get the list buckets api
operation so i think that is what we're
going to be doing here so i'm going to
click into that
okay
and then from there
what i'm going to do is just see if i
can copy this command so we will go
ahead and copy this and paste it in here
and i like how we got this little shell
here so we can tweak it so we need the
bucket name but i don't want to
return a list of all the buckets owned
by the author so
we don't have a bucket name that we want
to explicitly set here so it's required
false so we can remove that
okay we'll look at the next one select
required false use the select command to
control the command line output the
default is bucket specifying select will
result in
turning all the whole buckets
for that specifying the name
but it says it's not required so let's
just take that out as well
i don't think we need any of these
actually let's just go and put that in
there and i think that
there must be something we need to put
in front of that right well let's just
see what happens
uh the term is not recognized as the
name of the command function script is
operable so i think we're missing
something in front of here
we'll go to the user guide here quickly
and we'll get to the getting started
i just want a super simple example here
new bucket get bucket
well let's try this one here because
they have it here
and so it should just work right
i'm going to change this to usc 1.
the term new bucket is not recognized as
the name of the commandlet function so
i'm guessing that the commandlet's not
installed i would have thought that they
would have installed it by default so i
guess what we'll do is look at how to
install it
so
installing on
linux i suppose
so
[Music]
you can install the modulized version of
the powershell on computers to install
aws tools on linux pwsh to start
powershell core session so i guess
that's how you must start it on linux
and then install the module this way so
yeah i said it's easy to install these
things we'll hit enter
cross your fingers hope this works hope
this is fast
i'm just going to take a look here peek
forward here if you are not if you're
notified the repository is untrusted
you're asked if you want to trust anyway
just hit y so we're waiting for that
here um you're installing this module
from untrusted repository it's funny
that it's untrusted by but it's by aws
maybe that's some kind of drama between
microsoft not letting a bus have an
official module there but it looks like
it should be installed now so if i type
in get s3 buckets here
um
unless i typed it wrong that still
doesn't seem to be working if i go up
here and try to create a new bucket
still does not recommend recognize the
command command lit here so there must
be more going on here
[Music]
if you are notified you can now install
the module for each service
okay
what did we do
you're installing the the modules from
untrusted if you trust it change the uh
change its installation policy value by
running set policy command are you sure
you want to install this module from the
ps gallery so i said yes
and i gave it a capital y
and
it didn't do anything else
so
oh hold on here so this is
the installer
and then here is the actual tool that we
want to solve so it installed oh so we
just installed this thing and now we use
this thing to install s3 okay
great not hard okay
and so we'll just say yes to all
and so that's going to install i guess
everything oh we said ec2 and s3 well we
didn't need both but that's fine
and so what i'm going to do is go get
bucket and so now recognize it it lists
out the items here we can go and create
ourselves a new bucket
so we'll do that okay we'll make our way
back over the database management
console we'll go to s3 just because i
don't need all these buckets lying
around here
and i'm going to go ahead and delete
some of these buckets here so we'll say
delete
my bucket great
and we'll go to this one here and say
delete
my bucket excellent
all right so we have an idea how to use
powershell and so powershell is just
really popular because
it's the way you do inputs it's very
standardized and the outputs that come
so it's very popular um and a very
powerful scripting tool that's our cli
tool as well so
you know hopefully that's that was
interesting for you but what we'll do is
just close these off here and go back to
our home page always just clicking that
logo there and there we go
[Music]
so amazon resource names uniquely
identify aws resources and arms are
required to specify resource
and ambiguously across all of all of aws
so the iron has the following format
variations so there's a few different
things here but just notice here that
sometimes it has a resource id or it has
a path so with the resource type or
could be separated by a colon so the
partition
can either be aws china or gov cloud
because this is basically the aws portal
or url that are completely separated
from each other
as we talked about those earlier in the
course
then there's the service identifier so
ec2 s3 iam pretty much every service has
their own
service that name here that would be
identified so the region would be pretty
obvious usc 1 ca central 1 you'd have a
count id which would be 12 digits
the resource id
could be a name or a path so like for
imusers we have user bob this is an ec2
instance and most of the irons are
accessible via the airbus management
console and you can usually click the rn
to copy to your clipboard so here is it
is for an s3 bucket and notice that it's
a little bit different because it is a
global service aws there's no reason to
specify the region or the account id
or
anything else there like the resource
type so straight away we already know
it's a bucket so we can just say my
bucket so that one's really short but in
other cases it's really long so here it
is for a load bouncer and it has all the
information there and notice that like
this as it passes load bouncer app my
server
will be and then it has the id okay
for paths and arms they can also include
a wildcard asterisk and we'll see these
like with im policies or or paths these
are really useful when you are doing
um
policies where you have to specify an
army you want to say a group of things
and things like that so there you go
[Music]
all right so now let's take a look at
amazon resource name or also known as
arn
and so arns are used to reference
objects they're very commonly used when
you're using the cli or the sdk to
reference to something um the easiest
example is s3 right so if we go over to
s3 here and we create ourselves a new
bucket um so i'll go ahead and create
ourselves a new one here
we'll say my new bucket
i'm just going to put a bunch of numbers
in here it doesn't matter we'll hit
create bucket
and what we will see if we click into
this
is the orange should be under properties
and there it is okay so there are many
cases where you might want to use the
iron and a lot of times you'll just copy
it and a very common example would be
again with i am policy so we go over to
i am policies
right
and i want to get to policies here to
save myself some trouble
and we create a policy
you know i might want to restrict
someone to use only that bucket so let's
say s3
okay
and then i'm going to say
i want to be able to read and write from
a particular bucket we go drop down
these resources here
and so
here we have a lot of options
maybe i'll just get rid of the read
option
and i'm going to actually expand right
because it's just creating too much work
for me here and i just want to have
put put object that's that's what we use
to put something into a bucket so we
expand the resource here and notice it
says add the iron so we go here
and we could type the bucket name so
do that or we just paste it on in here
at the top so it's probably easier just
to grab it sometimes
but if you don't know an iron a lot of
times you can just expand this and then
fill it in and that's how you get an
iron
so put that there let's list oh you
could also do it that way which is
easier too
and so now if i go to json is it valid
there we go so here it's saying
um this policy allows somebody to put an
object into this particular bucket and
so that would be an example where we
would use
an iron okay or if you're doing uh if
you're using uh itabus support you might
have to use an arm to um to get help
from support saying hey look at this
particular resource exactly here and
then the the cloud support engineer can
help you okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the abs command
line interface before we do that we got
to define some terms so what is a cli so
a command line interface processes
commands to a computer program in the
form of lines of text operating system
implement a command line interface in a
shell okay so we have a terminal say
terminal is a text only interface so it
has input output environment then you
have a console this is the physical
computer to physically input information
into a terminal then you have the shell
a shell is the command line program that
users interact uh with uh to input
commands popular shell programs or bash
zsh powershell and uh you might remember
this one ms dos prompt so this has been
around for obviously a very long time so
maybe this kind of primes your mind for
what is a shell and just so you know
people commonly erroneously use terminal
shell or console generally describe
interacting with the shell so if we say
shell or console or terminal we're just
talking about the same thing but there
is technically a difference between
these three things but most people do
not care and i wouldn't worry about it
too much okay so now let's take a look
at the database command line interface
which allows you to pragmatically
interact with the adobe's api via
entering single or multi-line commands
into a shell and then here i say or
terminal but really it's just the shell
okay
so uh here is an example of one so we're
trying to describe uh ec2 instances and
then we're getting the output because we
asked to have it back in this table like
view
so the abcli is a python executable
program so python is required to install
the awcli the awcli can be installed on
windows mac linux unix the name of the
cli program is aws you'll notice that up
here in the top left corner there's a
lot more to this but this is all we need
for now okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the abyss
cli and the easiest way to get started
with this is actually via the cloud
shell so you'll notice this little icon
here in the top right corner that is
cloud shell and it's going to allow us
to um uh pragmatically do things without
having to set up our own environments so
if i just click that there okay
uh and i say do not show again close and
by the way if you don't see cloud shell
here it could be your region so like if
i go to canada central
it doesn't have it there and so if i was
to search cloud shell here
okay it's going to say it's only
supported in those regions so that's a
bit annoying but once cloud shell loads
it already has our credentials loaded
within our account and so this is going
to save us a lot of time in terms of
you know trying to get set up with the
exception that you have to wait for this
environment to create so it takes a
little bit of time but it's not that bad
um and while that is waiting what i'll
do is show you actually how you'd
install the cli yourself so if we typed
in about cli install
all right and we went here
the way you install i believe it's a
python library but if we went to version
2 and we just said linux
you go down here they'll have
instructions so you just curl it unzip
it and do that
um so you know it's if it's this and
then once it's installed you'll have the
8 of cli commands
this is still going so you know maybe i
can show you what it would be like to
install the cli by hand so if we wanted
to do that one easy way to do this is if
we just go to github it doesn't matter
what repository i'm just looking for
anything here and if i open up git pods
so if we go on the top here and type in
gitpod.com
maybe
that
i just want to see whoops
maybe it's get pods
like that
oh get pod you're not giving me oh you
know what it's dot io that's why okay so
if we go back here
sorry and we type in dot io
what this will do is launch me a
temporary environment and so this is
outside of aws so i'd actually have to
install the cli so this would be a great
opportunity to show you
how to install the cli i'm just doing it
this way because git pod is free to use
and
um you know it's going to set up an
environment and how let us simulate
installing the cli so here is the cli
here i'm going to see if i can bump up
the font
let's make the font as large as we can
go
light or dark dark sounds good to me
and so if we type in aws
and give it a moment we can see that we
have uh the command here so if i say abs
s3
ls whoops
that should be able to list things out
in a bucket so this is what's currently
in the bucket if you're wondering how do
i know what these commands are i can
just type in able cli commands
okay and we go here
and we go to the cli ref reference
then we have um anything we want here
right so we go down here and i just want
to see what's running in s3 and i go
here
and i scroll on down it's going to show
me commands like copy move remove
sync uh mbrb
list
right
and
if you're looking for a particular
command you go down say okay i'll look
at ls here and it will explain to me all
the little options that we can do with
it and then it will always give me
examples right so i can see examples
like that so if i wanted to move
something into an s3 bucket so let's say
i want to create a new s3 bucket um
we'll type in aws s3 and just hit enter
and it should tell us um the sub
commands maybe if i do like help like
this
and if we scroll on down so i guess it
just pulls up documentation let's open
it we give us like a tiny summary
okay so what we can do here because i
want to create a bucket
type in like buckets
if you don't know something you just go
about s3 cli
create bucket we'll go here
and then what i do is i always just go
to examples here so we have aws s3 api
create bucket and i know it's unusual
there's an s3 and there's an s3 api i
don't know why that is but it's always
been that way and i just don't question
it anymore and so here i can go ahead
and create a new bucket so i'll just go
ahead and paste that command in i do
want to change it up a bit here because
this name could be that has to be unique
so just to make sure i get what i want
i'm putting random numbers in here we're
going to choose the region as us east
one if i wanted to do other things here
i could scroll up and look at some flags
here so
uh it looks all fine to me
so i think i'll go back here and just
hit
paste
okay and so it created that bucket for
me
if i go over to s3
and we'll wait here a moment we can see
that bucket now exists if i wanted to
place something in that bucket what i
can do is just like touch a file so i'll
just say touch touches a linux command
to make just an empty file so we'll say
hello.txt
and then it would be a bus s3 um
[Music]
it would be sp to copy it and i'm going
to give it the local path hello dot txt
and then i need to give it the bucket
address so it'd be s3 colon forward
slash forward slash the bucket name so
we named it this i'm not even going to
try to type that in by hand because it's
too hard and then i want to say where i
want to put this file so i'm going to
say hello.txt and if i'm right that
should work as expected
and so it says i uploaded that file i
make my way back over to s3 i refresh
there is the file
if i want to copy this file back locally
all i have to do i'm just going to
remove i'm going to delete the original
hello txt file
ls to show you that there's nothing
there
and what i need to do
oops
is just revert this so instead of saying
the address here
we can go and type in
hello.txt
and if i do ls there's the file if you
don't know what the address is of the
bucket um a lot of times you can go here
and find it so
it should be
because they're always changing this ui
on me but we'll go to properties here
and there that's the iron
uh usually a good way to find it is if
you go into an actual object so if you
go here it will give you the full url so
i could have grabbed that and i could
have just pasted that in there
um but you know you learn after time
it's not hard to remember this s3 colon
forward slash forward slash the unique
name i do want to show you how to
install it by hand so here i'm in get
pods
i'm not sure how i can change this to a
dark theme
because i really don't like this on my
eyes we'll go down below here to color
theme and we'll say get dark there we go
and so
this is a temporary workspace so when i
close it it'll be gone so i'll be
totally fine and so i'm going to type in
abs to see that it's not installed we're
going to go over here this runs linux by
default so i already know that i'm going
to use linux we want to use version 2
here
so
for the latest version use this command
for a specific version no we just want
the generic one so i'm going to go ahead
and copy this
whoops yes allow we'll paste that in
we'll hit enter
okay then we'll take the next command
paste that in hit enter
we'll go take the next command here
we'll hit enter
you can now run uh aws so we type aws
and there's a command so
uh the only thing is that if we do a bus
s3 ls it's not going to work because we
don't have any credentials set so we'll
give it a moment to think so it says
unable to locate credentials you can
configure credentials by running it was
configured so we type in ito's configure
and by the way if this font is too small
i believe i can bump it up like this
not a great way to do it but it works
and so it says databus access key id so
what we can do is go over to iam
and what i'm looking for is my
particular user over here
and if you remember when we first
created our account it generated out
access key so i go to security
credentials and so
we have a key here but i need the secret
so this key is useless to me so i'm
going to go ahead and deactivate it
just because i don't even want this key
and i'm going to create myself a new key
so i'm going to have an access id and
secret whenever you generate these out
never ever ever ever ever show anyone
what these are these are your
yours and yours alone okay so this is
cloud shell we're fine we're just gonna
close that for now
and i'm gonna go back over to get pods
here and hit enter so that's the id
i'm gonna go grab the secret
hit enter paste
and i want it to go to us east 1 to save
myself some trouble
you can change the output from json to
tables i'm going to leave it as the
default here and so now if i type a bus
s3 ls
i get a list and so if i want to grab
that file there and grab that s3 uri and
we type in aws s3
api or sorry it's just ls sorry or sorry
cp
and we're going to paste that link in
and we're going to say hello.txt
and i must have done the command wrong
it's because we're missing s3 here
i just hit up on the keyboard to get
that command back and so i type in ls
for list
and i mean i have some other code here
so you know again any repo you want on
github it doesn't really matter
but you'll see there is that file
probably shouldn't use this one because
it makes a bit of a mess
um but yeah it's pretty straightforward
just to one thing to show you is where
those credentials are stored so by
default they're going to be stored in
um
it's going to be in the
hidden directory in your root or your
home directory called above stock
credentials so if i just do like ls here
you can see there's a config file and a
credentials file cat lets me print out
the contents of that file so i go here
and it's saying the default region is
usc 1. this is a tombl file even though
it doesn't have a dot tom along the end
of it i just know by looking at it
that's what it is config lets you set
defaults that are going to apply to all
of your credentials
and then within the credential file here
is the actual credentials so if you
wanted to just set them you could go in
here and just set them in here you can
also set multiple credentials so if i go
here and i'm going to open up and buy
because i'm not sure how to open it up
here in the main one but if you wanted
multiple accounts you would do like exam
pro and then you just repeat these with
different keys
right and then when you wanted to use a
cli command actually i'm going to go
back here for a second
okay
and if you want to
um
and by the way i'm using vi if you never
use vim it's it's a bit tricky to use uh
you might want to use nano instead if
you're if you're kind of new to this
because this will use like regular key
key cuts and then down below it shows
you what it is so this is like control x
or alt x
alt text no control x there we go
um but anyway so if i go into this file
and i delete the original one right and
now i try to do
um
this command here even though we already
have that file it should either hang or
complain
i could just kill that by doing control
c if i do a bus s3 ls
just notice that it's hanging so unable
to locate credentials because there's no
default one but if i go and i put
profile and i say exam pro
all right it'll now use that profile so
that's the way we do it
but hopefully that gives you kind of a
crash course into the cli
so yeah there you go okay so i'm just
going to go ahead and
close these off you can delete this
bucket if you don't want it
it's probably a good idea to delete this
here
and i'm just going to say permanently
delete
okay
very very good okay close that off and
yeah that's the introduction to the cli
so yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at software
development kits uh so a software
development kit or sdk is a collection
of software development tools and one
installable package so you can use the
aws sdk to programmatically create
modify delete or interact with aws
resources so the innovas sdk is offered
in a variety of programming languages so
we have java python node.js ruby
go.net php javascript c
plus and so here would be an example of
some ruby code where we are creating
ourselves um an s3 bucket so we're just
uploading a file there okay
[Music]
okay so now what i'm going to do is show
you how to use the abyss sdk and so uh
to do that uh we're going to need some
kind of ide
a a basically code editor and so we had
looked at get pods which is a third
party service and that's fine but let's
take a look at cloud9 because that is
built into aws
so if i just type in cloud9 here and go
over to ide i'm going to launch myself a
new environment so i'll hit create i'm
going to say my sdk environment
env if you if you have our timetable
environment like me
and we have some options so create an
ec2 instance for direct access create it
via systems manager run a remote with
ssh i'm going to leave it as the default
then we have the option to choose what
size i want to leave it on t2 micro
because that is the free tier then we're
going to scroll on down we have amazon
x2 linux ami i'm going to stick with uh
amazon linux 2 and we can have it turn
off after 30 minutes a great option for
us here we'll go ahead and hit next and
we'll hit create environment
and so we're going to have to wait a
little bit for this to launch it'll take
a few minutes as that is going let's go
to google type in in-bus sdk
to get to the main page and so the idea
here is that there are a bunch of
different languages you can use c plus
plus go java javascript.net node.js php
python and ruby
uh and so i'm a really big fan of ruby
i've been using ruby since 2005 and so
that's what we're going to do it in it's
also really easy to use and
it's a really great language so um
you know down below it's just showing
you that there's all these different
things if we go down to the sdk here and
we click on ruby
we'll we have examples where you have
the developer guide the api reference
and so this tells you how to get started
even here it's saying like hey go get
started with cloud nine which is great
as well i suppose
um and so here might show you how to
install it um and when we open up the
api references this is what it looks
like so a lot of times when i want to do
something i know it's like i want to do
something with
s3 so i scroll on down here and i look
for s3
right
and then i just kind of like
uh scroll around and look you know what
i mean sometimes you have to expand it
go into the client every api is slightly
different
so you do have to kind of figure out how
to navigate that i'm actually under s3
right now so i'm looking for the client
and i just know this from memory that
this is where it is so first you create
yourself a client and then you can do
api operations so if i wanted to like
list buckets
i just searched the word list and i just
scroll on down and there it is i click
into that and i have an example of how
to list a bucket so
i'm going to go back to cloud9 and it is
ready and it started in dark mode if
yours is not in dark mode which really
honestly why wouldn't you want dark mode
if we go up to i think it's like file
where is it uh preferences here gotta
click the cloud9 option
and
i'm just seeing if it like remembers my
settings i really like two two soft tabs
here
but uh there should be something for
themes down below and so
um
that doesn't seem like that's it
it used to be like a oh here it is if
you go here
and just choose like whatever you want
i'm on jet dark here and so if it's on
classic light or something you don't
like you can fix that there but i'm just
going to go here and just fiddle with my
settings
because i really like to use vim
keys i don't recommend this if you are
to change this if you are not a
programmer but i'm just going to change
it so that i can type here efficiently
so i'm just looking for the option here
and they moved it on me where did they
move it
it'd probably be like key bindings
ah bin mode there we go again don't do
that this is just for me so i can move
around in a different way so
what i want to do and by the way it
looks like this default screen we could
have just changed it here
i just clicked through all that for
nothing was here the entire time but
what we need is we need to make sure
that we have our credentials so if you
type in aws
s3 ls that's like my sanity check that i
always like to do to make sure i have
credentials notice that we didn't have
to set up any credentials it was already
on this machine which was really nice
and so i'm going to create a new file
here
and it's okay if you don't know anything
about ruby we're just going to have fun
here and just follow along so i'm going
to do example.rb i'm going to make sure
ruby's installed by doing ruby hyphen v
so it is installed which is great
uh you need a gem file so say new
gem file here
and if we go back to
the installation guide
we need the gem sdk here
actually i'm going to look at how to
generate a gemfile gem file because
there's some stuff that goes to the top
of those files
like this here
i think we just need this line here so
i'm just going to grab that
whoops paste that in allow good
and
i you can do gem aws sdk that will
install everything but uh we only want
to work with
s3 and so this is going to vary based on
each language but i know that if we type
in s3 we'll just get s3 and that's all
we really need
and so once we have that what we'll need
to do is use a bundle install so we're
going to make sure we're in the correct
directory i'm going to type in ls down
below notice the gem file is there and
by the way if the fonts are too small i
should probably bump those up
let's see how we can do that
uh editor size font
user settings
good luck trying to find
today um
project no
you think it'd have to be under user
settings right
ah here it is okay so
this is for
probably the editor so we'll go to 18
here
co code editor here
i'm trying to find the one for the
terminal probably over here
there we go
much easier okay so notice we have
example.rb and gemfile so we're in the
correct directory make sure i save that
i'm going to type in bundle install
and that's going to install the gems
give it a moment there it's going to
fetch notice that it installed
the aws sdk s3 and everything that it
was dependent on
and so now if we go over to our
example.rb file really when you're
coding for the cloud you can pretty much
copy paste everything so over here we
found this code here for s3 list buckets
and so i'm going to go ahead and paste
that on in
okay
and i know it looks really complicated
but we can quickly simplify this so i
know that this is just the output so i
don't need that
okay
and in ruby you don't need parentheses
or curlies if uh if you don't have any
things there and so all i need to do is
define a client
so if i click
uh if i go to the top here of this file
i think we're in the client right now
all the way the top all the way the top
here
that's what we need okay
and so
i'm going to paste that in now
we can set the region here so i'm going
to say us east one
right and then you'd have your
credentials
because the credentials are on the
machine in the
credentials file they're going to auto
load here i believe so i don't think i
need to set them
so i'm just going to take that out here
for a second
okay and i can do this if i want this is
just slightly different syntax it might
be easier to read if i do it this way
for you
okay and
i don't need double client there so we
have the client i like to name this like
s3 so i know what it is
and i put puts for the response
i'm gonna do inspect
and so puts is like print okay and so
now if i type in bundle exect let's just
make sure that it's in the context of
our bundler file ruby
example.rb um we have a syntax error on
this line here unexpected thing here
oh it's because of this it's because i
commented it out so i'm just going to do
curly parentheses comment out here
okay
actually to make it a bit easier i'm
just going to bring this down like this
okay and we'll paste that there
okay and we'll try this again
initialize constants a to bus oh yeah we
have to require it so we have to require
abs sdk s3 i think
we'll hit up
and uh we got a struck back so it is
working
we are getting an object back if we want
to play around with this a bit more i'm
just going to install another gem called
pry pry allows us to um inspect code so
we're going to do bundle install
and i'm going to go
back to ruby here i'm going to put a
binding pry in here
and then if i hit
up and i do bundle exec ruby example.rb
um
i installed it right
bundle install
yes undefined method pry
oh because i have to require it again
bad habit here
okay we'll hit up
and so
now i have an interactive shell and i
can kind of analyze that object so we
have a response if i type in rsp here i
have the structure object i can type in
buckets here
okay and it's showing me a bucket i can
give it get its name
um
oh i think it's an array so i think i'd
say like i'd say like zero here
or i could say first this is just how
the ruby language works we say name i
get the name
creation date
okay so you get the idea whatever you
want to do
you know you search for it you just say
i want to delete a bucket i want to
create a bucket right and you look for
it so i say create bucket here
i click on this
and i can see the options and they are
always really good about giving me an
example and then down below they always
tell you all the parameters that you
have there so that's how the sdk works
uh but yeah the credentials were soft
loaded here but you could easily provide
them yourself i should just show you
that before anything else
just because there's some variations
there
and i'm just trying to look for it
because it is separate code
so you could do this this is one way of
doing it so you could do it separate
from the code so if you only wanted to
configure it once
right because you could you could have a
lot of clients you wouldn't want to keep
on like for each client you wouldn't
want to put region in every time so i
could take this
and put this right here okay
and this is the file here where we have
the credentials so this would be our
um
our access key and our id
and so
you never want to put your code directly
just in here so if i open up if you go
cat
you would never want to do this but i'm
just going to show as an example here
credentials
oops i got to get out of this exit
address credentials
oh did they not even show it on this
machine which would be smart we wouldn't
really want to see our credentials here
uh hit up say ls
oh no it's there okay
cat whoops
cru
credentials there it is okay so
you know if we look here we can see that
there are credentials set it's a little
bit different we have this like session
token i guess it's to make sure that
this expires over time but if i was to
take these
okay and i was just to paste them in
here
that's one way you would do it
you never ever want to do this ever ever
ever ever you never want to do this
because you'll end up committing that to
your code
so this is really dirty to do so i don't
ever recommend to do it
if you wanted to have this applied to
everything you could put it up here and
so now when we call the clients
we don't have to do it
um of course if the they're loaded on
the machine you don't have to do it the
other thing is like if you if you want
you could load them in via environment
variables that's usually what you want
to do so you say a bus access key
right and then you say environment
databus
access secret
and so you'd set those by doing i think
it's like an export
environment variables
set
in linux
you think i know after like 15 years of
doing this but i never remember so you
type in export
so you go down into whoops here you type
in export and you just say something
like i'm going to show an example to see
if it works so i'm going to say hello
world
okay and if i do
hello like that
echo
see it prints it out so that's how you
would set it you'd set those there's but
there's actually very specific ones that
aws uses for
the api and it's these ones here so you
always want to use those
okay so you put that in there
and then there
but of course you know like if they're
already set in your machine you don't
have to even specify those because it
would auto load those environment
variables i don't think they're set
right now if we type in echo
just take a look here is are they going
to get auto loaded here
no so
but anyway so we could go here
just as an
example
and well actually they just show them
right here so you see your access key
but we go and we type in
export
and i'm going to paste the key in there
and i'm going to go to the front of it
we're going to type a bus access
key id equals
enter
and so now if i did echo on this aws
access key
id
okay shows up but i just want to show
you how it can kind of vary and those
conditions around it so yeah that is the
abuse sdk um and yeah a lot of times
you're just copying pasting code and
just kind of tweaking it you're not
really writing
real programming okay so hopefully that
is less intimidating so i'm just going
to close these off and i want to close
down this cloud9 environment
um
i might have to reopen this up in
another tab
and go to the management console here
and then go over to cloud9 and just
close this tab
and then i'll go ahead and delete this
environment oops i'll just type delete
here
even if you didn't it would turn off
after 30 minutes and you have that free
tier so it's not that big of a deal it's
up to you whether you want to use cloud9
or git pods cloud9 is really good
because it allows you to
it allows you to uh
use it runs on a virtual machine right
so you have a
a container runtime there and so it's
very easy to run containers on it um
whereas in like i've had some issues
with git pods but um yeah those are the
two okay
[Music]
well let's take a look at adam's cloud
shell which is a browser-based shell
built into the database management
console and so cloud shell is scoped per
region it has the same credentials as
the logged in user and it's a free
service so this is what it looks like
and the great thing about this is that
you know if you have a hard time setting
up
your own shell or terminal on your
computer
or maybe you just don't have access or
privilege to do so it's just great that
abuse makes this uh available to you and
so what you can do is click the shell
icon up at the top and that will expand
this here some things to note about
cloud shell is that it has some
pre-installed tools so it has the cli
python node.js kit make pip pseudo tar
tmux vmwget vim and more it includes one
gigabyte of storage free per aws region
it will save your files in a home
directory available for future sessions
for the same in this region
and it can support more than a single
shell environment so it has bash
powershell and zsh um and so enemies
cloud shell is available in select
regions so when i was in my canada
region i was like where's the little
shell icon but i realized it's limited
for some areas okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at
infrastructure as code also known as iac
and this allows you to write a
configuration script to automate
creating updating or destroying your
cloud infrastructure the way you can
think of isc it's a blueprint of your
infrastructure and it allows you to
easily share version or inventory your
cloud infrastructure
so aws has two different offerings
for iac
the first is cloud formation uh
commonly abbreviated to cfn and this is
a declarative iec tool and then you have
abs cloud development kit commonly known
as cdk which is an imperative iac tool
so let's just talk about the difference
between declarative and imperative and
then we'll look at these tools a little
bit closer uh each okay so declarative
means what you see is what you get it's
explicit it's more verbose but there's
zero chance of misconfiguration unless
the file's so big that you're missing
something uh commonly declarative files
are written in things like json yaml xml
so for cloud formation it's just json
and yaml
and so that's that side there so for
imperative you say what you want and the
rest is filled in so it's implicit uh
it's less verbose you could end up with
some misconfiguration that's totally
possible uh but it does more than
declarative and you get to use your
favorite programming language maybe
python javascript actually cdk does not
support ruby right now but i just have
that in there just as a general
description of what imperative is okay
[Music]
all right so just a quick look at
cloudformation so cloudformation allows
you to write infrastructure as code as
either json or yaml the reason why was
aws started with json and then everybody
got sick of writing json and so they
introduced yaml which is a lot more
concise which you see on the right hand
side so cloud formation is simple but it
can lead to large files or is limited in
some regards to creating dynamic or
repeatable infrastructure compared to
cdk a confirmation can be easier for
devops engineers who do not have a
background in web programming languages
a lot of times they just know scripting
and this basically is scripting since
cdk generates out cloudformation it's
still important to be able to read and
understand cloud information in order to
debug iac stacks knowing cloudformation
is kind of a cloud essential when you go
into the other tiers of aws
like solutions architect associate
professional or any of the associates
you need to know cloud information
inside and out okay
[Music]
okay so what i want to do now is
introduce you to infrastructure as code
and so we're going to take a look at
cloud formation and so we were just
using cloud9 for the sdk so we're going
to go back and create ourselves a new
cloud9 environment because we do have to
write
some code so i'll go ahead and hit
create here and i'm going to just say uh
cfn that's sort for cloudformation
example
and we'll hit next step
and we'll create ourselves a new
environment t2 micro
amazon x2 is totally fine we'll hit next
it'll delete after 30 minutes we'll be
fine we're within the free tier we're
going to give this a moment to load up
and remember you can set your theme your
your keyboard mode whatever you want as
that loads and as that's going we're
going to look up cloud formation
and so cloud formation
is very intimidating at first but once
you get through the motions of it it's
not too bad
um so we'll go to the user guide here as
we always do if you go to getting
started
it's going to just tell us some things
it's going to read about yaml files
um i don't think i really need to read
much about this here so i think we'll
just go start looking up some codes so
something that might be interesting to
launch is an ec2 instance
cloudformation so that's what i'll do is
i'll type in what i want so an ec2
instance and i'll just start pasting in
code so if we scroll on down below here
i'm going to go to examples because i
want a small example here this is
something that i might want to do
and we're going to give that a moment
here
it's almost done
you can do a database come on
as that is going i'm going to open a new
tab
i'm going to make my way over to
cloudformation
okay
and
you can see i have some older stacks
here
notice cloud9 when we create an
environment actually creates a
cloudformation stack which is kind of
interesting
um but if we go here
we can create a stack and we can create
a file and upload it here so
okay this is good i'm going to go ahead
and make a new file
we're going to call it template
dot yaml
just so you know yaml can be yml or
y-a-m-ml
there's a big debate as to which one you
use um i think that adabus likes it when
you use the full version so i just stick
with y-a-m-l
i'm going to double click into that
and so in the cc2 example i'm just going
to copy this okay and i'm going to paste
this in here
and i'm going to type in resources
oops capital
okay so that's a resource i want to
create
um
when you create cloud formation you
always have a template version so
i just need
a basic example here at the top
i guess that's a simple one is like a
hello world bucket
maybe we should do a bucket because
it'll be a lot easier
we don't have to make our lives super
hard here
okay um but what i'm looking for is the
version because that's the first thing
that you specify
i'm just trying to find it within an
example here
oh for frick's eggs cloudformation
version
so they don't have the format version
it's going to complain there it is okay
so we'll copy that
we'll go back over here
we'll paste that in there
it might be fun to do like an output
here so i'm gonna do like an output
outputs
and uh maybe instead of doing this we'll
type in a bus s3
confirmation
because what i'm looking for is what we
can set as output so we'll say return
values here
um
maybe we just want
returns the domain name
so we'll just say
uh
value
ref that that's going to get the
reference for it and we have to say
hello bucket
uh type string
i'll say outputs confirmation example
and even though i've written tons of
cloud information it's just like if
you're not doing it on day in day out
you start to forget what it is
so here for outputs we need a logical id
description value and export so
um
that is what i want so i'm going to go
ahead and copy that back here
this is just so that when we run it
we're going to be able to observe an
output from the cloud formation file
okay so the logical id is whatever we
want so hello bucket domain
it's funny because this is how you do
do kind of that would be the format for
terraform i was getting that mixed up
so the domain
of the bucket
the value here is going to be ref
hello
bucket
domain name
that's the output
export
value to export
uh can i get an example here
else name
oh you know what export is for uh cross
stacks we don't need to do that okay so
that's fine so what we'll do is set that
and we'll take out our old one and so
this should create us an s3 bucket so
with cloudformation you can
provide a template here by providing a
url or you can upload a file directly
so
i'm just trying to decide here how i
want to do this you can also use a
sample file or create a template in the
designer i'm going to go over to the
designer
because then we can just like paste in
what we want so if i go over to yaml
here
and we go back over here i copy this
i'm just going to paste this in here
and we're going to hit the refresh
button nobody ever uses the designer but
this is just kind of an easy example for
me to
place this in here
it's not really working maybe i go to
template dude here
refresh
there we go so there's our bucket it's
nice to have a little visualization and
i believe this is going to work as
expected so now that we have our
designer template i think if we hit
close what's this button say
validate template probably good idea
validating the template
template contains errors unresolved
resource dependency in the output block
of the template hello
domain
bucket
seems like it should be fine
let's go oops
let's go back over here
that's what i did i said reference
that value
oh uh maybe it's get a trib okay
it's get att sorry
get a trib
cloud formation
i can't remember if there's an r on the
end of it oh it's just att this is if
you're trying to get a return intrinsic
value so a reference is like what the
default one is but every time we do like
a logical name and attribute that's how
we get that there so
what i'm going to do here is just hit
refresh
and i'm going to validate that one more
time
now it's valid if i hover over this is
it going to upload it create the stack
we could save this save it
but we can save it in s3 bucket so we'll
say hello
bucket
and so now we have this url so i'm going
to copy it honestly i never use this
editor so it's kind of interesting
i'm going to leave
and we're probably going to hit create
stack but i just find it a bit easier if
we just kind of do it through
this here so go back create the stack
we're going to paste in the url we're
going to say next
and we're going to say
my new stack
and i didn't see what the name of the
bucket was
oh there's no name so it's going to
randomize that's perfect so we'll go
next
we have a bunch of options here we'll
hit next
we'll give it a moment here i guess we
have to review it create the stack
and this is the part where we watch so
it says create in progress and we wait
and we hit refresh
and we can see what's happening it's
trying to create a bucket
and if we go to resources this is this
is a lot easier to track because you can
see all the resources that are being
created
if you notice that when you use the cl
uh when you're using the abs management
calls in korean s3 bucket it's
instantaneous but like with cloud
formation there's a bit of delay because
there's some communication going on
board but here it is and notice if we go
to our outputs this is the the value of
the bucket domain name if we were to
make it with uh self-hosting which is
not what we're doing with it we could
also have an export name which would be
used for cross-referencing stacks which
is not something we care to do
but yeah that's how you create a stack
that way
um but you know we can also do it via
the sdk here so
what i can do
um
is look up what is the inves
cli cloud formation
because they have their own commands
here if i go here
there's a new one and there's an old one
so
if we go create stack
yeah there's things like this like
create stack update
um so if we wanted to do it this way
okay and i copied this here
i'm just gonna put this in my readme
here for a second
uh so here what you do is you say my new
stack
and you can provide the template url or
you could specify the local path here
so we have like a template body so i'm
gonna go ahead and grab that
okay
this would be like yaml
and
um i need to specify this file here so
template.yaml
and i'm just gonna go pwd here to get
the full path
okay
and i'm going to just paste that in
there oops
okay i'm going to do ls
okay so that gives us the full path of
the file you can also specify the
template url
and so this should work as well if i
take this and paste that on as a command
it's unable to locate parameter file
there's three
three triple slashes there we'll just
fix that there
paste
unable to load param file
no such file of directory and there's a
t missing
okay
be like don't be like me and make sure
you don't have spell any mistakes okay i
can type clear down here so i can see
what i'm doing we'll hit enter whoops
unable to load the parameter file notice
file or directory
home well i you didn't want the forward
slash
so another thing we can try to do i
think it will take it relative so if i
do this it should work
i don't ever remember having to specify
the entire path an error occurred while
calling the crate stack my new stack
name already exists if i go back over
here give this a refresh oh that's what
we named our stack the the one that we
did so i'm going to say stack2
okay
format unsupported structure when
calling the create stack operation
are you kidding me i do this all the
time
template body
yaml file cloudformation
unsupported structure take a look here
oh you know what i think uh this one's
out of date that's why so what we can do
is go to our old stack here and we can
actually see the template i can go ahead
and copy this whoops and we can go ahead
and paste that in there and then now
what i can do
so you know that's that's the reason why
it wasn't working okay so we'll hit
enter
um
unsupported structure
it should be supported
let's see if cloudformation can help us
out
um
apparently there was very unhelpful
error message formatting so try the
validate template option
i wonder if we could just do this
maybe if that would help here
i'm just heading up to try to run it
again
nope i guess we can try to validate it
here
it's like i'm not having much luck here
today
so we'll just say this here
maybe it's not even loading that file
where it is i
so there's no errors
i'm just going to make this one line
okay created so for whatever reason i
must have had a bug there and so
sometimes putting on one line helps that
out because i must have had an obvious
mistake there and now we can see the
stack is creating it's doing the exact
same thing it's creating a different
bucket though if we go over to our s3
here
again you know you don't need to be able
to do this yourself to pass the exam
it's just so i'm just trying to show you
like what it is so you kind of absorb
any kind of knowledge about what's going
on here notice down below it uses the
stack name followed by uh the read the
logical name of the resource there
okay
and what we'll do is wait for that to
create once that's created we can go
ahead and delete these stacks we could
also use the aws cloud formation to say
like delete stack but i don't want to
bore you with that today
and so we'll hit refresh here wait for
those stacks to vanish
okay those are gone uh what i'm going to
do is kill this cloud9 environment
if there's a way to do it from here i
have never known how to do it go back to
your dashboard well that's nice to know
we'll go ahead and just delete this
okay
we'll close that tab
and so now we are all in good shape and
so that was our introduction to
cloudformation okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at cdk so ctk
allows you to use your favorite
programming language to write
infrastructure as code and technically
that's not true because they don't have
ruby and that's my favorite but anyway
some of the languages include node.js
typescript python
java.net and so here's an example of
typescript typescript was the first
language that was introduced for cdk
it's usually the most up-to-date so
not always does cdk reflect exactly
what's in cloud formation but i think
they're getting better at that okay so
cdk is powered by cloudformation it
generates outcloud formation templates
so there is an intermediate step uh it
does sometimes feel a bit slow so i
don't really like that but you know it's
up to you cdk has a large library of
reusable cloud components called cdk
constructs at constructs.dev this is
kind of the concept of terraform modules
it is really really useful uh and
they're really well written and they can
just reduce a lot of your effort there
ct cdk comes with its own cli um and i
didn't mention this before but cloud
formation also has its own uh
cli okay cdk pipelines uh are
allow you to quickly set up ci cd
pipelines for cdk projects that is a big
pain point for cloud formation where you
have to write a lot of code to do this
whereas
the cdk has that off the bat makes it
really easy for you cdk also has a
testing framework for unit and
integration testing i think this might
be only limited to typescript because i
didn't see any for the rest of the
languages but um you know i wasn't 100
sure there
this
one thing about cdk is that it can be
easily
confused with sdk because they both
allow you to pragmatically work with aws
uh using your favorite language but the
key difference is that cdk ensures uh it
opponents
of your infrastructure so what that
means that's such a hard word to say but
what that means is that um
you know if you use this cdk to say give
me a virtual machine you'll always have
a single virtual machine uh because it's
trying to manage the state of the file
whereas uh when you use sdk if you run
it every time you'll end up with more
and more servers uh and it's not really
managing state so hopefully that is
clear between the difference there
[Music]
okay so we looked at cloud formation but
now let's take a look at cdk cloud
formation or confirmation cloud
development kit it's just like cloud
formation but you use a programming
language in order to implement your
infrastructure as a code i don't use it
very often i don't particularly like it
but you know if you are a developer and
you don't like writing cloud formation
files and you want to have something
that's more pragmatic you might be used
to that um this i think should be
deleting because we were deleting the
last one here and notice how it's grayed
out i can't select it so don't worry
about that create a new one it will say
example we'll hit next
t2 micro ec2 instance amazon x2 you know
the drill it's all fine here we'll go
ahead and create ourselves a new
environment we're going to let that spin
up there and as that's going we're going
to look up
adabus cdk
so it was cdk
and we probably want to go to github for
this
okay because it is open source
and so i want to go to getting started
and i have used this before but i never
can remember how to use it
probably the easiest way to
use this is by using typescript
so
here's an example initialize a project
make directory cdk oh first we gotta
install it right
so give that a moment so this is node
you know how we did like bundle install
this is like the same thing but for uh
typescript installer update the it was
cdkcli from npm we recommend using this
version
etc etc
so again we're just waiting for that to
launch but as we wait for that it's very
simple we're just going to install it
create a directory
go into that directory initialize the
example
here it's setting up an sqsq
which is um that's quite a complex
example
but you can see it's code right and then
we run cdk deploy and we'll deploy it
and then hopefully we'll have that
resource so again we're just waiting for
cloud nine
there we go so cloud nine is more or
less ready uh terminal seems like it's
still thinking
and we have a javascript one which i do
not care about there we go there's our
environment we're going to make sure we
have npm so we can type in npm
great it says version 8.1.0
and so
this is asking for 10.
okay i don't know if this gives us like
nvm installed mvm
it does so what we can do is do mvm list
that stands for node version manager
ruby has one as well and so it's telling
us what version we're on i want to
update um looks like we have a pretty uh
pretty new version but what i want is
the latest version of
oh but that's node version that's not
necessarily npm so we'll do node version
oh 17 okay we're well
well in the uh range of the new stuff so
what i'm going to do is scroll on down
we're going to grab this link here or
this code here hit enter
and that's going to install the adabus
cdk
so it says
file already exists oh so maybe it's
already installed on the machine
um
cdk let's type in cdk
because of course aws wants to make it
very easy for us this software has not
been tested with
what was that warning
with node 1701 you may encounter runtime
issues great aws you're like the one
that installed this stuff here so we get
a bunch of the commands which is great
and so what we'll do is follow their
simple instructions we'll say hello cdk
we will cd into this
and
now what we can do is run cdk init
and this language here
and so that's going to do a bunch of
stuff creates tons of files it's going
to vary based on what you're using
like which language because cdk comes
available in a variety of languages so
if you type in aws cdk
documentation here
notice up here
python java.net
so i think it has more than just those
three languages but um
you know i wish it supported more like
yeah i see here is c-sharp java
but i really wish there was a ruby
so we'll give this a moment here to get
installed and i will see you back here
when it is done okay
okay uh it turns out i only had to wait
like a second there but it says there's
a newer version of the cdk you probably
should install it but
i just want to get going here so as long
as i don't run into any issues i do not
care um but anyway so looking at this
and again i rarely ever look at this but
i'm a developer so it's not too hard for
me to figure out but under the lib this
is our stack that we're creating and
here is it is loading in sqs it's
loading in sns
and then the core library it's creating
an sqsq
and it's setting the visibility of that
timeout it's also creating an sns topic
so those are two resources that we
expect to be created
if we scroll on down to the getting
started it just says cdk deploy
so what we'll do is go ahead and hit
enter
and let that do whatever it wants to do
and it is thinking there we go so here
we have i am statement changes so it's
saying this deployment will potentially
make potential sensitive changes
according to your current security
approval options
there is there may be security related
changes not in this list do you want to
deploy sure we'll hit y
deploying creating cloud information
change that so cdk is using
cloudformation underneath
it's not complicated
and as that is going what we'll do is
we'll make our way over to our aws
amazon.com console
and if we go over to cloudformation
we'll see if we see anything yet
so it's creating a stack here we can
click into it we can go over to our
events
see that things are being created this
is always confusing so i always go to
resources to see what is individually
being created and they're all done
so we go over here and they exist
so here it says
that we have a queue called this
right sometimes they have links you can
link through it so
notice here i can click on the topic and
get to that resource in sns which is
nice for sqs i'm just going to type in
sqs enter
and there it is okay so we don't really
understand what those are we could
delete the stack this way there's
probably a cdk way to delete the stack
so
cdk destroy
i assume that's what it is
destroy okay so we'll type in cdk
destroy
given a moment
we're going to say yes
okay it's deleting in progress
we can even go back here and double
check
still thinking
again you know if we deleted these for
real it would take like a second
but you know sometimes they're just slow
sometimes it's because a resource can
get hung
as well
but uh i don't think anything is a
problem so here we can see what the
problem is
not necessarily a problem but it's just
the sqs is taking a long uh longer time
to delete where the s subscription is a
lot faster
so i'll just see you back here in a
moment okay okay so after a short little
wait there it finally finished uh i just
kept on hitting refresh until i saw it
deleted and so it's out of there and so
we'll get rid of our cloud9 environment
since we are done with it
so type in cloud9 up at the top
and we'll go ahead and delete
and we will go ahead and delete this
here thank you
and we will go back to our aws
amazon.console here just so we can get
our
bearings straight here
and there we go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
aws toolkit for vs code so aws toolkit
is an open source plugin for vs code to
create debug deploy it was resources
since vs code is such a popular
editor these days i use vim but it's
very popular um i figured i should make
sure you're aware of this um plugin so
it can do four things you get the abyss
explorer this allows you to explore a
wide range of database resources linked
to your aws account
uh and sometimes you can view them
sometimes you can delete them it's going
to vary per service and what's available
there then you have the aws cdk explorer
this allows you to explore your stacks
defined by cdk
then you have amazon elastic
container service ecs this provides
intellisense for ecs task definition
files intellisense means that when you
type
and you you'll get like autocompletion
but you'll also get a description as to
what it is that you're typing out then
there is serverless applications and
this is pretty much the main reason to
have database toolkit it allows you to
create debug deploy service applications
via sam and cfn and so
there you can see the command palette
and you can kind of access stuff there
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at access keys so
an access key is a key and secret
required to have pragmatic access to
database resources when interacting with
the awps api outside of the aws
management console so uh access key is
commonly referred to as aws credentials
so if someone says database credentials
so you generally are talking about the
access key not necessarily your
username and password to log in
so a user must be granted access to use
access key so when you're creating a
user you can just check box access key
um you can always do this after the fact
but it's good to do that as you're
creating the user and then you can
generate an access key and secret so you
should never share your access keys with
anyone they are yours if you give them
to someone else it's like giving them
the keys to your house it's dangerous
never commit access keys to a code base
because that is a good place for it to
get leaked at some point you can have
two active keys at any given time you
can deactivate access keys obviously
delete them as well access keys have
whatever access a user has to aims
resources so
you know you can do the database
management console so can the key
so access keys are to be stored in the
aws.aws credentials file so um and if
you're not familiar with linux this
tilde here this actually represents your
home folder so whether you're on windows
or a linux that's going to be your home
folder and then you have this period aws
that means that it's a hidden folder but
you can obviously access it and so in
the it's just a tommel like file i think
it's tommel um but i never
uh 100 verified that it's tommle it
looks just like tarmal
and so what you'll have here is your uh
default profile and so this is
what you would use um or this is what
any of your tools you use like the cli
or anything else would automatically use
if um
if you did not specify a profile you can
of course store multiple access keys and
then give it a profile name
um so if you are doing this for the
first time you might just want to type
in aws config and it'll prompt you and
you'll just enter them in there as well
i think that sets the default one when
you're using the sdk
you would rather probably use
environment variables because this is
the safest way to access them when you
are writing code all right
so there you go
[Music]
all right let's talk about access keys
access keys are very important to your
account um and so what we'll do is go to
im if you are the root user you can go
in and you can uh generate access keys
for people um but uh generally you're
doing it yourself for your own account
so i go to users i'm going to click into
mine here and we'll go over to security
credentials and here you're going to
notice access keys and one thing that is
interesting is that you can only ever
have two access keys at a time so hit
create i'm just going to close that
notice that the button is grayed out i
can
deactivate them if i feel that i haven't
used them in a while and i can make them
active again so i can bring them back
into access or what i can do is
make them inactive
right
and then i can delete them
and so
what i recommend
right even if you do not want to
pragmatically be using your account for
anything you always want to fill up both
these and the reason why and this is for
security reasons is that if somebody
wanted to come in
and uh uh get into your account what
they would do is they would try to find
a user
where they have access to them and then
they would try to generate out a key so
if both these keys are taken up so if
you generate both these keys
okay and this is the one you want to use
you deactivate the other one okay we're
not going to use that one and so now
there's no way for them to fill up that
other slot okay
and so that is my strong recommendation
to you but there's again only ever two
here i'm just going to
uh delete both of these so that
when we want to uh do whatever next in a
tutorial we'll go generate that out okay
so go ahead and clear that out
so hopefully that is
enough for you to understand what to do
with these axis keys okay
so i'm gonna go back here
there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at aws
documentation which is a large
collection of technical documentation on
how to use aws services which we can
find at doc.abs.amazon.com
and so this is kind of like the landing
page where you can see all the guides
and api references if you expand them in
there
into ec2 and you click on the user guide
you can see html in pdf format kindle
and you'll notice there's a link to
github and that's because all of these
docs are open source and you can
contribute to them if you choose to do
so i've done so multiple times in the
past it's quite fun so aws is very good
about providing detailed information
about every individ service and the
basis of this course and any aws
certification will derive mostly from uh
the adabus documentation so i like to
say that i'm not really coming up with
new information i'm just taking what's
in the docs and trying to make it more
digestible and i think that's the thing
is like the docs are really good you can
read them end to end but they are very
dense
and so it can be a bit hard to figure
out what you should read and what you
should not um but they are a really
great resource and you should spend some
time in there okay
[Music]
so i just want to quickly show you the
aws documentation like give you a bit of
a tour of it so if we go to
about.amazon.com and type in docs
i'm sure you might have seen this
through other tutorials but the idea is
that you have basically documentation
for basically any possible service that
you want and a lot of times you'll click
into it and what you'll get are these
little boxes and they'll show you
different guides and it's going to vary
based on service but a lot of times
there's a user guide there's an api
reference
those are the two that you'll see there
maybe go to something simpler like s3
that might be a simple example yeah user
guide api api reference and so
all of these are on github right if you
open these up the documentation is here
if you find something you don't like you
can submit issues
and uh and correct things you can even
submit your own examples i have um
i have committed uh example code to the
docs specifically for ai services so you
might be looking examples that i
implemented or even ruby examples since
i really like to promote ruby on aws you
can download it as a pdf or you can take
it as html a lot of times you're going
to the user guide and the way i build
the courses here is i actually go
through and i read these end to end so
you know if you wanted to do that you
want to be like me you can do that or
you can just watch my courses and save
yourself the trouble and not worry about
everything that is here but generally
the documentation is extremely extremely
good there are some exceptions like
amazon cognito where the content is good
but it's just not well organized so i
would say aws out of every other
provider they have the most complete
documentation
they generally don't keep their examples
or like tutorials within here it's
usually pretty light they'll have some
examples
um but like they like to have items labs
separately so you type if it's labs
github right you go here
and a lot of stuff is in here instead so
you have a lot of great tutorials and
examples over there okay
um but yeah pretty much that's all there
is to it is there consistency between
documentations no they kind of vary
um you know but uh it's all there is my
point and they're always keeping up to
date so that's all you need to know
about the aws documentation
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the shared
responsibility model which is a cloud
security framework that defines the
security obligations of the customer
versus the cloud service provider in
this case we're talking about aws and
they have their own shared
responsibility model it's this big ugly
blob here
and the thing is is that every single
csp has their own variant on the model
so they're generally all the same but
some visualizations make it a little bit
easier to understand or they kind of
include a little bit more information at
different parts of it and so just to get
make sure that you have well-rounded
knowledge i'm going to go beyond the
aws's shared responsibility model and
just show you some variants uh there's
also variance not just per uh csp but
also the type of cloud deployment model
and sometimes these are also scoped
based on a cloud service category like
compute or machine learning and these
can result in specialized share
responsibility models so that's what
we'll look at in this section okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at the
adab shared responsibility model and so
i've reworked the graphic because it is
a bit hard to uh digest and so i'm
hoping that this way will be a little
bit easier for you i cannot include the
in and of here just because we're
limited for space but don't worry we'll
follow that up with the next slide here
so there are two people that are
responsible or two
organizations that are responsible the
customer and aws and on investors side
they're going to be responsible for
anything that is physical so we're
talking about hardware global
infrastructure so the regions the
availability zones the edge locations
the physical security so think of all
that hardware that's there those data
centers um everything like that then
there's also software the services that
they're offering and so
you know this extends to all their
services but generally it breaks down to
the four core and so we're talking about
compute storage database and networking
okay and when we say networking we're
talking about like physically setting up
the wires and also you know the software
to set up the routing and all that kind
of stuff there
now looking at the customer side of it
they're responsible for configuration of
managed services or third-party software
so the platforms they use so whether
they choose to use a particular type of
os
the applications so if they want to use
like ruby on rails uh iam so identity
and access management so if you uh
create a user and you grant them
permissions if you give them things
they're not supposed to have access to
that's on you right then there's
configuration of virtual infrastructure
and systems so that would be choosing
your os that would be the networking so
there could be networking on the um
the virtual machines themselves or we
could be talking about cloud networking
in this case then there are firewalls so
we're talking about virtual firewalls
again they could be on the virtual
machine or it could be configuring like
knuckles or security groups on aws then
there's security configuration of data
uh and so there is client-side data
encryption so if you're moving something
from s3 from your local machine to s3
you might need to encrypt that first
before you send it over then there's
server side encryption so that might be
turning on server-side encryption within
s3 or turning it encryption on your ebs
volume then there's networking traffic
protection so you know that's turning on
vpc flow logs so you can monitor them
turning on aws guard duties so that it
can detect anomalies with your traffic
or or activities within your
aws account and then there's customer
data so that's the data that you upload
on the behalf of your customers or
yourself and what you decide to um you
know like what levels of sensitivity
that you want to lock it down do you
want to use amazon macy to
see if there's any public facing uh
personally identifiable information
that's up to you so there's a lot here
and honestly it's a lot easier than you
think um instead of thinking about this
big diagram what i do is i break it down
into this and so we have the in and the
oven that's what i said i could not fit
on the
previous slide there but the idea is
customers are responsible for the
security in the cloud so that's your
data and configuration so if it's data
that's residing on there or is this
something you can configure you are
responsible for it on the adaba side
they are responsible for the security of
the cloud so if it's anything physical
or hardware the operation of managed
services or global infrastructure that's
going to be on them and this in and of
thing is very important for the exam so
you should absolutely know the
difference between the two this is kind
of an aws concept i don't see any other
cloud service provider talking about in
and of uh so you definitely need to know
it okay
[Music]
so one variant we might see for the
uh shared responsibility model would be
on the types of cloud computing this
could also be applicable to the types of
deployment models but we're doing types
of cloud computing here and so we have
the customer's responsibility and then
the cloud service provider's
responsibility so we're seeing
on-premise
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service and
so when you are on-prem you're basically
responsible for everything apps data
runtime middleware os virtualization
servers storage networking basically
everything and just by adopting the
cloud you're almost cutting your
responsibilities in half here so now the
cloud service provider is going to be
responsible for the physical networking
uh the physical storage those physical
servers and because they're offering
virtual machines to you they're setting
up a hypervisor
on your behalf so virtualization is
taken care for you and so um you know if
you launch an ec2 instance you know
you're going to have to choose the os
that's why you're responsible whatever
middleware there the run time so
whatever kind of programs you install on
it
the data that resides on it and any kind
of like major applications okay
then we have platform as a service uh
and so you know the cloud service
provider is gonna take even more
responsibility there so when we're
talking about this we're thinking like
abos elastic bean stock right so you
know the you just choose what you want
and it's all managed so you might say i
want a ruby on a rail server but you're
not saying what os you need um you're
not
saying exactly you might say what
version of ruby you want but you don't
have to manage it if it breaks
or it might be managed updates and
things like that the last thing here is
like software as a service and this is
something where the csp is responsible
for everything so if you're thinking of
a software as a service think of like
microsoft word where
you're just writing uh you know writing
stuff in there and you know you you are
responsible for where you might choose
to store your data but the data is like
still handled by the cloud service
fighter because you know it's on the
cloud so on their servers right
so yeah hopefully that gives you kind of
an idea across types of cloud
computing responsibilities
[Music]
all right so what i want to do here is
just shift the lens a bit and look at
the shared responsibility model if we
were just
observing a subset of cloud services
such as compute and so we're going to
see infrastructure as a service platform
as a service software as a service and
now we have function as a service and so
that's what i mean when we shift the
lens we get new information
and so you can just see that you really
don't want to look at this from one
perspective okay so starting at the top
here we have bare metal uh and so abs's
offering is called the ec2 bare metal
instance and this is where you basically
get the whole machine uh you can
configure the entire machine with with
the exception of the physical machine
itself so as the customer you can
install the host os
the host os so the operating system that
runs on the physical machine and then
you can install your own hypervisor um
and then awesome is going to be
responsible for the rest the physical
machine now normally the next step up
would be dedicated but dedicated doesn't
exactly give you more responsibility it
gives you more assurance because it's a
single tenant virtual machine and that's
why i kind of left it out here but we'll
see it in the next slide that it is kind
of on the model and shares the same spot
as uh ec2
but ec2 is a virtual machine and so um
here the customer is responsible for the
guest os so that means that you can
choose what os you want whether it is
ubuntu or debian or windows but that's
not the actual os that is running on the
physical machine and so you're not going
to have control of that aws is going to
take care of that then there's the
container runtime so you know you you
can install docker on this or any kind
of container layer that you want um so
that's another thing that you can do so
aws is going to be responsible for the
hypervisor uh the physical machine and
the host os all right
then looking at containers it just has
more than one offering for containers
but we'll just look at ecs here and so
this is where you are going to
have uh you don't you don't install the
guest os right the guest os is already
there for you what you are going to do
is choose your configuration of
containers you're going to
deploy your containers you're going to
determine where you need to access
storage for your containers or attach
storage to your containers and databus
is going to be responsible for
the guest os
the there might not even be a guest os
but they're the host os the guest os the
hypervisor the container runtime and
you're just responsible for your
containers okay
then going to the next level here we
have platform as a service and so this
one also is a little bit odd where it
fits um because the thing is is that
this could be using anything underneath
it could be using containers it could be
using virtual machines
and so that's where it doesn't exactly
fit well on a linear graph but let's
just take a look at some things here so
this is where you're just uploading your
code
you have some configuration of the
environment you have options of
deployment strategies
the configuration of the associated
services and then a bus is going to be
responsible for the servers the os the
networking the storage the security so
it is taking on more responsibility than
infrastructure as a service um uh
whereas you know
aws is just gonna be responsible for
that so if it's a virtual machine that's
being under uh under the use their
business is going to be responsible for
this customer stuff okay you're not if
it's containers that abuse is going to
be responsible for this but it just
depends on how that platform as a
service is set up actually the way
elastic bean stock is set up is that you
actually have access to all that
infrastructure and you can fiddle with
it and so in that case uh whereas like
if you were to use heroku which is a a
third-party provider
you know they would take care of all
this stuff up here um and so you would
not have to worry about it but on aws
you actually are responsible for uh the
underlying infrastructure because you
can you can configure it you can touch
it so that's where you know again these
do not fit perfectly and you can't look
at platform as a service meaning that um
you're not responsible for certain
things it really comes down to the
service offering okay then we're taking
a look at software as a service so on
aws
this is going to be something like um
amazon work docs which is i believe a
competitor
not a very popular competitor but a
competitor to
microsoft sharepoint and this is for
content collaboration says the customer
you're responsible for the contents of
the document management of the files
configuration of sharing access controls
and the database is responsible for the
servers the os networking the the
storage the security and everything else
so you know if you use the microsoft
word doc and you type stuff in it you
say where to save it that's what you're
responsible for okay the last one here
on the list is our uh functions here and
so aws's offer is it was lambda and so
as the customer all you're doing is
you're uploading your code and database
is going to take care of the rest so
deployment container runtime networking
storage security physical machine
basically everything um
and so you're really just left to
develop okay so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea and again you
know we could have thrown in a few other
services like what we could not fit on
this slide here was
um
it was fargate which is a serverless
container as a function or sorry
serverless serverless container as a
service or container as a service so
you know that has its own unique
properties in the model as well okay so
let's just have kind of a visualization
on a linear graph here so we have the
customer's responsibility on the
left-hand side and it was a
responsibility on the right and we'll
look at our broad category so we got
bare metal dedicated virtual machines
containers and functions and so no
matter
which
type of compute you're using you're
always responsible for your code for
containers you know if uh you know like
uh the functions when you're using
functions there are pre-built containers
so you'd say i want to use ruby and
there's a ruby container and you don't
have to configure it but obviously um
you know when you're using container
service you are configuring that
container you are responsible for it for
virtual machines you know you're
responsible for the run time so you can
install a container runtime on there or
install a bunch of different packages
like ruby and stuff like that
the operating system you have control
over in the virtual machines for the
dedicated and we saw with bare metal you
have both uh controls of the host os and
the guest os and then only bare metal
allows you to have control of the
virtualization where you can install
that hypervisor so hopefully that gives
you an idea of compute and databases
offering there and also kind of how
there's a lot of little caveats when
we're looking at the shared
responsibility model okay
[Music]
all right so i have one more variant of
the share responsibility model and this
one is actually what is used by google
so um we're going to apply to aws and uh
see how it works so let's just kind of
redefine shared responsibility model or
just in a slightly different way so we
fully understand it so the share
responsibility model is a simple
visualization that helps determine what
the customer is responsible for and what
the csp is responsible for related to
aws and so across the top we have
infrastructure service platform as a
service software as a service but
remember there's other ones out there
like function as a service it's just not
going to fit on here
okay so and then along the side here we
have content access policies usage
deployment web application security
identity operations access and
authentication
network security remember that's cloud
networking security the guest os data
and content audit logging now we have
the actual traditional networking or
physical networking storage and
encryption and here we're probably
talking about the physical storage
hardened kernel ipc
uh the boot the hardware and so then
here we have our bars so we have the
csp's responsibility and the customers
responsibility so when we're looking at
a sas software as a service
uh the customer is gonna be responsible
for the content remember like think of
like a word processor you're writing the
content the access policies like say i
want to share this document with someone
the usage like how you utilize it can
you upgrade your plan things like that
then next on our list here is platform
as a service so generally uh you know
platform is a services for developers to
develop and deploy applications and so
they will generally have more than one
deploy strategy
and uh you know there might be some cost
saving measures to choose like uh you
might have to pay additional for
security uh or you or it's up to you to
configure in a particular way or you
might have to integrate it with other
services
uh and you know we saw that pass is not
a perfect uh definition or fit because
you know when we look at elastic bean
stock if you have access to those
resources and you can change them
underneath then you might have more
responsibility there than you think that
you would
okay the next one here is infrastructure
as a service and so this is extending to
identity so who's allowed to uh you know
log into your aws account
operations the things that they're
allowed to do in the account access and
authentication do they have to use mfa
things like that network security
obviously you can configure the security
of your cloud infrastructure or cloud
network um you know so you know do you
isolate everything a single vpc how do
you set up your security groups things
like that
we know with virtual machines you can
set up the guest os there's data and
content but remember that bare metal is
part of the uh infrastructure service
offering and so that's where we'd see
hardware or not hardware but you'd have
the host of the host os or
virtualization and so this again is not
a perfect representation
but it generally works okay and then
last and list there or just
looking at what the aws is responsible
for auto logging so of course database
has cloudtrail which is for uh
logging api um events but auto logging
could be things that are internally
happening with those physical servers
then the networking the physical storage
hardening the kernel airbus has i think
what's called the nitro system where
they have like a security chip that's uh
installed on all their servers then it's
the the boot os uh and then the hardware
itself okay
so just remember the customer is
responsible for the data and
configuration of access controls that
reside in aws so if you can configure it
or you can put data on it you're
responsible for it okay the customer is
responsible for the configuration of
cloud services and granting access to
users via permissions right so if you
give
one of your employees access to do it
you know even if it's their fault it's
your fault so remember that
again the csp is generally responsible
for the underlying infrastructure we say
generally because you know there's edge
cases like bare metal and coming back to
aws is in the cloud and of the cloud so
in the cloud so if you configure it or
store it then you the customer are
responsible for it and of the cloud if
you cannot configure it then the csp is
probably responsible for it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the shared
responsibility model from the
perspective of architecture and if
you're getting sick of share
responsibility model don't worry i think
this will be the last uh slide in this
section but let's take a look here so uh
we have uh
less responsibility more responsible at
the bottom so what we have down here is
traditional or virtual machine
architecture so global workforce is most
familiar with this kind of architecture
and there's lots of documentation
frameworks and support so maybe this
would be using elastic beanstalk with
platform as a service or using ec2
instances alongside with auto scaling
groups code deploy
load balancers things like that the next
level here is micro services or
containers this is where you mix and
match languages better utilization of
resources so maybe you're using fargate
which is serverless containers or
elastic container service or elastic
kubernetes service for containers on the
top here we have serverless or commonly
with functions as a service so there are
no more servers you just worry about the
data
and the code right so literally just
functions of code and so you could be
using the amplify serverless framework
or maybe able lambda for creating
serverless architecture so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking computing services and
before we jump into uh the entire suite
of computing services database have
let's just talk about ec2 for a moment
which allows you to launch virtual
machines so what is a virtual machine
well a virtual machine or vm is an
emulation of a physical computer using
software server virtualization allows
you to easily create copy resize or
migrate your server multiple vms can run
on the same physical server so you can
share the cost with other customers so
imagine if your server or computer was
an executable file on your computer okay
so that's the kind of way you want to
think about it when we launch a vm
we call it an instance and so ec2 is
highly configurable server where you can
choose the ami so the amazon machine
image that affects options such as
amount of cpus or vcpus virtual cpus
amount of memory so ram the amount of
network bandwidth the operating system
so whether it's windows ubuntu amazon s2
the ability to attach multiple virtual
hard drives for storage so elastic block
store
um and so the amazon machine image is a
predefined configuration for a vm so
just remember that
and so ec2 is also considered the
backbone of aws because the majority of
services are using ec2 as the underlying
servers whether it's s3 rds dynamodb or
lambdas that is what it's using so
um what i say also is just because when
we talk about the aws network that is
the backbone for
global infrastructure
and the networking at large and so ec2
is for the services okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
so we just looked at what ec2 is but
let's look at more of the broader
services for computing and these are the
more common ones that you'll come across
there's definitely more than just what
we're going to see on the single slide
here so break this down with virtual
machines containers and then serverless
for virtual machines remember that's an
emulation of a physical computer using
software and ec2 is the main one
but for our vm category we have amazon
light sale this is a managed virtual
server service it is the friendly
version of ec2 virtual machines so when
you need to launch a linux or windows
server but you don't have much invoice
knowledge you could launch a wordpress
here and you could hook up your domain
and stuff like that
so this is a very good option for
beginners we have containers so
virtualizing an operating system or os
to run multiple workloads on a single os
instance so containers are generally
used in microservice architecture when
you divide your application into smaller
applications that talk to each other so
here we would have ecs elastic container
service this is a container
orchestration service that supports
docker containers
launches a cluster of servers on these
two instances with docker installed so
when you need docker as a service or you
need to run containers we have elastic
container registry ecr this is a
repository of container images so in
order to launch a container you need an
image an image just means a safe copy a
repository just means a storage that has
version control we have ecs fargate or
just fargate now people are kind of
forgetting that it's it runs on ecs
these days that's why i have it in there
it is a service orchestration container
service is the same as ecs
accept you pay on demand per running
container so with ecs you have to keep a
ec2 server running even if you have no
containers running so it is manages the
underlying server so you don't have to
scale or upgrade the ec2 server so
there's the advantage over ecs okay then
we have elastic kubernetes service eks
this is a fully managed community
service criminal or so kubernetes
commonly abbreviated to k8 is an open
source orchestration software that was
created by google as generally the
standard for managing microservices so
when you need to run kubernetes as a
service then we have serverless
categories so when the underlying
servers are managed by device you don't
worry or configure servers soybes lambda
is a servless function service you can
run code without provisioning or
managing servers you upload small pieces
of code choose much uh how much memory
how long you want the function to run is
allowed to run before timing out and you
are charged based on the runtime of the
service function rounded to the nearest
100 milliseconds so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to do is just show you a
variety of different computing services
on aws so i'm going to try to launch
them and we're not going to do anything
with them i'm just going to simply
launch them okay so the first i want to
show you is ec2 and by the way we will
go more in depth and ec2 later on in
this course here
but what i'm going to do is go ahead and
launch the instance don't worry about
all this stuff but just choose the
amazon linux 2 so it's in the free tier
all right we're going to choose an
instance type of a t2 micro so that's
part of the free tier it's going to be
set as one all these options are fine i
want you to go ahead and review and
launch we're going to launch
and i don't want to generate any key
pair i'm going to proceed without a key
pair i'm going to acknowledge that
because i don't want it and that's all
there is to launching an ec2 instance
and so i can go here and view my
instances
and what you'll see is it's pending okay
and usually it has like a little
spinning icon maybe they've updated it
since then
so i go here it's hard to see because
there's all these terminated ones but i
don't need to do anything with it i just
wanted to show you the actions that
you'd have to do to launch it actually
we'll leave it alone maybe we'll see it
when it's launched the next one i want
to show you is
elastic container service
um and wow this this is all let's go
let's get the new experience please
that's so old
okay check box that on
and we'll hit get started
and we'll say create a cluster
and we have some options here networking
only ec2 linux plus networking uh
for use with either aws fargate or
external windows
um
this is if you're doing fargate which
we're not doing right now fargate is
part of elastic container service it
used it well it used to be it is called
ecs fargate but it was markets it as a
separate service we'll go to next we'll
say my ecs cluster
um we can create an empty cluster but
that would make it a fargate cluster
which we don't want there's an on-demand
server look it's m6i large if you're
very afraid of a lot of spend here you
don't have to do this you can just watch
me do it and just learn
well what i'm going to do is try to find
something super cheap so i want a t2
micro or a t3 micro t2 micro is part of
the free tier i don't know if we get to
choose t2 anymore in here they might not
let you
there it is
but you know t3 micro is great too i
just
whatever says it's free that's what i'm
going to go for
number of instances one the amazon linux
version is fine i don't care about a key
pair
[Music]
use existing vpc i don't want to have to
make a new one select the existing ones
okay
let it create a new security group
that's totally fine
allow those to be fine create a new role
that's fine create
okay
and so that's going to create ourselves
a cluster
i'm going to just make a new tab here
let's just check on our ec2 instance
and so if we look at our ec2 instance it
is running
okay great so it has a private ip
address it has a public ip address all
right
there's not much we can do with it i
can't even log into it because we didn't
generate it out of key pair a lot of
times you want to name these things so
let's go here name it my server okay
go back to our ecs instance and the
cluster is ready so we'll go here and oh
nice we got a new ui and so if we wanted
to deploy something as a service or a
task
um
we would need to
create a template like a task definition
file
uh they don't have a new ui for this
you're being redirected to the previous
version console because this isn't
available in the new experience yet of
course it isn't so we can create a new
task definition file that's what's used
to run it it's basically like a docker
file compose file whatever you want um
we have fargate or ec2 we are doing ecs
so we're going to have to do ec2 so
we'll say my ecs
task def file
um task role
optional i am role i don't need one
network mode i don't care
and then this is the idea is that
because a container allows you to use up
a particular amount of the
thing we don't have to use all of the
memory so we should look up what a t2
micro is
because i don't even remember what size
it is okay t2 micro aws
so we go here we look at the instance
types
and we're gonna flip over to t2
and it says that it's one vcpu
one gigabyte of memory so what i'll do
one
yeah one okay that's fine so what we
want and this is in megabytes so we'll
say 500 megabytes
and um
i don't know if we can do less than one
but i'm going to do one here
the task cpu must be an integer greater
than or equal to 128 okay fine 128. oh i
guess it's 1024 would utilize the whole
thing so i could say 512
okay
and this is where we would add our
container
so
i don't do this every day so i don't
remember how to do this we'll say my
container
and i need a repository here so i need
like docker hub hello world
okay i don't care what it is i just need
a image that's simple
and i'm looking for the address here
um
i'm hoping that's just this
docker hub url
so it'd be something like this right
docker io probably
docker io docker image
docker hub url in ecs
okay it goes to show how often i'm
launching these things
so repository url
docker image so i think that what we're
going to do here
hmm
i would really just like the url please
reviews
tags
where is it
where is it it's somewhere here right
uh
well let's just try it we'll go and
we'll type in
says image and tag so docker dot io
hello world i really need an image id
image url hello world
docker hub
they're not making my life easy here
today
anything i just want to see like a
single example
docker dot io
docker io
url examples
ecs
this is what it's like you know this is
what you're going to be doing if you are
um you know a cloud engineer you're
going to be googling a lot and just
trying to find examples
here
so here it says docker io the name the
hostname
okay so we'll just try it okay so i
think that
the the
the name here is underscore and then
it's hello world and that's what's
throwing me off here right docker io
just hold on here
repository url and then there's the tag
i don't know if like is the tag gonna be
like latest view available tags
latest okay so what i'll do here
and that's the thing you have to have a
lot of confidence too so hard limit soft
limit
do i have to set it
do i have to set any of these things can
i just go to the bottom and hit add
looks like i can
okay so we'll scroll on down create
we create our task definition file which
is fine we're going to go back to our
cluster it's going to bring us back to
the new experience we're going to click
into this cluster
holy smokes uh we're going to hit deploy
and we're going to choose service that
means it's going to continuously run
task means that when it's done running
it ends we're going to choose our family
or version that's the task definition
file there
it's not compatible with the selected
compute strategy
my task file
what if i just choose task
take that
okay so maybe some you have to like code
it so that it continuously runs i don't
care we don't need to run a service here
the selected task definition is not
compatible with the selected compute
strategy
okay
let's see why
can you double check if you're using
fargate strategy instead of the ec2 uh
blog design for the ec2 strategy so
probably what it's suggesting is that
the strategy file i made is not for the
right one here
task definitions
go back over here
well what's wrong with it
taskroll none
my container so what i'm going to do
because i don't trust this
i'm going to go ahead and delete this
can i delete this how do i delete this
oh boy
actions
deregister deregister
we'll create a new one and so it was has
tools like it was copilot
cli to make this a lot easier because
you can see this is very frustrating but
i chose this
so my task def
requires compatibility of ec2
default
512 512
add
container we're going to
uh was it docker dot io underscore
what's it called hello world
i will just say hello world here
and we'll just say
512 which is fine i don't care about any
port mappings i'm just reading it
carefully here to see what it wants
we'll say 512 maybe because i didn't
specify them it's complaining
this looks fine we'll hit add
okay
constraints type this all looks fine so
we'll try this again
and so we now have our file let's see we
can just run this task from here
ec2
this is just another way to do it so we
just choose the cluster this is actually
a lot easier to do it this is old old
old eh this is ugly
and so now it launches so you know if
you have trouble one way then just do it
another way and sometimes it'll work
here so i don't expect this task to
really work in any particular way
if it's pending that's fine if it fails
it's fine if it's successful that's fine
i don't care
i just want to go through the motion so
it was successful
it ran and then it stopped
i don't know if we could see like the
output anywhere probably what it would
do is it would log out something like
into
somewhere
and so i don't know if like there's logs
turned on for this if i go over to like
cloud watch logs
maybe i could see something
a lot of these services will
automatically create cloud watch logs so
sometimes you can just go look at them
there
so we'll drop down we'll go to log
groups here
there is some stuff here um there's a
couple that i created from before just
go ahead delete those
and so what i'm looking for is like ecs
so no there's no logging happening here
which is totally fine so that is ecs um
for fargate it's pretty much
the same the difference is that fargate
is like it has to start up and run so
it's a lot slower to watch
okay
and now let's go take a look at
lambda
okay
so this is our serverless compute
so go ahead and create ourselves a
function uh we can start from a
blueprint
that doesn't sound too bad
and i personally like ruby so no i'm not
getting much here
but we can do is look for something like
hello do we have like a hello world
there we go hello world and we'll click
that we'll say my hello world
uh it's going to create those
permissions that's fine it's showing us
the code it's very simple okay it's
going to console log out these values
not a very good hello world function
doesn't even say hello world
how can you call it a hello world
function if it doesn't say hello world i
don't understand
so i'm going to go ahead and create this
function usually doesn't take this long
okay so uh here is our function here is
our code notice that this is cloud9
okay and you can even move that over to
cloud9 they didn't have this button here
before that's kind of cool i hit test
they used to have it up here
but i guess they wanted to make it more
obvious so they moved it down here which
is nice so what i can do is
hit this oops my test
it's going to send a payload here to the
actual function and it's going to
tell us if it worked
okay so can i run my test
go over here to test
it changed a bit so i guess i created
there it succeeded so i have my logs
okay so it's going to output those
values there
so there are the three values which
basically is nothing
maybe you were supposed to set those an
environment variable but you can see
you're just uploading uh some code right
it's just a bit of code it's not like a
full app or anything so we
launched an ec2 container we did a
a um
sorry an ec2 instance a container we did
a serverless function there's other
things like eks but that is really
really hard to set up
okay because you'd have to use like
kubernetes commands and stuff like that
and my kubernetes knowledge is always
very poor um i'm just taking a peek here
to see if they've updated it so yeah you
create the cluster but like deploying it
is
forget it i'm just trying to think of
there's anything else i kind of want to
show you um no those are the main three
i would say so i'm pretty happy with
that um what i'm gonna do is
go and kill all these things so we're
gonna go over to lambda
okay
and i'm going to go ahead and delete
this
as you saw ecs was the hardest and no
matter how many times i've built things
in ecs and i've deployed full things on
ecs i can't remember i always have so
much trouble with task definition files
it's unbelievable we'll go over to our
cluster here
and
ecs cluster up here
make sure you're not in the fargate
cluster i know i'm clicking really fast
but there's just so many things to click
and i'm going to click into this cluster
we're going to hit edit because this is
running an ec2 instance right i need to
destroy it
um
it just took me back to the old one here
i want to delete no i want to delete the
cluster
click back here
where do i delete it
up here
here
i can't checkbox anything
uh
how do i
delete this do i have to delete the task
first maybe so we'll go here
i mean it's already stopped there's
nothing to do
edit
uh
account settings
wow this is confusing
okay
how to delete ecs cluster
you gotta be kidding me i have to
actually look this up so open the ses
console from navigation in the
navigation choose clusters
and the new turn off the
turn off new ecs experience and choose
the old console the delete cluster
workflow is not supported in the ec ecs
console are you serious
then why
why do you have it like why even let
people use the new experience if that
you don't have all the functionality
there um
oh i was gonna give it feedback but it
didn't let me here's it says uh
i need to delete an ecs cluster
no okay so i'm here
there's my big ugly cluster
delete cluster
okay
so yeah it's a struggle okay like things
are always changing on me but you just
have to have confidence and if you've
done it a few times you know that you
can do it
right um and that's one of the biggest
hang-ups to cloud i would say so it's
going to take a few minutes apparently
to delete the cluster as that is going
let's go over to ec2
i didn't close it i kept this tab open
and uh
there's our ec2 instance
we can go ahead and terminate that
instance terminate
okay
and
if this says it's terminating then we're
in good shape terminator shutting down
that's fine
and notice here that's the ecs instance
just make sure you shut down the my
server not the um the ecs instance
because that's going to stop and so this
has already terminated but if we go back
here
notice that it says that it's not done
but clearly
clearly has shut down
okay
so i'm going to wait here for a bit even
though i know it's been deleted maybe
it's deleting things like the auto
scaling group so we go down below here
right so that's probably what it's doing
it's probably trying to destroy the auto
scaling group
but it doesn't show any here so it must
have already destroyed it
yeah so task services delete so i'll be
back here in a bit but i know it's safe
it's already deleted but i'll see you
back here in a bit okay
so i waited literally a second and it's
now deleted so we deleted our lambda we
deleted our oh did we delete our lambda
good question
now i'm not really worried about the
lambda because
i guess we did but i'm not really
worried about it because um
you know
when it rests at idle it's not
costing us anything where the ecs and
the ec2 are backed by ec2 instances so
we do have to shut those down okay and
again remember you make sure you're in
the correct region sometimes that gets
flipped over and then you think those
resources are gone but they're actually
not they're just running in another
region so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at higher
performance computing services on aws so
before we do we've got to talk about the
nitro system so this is a combination of
dedicated hardware and lightweight
hypervisor enabling faster innovation
and enhanced security all new ec2
instant types use the nitro system and
the nitrous system is designed
by aws okay so this is made up of a few
things we have
nitro cards
these are specialized cards for vpcs ebs
instant storage and controller cards you
have nitro security chips these are
integrated into the motherboard protects
hardware resources and we have the nitro
hypervisor this is the lightweight hyper
visor memory and cpu allocation bare
metal like performance there's also
nitro enclaves but that's a bit out of
scope here but that has to do with like
ec2 isolation okay
then we have bare metal instances so you
can launch ec2 instances that have no
hypervisor so you can run workloads
directly on the hardware for maximum
performance and control we have the m5
the r5
ec2 instances that can run bare metal
there's other ones i believe i've seen
as well but you know
if you are running bare metal you can
just go investigate at the time of okay
we have bottle rocket this is a linux
based open source operating system that
is purpose built by adabus for running
containers on vms or bare metal hosts
then let's just define what hbc is so
it's a cluster of 100 of thousands of
servers with fast connections between
each of them with the purpose of
boosting computing capacity so when you
need a super computer to perform
computational problems too large to run
on a standard computer or computers or
would take too long this is where you
know hbc comes into play one solution
here is abs parallel cluster which is an
ada supported open source cluster
management tool that makes it easy for
you to deploy and manage high
performance computing hpc clusters and
aws so hopefully that gives you an idea
of this stuff okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at hpc or
high performance computing on aws so hpc
is for uh running large complex
simulations and deep learning workloads
in the cloud with a complete suite of
high performance computing product
services gains insight faster and
quickly move from idea to market blah
blah blah it's for ml or very complex
scientific computing stuff these run at
least on c5 ends
okay and the way it works is that you
use this cli called p cluster variable's
parallel compute
or
it was parallel cluster stuff and so
let's see if we can get this installed
very easily
um so what i'm going to do
is see how hard it is to install
now i don't recommend you running this
because i don't know what it's going to
cost me and if i make a misconfiguration
i don't want you to have that spent here
but i don't think it's that dangerous so
i'm going to go back over to usc 1 here
i'm going to open up cloud shell
and i'm going to give it a moment to
load
and so as that is loading let's take a
look at how we would go ahead and
install this so install the current
parallel
it is parallel i think we just copy that
line
okay
and so we have to wait for environment
to spin up alright so once it has spun
up we will install it
and then we will jump over
to this tutorial
here okay so we'll give this a moment
and after waiting a little while here it
looks like our shell is ready it looks
like it's in bash um i'm just going to
type in aws s3 ls that's a sanity check
okay
and it works that's great so go back
over here and i'm going to go back up to
install for linux
and what i need
is that single command
where is it
so
i'm certain that we already have linux
or python installed
but i just
want the command to install it
we saw it a moment ago here i'm just
going to back out until i can find it
one more
there it is so it's under oh it's this
link here and that's what i talk about
the documentations being tricky
sometimes you have to click these uh
headings here to find stuff so
this is the first time installing it so
we'll grab that usually you're supposed
to create in virtual environments with
python i don't care this is my cloud
shell it doesn't matter to me so we're
going to go ahead and download that and
hopefully it is fast and it was super
fast which was really nice and so what
we'll do is go check out the p cluster
version
okay and that looks fine to me i'm going
to go down below here to run our first
job
the returns the it gives outputs i don't
think we need to configure it because we
already have our cli so what i'm going
to do is go ahead and create ourselves a
new cluster
um beginning cluster creation
configuration file config not found so i
guess we do have to configure this
configure
and it's asking what region do we want
to be in um if i have usc 1 i would
choose it for some reasons all the way
for number 13 that is not a lucky number
but i'm going to choose it anyway anyway
no key pair found in us east 1 region
please create one of the following
so create an ec2 key pairs
no options found for ec2 key pairs
that's fine so what i'll do is go over
here
and we'll go over to ec2
and we will go over to key pairs key
pairs key pairs key pairs we'll create
ourselves a new one here so say
hpc key pair
or just my hpc
so we know what it is for
we have putty or pem we're going to do
pem because we're on linux we'll create
that
and notice that it downloaded the pen
down down here and we're going to need
that for later
um and so what i'll do
is i'll type in p cluster here again
configure we'll choose 13
we'll choose number one here
allowed values for the scheduler i have
no idea
what these are
uh let's choose the number one allowed
values for the operating system amazon
linux 2. i know what that is minimum
cluster size
one
maximum cluster size
two
head notice instance oh t2 micro you can
do that yeah let's do it i didn't know
we could do that enter compute type uh
t2 micro sure
so i thought that we'd have to use a c5n
but i guess apparently not automate vpn
vpc creation yes of course
network configuration so allowed values
for the network configuration
a head node in a public subnet and can
and compute fleet in a private subnet
a head node and compute that will do in
the both just to make our lives easier i
don't care
first one sounds more secure of course
and so
oh it's creating cloud information sack
wow this is easy i thought this was
going to be super painful okay so we'll
go over here we'll go take a look at
what cloudformation's doing
all right
now i don't care if we actually run a
task on here but it was just interesting
to go through the process to see how
hard it was and we will go look at what
resources are being created so it's
creating an internet gateway so it's
literally creating a isolate vpc for it
which is totally fine i guess
it's creating a subnet it's creating a
route table refresh here
um i'm not sure how much it wants to
create here
it just looks like vpc that's all it's
creating i thought maybe the ec2
instances would show up here but maybe
it's going to launch that at
on a need be basis
okay so that's all created oh now it's
doing a vpc gateway
i think vpc gateways cost money let's go
take a look here people say pricing
yeah there's a
transfer fee so just be careful about
that
you know again you just can just watch
along here you don't have to do it
default route depends on public so now
it's creating ec2 route
i don't know what an aws ec2 route is
i've never seen that before sometimes
what we can do is go into ec2 and then
take a look on the left hand side you
see anything in here we don't know what
it is we just type in ec2 route cloud
formation sometimes cloudformation is
great for figuring out what a component
is not all components are represented in
the um
um
management console so specify route in
the row table oh it's just a route okay
and we'll go back here we'll refresh
so that is done
is the stack done
created complete good we'll go back to
our cloud shell
it says you can edit your configuration
file or simply do etc so now let's see
if we can create the cluster
i assume this would create ec2 instances
so the job scheduler you are using is
sge this is deprecated in future use
parallel cluster well should have told
me okay
there is a new version of three zero one
parallel available i don't understand
because i just installed it right
we'll go back to cloudformation we're
just gonna probably create nested stacks
which
that's what i thought it would do nessa
stacks means that it's reliant so
there's one main one and then there's uh
children stack
so go here see what resources it's
creating
a whole bunch of stuff wow
so many things that sqsq sns
a network interface
a dynamodb table
yeah you probably don't want to run this
you just want to watch me do it
and then we go into here it's creating
an ec2 volume so that's going to be ebs
and then here we have
a log group i don't know why they
separated those out it seemed very
necessary
we are waiting on the elastic ip that
always takes forever creating elastic ip
root instance profile that is the item
role for it
that didn't take too long
these these take a long time i never
know why
you create a role it's really easy but
attaching an iron policy you're always
waiting for those
um
so
i'm gonna just stop it here i'll be back
in a second because i don't want to have
to make you watch me
stare at the screen here okay
all right so after a really really long
wait um
and it always takes some time there it
finally created i'm not sure what it's
made i mean we generally saw over here
in the outputs
but usually the cost that i'm worried
about is whatever it's launching under
ec2 it might not even have launched any
servers here we're going to take a look
here and see if there's anything
so
we have a master and a compute and
they're t2 micro so
seems pretty safe here
this compute is not running yet so i'm
assuming that this is
like the machine that does the computing
and maybe if you had multiple machines
here like that would be the cluster like
would manage multiple computes
i'm not particularly sure but let's just
keep going through the tutorial and see
what we can do the next step is we need
to get this pen key
in our cloud shell here so this i don't
know where this is but what i'm going to
do
is i'm going to move it to my desktop
i'm doing this off screen by the way so
i'm moving it to my desktop and then i'm
just going to go and upload the file
okay
and there it is so we'll say open
and we'll say upload
and it's going to upload it here onto
this machine and i believe this is on
like uh i think this uses an efs
instance
like if you're wondering where the
storage for cloud shell is if we go over
here i think it's efs
is it
uh i don't know where it is okay maybe
it's just uh maybe it's somewhere else
okay i can't remember where it is but
anyway um so now
it's created the cluster can i hit enter
here
okay
can i create a tab
like if i quit this is it going to kill
it
it exited it which is i think it's fine
i don't think it stopped running
and so now if i do an ls there's my key
and so we can go back to our
instructions we just have too many tabs
open here
drag this all the way to the left here
and so we can try to use our key here to
log in
so what i'm going to do is
go here and we'll say my hpc pem and see
if that works we'll say yes
and permission denied it is required
your private key is not accessible
that's because we have to mod it
um
i never remember the command anymore
because i rarely ssh into machines but
if we go to connect
and we go to ssh client it will tell us
that we need to run
chamod 400 okay so that's what we need
to do is we need to do a chamat400
just wanted to grab that code there
okay and now if we hit up we should ssh
into the machine there we are
we are in the instance
we'll type it exit and so now we want to
run our job on this machine
and if we go back over to here
i guess we can go create our first job
so i'm just doing this in vi
and i'm gonna paste that in yep
and i don't want the first line oh okay
that's perfect oh great
right
quit oh there's no file name hold on
here
so i need to name this file something so
i'm going to say job.sh
and we're going to paste that again here
we'll say paste
and i don't know if that's cut off yeah
it is okay great
is that one okay
i don't trust that the first line is
there
so what i'm gonna do
is go back to our tutorial here
it's shebang forward slash bin forward
slash bash
uh
this then that
forward slash bin forward slash bash
just double check it looks good to me
we're going to quit that i'm just going
to make sure that it is what we said it
is so job.sh
looks correct to me good and so we'll
try to run our job here so i'm going to
say q
um job.sh
ls
and i guess it really depends on what we
decided to use when we set up that thing
i can't remember what we choose as our
queue
we do qstat
oh you okay okay okay so i think the
thing is like you see how we have sg i
think that that's what we use to queue
up jobs and so we have to have that
installed probably so install
configure sun grid engine
sg install
linux
oh boy that looks like a lot of work
so i don't think we need to do anything
further here but as far as i understand
the idea is that you're choosing
some kind of way to manage these and so
i'm not sure what q q sub is let's just
go look at what that is what is q sub
oh that is the sun grid engine
okay so
how do we install that
um
[Music]
i'm just gonna see if we can install it
so i'm gonna do
i think this is using yum
so if i do clear here
clear
yum install q sub let's see if i can do
it
sudo yum install qsum no package
available
amazon linux 2
q sub because that's probably what we're
running in cloud shell
q sub doesn't tell us how to install it
that's great
so that's probably what it is and so in
order to use this we would have to
install that
sun whatever whatever
and then we go through we do q sub it
would cue it up um you could do q stat
cat hello destroy it that's pretty much
all we really need to know to understand
this
it would have been nice to queue up a
job and see it work but you know we're
getting kind of into a hairy territory
here and i think that we fundamentally
understand how this does work so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to go here
i'm going to remove the job.sh here and
i want to destroy this cluster
so i'm going to do p cluster commands
to figure out what all the commands are
and there's probably a delete command so
we'll go back up here
be cluster
where is our credit so we'll say delete
okay and so what that's going to do is
just tear down all the stuff now
so if we go over to cloudformation
okay and
it looks like it's destroying so
yeah i'll see you here uh back in a bit
when it's all destroyed okay
all right so after a short little wait
there it has destroyed it has been so
long that i uh my connection vanished
but just make sure if you did follow
along for whatever reason uh you know
make sure that the stuff is deleted and
it looks like it did not destroy uh this
so i'm going to go ahead and delete that
that's just vpc stuff so i'm not too
worried about it i know that's going to
roll back no problem and so i'm going to
consider this done so i'm going to make
my way back to the management console
close this stuff up and we are good to
go for our next thing
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at edge and
hybrid computing services so what is
edge computing when you push your
computing workloads outside of your
network to run close to the destination
location
so an example would be pushing computing
to run on phones iot devices external
servers not within your cloud network
what is hybrid computing when you're
able to run workloads on both your
on-premise data center and the above
vpc okay
so we have a few services here starting
with abus outposts this is a physical
rack of servers that you can put into
your data center invoice outputs allows
you to use aws api and services uh such
as ec2 right in your data center then we
have abs wavelength this allows you to
build and launch your applications in a
telecom data center by doing this your
applications will have ultra low latency
since they will be pushed over the 5g
network and be closest as possible to
the end user
so they've partnered with things like
verizon vodafone business and a few
others but those are the two noticeable
ones okay we have vmware cloud on aws so
this allows you to manage on-premise
virtual machines using vmware
within ec2 instances the data center
must be using vmware for virtualization
for this to work okay
then we have abs local zones which are
edged data centers located outside of
the database region so you can use it as
closer to the edge destination when you
need faster computing storage databases
in populated areas that are outside of
aws region you could do this there's
some other edge offerings on aws that
aren't listed here like sagemaker has
was called like neo stage maker unless
you do edge computing with
ml but i mean this is good enough okay
[Music]
all right so i wanted just to show an
example of edge computing because we
didn't cover it in our generic compute
and so there's a variety of services
that allow you to do edge computing like
wavelength and so
i've never actually launched wavelength
before and i think that you have to
request it so
if i go over to support here again i've
never done this before but i'm sure we
can figure it out pretty easily i feel
that if we create a case
um maybe it's like service limit
we type in wavelength here well nope not
there
so how do we get wavelength wavelength
request
so that's what i'm looking for here
okay
how do i use wavelength aws
whoops
and sometimes what i'll do is go to the
docs here
opt into wavelength zones before you
specify wavelength zone for resource or
service you must opt into it to opt in
go to the aws console
okay so we'll go to ec2
and
then it's going to say use the region
selector in the navigation bar to select
the region which supports your
wavelength
so i know that there's stuff in
uh us west because
of las vegas right or not las vegas but
los angeles right
so if we go over here there's definitely
that over there on the navigation pane
of the ec2 dashboard under account
attribute select zones
okay do we see zones here
zones
oh ec2 dashboard
zones let's go check here again
on the navigation pane choose ec2
dashboard we are there right
and under account attributes settings
account attributes
oh over here okay
oh it's here zones
and so there we have two zones and we
see
switch regions to make
zones a different region
okay so
under zone groups turn on wavelengths
zone groups
okay nothing there so i'm just going to
switch over to another one here
oh maybe oregon
maybe cs west 2. oh look at all the
stuff we have here i've never seen these
before okay so
here is the wavelength one so that is
the los angeles one
we can go ahead and enable this before
december the zone group i'm not sure
what zone groups cost so
wavelength zone pricing
again you might just want to watch me do
this because it might cost money
and so you might not want to
have to spend for that
pricing
provides mobile networks wavelengths are
available across whatever learn about
the data transfers enterprise about ec2
instances
okay so what's the price
we're going to here
alright so what i'm going to suggest to
you is don't do this but i'm going to do
it and we're just going to see what the
experience is like okay
so i'm going to update my zone so now i
have this one so we'll say enable
i'm going to assume that it has to do
with like data transfer costs
okay
and uh we're going to go over to ec2
and we're going to go over to instances
here
we're going to launch an instance and
we're going to see if we have that
available now i don't know if we're
restricted to particular to particular
uh instances i assume we can launch a
linux machine
it'd be really weird if we couldn't you
know we'll go over to configuration and
what we want to do is choose
the zone so how do we do it so once it's
turned on
confirmation confirm it configure your
network so create a vpc create a carrier
gateway so you can connect your
resources into the vpc to the
telecommunication network
holy smokes this is complicated
but it's just kind of interesting to see
like the process right
you know it's not for our use case but
uh
carrier gateway right
and as i do this i always check up all
the costs here so i say
carrier gateway
pricing aws because maybe that's where
the price is
okay if you don't get a pricing page
then usually that's hard to say
logically isolated virtual networks
again it's not telling me what
um to use carrier you need to opt into
at least one wavelength zone but i did
right
and sometimes what happens is that it
just takes time for the opt-in to to go
so go here manage the zone settings
that was a lot easier way so we have one
it's we're opted in right here
okay
and
okay we'll go here again if that one
didn't work um
we can try
so i guess these are all the regions
denver things like that
can i
opt into this one opt-in
it's not super exciting like all we're
going to do is launch an ec2 instance
but you know we'll go through the
process here a bit
and i don't know why i can't create one
so we'll go back over to the
instructions here
credit so you can connect so create a
route table using the vpc to the route
table so i think that's as far as we're
going to get here because i'm not seeing
any options here but the idea was that
we would have to create a carrier
gateway we'd update our route tables and
all we would be doing is launching an
ec2 instance so you know it's no
different than launching it you just
choose a different subnet so i think
you'd have to create a subnet for that
zone and launch it in there and that
would be edge computing another example
of edge computing would be something
like via cloudfront
which we have these
edge functions or
not edge functions have functions here
and so these are functions that are
deployed to cloudfront so
my cloudfront function
and these would be deployed to um
edge locations right and all you can use
here is javascript so here's an example
of one
and
um i'm fine with this
development live this function is not
published we'll go to test
test the function it's good
publish publish that function and so
the advantage of this is that you know
if you have functions that are in it
with lambda there's a chance of cold
start
um whereas if they're deployed on the
edge here there's still probably a cold
start but it's going to be a lot faster
because it's a lot closer to
the edge location so
um you know
it's just the different uh different
cases but yeah there was one where we're
launching ec2 workload into wavelengths
which we couldn't complete which is
totally fine and then we have these
functions on the edge there's other edge
computing services like within sagemaker
you can deploy i think it's called like
neo sagemaker and then for iot devices
those are obviously on the edge so you
can deploy those as well
but generally that gives you an idea of
edge computing okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're looking at cost and capacity
management computing services so before
we talk about them let's define what is
cost management so this is how do we
save money and we have capacity
management how do we meet the demand of
traffic and usages through adding or
upgrading servers so let's get to it the
first are the different types of ect
pricing models so you got spot instances
reserved instances saving plans these
are ways to save on computing by paying
up in full or partially or by committing
to a yearly contract or multi-year
contract
or by being flexible about the
availability interruption to computing
services we have it was batch so this
plan schedules and executes your batch
compute workloads across the full range
of aws computing services which can
utilize spot instances to save money we
have abyss compute optimizer so suggest
how to reduce costs and improve
performance by using machine learning to
analyze
your previous usage history we have ec2
auto scan groups so asgs these
automatically add or remove ec2 servers
to meet the current demand all of
traffic they will save you money and
meet capacity since you only run the
amount of servers you need then we have
elb so elastic load bouncer so this
distributes traffic to multiple
instances we can reroute traffic from
unhealthy instances to healthy instances
and can route traffic to ec2 instances
running in different availability zones
and then we have elastic beanstalk here
which is easy for deploying web
applications without developers having
to worry about setting up and
understanding the io underlying aweso
services similar to heroku it's a
platform as a service so not all these
are about cost some of them are about
capacity management like elb
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the types of
storage services and no matter what
cloud service provider using they're
usually broken down into these three
where we have blocks file
and um
uh object okay so let's take a look at
the first so this is going to be for
block storage so for aws this is called
elastic block store data is split into
evenly split blocks directly accessed by
the operating system and supports only a
single right volume so imagine you have
an application
over here and that application is using
a virtual machine that has a specific
operating system and then it has a drive
mounted to it uh it could be using fc or
scuzzy here
but the idea here is when you need a
virtual drive attached to your vm is
when you're going to be using block okay
the next one here is for um file or it's
just basically a file system so this is
about elastic file storage so the file
is stored with data and metadata
multiple connections via a network share
supports multiple reads writes locks the
file so over here we could have an
application but it doesn't necessarily
have to be an application and so it's
using nasa exports as the means to
communicate and so the protocols here
can be nfs or smb which are very common
uh file system protocols and so the idea
here is when you need a file share where
multiple users or vms need to access the
same drive so this is pretty common
where you might have multiple virtual
machines and you just want to act as
like one
drive one example that could be like
let's say you're running a minecraft
server you're only allowed to have one
world on a particular single drive but
you want to be able to have multiple
virtual machines to maximize that
compute that'd be a case for that um so
there you go then the last one here is
like object storage and so for aws this
is called amazon simple storage service
or
also known as s3 so object is stored
with data metadata any unique id scales
with limited uh
with limited no file limit or storage
limit
so there's really very there's very
little limit to this it just basically
scales up supports multiple reasons
right so there are no locks and so the
protocol here we're going to be using
https and api so when you just want to
upload files and not have to worry about
the underlying infrastructure not
intended for high
iops so input and outputs per seconds
okay so depending on how fast you have
to do your read and writes are going to
determine uh you know whether you're
going uh this direction or the other way
um or you know how many
need to actually connect at the same
time and whether it has to be connected
as a mount drive to the virtual machine
okay
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're going to do a short introduction
into s3 because on the certified cloud
partitioner they ask you a little bit
more than they used to and so we need to
be a bit familiar with s3 because it is
um at least i think that abel's
considers its flagship uh storage uh
service and it really is one of the
earliest services is the second one ever
launched okay so what is object storage
or object-based storage so data storage
architecture that manages data as
objects as opposed to other storage
architectures so file systems where
these are others right so which manages
data as files and a hierarchy and block
storage which manages data as blocks
within sectors and tracks that get
stored on an actual uh drive
and so uh the idea here is we have s3
which provides basically unlimited
storage you don't need to think about
the underlying infrastructure the s3
console provides interface for you to
upload and access your data okay so we
have the concept of an s3 object so
objects contain your data they are like
files but objects may consist of a key
this is the name of the object a value
the data itself made up of a sequence of
bytes the version id when versioning
enabled the version of the object
metadata additional information attached
to the object and then you have your s3
buckets the buckets hold objects buckets
can also have folders which in turn hold
objects s3 is a universal namespace so
bucket names must be unique it's like
having a domain name okay and one other
interesting thing is an individual
object can be between zero bytes and up
to five terabytes so you have unlimited
storage but you can't have uh files of
uh incredible size uh i mean five
terabytes is a lot but nothing beyond
that for a single file but just
understand that you can actually have a
zero byte file uh and for like associate
certifications that can be
a an actual question so that's why it's
there
all right let's take a look at s3
storage glasses um and so for the
certified cloud partitioner we need to
know generally what these are for
associated levels we need more detail
than we have here but let's get through
it so adabus offers a range of s3
storage classes the trade retrieval time
accessibility durability for cheaper
storage and so the farther down we go
here the more cost effective
it should get
pending uh you know certain conditions
okay so when you put something to s3
it's going to go into the standard uh
tier the default tier here
and this is uh incredibly fast it has
99.99
availability 11 9's durability
and it's replicated across three azs and
so
uh you know we have this cheaper meter
here here on the left-hand
side that would apply this is very
expensive and it's not actually
expensive but it is expensive at scale
when you can uh better optimize it with
these other tiers so just understand
that then you have the s3 intelligent
tiering so this uses ml to analyze
objects and usage and determine the
appropriate storage class it is moved to
the most cost effective access tier
without any performance impact or added
overhead then you have s3 standard ia
which stands for infrequent access this
is just as fast as s3 standard but it's
cheaper if you access the files less
than once a month there's going to be an
additional retrieval fee applied so if
you do try to retrieve data as
frequently as s3 standard it's going to
actually end up costing you more so you
don't want to do that okay then you have
s3 one zone ia so as it says it's
running in a single zone so it's as fast
as s3 standard but it's going to have
lowered availability but you're going to
save money okay there is one caveat
though your data could get destroyed
because it's remaining in a single uh a
z so if that
a z or data centers um suffer a
catastrophe you're not going to have a
duplicate of your data to retrieve it
okay and then you have s3 glacier so for
long-term cloud storage retrieval of
data can take minutes to hours but it's
very very very cheap and then you have
esri glacier deep archive which is the
lowest cost storage class but the data
retrieval is 12 hours and so you know um
all of these here to here these are all
going to be in the same abyss s3 console
or amazon s3 console s2 glacier is
basically like its own service but it's
part of s3 so kind of lives in this
weird state there's one here that we
didn't have a list here which is s3
outputs because it has its own storage
class it doesn't exactly fit well into
this kind of leaner cheaper
thing here okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're taking a look at the aws snow
family so this is storage and compute
devices used to physically move data in
or out of the cloud when moving data
over the internet or provide private
connection that is too slow difficult or
costly so we have snow cone snow ball
edge and snowmobile and so there
originally was just snowball and then
they came out with snowball edge
and edge introduced edge computing
that's why there's edge in the name
but pretty much all of these devices
have edge computing uh and they do
individually come with some variants so
with the snowball snow cone it comes in
two sizes where it has eight terabytes
of usable storage and then there's one
with 14 terabytes of usable storage for
snowball edge it technically has like
four versions but i'm going to break it
down to two for you we have storage
optimize where we have 80 terabytes of
use
of usable storage there and then compute
optimize
30.9.5 terabytes and even though it's
not here you get a lot of vcpus and
increased memory which could be very
important if you need to do edge
computing before you send that over to
aws and then last here we have
snowmobile which can store up to 100
petabytes of storage um in the
associates i cover these in a lot more
detail because there's so much more
about these like the security of them
how they're tamper proof something like
how they have networking built in the
the connection to them but you know for
this exam that's just too much
information um you just need to know
that there are three uh three ones in
the family and generally what the sizes
are and that they're going to be all
placed into amazon s3 uh what's
interesting is that you know snowmobile
only does a hundred petabytes but adabus
markets it as you can move exabytes of
of um content because you can order more
than one of these devices so uh they'll
market it saying like snowball edge is
when you want to move uh petabytes of
data and snowball mobile is when you
want to move exabytes but you can see
that a single thing isn't in the
exabytes just in the petabyte okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at all the
innova storage services in brief here so
let's get to it so the first is simple
storage service s3 this is a serverless
object storage service you can upload
very large files and an unlimited amount
of files you pay for what you store you
don't worry about the underlying file
system or upgrading the disk size you
have s3 glacier this is a cold storage
service it's designed as a low-cost
storage solution for archiving and
long-term backup it uses previous
generation hdd drives to get that low
cost
it's highly secure and durable we have
elastic block store ebs this is a
persistent block storage service it is a
virtual hard drive in the cloud and you
attach to ec2 instances you can choose
different kinds of hard drives so ssd
iops ssd throughput hdd and
a cold hhd okay we have elastic file
storage so efs it is a cloud native nfs
file system service so file storage uh
you can mount to multiple ec2 instances
at the same time when you need to share
files between multiple servers we have
storage gateway this is a hybrid cloud
storage service that extends your
on-premise storage to the cloud we've
got three offerings here file gateway so
extend your local storage to amazon s3
volume gateway cache is your local drive
to s3 so you have a continuous backup of
the local files in the cloud tape
gateway so stores files onto virtual
tapes for backing up your files on very
cost-effective long-term storage we got
warmer page here because there's a lot
of services here we have eight of us
snow family so these are storage devices
used to physically migrate large amounts
of data to the cloud and so we have
snowball and snowball edge these are
briefcase size data storage devices
between 50 to 80 terabytes i don't
believe snowball is available anymore
it's just snowball edge but it's good to
have all of them in here so we can see
what's going on we have snowmobile this
is a cargo container filled with racks
of storage a compute that is transported
via a semi-trailer tractor truck to
transfer up to 100 petabytes of data per
trailer i don't think we're going to be
ordering that anytime soon because
that's pretty darn expensive but that's
cool we have snow cone this is a very
small version of snowball that can
transfer eight terabytes of data we have
aws backup a fully managed backup
service that makes it easy to centralize
and automate the backup of data across
multiple services so ec2 ebs rds
dynamodb efs storage gateway you create
the backup plans we have cloud endure
disaster recovery so continuously
replicates your machine in a low cost
staging area in your target able's
account and preferred region enabling
fast and reliable recovery in case of
i.t data center failures we have amazon
fsx this is a feature rich and highly
performant file system that can be used
for windows so that would be using smb
or linux which uses luster
and so there we have the amazon
fsx for windows file server so use smb
protocol and allow you to mount fsx to
windows servers and then the luster one
which uses a linux luster file system
and allows you to mount ffsx linux
servers are there any storage services
missing here not really i mean you could
count elastic container repositories one
but that's kind of something else or you
could also count
maybe um
code commit but you know i kind of put
those in a separate category where we
those are in our developer tools or our
containers okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do is show
you around s3 so we'll make our way up
here and type in s3
and
we'll let it load here and what we're
going to do is create a new bucket if
you do not see the screen just click on
the side here go to buckets and we'll
create ourselves a new bucket so bucket
names are unique so let's say my buckets
and we'll just pound in a bunch of
numbers i'm sure you're getting used to
making buckets in this
in this course so far
so if we scroll on down notice that it
says block public access settings for
this bucket and this is turned on
uh like the blocking is turned on by
default because s3 buckets are the
number one thing
that are a point of entry for malicious
actors where people leave their buckets
open so if we want to
grant access to this bucket for people
to see this publicly we'd have to turn
this off okay but for now we're going to
leave that on you can version things in
buckets which is pretty cool you can
turn on encryption which you should turn
on by default and use the amazon s3 key
on the certified cloud partitioner it's
going to ask you about client-side
encryption and server-side encryption so
you definitely want to know what these
are i'm going to turn it off for the
time being so we can kind of explore uh
here by ourself here then there's object
lock so we can lock files so that um
you know there you know people aren't
writing to them multiple times so go
ahead and create a bucket
and it's very quick so here's the new
bucket we made
and you'll notice we have nothing here
which is totally fine if i go to
properties
um
you know we can see that we can turn on
bucket versioning turn on encryption but
what i'm going to do is i'm going to go
grab some files i remember i saved
some files recently here i'm just going
to make a new folder called star trek i
just have some graphics you can pull
anything off the internet you want to do
this yourself
but i'm just going to prepare a folder
here it'll take me a moment
okay
just a moment
okay great so now i have my folder
prepared and so what i want to do is
upload my first file so i can go here
and upload
and actually i can upload multiple files
you can add a folder which is nice and
so in here if i want to upload these
files here whoops i'll just select
multiples i'll hit open it'll queue them
up which is really nice we can see the
destination details here if we want to
turn it versioning on we could there
we could apply permissions for outside
access but we have uh things turned on
but what's really important is the
properties where we have these different
tiers and so based on the tier that you
use the the lower you go at least it
should be the cheaper it's going to get
but it's going to have some trade-offs
let me cover that through the course
then there's that server side encryption
um and i'm going to hit upload we'll
just individually turn it on so
you're going to see this progress go
across the top these have all been
uploaded i'm going to click click on my
destination bucket
and so we can do is we can
open these if they're images they'll
show us
right here in the browser
we can download them so if we need to
get them again
all right we can create a folder here
and just say star trek
or enterprise d
enter prize d here
okay but it's not really easy it's not
like i can drag this into there um i
might be able there's no move option so
you'd actually have to copy it into the
destination and then delete the old one
it's not like using a file system you
know there's a lot more work involved
but you know it's a great storage
solution
um so let's look at encryption so i have
this selected here if i click into it
i can go to permissions i can go to
versions see that i'm looking for
encryption here we go so if i turn it on
i can enable encryption and i can choose
whether i want to use an amazon s3 key
so ss e
s3 so an encryption key that amazon s3
creates manages and uses for you then
you have itabus
ssc kms
and i believe this uses aes up here
which is totally fine then you have kms
down here and it's interesting because
they're like database will manage the
key for you and then this one abyss will
manage the key for you it's just
slightly different this one of course is
a lot simpler it's not many reasons not
to turn on encryption but i'm going to
go turn this one so that it is encrypted
here
and just because it's encrypted doesn't
mean we can't access the file i can
still download it i can still view it
because aws is going to decrypt it right
so if i go i click on this one and i say
open
okay even though it's encrypted i can
still view it right it just means that
it's encrypted on the storage right so
if somebody were to steal that hard
drive or whatever hard drive it's
sitting on on a bus if they can't even
figure it out it's encrypted they're not
going to be able to open up the file
right so that is the logic there but
through here
i can get it
something that's really interesting with
um
s3 is the ability to
have life cycle events so i'm just kind
of looking where that is it's usually in
the bucket so if i go to management up
here i can set up a lifecycle rule and
what i can do is say like
move this to deep storage
okay
and then i can say what it is that i
want to filter so maybe it's like
data.jpg
or i can say apply to all objects in the
bucket i acknowledge that and we say
move current versions of objects between
storage classes and i check box that on
and i can say move them to glacier after
30 days
i think if i go lower it'll complain
probably when i save there and so the
idea is that we can move things into
storage so maybe you have files coming
in down below it's showing you here
right so
a file is uploaded and then after 30
days then move them into glacier so we
save money okay that's a big advantage
of s3 there's a lot of things going on
in s3 here
like you can turn on um
uh wherever it is you can turn on
web hosting so you can turn this into
like a website down below here there's a
whole a whole bunch of things that you
can do okay so we're not going to get
into that because that's just too much
work
but
you know we learned the basics of s3 so
what i want to do to delete this i have
to empty it first watch it'll be like
you cannot delete it you need to empty
the bucket first so go ahead and empty
it
and i'll save my bucket empty
or sorry i guess i have to type in
permanently delete
perm
[Music]
delete
no
they used to oh yeah i can copy it okay
great
and so once the bucket is emptied i can
go back to the bucket
and
i'll go back one layer and then i'll go
ahead and delete my bucket
and you can only have so many buckets i
think it's like a hundred you get like
100 buckets
how many buckets can you have
in aws
100 buckets yeah i was right
and i think if you wanted to know how
many you pro there's probably like a
service limits page service limits
service quotas
so you go here you say aw services s3
how many buckets 100 right there
okay so you know that gives you kind of
an idea what's going on there but there
you go that's s3
[Music]
all right so let's go take a look at
elastic block store which is uh virtual
hard drives for ec2 so what i'm going to
do is make my way over to the ec2
console because that is where it's at
and on the left hand side if we scroll
on down you'll see elastic block volumes
or elastic block store volumes and so we
can go here and the idea is we can go
ahead and create ourselves a volume and
what you'll notice is that we have a few
different options here we have general
purpose provisioned iops cold hdd
throughput optimized magnetic
magnetic beam basically like physical
tape that you can use to back up like
the old school stuff and so you have all
these options here and you can choose
the size so when you change these
options you're going to notice that some
things are going to change like the
through throughput or iops so notice
that
general purpose is fixed at between 300
to 3000 and notice that it goes from one
gigabyte to
how many ever that is that's a lot there
and so it's not too complicated but in
practicality i don't really create
volumes this way what i do
is i'll just go launch an ec2 instance
so i'll say launch ec2 instance and
we'll choose amazon linux 2
and again you know if we haven't done
the ec2 follow along we'll cover all
this stuff in more detail don't worry
about it
we go to configure instance then we go
to add storage and this is what you're
going to
be doing when adding ebs volumes um to
your ec2 instances and you'll notice we
always have a root volume that's
attached to the ec2 instance that we
cannot remove we can change the size up
here i believe the oh it shows us right
here that we have up to 30 gigabytes so
sometimes you might want to max that out
to take advantage of the free tier you
notice we can also change this there
might be some limitations in terms of
the root volume so notice that we have a
few more options here we can't have a
cold hdd or
hdd as our
root volume
uh notice we have a delete on
termination so ebs volume persists
independently from the running life so
you can choose to automatically delete
ebs volume when the associated instance
is terminated so if you take this off if
the ec2 instance is deleted the volume
will still remain which could be
something that's important to you
uh for encryption here um you might want
to turn it on and so generally aws
always has a kms managed key which is
free so you check box that on it will be
encrypted
you can turn it on later
but you can never turn encryption off
but you should always uh turn encryption
on and so just be aware to turn that on
you can also add file systems down below
here but maybe we'll talk about that
later because i think that gets into um
efs okay so that is a different type of
file storage there but that's pretty
much
all there is to it uh you just go ahead
and create your volume there and then it
would show up under ebs we could take
snapshots of them to back them up that
goes to s3 but that's all we really need
to know here okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at elastic
file
system or efs
storage manage file storage
what is efs stand for efs system elastic
file system okay sorry and so what we
can do is go ahead and create a file
system here so i'm going to say my efs
and the great thing is that it basically
is serverless so it's only going to be
what you consume right so what you store
and what you consume
and i think that's what's going to be
based on we have to choose a vpc i want
to launch it in my default vpc
and we have the choice of regional or
one zone
i guess this is going to be based on
what gets backed up to s3 possibly so
one zone probably is more cost effective
but i'm going to choose regional and
that's a new option i never noticed
before i just opened it up to see a few
more things here we have general max io
bursting provision things like that
we'll hit next
we'll choose our azs
and uh then you might have to set up a
policy so i'm going to hit next here
you'll go ahead and hit create so you
know this is really interesting but the
trick to it is really mounting it to
a dc2 instance
and that's kind of the pain okay
so if we go into this
um you have to mount it
and
there are commands for it so like efs
mounting linux commands
okay
i've done this in my solutions architect
associate uh but you know again i'm not
doing on a regular basis so i don't
remember
and so if we go here i'm just trying to
see if we can see some code that tells
us how to mount it
so mounting on an ec2
ec2 linux instance with the ef-s mount
helper
um so i don't know if they had that
before but that sounds interesting so
pseudo mount hyphen t the file system
the efs mounting point
yeah this looks a lot easier than what
we had before okay so before i had to
enter a bunch of weird commands but now
it looks like they've boiled it down to
a single command but once you have your
efs instance
um
i'm going to assume that there is an
entry point here
just clicking around here seeing what we
can see
i would imagine we have to create an
access point
so my access point
sure
i don't know if it's going to let me
just do that
it did and so i would imagine that you'd
probably use an access point let's go
back here if that's mount point
i think that's the same thing i think
the mount point and the access point you
create access points and that's what you
use uh we can go here we can attach it
so oh yeah here's the command so
um mount via dns or mount via ip address
so it doesn't look too hard
we can try to give it a go i haven't
done it in a while it looks like they've
made it easier so
maybe we'll try it out okay
so go to ec2 here
and
i'm going to launch an instance
i'm going to choose amazon linux2
okay we're going to go and
choose that and then
we want to choose a file system
and so
it's going to mount to here okay
and storage is fine all this is fine and
i'm going to go ahead and launch this
and
i need a new key pair so create a new
key pair
this will be for efs example
okay
we're going to download that key pair
there we're going to launch this
instance
okay and then we're going to go view
this and as that is launching what i'm
going to do is open up my cloud shell
and i'm going to want to upload this pen
so again like before i'm going to drag
it to my desktop off screen
and then what i'm going to do is upload
this file so i have it
efs example
okay we're going to upload it
i just want to see if we can access that
efs volume
and so
if i do ls
that's our old one which i can delete by
the way i'm never going to use that
anytime soon yes
ls and i'm just delete the hello text
there so it's a bit cleaner for what
we're doing and so we need to mod that
uh efs example
and we saw that's how like if you want
to try to connect to a server remotely
that's what you do right so i believe
that the drive is mounted
if i go to storage does it show up here
it doesn't show up under here
but
what we're waiting for are these two
status checks to pass and then we can
ssh into this machine
and i'm just going to go back here and
take a look here so using the efs mount
helper
so sudo mount hyphen t efs tls this
volume to efs and so i imagine it's
going to mount it to efs here using the
nfs client
so i guess it just depends on what we're
going to have available to us
even if the sas checks haven't passed
i'm going to try to get into this anyway
so
what we can do is click on this
grab the public ip address we'll type in
ssh
ec2 hyphen user at sign paste this in
hyphen i efs example pem i usually don't
log in via ssh
um but you know just for this example i
will and so i want to see if this drive
exists
it usually be under mount right
there it is
okay so it already mounted for us
so i can do touch
hello world
dot text
say sudo here
i can say sudo vi i'm going to open up
the file and say
hello from another
computer okay
and so i've saved that file and what i
want to do now
oops
oh okay sorry i'm in the cloud shell
here but what i want to do now is i want
to kill this machine
okay and what i'm going to do is spin up
another ec2 instance
i'm going to see if when i mount that if
that file is there if it actually worked
but wow that is so much easier than
before i can't tell you how hard it was
to attach an efs volume the last time i
did it um so we'll go ahead we'll add
that and the storage is fine we're gonna
go to review here
we're gonna say launch and i'm just
gonna stick with the same key pair there
we're going to give that moment to
launch
and we're going to go to view instances
and so now this one is launching as
that's launching let's just go peek
around and see what we can see so you
know i imagine if we didn't add that
file system during the the boot um and
we were we're adding it after the fact
we probably could just ran that line and
added it really easily
i'm not going to bother testing that
because i just don't want to go through
that trouble to do that
i still can't remember what these access
points are for
um
but uh that's okay it's kind of out of
the scope for the certified cloud
partitioner
and so i'm just curious
so we have some nice monitoring here
right so that's kind of nice
um i guess they're trying to suggest
here like aws backup data sync transfer
so that would just be backing up
simplify
automates accelerates moving data okay
that's pretty straightforward
transfer family fully managed sftp okay
so nothing exciting there
and we're going to refresh that there
and this is initializing so let's go see
if we can connect to this one so i'm
going to go ahead and grab that public
ip address i'm going to hit up
okay i'm going to swap out that ip
address and we're going to see if we can
connect to that
machine yet so we'll say yes
and we got into it so that's great and
so what i'm going to do is go again into
the mount directory efs fs1 ls and there
it is i'm going to do cat hello world
and so it works
and so that's the cool thing about dfs
is that you have a file system that you
can share among other
ec2 instances i'm sure users could
connect to it using the nfs protocol i'm
not the best at like networking or
storage networking so i'm not going to
show that here to you today but that
gives you a general idea how efs works
again you only pay for what you store it
is serverless so we'll go here and type
delete because i'm done with this i'll
probably destroy the instance first
it doesn't get mixed up
and just so we clean up a little bit
better here i'm going to delete these
keys
here delete
okay
and we'll go ahead and delete this one
as well
delete
so i'm done with that
uh we'll make sure that that is tearing
down that is good and we'll make our way
back over here and it says enter
probably the id's name in so we'll enter
that in and hit confirm
and we'll see is it deleting i'm not
confident with it i'm going to do it one
more time confirm that by entering the
the file system's id so we'll put it in
again
is it destroying i cannot tell there we
go so it's destroying we are in good
shape it is gone our data is gone
um but yeah that is efs
[Music]
all right let's take a look at um the
snow family in aws so if we type in snow
up here and we click into into the snow
family this is where we can probably
order ourselves a device
i might not be able to order them at
least when i originally looked at this
like way back in the day it wasn't
available in canada so i'm kind of
curious to see what there is but the
idea is that you're going to go here in
order and you have some options so you
can import into s3 or export from s3 and
then down below we have local compute
storage so perform local compute storage
workloads without transferring data you
can order multiple devices and clusters
for increased durability and storage
capacity so it sounds like you're not
you're not um
transferring data you're just using it
locally on to um it's like basically
buying renting temporary computers which
is kind of interesting i never saw that
option before but we're going to choose
import into aws s3 and we're just going
to read through this stuff and it's not
my expectation that we're going to be
able to submit a job here and you
probably don't want to because it's
going to cost money but i just want to
show you the process so we can see what
there is here so snow job assistance if
you're new to snow family run a pilot of
one to two devices so batch file smaller
than one megabyte benchmark and optimize
deploy
staging workstations
discover remediate environmental uh
issues early files and folders name must
conform to amazon s3 prepare your ami
once the pilot is completed confirm the
number of snow family devices that you
can copy devices to simultaneously
follow the best practices use the
following resources to manage your snow
devices so we have aws open hub
and then there's the edge client cli
so open hub is a graphical user
interface you can use to manage snow
devices so that's kind of cool and then
we have the cli which i imagine is
something that's very useful to use
so just close those off here and then we
have other things so i'm going to say i
acknowledge i know what i'm doing which
i don't really but that's okay and then
here we are going to enter in our
address so we say andrew brown
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna enter
this in for real just whatever so it'll
be toronto
exam pro
um canada
oh see so there's there's the thing you
can only ship it to the us and so that's
as far as i can get okay
um and that's the thing is like if you
really want to know aws inside and out
you got to be in the us but let's
pretend that we do have an address in
the states what's a very famous address
so what is the address of the white
house
okay
there it is
so i'm just going to copy that in
because again we're not going to submit
this for real i just want to
see what's farther down the line here
okay
uh
what's nw
is that the state it's in washington
right
is is this part of it nw northwest is
that a thing i'm from canada so i
couldn't tell you um so we'll go down
here and we have washington do we have a
second address line it doesn't look like
it um
we have a zip code i believe this is the
zip code
and
do we need a phone number looks like we
do four one six
uh one one
one one one one one okay
we have one day or two day shipping
why not just have one right and so then
we can choose our type of device so we
have snow cone snow cone ssd snow cone
optimized i'm surprised i never took a
screenshot of this earlier um compute
optimized things like that so you can
choose which one you want it looks like
we're going to see some different
options but we'll go with snow cone
my snow cone
and
snow cones do not ship with a power
supply or ethernet cable snow cone
devices are powered by 45 watt cb
c
usb c power supply i'll provide my own
power supply and cable do not ship with
a power supply or ethernet cable that's
fine
uh snow cone wireless no can connect
your wireless connection connect the
buckets you want there's a bucket we
created earlier
computing
use compute using ec2 instances use a
device as a mobile data center by
loading ec2 ami so here's an ami that i
might want to use
uh aws iot green grass validated ami not
interested remote device management you
can use
opshub or etc to monitor reboot your
device that's fine
and so then we need to choose our
security key
i don't know if i'll have to set the
service role we'll see what happens here
and
we'll let it
update that's fine
and so then i guess we just hit create
job and so i don't really want to order
one um so i'm not going to hit that
button and also it's going to go to the
white house and they're going to be like
andrew brown why did you do that so
that's not something i feel like doing
today but at least that gives you an
idea of that process there and i imagine
that uh if you go the other way it's
gonna be pretty similar yeah it's just
like
same stuff i think
so it saved that address that it's not a
real address and the the options are a
little bit uh
limited here and it's like nfs space s3
based so it's slightly different but
it's basically the same process just
curious we'll take a look at the last
one there
since there are three options just
curious
okay similar thing okay so
yeah that's pretty much all i want to
know about um the snow family and that's
about it okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at what is a
database so a database is a data store
that stores semi-structured and
structured data and just to emphasize a
bit more a database stores more complex
data stores because it requires using
formal design and modeling techniques so
databases can generally be categorized
as either being relational so structured
data that strongly represents tabular
data so we're talking about tables rows
and columns so there's a concept of row
oriented or columner oriented and then
we have non-relational databases
so these are semi-structured that may or
may not distinctly resemble tabular data
so here is a very simple example the
idea is that you might use some kind of
language like sql put in your database
and you'll get back out tables for
relational databases let's just talk
about some of the functionality that
these databases have so they can be
using a special specialized language to
query so retrieve data so in this case
sql specialized modeling strategies to
optimize retrieval for different use
cases
more fine-tuned control over the
transformation of the data into useful
data structures or reports and normally
a database infers someone is usually
using a relational row-oriented data
store so
you know just understand that when
people say database that's usually what
they're talking about like postgres
mysql relational row store is usually
the default but obviously there's a lot
more broader terms there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at what is a
data warehouse so it's a relational data
store designed for analytical workloads
which is generally column oriented data
store okay so companies will have
terabytes and millions of rows of data
and they'll need a fast way to be able
to produce analytics reports so data
warehouses generally perform aggregation
so aggregation is the idea of grouping
data together so find a total or an
average
and data warehouses are optimized around
columns since they need to quickly
aggregate column data and so here's kind
of a diagram of
a data warehouse and so the idea is that
it could be ingesting data
from a regular database here i'm just
getting out my pen tool so it could be a
regular database or it'd be coming from
a different data source that isn't
compatible in terms of the schema and
you use like etl or elt
or etl to get that data into
that data warehouse so data warehouses
are generally designed to be hot so hot
means that they can return queries very
fast even though they have vast amounts
of data data warehouses are infrequently
accessed meaning they aren't intended
for real-time reporting but maybe once
or twice a day or once a week to
generate business and user reports of
course it's going to vary based on the
the service that is offering the data
warehouse a data warehouse needs to
consume data from a relational database
on a regular basis and again it can
consume it from other places but you'll
have to transform it to get it in there
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at a key value
store so a key value store or database
is a type of non-relational database or
nosql that uses a simple key value
method to store data and so key value
stores are dumb and fast but they
generally lack features like
relationships indexes aggregation of
course there are going to be providers
out there have managed solutions that
might polyfill some of those uh issues
there but i want to show you the
underlying way that key value stores
work to kind to kind of distinguish them
between document stores so a key value
stores literally a unique key alongside
a value and the reason i'm representing
that is zeros and ones is because i want
you to understand that that's what it is
it's basically just some kind of of data
there and how the key value store
interprets it is going to determine what
it is so when you look at a document
database that is just a key value store
that
interprets the value as being documents
right and so key value stores can and do
commonly store
um
multiple uh like an associative array
that's pretty common so even for
dynamodb that's how it does it and so
that's why when you look at a key value
store it looks like it uh a a table but
it's not actually a table it's
schema-less because underneath it's
really just
um you know that associative array and
so that's why you can have columns or
sorry rows that have uh
different amounts
of columns okay so due to the design
they are able to scale very well beyond
a relational database and they can kind
of work like a relational database
without all the bells and whistles so
hopefully you know that makes sense okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at document
stores so a document store is a nosql
database that stores documents as its
primary data structure and a document
could be an xml
type of structure but it also could be
something like json or json-like
document stores are sub-classes of key
value stores
and the components of a document store
are very uh comparable to relational
databases so just kind of an example
here where in a relational database
they'd be called tables now you have
collections they were called rows now
they're called documents you had columns
they had fields they may have indexes
and then joins might be called embedding
and linking so you can translate that
knowledge over uh you know they they're
not as
they don't have the same kind of feature
set as a relational database but you
have better scalability and honestly
document stores are just key value
stores with some additional features
built on top of it okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're going to take a look at the girl
database services that are available on
aws so we have dynamodb which is a
serverless noaa skill key value and
document database it is designed to
scale to billions of records with
guaranteed consistent data returned in
at least a second you do not have to
worry about managing shards and dynamodb
is adabus's flagship database service
meaning whatever we think of a database
service that just scales is cost
effective and very fast we should think
of dynamodb and in 2019 amazon the
online shopping retail uh shut down
their last oracle database and completed
their migration to dynamodb so they had
7500 oracle databases with 75 petabytes
of data and with dynamodb they reduced
that cost by 60 and reduce the latency
by 40 percent so that's kind of to be
like a testimonial between relational
and a no school database so when we want
a massively scalable database that is
what we want dynamodb for and i really
just want to put that there because if
you remember that you're going to always
be able to pass
or get those questions right on the exam
okay then we have documentdb so this is
a no scroll document database that is
mongodb compatible so mongodb is very
popular nosco among developers there
were open source licensing issues around
using open source mongodb so aws got
around it by just building their own
mongodb database basically so when do
you want a mongodb like database you're
going to be using documentdb we have
amazon key spaces this is a fully
managed apache cassandra database so
cassandra is an open source nosql key
value database similar to dynamodb that
is columnar store database but has some
additional functionality so when you
want to use apache cassandra you're
using amazon key spaces
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at relational
database services starting with
relational database service rds and this
is a relational database service that
supports multiple sql engines
so relational is synonymous with sql and
online transactional processing oltp
and relational databases are the most
commonly used type of database among
tech companies and startups just because
they're so easy to use i use them i love
them
rds supports the following sql engines
we first have mysql so this is the most
popular open source sql database and it
was purchased and is now owned by oracle
uh and there's an interesting story
there because when oracle purchased it
they weren't supposed to have it um
mario db was or sorry my squad was sold
to oracle sun systems and then within
the year
um uh oracle purchased it from them and
the original creators never wanted it to
go to oracle just because of their uh
the way they do licensing and things
like that and so
the original creators came back and they
decided to fork mysql and then maintain
it as mariodb just so that you know
oracle never kind of pushed away the
most popular database so that everyone
had to go to a paid solution then you
have postgres so psql as it's commonly
known is the most popular open source
sql database among developers this is
the one i like to use because it has so
many rich features over mysql but but it
does come with added complexity then
oracle has its own sql proprietary
database which is well used by
enterprise companies but you have to buy
a license to use it
then you have microsoft sql so
microsoft's proprietary sql database
and with this one you have to buy a
license to use it then you have aurora
so this is a fully managed database uh
and there's a lot more to going on here
with aurora so we'll talk about it
almost acts as a separate service but it
is powered by rds so aurora is a fully
managed database of either mysql so five
times faster or postgres
sql three times faster database so when
you want a highly available durable and
scalable and secure relational database
for postcode to mysql you want to use
aurora
then you have aurora serverless so this
is a serverless on-demand version of
aurora so when you want the most of the
benefits of aurora but you can trade
off to have cold starts or you don't
have lots of traffic or demand this is a
way you can use aurora in a serverless
way then you have rds on vmware so this
allows you to deploy rds supported
engines to on-premise data centers
the data center must be using vmware for
server virtualization so when you want
databases managed by rds on your own
database center
uh and yeah i realize that this is a
small spelling mistake should say just
on here but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the other database
services that abuse has because there's
just a few loose ones here so let's talk
about redshift so it is a petabyte size
data warehouse and data warehouses are
for online analytical processing olap
and data warehouses can be expensive
because they are keeping data hot
meaning that they can run a very complex
query and a large amount of data and get
that data back very fast so when you
need to quickly generate analytics or
reports from a large amount of data
you're going to be using redshift then
you have elastic cache so this is a
managed database of an in-memory and
caching open source databases such as
redis or memcache so when you need to
improve the performance of an
application by adding a caching layer in
front of your web servers or database
you're going to be using elastic cache
then you have neptune this is a managed
graph database the data is represented
as interconnected nodes i believe that
it uses gremlin as the way to interface
with it which is no surprise because
that's what it looks like most clusters
providers are using so when you need to
understand the connections between data
so mapping fraud rings or social media
relationships
very relational database heavy
information you're gonna want to use
neptune we have amazon time streams it's
a fully managed time series database so
think of devices that send lots of data
that are time sensitive such as iot
devices so when you need to measure how
things change over time we have amazon
quantum ledger database this is a fully
managed
ledger database that provides
transparent immutable cryptographically
variable transaction logs so when you
need to record a history of financial
activities that can be trusted
and the last one here is database
migration service dms it's not a
database per say but it's a migration
service so you can migrate from
on-premise database to aws from two
databases in different or same database
accounts using different sql engines and
from an esque wall to a nosql database
and i'm pretty sure we cover this in a
bit
greater detail in this course okay
[Music]
all right let's go take a look at
dynamodb
which is awesome's nosql database so
we'll go over to dynamodb
and what we'll do is create ourselves a
new table
and we'll just say my dynamodb
table
and you always have to choose a
partition key you don't necessarily have
to have a sort key but it could be
something like
um
like it you want to be really unique so
it could be like email and this one
could be created at right
and so we have string binary notice that
the the types are very sim simple then
for settings we have default settings or
customized settings so the default is
use provision capacity mode rewrite five
rules etc custom
no secondary indexes use kms so i'm
gonna just expand that to see what i'm
looking at
we have two options here on demand so
simplify billing by paying the actual
reads and rights that you use or
provisioned
which is this is where you get a
guarantee of performance so if you want
to be able to do
you know whatever it is a thousand i
don't know what it goes up to but like a
thousand read writes per second
then that's what you're paying for okay
you're paying for being able having a
guarantee
of that
um of that capacity okay i'm not going
to create any secondary indexes but
that's just like another way to
look at data notice down below that we
have a cost of two dollars and
ninety-one cents
uh then we have encryption at rest so
you can do owned by amazon dynamodb
that's pretty much the same as like a
bus has or s3 has
ssc
s3 there you could use uh
actually i guess most of these are
probably kms i would imagine
we'll go ahead and create the table here
and that's going to create the table
this is usually really really fast
we'll go here
and
what we can do is insert some data so as
it's just starting up here we can go
over to
our tables they recently changed this ui
so that's why i look a bit confused
view items up here okay and then from
here we can create an item so i can add
something say so andrew at exam pro dot
co
and
2021 uh
well we'll just do the future so let's
say 20 25
0.505 i don't want to have to think too
hard here but we can add additional
information so i can say like
uh
[Music]
today true
we could say
um
make it like a list
you know
food
and then i could go here and then add a
string
it is not working oh there we go there
we are so we could say like
um banana
and then we could say pizza right we can
go ahead and create that item
so now that item is in our database uh
we can do a scan that will return all
items we can query we can actually have
some limitations of what we're choosing
there's the party cue editor so we can
use sql to select it
um i have not used this before
party q
aws or partyq
dynamodb
examples
i'm hoping i can just find like an
example of some of the language getting
started here i don't need to i don't
need an explanation just show me an
example
query here and i will i'll get to it
here
okay so here's some examples right so
maybe we can give this a go um so we
have our table here so my
dynamo
db table
and i just want the email back
we don't need a where
we'll run this
see if it works
there we go
i'm not sure if we could select
additional data there so i know that we
had some other things like food
there it is okay so that's really nice
um
addition to it
dynamodb can stream things into a
dynamodb stream to go to kinesis and do
a lot of fun things so there's all sorts
of things you can do with dynamodb but
i'm pretty much done with this so i'm
going to go ahead and delete this table
and notice that it also creates some
cloudwatch alarms so we want to delete
this as well create a backup no we do
not care go ahead and delete that
and that is dynamodb
[Music]
okay so now i want to show you uh rds or
relational database service so go to the
top here type in rds
and we'll make our way over there
and so rds is great because it allows us
to launch relational databases
sometimes the ui is slow i'm not sure
why it's taking so long to load today
but every day is a bit different and so
what we're going to do is go ahead and
create a new database
you're going to notice that we're going
to have the option between creating a
standard or easy i stick with standard
just because i don't like how easy hides
a lot of stuff from us even here like it
says two cents per hour but it's not
giving us the full cost so i really
don't trust it because if you go down
here and you chose their dev test here
look it's like a hundred dollars it's
not showing the the
cost preview right now maybe because we
didn't choose the database type sorry i
wanted to choose postgres but before we
do that let's look at the engine types
we have amazon aurora so we have between
mysql and postgres mysql maritab
postgres oracle
microsoft sql notice for microsoft sql
it comes with a license you don't have
to do anything with that
it might change based on the addition
here
nope comes with a license for all of
them which is great
if you want to bring your own license
that's where you need a dedicated host
right running
microsoft sql for oracle uh you have to
bring your own license that's going to
be based on um importing with the abs
license manager but we go over to
postgres which is what i like to use
we're going to set it to dev test to try
to get the cheapest cost scroll down
look 118 dollars we can get it cheaper
we get super cheap so here the password
is going to be testing one two three
capital on the t so an explanation mark
on the end okay because it has a bunch
of requirements of what it wants
here i want a t2 micro
so i'm just going to scroll down here
what is going on here standard oh look m
classes
i don't want an m class i want a
burstable class that's the cheap ones
and so we go here can we still do a t2
micro or is it now t3
so i don't see t2
so i imagine a t3 micro must be the new
it was free tier so we go it was three
tier here
right
and if i go to
[Music]
databases
um rds
on the t2 micro 750 hours but i can't
select it
so
i'm going to assume
that the t3 micro must be the new
tier if it's not there right
let's just say include previous
generations
and then maybe i can see it then
okay so i don't see it there
i really don't like how they've changed
this on me
okay so the oldest i can choose is a t3
micro which is fine i just i just know
t2 being the free tier that's all
uh this is fine we don't want auto
scaling turned on for our example here
we do not want
a multi-az so do not create a standby
that's going to really jump up our cost
we don't need public access
it will create a vpc that's fine
password authentication is fine we have
to go in here which i don't know why
they just don't keep that expanded
because you always have to come in here
name your database so my database
we choose our postgres version here i'm
going to turn backups off because if we
don't
if we don't it's going to take forever
to launch this thing
encryption is turned on you can turn it
off
but generally it's not recommended
we can have performance insights turned
on i'm going to turn the retention
i will leave it to seven days because we
can't turn that off we don't need
enhanced monitoring so i'm just going to
turn that off
and uh that's fine we're not going to
enable delete protection here and
so we are good we can now go ahead and
create our database
and what we'll do here is wait for that
database to be created so the thing is
is like
if we're doing the solutions architect
or the
developer associate stuff i'd actually
show you how to connect to the database
um it's not that hard to do like you
just have to connect uh grab all the
database information so it's going to
have an endpoint a port stuff like that
and you'd use something like table plus
or something to connect to the database
but that's out of scope of the certified
cloud partitioner i'm just going through
the motions to show you that you can
create an rds database very easily but
not how to connect to it and actually
utilize it okay
and so that would spin up and we would
have a server and after that we can just
go ahead and delete the server here so
just say delete me
okay
and that's all there really is to it
there is the special type of database
like aurora doesn't have its own like
console page it's part of rds so if you
want to spin up aurora you just choose
the compatibility you want you can
choose between provisioned or serverless
the serverless is supposed to be really
good for
scaling to zero cost so that's something
there so you'd fill that all out but the
initial cost is a lot more expensive you
can't choose a t2 micro here um unless
it lets you now
it is for
provisioned it's uh
oh t2 t3 medium is the smallest you can
go okay so if you reach the point we're
using a medium-sized database then you
might consider moving over to aurora
just because it's going to be highly
scalable et cetera like that
um so that's a consideration there
there's also something called babelfish
um that it was announced last year when
i when i shot this
or when i'm shooting this as of now and
the idea was to make it compatible with
mysql sql server to migrate over to
aurora post sql which is kind of
interesting um but that's about it so if
our database is destroying i think it is
just going to go back over here to rds
it's taken a long time to load today
and i think it's already deleted maybe
we go to databases here it's deleting so
i'm confident it's going to delete so
there we go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at redshift
so redshift is a data warehouse and it's
generally really expensive so it's not
something that you're going to want to
launch
uh day to day here but let's see how far
we can get with it um just by running
through it so what we'll do is go ahead
and create a cluster and again you can
just watch me do this you don't have to
create you don't have to create one
yourself
so free trial configure for learning
that sounds good to me
it's free for a limited time if your
organization has never created a cluster
well i rarely ever create these so when
the trial ends delete your cluster to
avoid the charges of on-demand okay that
sounds fair
so here we're going to have two v3 cu's
it's going to launch a dc a
dc too large
so let's look that up for pricing
me prices please please please
um
i think it's loading right here okay
so i don't know how much it is but i
know it is not cheap
and down below we have sample data is
loaded into your redshift cluster that
sounds good to me ticket is the sample
data okay
ticket sample data
redshift i just imagine they probably
have like a tutorial for it here
they do right here
and so because i want to know what we
need to do to query it right if we can
even query it via the interface here so
the admin user is adabus user
and the password is going to be capital
t testing one two three four five six
exclamation
and we'll hit create cluster
oh cool we can query the data right in
here so that's what i wasn't sure about
whether we would be able to just query
it in line because before
you'd have to use java with jdbc or an
odbc driver
and download the jar and it's not as fun
as it sounds of course but looks like we
can query data once the data is loaded
so that looks really good i guess we can
pull data in from
the marketplace so that's looks pretty
nice too
and i guess we could probably integrate
it into other things like quicksite
because you probably want to adjust your
data over there
again i usually don't spend a lot of
time in redshift but it looks like it's
a lot easier to use i'm very impressed
with this so i don't know how long it
takes to
launch a redshift cluster i mean it is
160 gigabytes of
storage there it's
even at the smallest it's pretty large
so what i'm going to do is to stop the
video and i'll be back when this is done
okay
okay so after a short little wait here
um it was a lot faster than i was
expecting but uh it's available and so
looks like here it says to query the
sample data use redshift version 2. so
i'm going to click that
and i'm sure there's tons of buttons to
get here and it'd be great if it just
populated the query for me
it doesn't but this looks really nice
really nice ui i wonder if it has like
some existing queries
no
that's okay so what i'm going to do here
is i'm going to go ahead and pull out
this query and see if we can get this to
work here
never found out what those prices were
though
okay
and what we'll do is hit run i like how
there's like a limit of 100 but here it
has that so we'll go ahead and hit run
and see what data we get so relation
sales does not exist
okay so
what's going on here
um we'll go up here so most of the
examples in the redshift documentation
uses a sample database called ticket the
sample the small database consists of
seven tables you can load the ticket
data set by following the this here
okay so to load the sample data from
amazon s3
okay so
i would have thought it already had the
data in there i could have swore it
would have
dev
public
tables
zero tables
okay so
i don't think there's any data in here
and so we're going to have to load it
ourselves
i really thought it would have added it
for us
let's go ahead and create these tables
and see if this is as easy as we think
so run that create that table
cool okay
we got it down here
we'll run that we'll just run each at a
time
i think there's seven of them so
date already exists okay that's fine
event already exists saying all these
tables exist
maybe i just wasn't patient
hmm okay
um
interesting all right so maybe we'll go
back and uh run that query maybe we just
had to wait a little while for that data
to load
run
okay so you know what i think it was
doing this for us if if it did not
create it for us we would have to go
through all these steps which is fine
because we're learning a little bit
about
redshift but
looks like we just had to wait there so
it looks like you would run those you
download that you use the copy command
to bring it over there
it looks like you can do all of this via
the uh this interface here and we've
done a query so that's kind of cool
um i imagine you probably could like
save it or export it what if we chart it
what happens
okay you can chart it
it's kind of fun
can we export it out to just we can save
it i thought maybe it could export out
to quicksite but i i suppose you'd
rebuild it in quickside a
but yeah i guess that's it right there
so that's pretty darn simple so what i'm
going to do is make my way back over to
redshift because we are done for this
example
and we will go over to clusters here
and i'm going to go ahead and
delete my cluster
delete
create file snapshot nope
delete the cluster
there we go
so i'm pretty sure that will succeed no
problem there and we are done with
redshift and redshift is super expensive
so just make sure that thing deletes
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at cloud
native networking services um and so i
have this architectural diagram i
created which has a lot of networking
components uh when people create
networking diagrams for aws they don't
always include all these things here
even though they're there so we're just
being a little bit verbose so you can
see okay the first thing is our vpc our
virtual private cloud this is a
logically isolated section of the
database cloud where you can launch
database resources that's where your
resources are going to reside not all
services uh require you to select a vpc
uh because they're managed by aws but i
wouldn't be surprised if under the hood
they are in their own vpc okay
then if you want
the internet to reach your services
you're gonna need an internet gateway um
then you need to figure out a way to
route things to your various subnets and
that's where route tables come in
then we need to
define a region that it's going to be
which is a geographical location on your
network then you have your availability
zones which are basically your data
centers where your resources are going
to reside then you have subnets which is
a logical partition of an ip network
into multiple smaller network segments
and these pretty much map to your
availability zones if you're making one
per a z
and then we have knuckles these act as a
firewall at the subnet level then we
have security groups that act as a
firewall at the instance level so
hopefully that gives you a good overview
okay
[Music]
all right so now let's take a look at
enterprise or hybrid networking so we
have our on-premise uh environments or
your private cloud and then we have our
aws account or our public cloud so
there's a couple services here that we
can bridge them together the first is
aws virtual private network vpn it's a
secure connection between on-premise
remote offices and mobile employees then
you have direct connect this is a
dedicated gigabit connection from
on-premise data center to aws so it's a
very fast connection a lot of times a
direct we say it's a
private connection but that doesn't
necessarily mean secure it's not
encrypting uh the data in transit so
very commonly these services are used
together not just singular okay
and then uh we have private links and so
this is where you already uh are using
aws but you want to keep it all within
databus never going out to the internet
okay so these are generally called vpc
interface endpoints and then the
marketing pages call them private links
which is a bit confusing but you know it
just keeps traffic within the database
network so it does not transverse out to
the internet okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at vpcs and
subnets so a vpc is a logically isolated
section of the database network where
you launch your aws resources and you
choose a range of ips using a cider
range so cider range is an ip address
followed by this netmaster subnet sub
mask that's going to determine how many
ip addresses there are
and there's a bunch of math behind that
which we're not going to get into
but anyway so here is an architectural
diagram just showing a vpc with a couple
subnets so subnets is a logical
partition of an ip network into multiple
uh smaller network segments and so
you're essentially breaking up your ip
ranges for vpcs into smaller networks so
just thinking about cutting up a pi okay
so subnets need to have a smaller cider
range to
the vpcs represent for their portion so
uh four slash 24 is actually smaller
which is interesting the the higher the
number gets the smaller it gets and so
this would allocate 256 ip addresses and
so that's well smaller than 16 okay
we have the concept of a public subnet
so this is one that can reach the
internet and a private subnet the one
that cannot reach the internet and um
these are not strictly enforced by aws
so the idea is that when you have a
subnet you can just say don't by default
assign publicly assignable ip addresses
but it's totally possible to launch an
ec2 instance into your private subnet
and then turn on um
the ip address so you've got to do other
things to ensure that they stay private
or public okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are comparing security groups versus
knackles so i have this nice
architectural diagram that has both
knuckles and security groups in them and
we'll just kind of talk about these two
so knackles stand for network access
control lists and they act as a virtual
firewall at the subnet level and so here
you can create and allow uh and deny
rules and this is really useful if you
want to block a specific ip address
known for abuse
and i'm going to just kind of
compare that against security groups
because that's going to be a very
important difference okay so security
groups act as a firewall at the instance
level and they implicitly deny all
traffic so you create only allow rules
so
you can allow an ec2 instance to access
port on uh
port 22 for ssh but you cannot block a
single ip address and the reason i say
that is because in order for you to
block a single ip address and secure
group you would literally have to block
or you'd literally have to allow
everything but that ip address and
that's just not feasible okay and so if
you can remember that one particular
example you'll always be able to
remember the difference between these
two one other thing that
aws likes to do is is ask which ones are
stateless which ones are stateful but at
the cloud particular level they're not
going to be asking you that okay
all right let's learn a bit about
networking with aws so what i want you
to do is go to the top and type in vpc
which stands for virtual private cloud
and what we'll do is set up our own vbc
it's not so important that you remember
all the little bit of details but you
get through this so that you can
remember the major components so what
i'll do is create a new vpc i'm going to
call this my vpc
uh tutorial and here i'm going to say
forward slash 10.0.0.06
the reason you're wondering why i'm
doing that if we go to x y
x y z here
this tells you the size of it so i go
here i put 16 so you can see we have a
lot of room if we do 24
it takes up it it's smaller see so this
is basically the size of it right the
empty blocks over here so we're gonna
have a lot of room so we do ten zero
zero zero sixteen we don't need ipv6
we're gonna go ahead and create that
and once we have that we can go ahead
and create a subnet which we will need
so we're going to choose our vpc we'll
go down here and say my subnet tutorial
and we'll choose the first say z you can
leave it blank it'll choose it random
and then we need to choose a block that
is smaller than the current one so 16
would be definitely um
well 16 is the size that we have now so
we can match that size but
10.0.0.0 forward slash 24 would be
absolutely smaller okay so go ahead and
create that subnet
and so that is all set up now
um
let's see if our route table is hooked
up so our route table says where it
links to
and it says to local so it's not going
anywhere and that's because we need to
attach a
internet gateway that allows us to reach
the internet so if we go over here and
create a new internet gateway we'll say
my igw
and we'll go ahead and create that
and what we'll do is
associate that with our vpc we created
here
okay
and so now that we have the internet
gateway attached we want that subnet to
make its way out to the internet so if
we go to the route table we can edit the
route table association here
i like how it keeps on showing me this
as if i don't know what i'm doing but i
do
and so
this would change that particular
association but i want to add to that
route table
so i thought when i clicked that it
would allow me to add more but
apparently i got to go to route tables
over here
and i'm looking for the one that is ours
we can see that it's over here
you could even name it if we wanted to
like my route table
notice that we apply
names it's actually just applying a tag
see over here it's always what that is
so go over to routes and we want to edit
the routes and we want to add a route
and we want this to go to zero zero zero
and we're gonna choose the internet
gateway
okay
we're gonna say save changes
and what that's going to allow us to do
is to reach the internet
um and so what i want to do is go back
to subnet i was just curious about this
i've never used this before
um so it looks like we could just choose
some options here i'm not too concerned
about that but i assume like that's used
for debugging azure's had those kind of
services for a long time and so it was
been starting to add those so you can
easily debug your network which is nice
so
we have a subnet the subnet
can reach the internet because there's a
there's a
internet gateway and it's hooked up via
the route table one thing that matters
is will it assign a public ip address
so that is something that we might want
to look into
it's not the default subnet which is
totally fine
so it says auto assign
is no so that might be something that
you might want to change
so here we would go to edit the rope
table association no it's not there they
changed it on me
it used to be part of the setup
instructions you should just checkbox it
now and they moved it modify the
autoassign so we'll say enable so that
means it's always going to give it a
public ip address on launch
and while we're here i'm just going to
double check if i have any elastic ips i
did not release okay just double
checking here
and so
this is all set up and we should be able
to launch a
ec2 now within our our new vpc so i'll
go over here to ec2
okay
and i'm going to launch a new instance
let's say amazon links 2
we're going to choose this tier here
and now what we should be able to do is
select that
and that is our subnet there okay
go ahead and launch that i don't care if
we use a key whatsoever so i'm gonna go
ahead and launch that there
okay we'll go back
and so there you go it is launching so
we created our vpc and we launched uh in
it no problem whatsoever
so hopefully that is pretty darn clear
um so yeah
what i'm going to do is i'm going to let
that launch because i want to show you
security groups
so within aws you can set security
groups and knackles
and that's going to allow or deny access
based on stuff and when we launched this
ecto instance it has a default security
group that was assigned we could have
created a new one but what i might want
to do is create myself a new security
group here
okay and you can end up with a lot
really fast like here's a bunch
and i can't even tell what's what so
like this bunch for load balancers and
things like that
and so i might just go ahead and delete
a bunch of these because i cannot tell
what is going on here
and
we'll delete these security groups
and sometimes they won't let you delete
them because they're associated with
something like a network interface or
something
all right but
we need to find out which one we're
using right now
so the one that we are using is the
launch wizard4 so we'll go into here
and i don't know if you can rename them
after they've been created i don't think
so which is kind of frustrating because
if you want to rename it it's like i
don't want that to be the name
so what's interesting is you can go here
and you can edit the routes
the rules sorry the inbound rules and
the outbound rules and so here it's open
on port 22 so that allows us to ssh in
we could drop this down and choose
different things so if we want people to
access a website we go port 80 and we
save from anywhere ipv46 so now anyone
can access it
you might want to do something like
give it access to postgres that runs on
port 5432 things like that
um could be something else
like maybe you need to connect a
redshift that's on that port you can go
ahead and save those rules we're just
going to say uh from anywhere it can
even say my ip so maybe only i'm allowed
to connect to it right
so you added inbound rules you don't
really ever have to touch outbound rules
it's set for all traffic so it's stuff
that's leaving
uh the
that there one interesting thing to note
about security groups is that
you don't have a deny
option right so let's say you only
wanted a particular ip address you only
wanted let's say what's my ip my ip
address
so that is my ip address and let's say
i wanted to block it
right so i go here and i say okay i want
to block
on all tcp i want to block this number
right
but i can't do that all i can say is i
allow this number so in order to do it i
would have to enter everything but this
number in here and you can enter ranges
in
with like these forward slashes and
stuff like that but you would imagine
that'd be really hard because you have
to starting to like
you'd have to start and go through every
single ip address in the world to get it
out of here and that's almost impossible
and that's the key thing i want to
remember about security groups
so that's security groups and there's
also knackles
knackles they're associated with subnets
so they probably show up under vpc i
rarely touch knackles rarely ever have
to
um
i mean they're great tools but you know
for me i just don't ever need them
so knackles are associated with subnets
so we can go here and try to see my
subnet tutorial so we created our subnet
we got a knackle for free and we can set
inbound and outbound rules and so here
here is where we could say okay i want
to add a new rule
and i want to and i want to make the
rule number 150
you always do these in the hundreds okay
or the power of tens so that you can
move them around easily
and i can say all
traffic that comes from
this ip address
i'm gonna put the forward slash zero
that just means a single ip address
and i say deny right and so now
uh this at my address i can't access
that ec2 instance okay if i try to go
there's nothing running on the server
but if i was to try to use it i wouldn't
be able to do it
and and this applies to anything for
that subnet it's not for a particular
instance it's for anything in that
subnet so hopefully that is is pretty
clear there
but that's pretty much all you really
need to know i mean there's lots of
other stuff like network firewalls all
these other things it gets pretty
complicated
it's well beyond what we need to learn
here but what we'll do is tear down that
ec2 instance
okay
we'll terminate that
and once that instance is destroyed we
can get rid of our security group and a
bunch of other stuff
and there's always a bunch of these darn
things
so we'll say delete
one security group associated
so we go here this is the one we are
using but i wanna get rid of all these
other ones
okay if i go here it could be because
like of inbound rules
so see this one because you can
reference
another security group within a security
group so i'm just going to go save that
there
see any my ip there oops
it's set to
nfs so that might have been set up for
our access point
i could just delete it that would
probably be easier
okay
so that's one that's kind of of a pain
so i'm just looking for rules that might
be referencing other security groups
to get rid of them
okay let's try this again
we'll go ahead and delete
i'm leaving the um
i'm leaving the uh the defaults alone
because those come with your vpcs and
you don't want to get rid of those
it won't let me delete
this one so i'm going to go edit that
rule
delete it save it
you might not have this kind of cleanup
to do it's just might be me here you
know
um outbound inbound
let's try this again here
delete
and i'll open this one up
must be this one that is referencing the
other one
i'm just going to delete the rule
and this is something that's just kind
of frustrating with aws but it's just
how it is where
sometimes it's hard to get rid of
resources because you have to click
through stuff so it's not always a clean
you might have like lingering resources
and this isn't going to cost us anything
but it's just the fact that um
that it just makes things
harder to see what you're doing you know
this last one really doesn't want to go
away
so i'm just trying to delete all the
rules out of here get rid of it
can i delete this one now
one group associated it will not show me
what it's talking about okay here it is
um
ah okay this is referencing it
it was the one there was an old one i
don't know what this is
we'll go down here
and we'll go here and delete that and
while i've been cleaning all these up
now we can go over to our instance make
sure that it's terminated it is good
because if our instance is not
terminated we cannot destroy the vpc uh
prior the vpc could not be destroyed
unless you detach the internet gateway i
wonder if it's going to still complain
about that
we'll say yes it actually looks like it
includes it in the cleanup
type delete here
there we go so we're all good we're all
cleaned up there you are
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this video i just want to show
you cloud front so let's make our way
over to cloudfront
and cloudfront is a content delivery
network and it's used to cache your data
all over the place as you can see i have
some older ones here if you have a
splash screen what you can do is just
look for the left-hand side there might
be a hamburger menu open that up and
then click on distributions and what
we're going to do is create a new
distribution if you don't want to create
one because these do take forever to
create
you can just kind of watch along i don't
even feel like i'm going to hit the um
the create distribution button because i
just hate waiting for so long but the
idea is that you have to choose an
origin and so the origin could be
something like an s3 bucket a load
bouncer media store this is where um the
the content distribution network is
going to source
its content right so if i say
this bucket here
and i just it will probably default to
the root path the idea is that it's
going to be able to pull content from
there and then cache it everywhere
and then down below you can say
okay set the type of protocol redirect
to here you can set up caching rules or
like how often do you want it to cache
like cache a lot don't cache a lot but
the great thing is like you have these
edge or these um lambda edge functions
so you can
read and modify the requests and
response to the cdn which is very
powerful but what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to go look at what we already
have because again i said they take
forever to spin up and we're not going
to see too much if we do so once it's
spun up this is what it looks like so
you'll have an origin it says where it's
pointing to you can create multiple
origins group them uh you can modify
your behavior so that was basically what
we're looking at before as you can see
we have our behavior there nothing super
exciting
we can set up error pages you can
restrict based on geographical locations
so if you're for whatever reason if you
if you're not allowed to serve content
in uk you could say exclude this
geographical region right so you have an
allow list
or a block list saying like okay we
can't do uk because like let's say you
just don't want to do um
england you don't want to do um uh gdpr
for whatever reason you could block out
i don't know i'm having a hard time here
britain
england it's england right united
kingdom there we go so you just say okay
forget united kingdom i don't have to do
gdpr now uh for invalidations the idea
is that you know it is a cache so things
can get stale or just persist and so
here you can just type in say i want to
get rid of
image.jpg and then you create that
invalidation and then it will go delete
it out of the cache and so the next time
someone requests they'll get the fresh
content this usually doesn't take that
long but that's pretty much cloudfront
in a nutshell okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at ec2 also
known as elastic compute cloud and so
this is a highly configurable virtual
server or it's also known as a virtual
machine and that's what we're going to
generally refer to it uh ec2 is
resizable compute capacity it takes
minutes to launch new instances and
anything and everything on database uses
ec2 instances underneath that's why we
generally call it the backbone to all
the eight of the services and uh you're
gonna just have to choose a few options
here so the first thing you'll need to
do is choose your os via your amazon
machine image so that's where you get
red hat ubuntu windows amazon linux zeus
it might also come with pre-installed
libraries and things like that then you
can choose your instance type that's
going to determine things like your
vcpus your memory so here you can see
how many there are and you'll have like
a monthly cost
and that's the name of the instance type
then you have to add storage so very
commonly you're attaching elastic block
storage or elastic files
system or service
and so you know if you do choose your
ebs
you are going to have to determine what
type it is so whether it's a solid state
drive a hard disk drive a virtual
magnetic tape or even attaching multiple
volumes not just a single one and the
last thing is configuring your instance
so this is configuring the security
groups the key pairs user data im rolls
placement groups all sorts of things so
we will experience in that because we
will show you how to launch an ec2
instance and it'll make a lot of sense
if it does not make sense right now okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at ec2
instance families so what are instance
families well instant families are
different combinations of cpu memory
storage and networking capacity and
instance families allow you to choose
the appropriate combination of capacity
to meet your application's unique
requirements different instance families
are different because of the varying
hardware used to give them their unique
properties and we do talk about this
thing about uh
capacity reservation where aws can
actually run out of a particular type of
instance family because they just don't
have enough hardware in that data center
so you have to reserve it but let's go
through the different types of instance
families the first is general purpose
and these are the names of the different
families uh very popular ones is the t2
the t2 and one that's really interesting
is the mac which actually allows you to
run
a
mac server
so these are great balance of compute
memory and network resources so you're
going to be using these most of the time
the use cases here would be web servers
code repositories things like that then
you have compute optimize so um they all
start with c uh no surprise there
they're ideal for compute bound
applications that benefit from high
performance processor thread cases here
are scientific modeling dedicated gaming
servers ad server engines things like
that then you have memory optimized um
and so there's a variety here these are
fast performance for workloads that
process large data sets and memory
they're great for in-memory caches and
memory databases real-time big data
analytics then you have accelerated
optimize so this is your p2 p3 p4 things
like that these are hardware
accelerators or coprocessors these are
great for machine learning computational
finance seismic analysis speech
recognition if you're doing um uh ml on
aws you'll start coming across these
types aws technically has a separate
page on sagemaker ml machines but
they're all pulling from these instance
families okay then we have storage
optimized so i3 i3en things like that
these are highly high sequential read
and write access to very large data sets
on local storage the use cases here
would be nosql in memory or
transactional databases data warehousing
for the certified cloud partitioner you
just need to generally know these five
categories not the names of the instance
families if you're doing
associates or above you definitely want
to know these things in a bit more
detail and i want to say that commonly
instant families are called instance
types but an instance type is a
combination of size and family but even
aws documentation doesn't make this
family distinction clear but i know this
because you know in azure they make that
very clear and and gcp and so i'm
bringing that language over here to just
kind of normalize it for you okay
[Music]
let's take a look at what ec2 instance
types are so an instance type is a
particular instant size and instance
family and a common pattern for instance
sizes you'll see is things like nano
micro small
medium large x large 2x large 4x large
8x large and you know generally they're
you to the power of twos but sometimes
it'll be like 12 14 16 where it's even
uh and so when you go to launch your ec2
instance you're going to have to choose
that instance type and so here you can
see
you know here's our ttmicro and then we
have um the small the bdm the large
the x large
okay but there are exceptions to this
pattern for sizes so you know there is
one particular one called uh dot metal
and so that's going to indicate that
this is a bare metal machine and then
sometimes you get these oddball ones
like
9x large so you know the rule of power
of two or even numbers is not always the
case uh but generally it'll be pretty
even for you know the start here okay uh
just talking about instant sizes so the
easy two instance sizes generally double
in price and attributes so uh just
bringing up these numbers a little bit
closer starting at the small here you're
gonna notice one
two
it doesn't maybe double there but four
and here we see twelve twenty four uh
almost doubles there almost doubles
there but i want to show you that the
price is generally almost double so 16
33 67
135 and so a lot of times like you
always have the option to say okay do i
want to go to the next instance size up
or have
an additional distance of the same size
and sometimes it's a better approach to
get an additional instance because then
you can distribute it across another az
but then you also meet additional
capacity so there you go
[Music]
so we talked about dedicated instances
and hosts a little bit but let's just
make that distinction very clear so
dedicated hosts are single tenant ec2
instances designed to let you bring your
own license so byol based on machine
characteristics and so we'll compare the
dedicated instance to the dedicated host
across isolation billing
physical characteristics visibility
affinity between a host and instance
targeted instance placement automatic
instance placement and add capacity
using allocation request so for
isolation for dedicated instance you're
going to get instance isolation so you
can have the same customer on the same
physical machine but there is
virtualization there for them and
there's a guarantee of that
for a dedicated host you have physical
server isolation so you get the whole
server
for billing uh on a dedicated instance
it's per instance billing and it's gonna
have an additional fee of two dollars
per region and for dedicated hosts it's
per host billing so it's a lot more
expensive but you get the whole machine
uh for visibility of physical
characteristics you're not going to get
any of that information for a dedicated
instance for dedicated hosts you are
such as sockets core host host id and
this is really important when you have a
bring your own license and they're
saying this license is for x amount of
cores or x amount of sockets
then we have affinity so there's no
affinity for dedicated instance for
dedicated hosts you'll have consistency
with deploys to the same instance the
same physical server there's no control
of target instance placement for
dedicated instance you do have control
on a dedicated host
for automatic instance placements you
have it for both
and to add capacity using allocation
requests it's a no for dedicated
instance and it's a yes for dedicated
host
so i want to come back to the main point
that's what's highlighted here is that
on a dedicated host you have visibility
of sockets core host id
and this is really really important when
you're bringing your own license byol
such as
you know
microsoft sql servers where you have to
specify the mana cores and things like
that okay
[Music]
so we've been talking about uh tendency
and i just wanted to make it very clear
uh the difference between the different
levels of tendency on aws so we have
three okay so we got dedicated hosts so
your server lives here and you have
control of the physical attribute so
basically the whole server okay
then we have dedicated instances so your
server is on the same uh physical
machine as other customers but the
actual slot that you have the dedicated
instance will always be the same and
then we have the default so your
instance will live somewhere on the
server uh and when you reboot it's going
to be somewhere else so there's no
guarantee that it's going to be in the
same place every single time okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
be looking at ec2 and also um services
that are adjacent to it so like auto
scaling groups load bouncers elastic ips
things like that so we fully understand
ec2
you don't have to know tons for the exam
but you should be able to go through the
motions of this with me so you can
cement that knowledge
for some of those deeper concepts like
working with key pairs and things like
that
so let's make our way over to the ec2
console and learn what we can learn
um and generally when you go over the
ec2 console it'll bring it to the
dashboard for whatever reason to bring
me there and then the idea here is that
on the left hand side we can make our
way over to instances
okay and this is where we can launch our
first instance
so we go here and launch our instance
the first thing we're going to be
presented with is to choose our mi or
amazon machine image and so that is a
template that contains the software
configuration so the operating system
applications and other binaries that
would be installed on that os by default
all right and so we have a variety that
we can choose from in the quick starts
and generally the ones that you're going
to see first are the ones that it'll
support so there are
amis or operating systems that aws will
support when you contact them and then
there's ones that are outside that where
they'll still help you with but they
might not have the knowledge on so just
understand that if you pick from these
core ones you're going to be in good
shape the most popular is the amazon
linux 2 because it's part of the free
tier and it is very minimal and well
hardened by aws so it's a very good
choice there but you can see you can
install a bunch of things
so like if you want to launch a mac os
server you can absolutely do that a red
hat
susie ubuntu a windows server you name
it they have it if you wanted something
more
farther out there you can go to the
marketplace and
subscribe to one that is managed by
company basically everything exists
under the sun here or you can get a
community ami so these are ones that are
contributed by the community for free
but we're going to go back to quickstart
here and what i want you to notice is
that there is this ami id that's how we
can uniquely identify what we're using
if we were to change region even with
the same amazon x2 instance this thing
will change so just understand that it
is regional based and it comes in a
64-bit variant and a arm variant and so
we're going to be using the x86 here
you can notice here you can change it on
the right hand side we're going to stick
with x86 i'm going to go ahead and hit
next
so now we're going to choose our
instance type and so this is going to
decide um
greatly how much we're going to be
spending because the larger it is the
more we're going to spend so see this t2
micro if we wandered into the pricing
for that we go to ec2
pricing aws
and once we get to ec2 pricing we want
to go to on demand
and from here this will load
and so down below we can kind of go find
our price it should show us
it should show us the list ah here it is
okay so i can say a t2 micro
and we can see the on demand is this
so it seems really cheap what you got to
do is do the math so if you do time 730
that's how many hours there are in a
month
if we launch a ttmicro and let's say we
didn't have the free tier we you do if
you first made your account you're going
to have 700 750 hours for free for the
free tier but if you didn't it would
only cost you eight dollars and and 46
cents usd okay
so just be aware of that if you ever
need to figure something out go there
copy it do the math 730 it's pretty easy
so here we have a t2 micro in the t2
family it's going to have one v v cpu
notice it has a v for virtual so there
could be more than a single cpu on the
underlying hardware but we're only going
to have access to one virtual cpu we
have one gigabyte of memory
it's for low to moderate network
performance so that's a factor that can
change if you need like
gigabit stuff like really fast
connections for on-prem hybrid
connections and you have specialized
servers for that but for this this is
fine the ct micro is great uh if you
want you can also search this way to see
all the instance families and things
like that you can filter for current
generations all generations so this is
fine okay
so from there we're going to go to
configure our instance type you can say
let's launch multiples of these
instances let's turn on spot to save
money and try to bid for a particular
price
we can change our vpc it's going to
default to the default vpc um if you
have no subnets just going to pick one
at random here which is fine
whether to auto assign a public ip
address if you do not have an ip address
you cannot reach the internet so
generally you want this to be enabled
this is dependent on the subnet whether
it will default to enabled but it
doesn't matter if you have an ec2
instance in a private or public subnet
you can always override this and give it
a public ip address you have placement
groups which allows you to place servers
together closely not something for the
certified cloud partitioner there's
capacity reservations so if you're
worried about
database running out of this you can
reserve capacity so that's kind of
interesting domain join directory this
isn't something that i've done much with
but i imagine that has something to do
with um direct active directory or
something like that to join information
then you need to uh
have an im role and we absolutely do
need an item rule here so what i want
you to do is create a new role it's
going to close off these other tabs here
and we will go
wait a moment create a new role here and
we want to do this for ec2 so we say ec2
is what we're creating the rule for
we'll hit next and
i don't know if i have a policy but i'm
gonna go ahead and um oh well i don't
need to make a new policy but i just
want ssm and the reason i want ssm is so
that
i can um
use sessions manager to log in so we
don't have to use key pairs we will use
key pairs but if we didn't want to use
it that's what we could do and this used
to be the old roll it'll tell you hey go
use this new one here so i just want to
make sure i know which one it is
and so we'll just checkbox that on we'll
hit next we can add tags right here it'd
be well actually we don't need to add
any tags here so that's fine we'll sit
next and then i'll just say my
ssm ec2 role
okay
and we'll create that role
and now that we have created that role
we can go back to our first tab here and
give this a refresh and then drop down
and it should show up here
if we go down here a little bit we could
turn on extra monitoring there is
monitoring built in but if you wanted to
monitor it to a lower uh like it more
frequently you could do that as well we
want share tenancy right this is where
you change the dedicated instance or
dedicated host obviously these costs
more but we're gonna stick with shared
elastic conference so this is for um
uh attaching a a fractional gpu great
for ml not something that we want
there's credit specification i don't
remember seeing this before selecting
unlimited for credit specification
allows for uh to burst beyond the
baseline so it's for bursting
here you can attach an uh efs so if you
need a file system that you want to
mount or attach um
then there's the enclave option so nitro
enclave enables you to create isolated
compute environments to further protect
your and securely process highly
sensitive data so it might be something
you might want to checkbox on um based
on your use case
and then down below are we have the
ability to enter our user data and this
is something we want to do because we
want to install
apache so that we have something to work
with here so what i'm going to do is
make a shebang so that is a pound and an
exclamation mark i know that's really
small so i'll try to bump up my font
here so you can see what i'm doing
and we're going to do a forward slash
bin and a forward slash bash on the next
line here we're going to do yum install
hyphen y httpd
that's going to install apache and why
it's not called apache i don't know why
but they call it httpd
there's no apache in the name there and
so we'll say systemctl start httpd
system ctl enable httpd so we're saying
startup apache and then make sure that
it stays running if we restart our
machine
very simple so from there we will go to
our storage we'll say add or storage and
this is at 8 gigabytes by default we
could
turn that up to 30 if we like so you can
go all the way up to 30 if you like and
you might want to do that but i'm going
to leave it at 8. we could change our
volume type i'm fine with gp2 because
that's very cost effective and if we
want to turn encryption and you should
always turn on encryption there's no
reason not to
and so we'll turn that on it's not like
it's going to cost you more it's going
to be the same cost it's just your
choice there if we want to add a tag yes
we're going to add a name and we're
going to say my ec2 instance
okay
and so that's going to give us a name
which is something we would really like
to have then we have a security group
i'm going to just create a new query
book called my
ec2sg here
and you'll say my ec2
sg something you cannot do is rename a
security group once you've made it so
make sure you don't make a spelling
mistake up here
and we want to be uh
accessing that http http
or it's going to launch a website so in
order to do that we need to make sure we
have http as the type with the port 80
open and we want it from anywhere so
we'll say anywhere and that will be
0.0.0.0.0
and that's for the ipv4 this is for the
ipv6 okay so
we'll just say internet
and this is for ssh right
and for this i would probably suggest to
say my ip but since we might be using a
cloud shell to do that we're going to
leave it as anywhere so that we don't
have any issues connecting so from here
we'll review and launch
and you can review
what it is that's going on here it's
going to say here hey you have an open
port that's okay we we want the internet
to see our website because that's the
whole point there and we'll go ahead and
launch it it's going to ask for a key
pair we can go down and say proceed
without key pair but what i'm going to
do is i'm going to create a new key pair
because i want to show you how those
work and i'm sure we've already done in
this course once but we'll do it again
and so i'm going to just name this as my
ec2 instance here and then we're going
to go download that key pair it's going
to download a pem file
there and so now we can go ahead and
launch that instance
and while that is launching so i'm going
to just close this other tab here we're
going to click on the view instances and
so here is that instance that's why we
put the tag so we can have a name there
we're going to wait for that to start
but as that's going i'm going to make a
new tab by just right clicking here on
the logo
click anywhere pretty much to do that
and once we do that we'll click on cloud
shell
and as that is going what i want to do
is take this pim down below i'm going to
move it to my desktop to make it easier
for me to upload i'm doing this off
screen
okay
and
uh once this environment's running i'm
going to go ahead and upload that okay
so we'll just give it a moment to do
that we're also waiting for the server
to spin up as you'll notice there is a
public ip address here it says it's
running so if we want we can copy it
we're looking for those two checks to
pass so the server could be available
but generally you want to wait for those
two system checks because one says hey
the hardware is fine the network's fine
things like that okay but if i take that
ip address paste it on and up here we
have the web page so that is working uh
no problem there so that's great
and we'll go over to cloud shell and
that is still starting uh it's not the
fastest but that's just how it is
and um you know we'll get going here in
a second as soon as
this decides to load
there we go so it's loaded i can type
clear here just to clear that screen out
and so what i want to do is upload that
pem file so i'm going to go and upload
that file we're going to go ahead and
select it i'm going to go to my desktop
here whoops my desktop and we are going
to choose my ec2 instance pem
all right and from there we'll hit
upload that's going to upload that pem
file
once that is uploaded we're going to do
ls
okay and so this is from a previous
tutorial so i'm going to go ahead and
just delete that other one there we'll
say remove efs example pem
yes
okay we'll type clear
and then what we can do here is type in
chamod and
i believe it's 400
and what do we call this my ec2 instance
pem if you hit tab it will auto complete
which is nice and if you do ls hyphen la
we can take a look at that file and see
it should look like this should have
only one r here so the idea is you're
locking it down so it's not writable or
executable it's just readable because
that's what you have to have it if you
want to ssh and so if we want ssh what
we'll do is hit the connect button here
and we have four options they just give
you too many options it's gonna be a
fifth one for sure soon but right now
we're talking about ssh so for ssh um we
had the chamod or file which we did and
then we need to use this dns to connect
to it and so this is the full line here
if you click on this copy that over and
paste it in
that should be everything and notice
we're doing ec2 user
followed by this you could put the ip
address in here it said if you preferred
so if you were over here
you could go and take that ip address
which is
i think shorter nicer but um you know if
you just click that one button it works
that's fine you always have to accept
the fingerprint then you'll be inside
the instance you can type who am i to
see which user you are you're the ec2
user that's the user that aws creates
for their amazon linux instances
it's going to vary per
ami so not all amis have an ec2 user it
might be something else but that's
generally the ones that adas uses for
their supported ones and so if we do um
an ls
again we're in the server right now we
can tell because it says right here or
if we do a pwd we can kind of just kind
of look around so i think it's going to
be at var ww that's where ht httpd or
apache always puts their files here
so i go in here whoops
i'm just looking for
the index file
so i thought the index file was in
cd bar www
hmm
html
well where the heck is it so i'm going
to just touch a file here and see if it
overrides it
oh i don't care i'll just type sudo
and what we can do is just try to
restart this system ctl um
there's a very similar command that's
like uh service and so i always forget
the order of it so
i think it'd be i'm just checking
probably
restart
httpd
and so fail to restart the policy was
not provided as the name service
service
uh maybe sudo
there we go and so if we go back here
i'm gonna see if it changed
because it will take whatever is in the
index.html file so if there's no file
there it's going to show that there and
so what i can do
is i can edit this file i'm going to
type vi index html and
um i'm going to hit i for insert mode
oh it says it's read only so what we
have to do
cue colon cue quit
oops clear
ls and so what we need to do is do sudo
vi
index html
and so vim every single key is a hot key
okay um
i'm not teaching vim here but i'm going
to teach you the basics but the idea is
that when you're here notice that the
cursor is blinking when i hit i it
enters insert mode now i can type
normally so i'd say hello
uh hello cloud okay and i'm gonna hit
escape to go back to um
navigation mode whatever you wanna call
it i'm gonna hit colon so it brings up
the command i'm gonna type in uh write
and quit okay and hit enter
and so i'll type clear and so oops clear
and so we'll hit up till we get that
command
sudo systemctl restart httpd we'll hit
that hit enter
okay and it should restart
pretty fast
there it is this is hello cloud i
probably didn't even have to restart it
to do that but anyway so now that
instance uh you can see how we're
updating that so what i want to do is
just do a sanity check and make sure
that if we restart this instance that
we're going to be able to
have apache running that's something you
should always do if you have an app and
you or anything you install it restart
your server make sure that everything
works so what i'm going to do
is uh just hit exit here so we go back
to the top level cloud shell type clear
i'm going to go back over to my ec2
instance
i'm gonna have to click around to find
it here and what i want to do is reboot
it
okay and if i reboot the machine the ip
address is going to stay the same okay
so if we reboot it the ip address is
going to stay the same and the reboot's
going to happen really fast if we want
to observe that reboot we could go over
to
um here on the right hand side go to the
system log and it would show us that it
it had rebooted
i think so yeah it does cloud in it
there i think it rebooted
not sure
but anyway if it's rebooted then we can
go ahead and connect and make sure
everything's fine so let's just go here
and hit enter
and let's see if the what the webpage is
here
notice that it's hanging right so it's
probably because it's still restarting
even though it doesn't look like it is
and that's something that you have to
understand about the cloud is that
you have to think about what you're
doing and have confidence that it is
happening and also just double check it
but uh that's something that can be kind
of frustrating because these are
globally available services uh they're
massively scalable and so one of the
trade-offs is that you don't always have
the most
uh responsive uh uis aws has one of the
most responsive uis out of all the major
providers but even still like sometimes
i have to second-guess myself but the
page right now is not working now it is
so it's fine so it just took time for
that to reboot
and so um what i want to do is connect a
different way so we're going to go here
and we're going to hit um we're going to
checkbox that on we're going to hit
connect and instead of using ssh client
we're just going to go to sessions
manager and hit connect
and this is the preferred way of
connecting because you don't have to
have this this ssh key and that's a lot
more secure because if someone has that
key and you you know you hand it to
someone they could hand it to somebody
else and then you have a big problem on
your hands so here this looks very
similar but if you type who am i it
actually logs in as the ssm user which
is kind of annoying so i type in sudo su
i have to do this hyphen here and then
i'm going to say the user i want to be
which is ec2 user
and then if i type umi we are the
correct user you can't do anything in
that ssm hyphen user or
ssm user so you got to switch that over
and i can bump this up to make it a bit
larger so this is obviously not as nice
as working over here or even in your own
terminal but
it's a lot more secure and it's tracked
and all these other things so we really
should be using it okay
and um i really don't like having to
bump this up with my html i'm just go
back to zero there there's probably a
way to configure that but anyway
let's just go
and take a look at our file
i'm gonna type buy again and we're gonna
do var
www.html
index html
i could put pseudo in front of there
and again remember you have to hit i to
go into insert mode
and what i'm going to do is just
capitalize that hello cloud give that
exclamation mark colon wq to quit right
quit i'm going to go back here refresh
okay so we don't have to restart our
server which is nice
all right
so um
that's that that's pretty clear so i'll
hit terminate here
and i don't think we need cloud shell
for anything so i'm just gonna close
that
and so that's pretty much it when it
when it comes to working with an ec2
instance and so the next thing i want to
show you is elastic ip okay
[Music]
okay so now i want to show you elastic
ip
commonly abbreviated to eip and so all
that is it's just a
a static ip and ip that does not change
because this ec2 instance here notice
that it's 54 163 4 104
and what would happen if we were to stop
this instance not reboot it but stop it
because for whatever reason we had to or
or um for whatever reason
and if we were to stop this instance and
we were to restart it
okay
and we have to wait for it to stop but
that ip address is going to change okay
so 54 163 4104 hopefully we can observe
that
i'm just going to write that down so we
do not forget
so i can prove to you that it does
change
and now that it it's still stopping here
so as that's stopping we're just going
to go ahead and get our elastic ip and i
will prove that as we go here so i'm
going to go over to here
and so what i want to do is reserve or
allocate an elastic ip address and so
i'm going to say us east 1
and it's going to say from the amazon
pool of ipv4 addresses so eight of us
has a bunch of ip addresses they're
holding on to and so you can just
allocate one
and once you've allocated that's your ip
address so coming back to here
okay this has stopped
notice there is no public ip address
we're going to start it again
okay and then we'll just checkbox it on
and we just have to wait a little while
to see what the ip address is going to
be i'm going to tell you it's going to
be something else
so if i go back here this is 54 235 12
110 and our original one was 54 163 for
104. so the reason why it's important to
have the same address is that if uh you
have a load balancer well not a load
bouncer but if you have a domain
pointing to your i your server and you
reboot then the route you have a
dangling um
a path or route where revenue 3 which is
going to be pointing to nothing and so
it was does have things to mitigate that
like aliases and things like that but in
general you know there's cases where you
just have to have a static ip address
and so we had allocated one over here
and if we want to assign it we're going
to associate that elastic ip address
we're going to drop it down choose the
cc2 instance
um i suppose the private ips as well and
then we're going to go ahead and hit
allocate or associate
and once it's associated it should now
have 34 199 121
116. so we go over here
and we're going to take a look here and
that's its ip address we can pull it up
okay and that's that so yeah that's
elastic ip
[Music]
okay so now that we
have our elastic ip we have our ec2
instance running let's say um you know
we lose the server we terminate it so we
would lose all of our configuration so
if we wanted to bake this ami to save it
for later what we'd have to do is go and
create an image so to do that we go to
the top here and we go to images and
templates and we can create an image or
we can create a a template which is a
lot better but for the time being we're
going to go ahead and create an image
and when you create an image you're
basically creating an ami and so here
i'm just going to say my ec2
and i'm going to 000 to just kind of
like number it so that's a very common
numbering just do three zeros and then
increment by one and so here i'm going
to say my apache server
and so it's going to save some settings
like the fact that there is a volume you
could save some tags there and so i
might go ahead and add a tag and it'll
say name and we'll just say my ec2
server or
so that it remembers that
okay
and then what we'll do is go ahead and
create our image
and so this can take a little bit of
time if we go over to
uh images here
it's going to be spinning for a while
and we'll just wait until it's done okay
all right so after waiting a little
while here our ami is ready so we're
just waiting for it to go available if
you do not see it just make sure you hit
the refresh
because sometimes aws will just spin
forever
and so that's just something you'll have
to do
so you know hopefully that makes sense
what we'll do is go make our way back
over to instances here and we can launch
one this way well actually we can do it
over from
the ami page so what i'm going to do is
just terminate this instance we're all
done with it
okay and we'll hit terminate it's
totally fine and it had a message about
elastic ips about releasing them so when
it does that the elastic ip is still
over here so it did not release it so
what we're going to do is go ahead and
disassociate the elastic ip
okay
and then we're also going to release the
ip address because if we don't we're
going to have this ip addresses sticking
around that we're not using it this is
going to charge us a dollar a month over
month so just be aware of those because
that's just kind of like a hidden cost
there but what we're going to do is go
over to ami
and we're going to select it here we're
going to go to actions we're going to go
ahead and launch
and what it's going to do is make us
fill all this other stuff again so if
you had made a launch template we
wouldn't have to fill out all the stuff
it'd be part of it but that's what i'm
trying to show you with this ami stuff
so
instead of filling out all this what i'm
going to do is now go create a launch
template just to kind of show you that
that would be a much easier way to work
so we go over to ec2 instances and then
on the left-hand side we're looking for
a launch template launch launch
configurations is the old thing
um launch templates here we go
so what we'll do is create ourselves a
launch template we'll just say my apache
server
and
then down below we need to choose our
ami so we're going to go here and we
need to type it in so what did we call
it my ec2
i really don't like this search here
it's very slow and frustrating but once
we find it whoops
that's why i don't like it because a lot
of times you'll be loading and you'll
end up clicking the wrong thing
okay so
uh i don't like this okay we'll type in
my
give it a second
there it is and just wait because it
will keep loading and then once it's
loaded hit enter
and so it has that instance selected and
then from there
uh don't include in the launch template
so here we could be explicit i would say
i want this to be
t2 micro but we could exclude it if we
wanted to we could specify the key pair
here um not that we really want to use
key pairs we'll say my ec2 instance then
down down here for the networking we can
specify that security group we created
so we created one here called myec2sg
um storage is fine it's going to be
encrypted network interface is fine
advanced details what i want to do is
set the i am instance profile that's
really important because we don't want
to have to figure out that role every
single time
so put that there
and that should be
everything and we could put user data in
there but it's already baked into our
ami so we don't have to worry about
anything so what i'm going to do here is
go ahead and create this launch template
and then we're going to view this launch
template and so now what we can do is
then use it to
launch an instance
okay
and so we're going to look here and it's
very similar to dc tube except it's
vertical so we're going to have one
instance it's going to use that ami that
instance type so you can see how you can
override them which is nice we're going
to check the advanced details and make
sure that iom profile is set and we'll
go ahead and launch this from a template
so
from there we can go ahead and click the
instance value there
and just be aware that when you do click
through links like that you'll end up
with a search so i was just check box
that off so i can see what i'm doing
and so we're just waiting for this
instance to show up and the only thing i
noticed is it didn't set our darn tags
so i wanted the name in there and i
think it's because we set it in the ami
but it didn't carry over to the launch
template so i'd have to go back to the
launch template and update it probably
so if i go into here into the launch
template
we can probably modify create a new
version
and then add tags there
so we say name
my apache server
i realize i'm changing between them and
so that should allow us to have a
version two so we'll create that
and but anyway that will be for the next
time we launch it okay
and so this instance is running i'm
gonna go grab the ip address
the server may or may not be ready we'll
take a look here
and so it's just spinning if it's
spinning it's either the server is not
ready or um our port's not open so it
was just
getting ready to work there so it is
working now
so that is our launch template so now
you know we don't have to worry about
losing our stuff and if we need to make
new versions we can just
bake new amis
and increment them
and attach them as new versions of the
launch template okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to show you in
this follow along is to set up an auto
scaling group for our ec2 instance and
the idea behind this is that
we'll be able to always ensure that a
single server is running or increase the
capacity if the demand requires it so in
order to create an auto scaling group we
can go all the way down below to here
and so you know i really don't like the
autoscaling group form but it's okay
we'll work our way through it so the
first thing is we'll have to create our
or name our auto screen group so let's
just say my asg and then we'll have to
select a launch template which is great
because we already have one and then
we'll have to select the version i'm
going to select version two so that it
applies that tag name
and we'll go to next
and so here
it's going to need to select a vpc and
then we need some subnets so we're going
to choose three just because to have
high availability you have to be running
at least three different availability
zones so that's why we have three
different subnets and then down below we
have the instance type requirements so
uh t2 micro
launch template looks good to me so
we'll go ahead and hit next
and then from here we can choose to do a
load balancer and so i want to do the
load balancer separate so we won't do it
as of yet but very often if you're going
to have an auto selling group you're
going to usually have a load balancer
but we'll talk about that when we get to
that point there so we'll just go to the
bottom here and hit next and so this is
what's important so
how many do you want to be always
running and so we always want to have
one and maybe the maximum capacity is
two and you want the desired cast
capacity to be around a particular
number so if you had three and you said
the desired is two
there are things that could try to work
to always make sure there's two but we
just want to have one for this example
we can set up scaling policy so i do
target tracking scaling policy and so
here we could do it based on a bunch of
different things so if the cpu
utilization went over 50 percent it
would launch another server so that
might be something we might want to set
so we're not going to try to trigger the
scaling policy but we might as well just
apply because it's not too hard and you
can also do a scaling scale in
protection policy so if you want to make
sure it does not
reduce the amount of servers that's
something you could do
we could add a notification to say hey
there's a scaling policy happening here
which is fine we don't have to worry
about that and there's tags so add text
to help you search filter etc
so i'm going to put a tag here i'm going
to say name
i'm just wondering if this is going to
attach to the ec2 instance or this is
for the auto scanning group you can
optionally choose to add tags to
instances by specifying tags in your
launch template so we already did that
so i don't need to put a tag here
and so we can review
our
auto scaling group and go ahead and
create that auto scaling group
okay and so that auto scaling group
expects there to be a single instance so
what's going to do is it's going to
start a launching an instance and so
what i'm going to do is just get rid of
this old server because we don't need it
anymore this old one here
okay and you can already see
okay that the load balancer
is launching this new one here and
remember we updated our version two to
have that name so that's how we know
that it is so if we go back over to our
auto scaling group
okay it's now saying there's an instance
we don't have a status as of yet
and so there are ways of doing uh status
checks to for it to determine whether or
not the server is working
because if the server is unhealthy what
it would do is it would actually kill it
and then start up a new one right so if
i go down below it's right now doing the
ec2 health check and the ec2 health
check just means that is the server
working right is it running it doesn't
necessarily mean like hey can i load
this web app um but you know it's very
simple so we'll give it a moment here
to start up and just make sure that it's
working
okay and i think it's ready so if i take
that public ip address here and paste it
in there it is okay
so if we were to
tell it to increase the capacity to
three then what it would do is it would
launch three and then it should probably
launch it all evenly to those other
it should evenly launch it to all those
other uh availability zones and then
we'll have something that is highly
available okay
so that's pretty much it for this and
then we'll move on to auto scaling
groups
[Music]
all right so we have our ec2 instance
now managed by an auto screen group and
the great thing is that if we terminate
this instance this auto discounting
group will launch another uh instance to
meet our particular capacity um the only
thing though is that if we were to have
multiple ec2 instances running like
three of them
um how would you distribute traffic to
the mall right so you know you have an
ip address coming in from the internet
but let's say you want to evenly
distribute it and that's where a load
bouncer comes into play
and even if you have a single server you
should always have a load balancer
because it just makes it a lot easier
for you to scale when you need to
and you it acts as an intermediate layer
where you can attach a web application
firewall you can attach an ssl
certificate for free
so there's a lot of reasons to have
a load balancer so what we'll do is go
down below on the left-hand side and
we're going to make our way over to load
bouncers and we're going to create
ourselves a new load balancer so i'm
going to hit create load balancer here
and you're going to see we have a lot of
options application load bouncer network
load balancer gateway load balancer and
then the classic load bouncer and so we
are
running an application so i'm going to
create an application load balancer and
here i'm going to say my alb
for an application load balancer this is
going to be internet facing it's going
to be ipv4
we're going to let it launch in the
default
subnet and we're going to choose the
same
the same
azs
right so that we get the same subnets as
our
that are in our auto scanning group and
that's really important okay
and then here um you know we need to
have a security group and i just feel
like selecting the same one here because
that should work
no problem there
and we want to make sure that we can
listen on port 80 and then it's going to
forward it to a a target group it looks
like i might have a target group there
from before so just to reduce that
confusion you won't have this problem
i'm just going to double check if that's
true
so do i have a target group from there
before before yes i do
that came from
i'm not sure it might have been created
by um
elastic bean stock and wasn't deleted
okay so i'll go back over to here just
so there's less confusion
and
we were selecting our target group so
we're going to create a new target group
so we'll go over here
and here you can choose whether it's
instance ip lambda application load
balancer so you could point it
specifically to an ip address and so if
it was a static ip address that would
make sense
uh apparently you can port uh
point it directly to instances i don't
remember seeing that option before
i guess that makes sense yeah no sorry
that makes sense because i would go to
uh vpcs okay or sorry uh asgs
autoscaling groups it's just that
you're pointing them to auto screen
groups you're not pointing them to
instances so that's why that's confusing
so i'm going to say
my
target group it'll be for port 80 here
protocol http 1 is fine we want to be in
the same
vpc so that's fine as well
and down below we have our health check
and so the forward slash means that it's
going to hit the index.html page and so
if it gets back
um something healthy and that that
something healthy is going to be um
port 80 then it's going to be considered
good
and then we can say the threshold of
check so i'm just going to reduce this
so it's not so crazy so we'll say three
uh two and then ten
okay
and then it expects back a 200 which i
think that's what we'll get back so
we'll go ahead and hit next and so now
we have our target group and it should
register instances so it's saying hey we
detected this and this fits the
requirements for this so this is now
uh this is now in this target group okay
so we can go back over here
and we can now drop down and choose oops
hit the refresh button
and choose our target group
so i'm not
seeing it here so i'm gonna go back over
here oh we didn't create it okay
and now we can go back hit refresh and
there it is
and yeah that looks all good so we'll go
ahead and hit create load bouncer
we can view the load balancers and these
crate really fast
if we scroll on up
what we can do is now access our server
through this dns name okay so we copy
that
paste that on in there
does it work
not as of yet so if it's not working
there because we did say look at these
instances another way is to directly
associate your auto scaling group with
the load balancer
so if i go into here and we hit uh
edit
there is a way
aha a little bouncer so
we want to associate this way and we
want to say this target group here
and also while we're here we might as
well set it to elb so it's going to use
the elb check so that makes it so the
auto scaling group
if it wants to restart server it's going
to use the elbs check which is a lot
more sophisticated
and then what we'll do is go hit update
okay
and now if we go back over to our load
balancer i'm just going to close some of
these tabs so it's a little less
confusing
a little bouncer here
i think we should be able to see through
here whether it is seeing it
let's go down below listeners monitoring
integrated services no it's going to be
through the target group
okay
i mean it already had it there so maybe
it's just that it hasn't finished the
check so over here it has a health
status check oh now it's healthy okay so
if it's healthy in the target group and
the load bouncer is pointing to it then
it should technically work so we're
going to go ahead and
copy the dns again here make a new tab
paste it in
and there it is okay so
that's how you're gonna access
all your all your instances that are
within your auto scanning groups you're
gonna always go through the dns and so
if you had a row 53
domain like your domain managed by aws
you just point to the load balancer and
that's how you hook it up so that's
pretty much it so yeah there you go
all right so there you go we learned
everything we wanted to know about ec2
so the the last thing to do is to tear
everything down so we have a load
balancer we have an auto scanning group
um and those are the two things we'll
have to
pull on down so the first thing would be
to take down the auto scaling group and
when you delete another scaling group
it's going to delete all the ec2
instances so we'll do it that way if you
tried to delete the ec2 it would just
keep on spinning up so you have to
delete that first and so as that's
deleting then we'll be able to delete
our load balancer i'm going to try
anyway to see if i can delete it at the
same time
and so i'll go up here i'm going to go
ahead and delete that load balancer
actually it did work no problem
i'm gonna make sure i don't have any
elastic ips
i'm gonna also make sure i don't have
any key pairs
you can keep your key pairs around but
like i just want to kind of clean this
up so
okay
okay and that instance should be
terminating
go back to the auto scan group here
if we click into it we can check
its activity here
so it's just saying successful so it is
waiting on elb connection draining which
is kind of annoying because we deleted
elb so there's nothing to drain
um draining is just to make sure that uh
you know there's no interruptions when
terminating services so just trying to
be smart about it
and all i want to see is that it's just
saying terminating over here and then i
think we're done
okay so we'll just have to wait a little
while here okay
and i'll see you back in a moment okay
all right so after waiting a very long
time it did destroy so if i go down over
to my load balancer here we're gonna see
that it does not exist so there was that
connection draining thing which was kind
of annoying it's probably because i
deleted the load balancer first and then
the um
the uh
the autoscaling group second and
probably connection draining was turned
on but it's not a big deal we just
waited and it did eventually delete so
we're pretty much all done here so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at ec2 pricing
models and there are five different ways
to pay with ec2 remember each two are
virtual machines so we have on-demand
spot uh reserved dedicated and adamus
savings plans so what we'll do is look
at these in summary here and then we'll
dive deep onto each of these different
pricing models so for on demand you are
paying the uh a low cost and also you
have a lot of flexibility with this plan
uh you are paying per hour so this is a
pay-as-you-go model uh or you could be
paying down to the second which we'll
talk about uh the caveats there when we
get to the on-demand section this is
suitable for workloads that are going to
be short-term spiky unpredictable
workloads uh that cannot be interrupted
and it's great for first-time
applications and the on-demand pricing
model is great when you need the least
amount of commitment for spot pricing
you can see we can save up to 90 percent
which is the greatest savings of out of
all these models here uh the idea here
is you're requesting spare computing
capacity that database is not using and
that's where you're gonna get that
savings you have flexible start and end
times
but your workloads have to be able to
handle interruptions because these
servers can be stopped at any time to be
giving to more priority customers and
this is great for non-critical
background jobs very common for like
scientific computing
where jobs can be started and stopped at
any given time this has the greatest
amount of savings then you have reserve
or reserved instances this allows you to
save up to 75 percent this is great for
steady state or predictable usage you're
committing with aws for ec2 usage over a
period of one or three year terms you
can resell on
unused reserve instances so you're not
totally stuck with this if you buy them
this is great for the best long term
savings then you have dedicated so these
are just dedicated servers and
technically not a pricing model but more
so that the fact that it can be utilized
with pricing models um but the idea here
is it can be used with on demand
reserved or even spot this is great when
you need to have a guarantee of isolate
hardware for enterprise requirements and
this is going to be the most expensive
so yeah there you go and we'll dive deep
here okay
[Music]
so the on-demand pricing model is a
pay-as-you-go model where you consume
compute and then you pay later so when
you launch an ec2 instance by default
you are using that on-demand pricing and
on-demand has no upfront payment and no
long-term commitment you are charged by
the second up to a minimum of 60 seconds
so technically a minute or the hour so
let's just talk about the difference
between those uh per second billing and
those per hour billing so per second are
for linux windows windows with sql
enterprise windows with sql standard
windows with sql web instances that do
not have a separate hourly charge and
then everything else is going to be um
per hour and so
you know when i'm launching ec2 instance
i can't even tell when something's per
second or per hour you just have to know
that it has a separate hourly charge but
generally you know if you're just
launching things it's going to probably
be the per second billing when you look
up the hourly or the the pricing it's
always shown in the hourly rate so even
if it is using uh per second billing
when you look up that pricing it's
always going to show it to you like that
but on your bill you'll see it down to
the second okay up to the first 60
seconds and on demand is great for
workloads that are short-term spiky or
unpredictable uh but when you have a new
app development this is where you want
to experiment and then when you're ready
to uh start saving because you know
exactly what that workload's going to be
over the span of a year or three that's
where we're going to get into reserved
instances which we'll cover next
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at reserved
instances also known as ri and this is a
bit of a complex topic but uh you know
if we do get through it it's going to
serve you well through
multiple aw certifications so let's give
it a bit of attention here so ri is
designed for applications that have a
steady state predictable usage or
required reserve capacity so the idea is
that you're saying to aws i'm going to
make a guaranteed commitment
saying this is what i'm going to use and
i'm going to get savings because abuse
knows that you're going to be spending
that money okay so the idea here is that
the reduced pricing is based on this
kind of formula where we have term class
offering the r a tributes and payment
options technically the ra tributes
don't exactly factor into it other the
fact that they on our attribute could be
like the instance type size
but i'm going to put that in the formula
there just because it is an important
component so let's take a look at each
of these components of the formula to
understand how we're going to save so
the first is the term so the term uh the
idea here is the longer the term the
greater the savings so you're committing
to a one year or three year contract
with aws
um and one thing you need to know is
that these do not renew so
at the end of the year the idea is that
you have to purchase again
and when they do expire your instances
are just going to flip back over to on
demand with no interruptions to service
then you have class offerings and so the
idea here is the less flexible the
offering the greater the savings so the
first is standard and this is up to a 75
reduction in the price compared to on
demand and the idea here is you can
modify some ra attributes which we'll
we'll talk about when we get to the um
ra tribute section there then you have
convertible so you save up to 54 reduced
pricing compared to on demand and you
can exchange uh ris based on the ri
tributes if the value is greater or
equal in value and there used to be a
third class called schedule but this no
longer exists so if you do come across
it just know that abuse is not planning
on offering this again for whatever
reason i'm not sure why
then there are the payment options so
the greater upfront the greater the
savings so here we have all upfront so
full payment is made at the start of the
term partial front so a portion of the
cost must be paid up front and the
remaining hours in the terms are billed
at a discounted rate and then there's no
upfront so you are billed at a
discounted hourly rate for every hour
within the term regardless of whether
the reservation is being used and this
is really great this last option here
because basically you're saying to aws
you're saying like i'm just going to pay
my bill as usual but i'm going to just
tell you what it's going to be and i'm
going to save money so if you know that
you're going to be using a t2 medium for
the next year uh you can do that and
you're just going to save money okay so
ris can be shared between multiple
accounts within an organization and
unused rise can be sold in the reserved
instance marketplace but we'll talk
about the limitations around that when
we get a bit deeper in here just to kind
of show you what it would look like at
the end of this console and they updated
it i love this new ui here the idea here
is you're going to filter based on your
requirements and that's going to show
you ris that are available and then
you'll just choose the desired quantity
you can see the pricing stuff there
you're going to add it to cart you're
going to check out and that's how you're
going to purchase it okay
[Music]
so another factor to that formula were
ri attributes and sometimes the
documentation calls them r attributes
sometimes they call them instance
attributes but these are limited based
on class offering and can be
uh can affect the final price of the r
instance and there are four rh
attributes so the first is the instance
type so this could be like an m4 large
and this is composed of an instance
family so the m4 and the instant size so
large okay then you have the region so
this is where the reserved instance is
purchased then you have the tendency
whether your instance runs on shared so
the default which would be multi-tenant
or a single tenant which would be
dedicated hardware and then you have the
platform whether you're using windows or
linux even if you're using on-demand of
course this would just affect your
pricing but there are some limitations
around here which we'll get into as we
dive a bit deeper here with our eye okay
[Music]
all right let's compare regional and
zonal ri so when you purchase an ri you
have to determine the scope
for it okay so this is not gonna affect
your price but it's gonna affect the
flexibility of the instance uh so this
is something you have to decide so we're
gonna talk about regional ri which is
when you purchase it for a regional and
zonal ri when you purchase it for an
availability zone so when you purchase
it for a regional ri
it does not reserve capacity meaning
that there's no guarantee that those
servers will be available so if anybody
runs out of those servers uh you're just
not going to have them but when it's
zonal uh you are reserving capacity so
there's a guarantee that those will be
there when you need them
in terms of az flexibility
you can use the regional ri for any az
within that region but for the zonal ri
you can only use it for that particular
region we're talking about instance
flexibility
you can apply the discount to uh any
instance in the family regardless of the
size uh but then when we're looking at a
z there is no instance flexibility okay
so you're just going to use it for
exactly what you defined you can queue
purchases for regional ri you cannot
queue purchases for zonal ri so there
you go
[Music]
let's talk about some ra limits here so
there's a limit to the number of
reserved instances that you can purchase
per month and so the idea here is that
you can purchase 20 regional reserve
instances per region and then 20 zonal
reserve instances per az so if you have
a region that has three az's you can
have uh 60
zonal reserved instances in that region
okay there are some other limitations
here so for regional limits you cannot
exceed the running on demand instance
limit by purchasing regional reserve
instances the default for on-demand
limit is 20 so before purchasing your ri
ensure on-demand limit is equal to or
greater than your ri you intend to
purchase you might even want to open up
a service limit increase just to make
sure you don't hit that wall for zonal
limits you can exceed your running on
demand instance limit by purchasing
zonal reserve instances if you're
already uh have 20 on-demand instances
and you purchase 20 zone reserved
instances you can launch a further 20
on-demand instances that match the
specification of your zonal reserved
instances so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about capacity reservation so
ec2 instances are backed by different
kinds of hardware and so there is a
finite amount of servers available
within an availability zone per instance
type of family remember an availability
zone is just a data center or a
collection of data centers and they only
have so many servers in there so if they
run out because the demand is too great
you just cannot spin anything up and so
that's what's happening you go to launch
specific ec2 instant type but abs is
like sorry we don't have any right now
and so the solution to that is capacity
reservation so it is a service of ec2
that allows you to request
a reserve of vcc instance type for a
specific region and a z so here you
would see that you just select the
instance type platform a z tendency the
quantity and then here you might
manually do it specify time
or you might say okay i can't get
exactly what i want but can give me
something generally around that kind of
stuff or that type that i want so the
reserve capacity is charged at the
selected instance type on demand rate
whether an instance is running in it or
not and you can also use regional
reserve instances with your capacity
reservations to benefit from billing
discounts so there you go
[Music]
so there are some key differences
between standard and convertible ri so
let's take a look at it here so the
first is that with standard ri you can
modify your attributes so you can change
the az within the same region you can
change the scope from a zonal ri to
original ri or vice versa you can change
the instant size
as long as it's a linux and it has the
default tendency you can change the
network from ec2 classic to vpc and vice
versa but where you're looking
convertible you you don't modify ri
tributes you perform in exchange okay
and so standard rise cannot do exchanges
where convertible ri you can uh exchange
during the term for another convertible
ri with new ra attributes and this
includes the instance family instant
type platform scope and tenancy um in
terms of the marketplace you ca they can
be bought in standard ri uh in the
marketplace or you can sell your ri if
you uh don't need them anymore but for
convertible ri they cannot be sold or
bought in the marketplace you're just
dealing with aws directly okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the reserved
instance marketplace we had mentioned a
prior so let's give it a little more
attention here so it allows you to sell
your unused standard ri to recoup your
spend for alright you do not intend or
cannot use so reserved instances can be
sold after they have been active for at
least 30 days and once database has
received the upfront payment you must
have a u.s bank account to sell ri on
the ra marketplace there must be at
least one month remaining in the term
for the ri you are listing you will
retain the pricing and capacity benefit
of your reservation until sold and the
transaction is complete your company
name and address upon request will be
shared with the buyer for tax purposes
a seller can set only the upfront price
of an ri the usage price and other
configurations such as instance type
availability zone platform will remain
the same as when the ri was initially
purchased the term length will be
rounded down to the nearest month for
example a reservation with 9 months and
15 days remaining will appear as 9
months on the rm market you can sell up
to 20 000 usd in reserved instances per
year if you need to sell more ri
reserved instances in the govcloud uh
region cannot be sold on the ra
marketplace so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are taking a look at spot instances
so a bus has unused compute capacity
that they want to maximize the utility
of their idle servers all right so the
idea is just like when a hotel offers
booking discounts to fill vacant suites
or planes offer discounts to fill a
vacant seats all right so spot instances
provide a discount of 90 compared to
on-demand pricing spot instances can be
terminated if the computing capacity is
needed by other on-demand customers but
from what i hear rarely rarely does spot
instances ever get terminated
it's designed for applications that have
flexible start and end times or
applications that are only feasible at
very low compute costs so you see some
options here like load balancing
workloads flexible workloads big data
workloads things like that um there is
another service called ada's batch which
is for doing batch processing and this
is very common what you use spot with
and so you know if you find the spot
interface too complicated you're doing
batch processing you want to use this
service instead um there are some
termination conditions so instances can
be terminated by aws at any time if your
instance is terminated by a bus you
don't get charged for a partial hour of
usage if you terminate an instance you
will be still charged for an hour that
it ran so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at
dedicated instances so dedicated
instances is designed to help meet
regulatory requirements innovas also has
this concept called dedicated hosts and
this is more for when you have strict
server-bound licensing that won't
support multi-tenancy or cloud
deployments and we'll definitely
distinguish that in this course but just
not in this slide in particular um and
so to understand uh dedicated instances
or hosts we need to understand the
difference between multi-tenancy and
single tendency so multi-tenancy you can
think of it like everyone living in the
same apartment and single tendency you
can think of it everyone having their
own house so the idea here is that you
have a server i'm just going to get my
cursor or my pen out here to say server
and you have multiple customers running
workloads on the same hardware and the
idea is that they are separated via
virtual isolization so they're using the
same server but it's just software that
might be separating them okay
and then we have the idea of single
tenancy so we have a single customer
that has dedicated hardware so the
physical location is what separates
customers
um and the idea here is that dedicate
can be offered via on-demand reserved
and spot so that's what we're talking
about dedicated here in the pricing
model just so you know that you know
even though these are a lot more
expensive than on-demand uh you can
still save by using reserve and also
spot which i was very surprised about
um
and when you want to choose dedicated
you're just going to launch your ec2 and
you'll have a drop down where you have
that shared so that's the default
dedicated so you have dedicated instance
and dedicated hosts and again we'll talk
about dedicated hosts later when we need
to here um and so again the reason why
um you know enterprises or large
organizations may want to use dedicated
instances is because they have a
security concern or obligation about
against sharing the same hardware with
other aws customers okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at ava savings
plans and this is similar to reserved
instances but simplifies the purchasing
process so it's going to look a lot like
all right at the start here but i'll
tell you how it's a bit different okay
so there are three types of saving plans
you have compute savings plan ec2
instance saving plans and sage maker
saving plans uh and so you just go ahead
and choose that you can choose two
different terms so one year three year
so it'd be simple as that and then you
choose the following payment options so
you have all upfront partial payment and
no upfront and then you're going to
choose that hour of the commitment
you're not having to think about
standard versus convertible uh regional
versus zonal ri attributes it's a lot
simpler uh let's just talk about the
three different saving plans or types in
a bit more detail so you have compute so
compute savings plans provides the most
flexibility and helps to reduce your
cost by 66 percent these plans
automatically apply to ec2 instances
usage aws fargate abuse lambda service
uses regardless of the instance family
size az region os or tenancy then you
have ec2 instances so this provides the
lowest prices offering saving up to 72
percent in exchange for commitment to
usage of instance uh individual instance
families in a region so automatically
reduce uh your costs on the selected
instance family in the region regardless
of az size os tenancy gives you the
flexibility to change your usage between
instances with a within a family in that
region and the last is sagemaker so
helps you reduce stage maker costs by up
to 64 percent automatically apply to
stage maker usage regardless of instance
family size component aws region if you
don't know what sagemaker is that's
aws's ml service and it uses ec2
instances or specifically ml ec2
instances so everything's basically
using ec2 here but there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the xero
truss model and the zero trust model is
a security uh model which operates on
the principle of trust no one and verify
everything so what i mean by that is
malicious actors being able to bypass
conventional access controls
demonstrates traditional security
measures are no longer sufficient and
that's where the zero trust model comes
into play so with the zero trust model
identity becomes the primary security
perimeter
and so you might be asking what do we
mean by primary security perimeter the
primary or new security perimeter
defines the first line of defense and
its security controls that protect a
company's cloud resources and assets
um if this still doesn't make sense we
do cover a part of the defense in depth
where you see the layers of defense from
data all the way to physical and so you
can kind of see you know what we're
talking about in that model there
but the old way that we used to do
things is network-centric so we had
traditional security focused on
firewalls and vpn since there were few
employees or workstations outside the
office or they were in a specific remote
office so we treated the network uh the
network as kind of like the the boundary
so if you're in in office there's
nothing to worry about but we don't
think like that anymore because
everything is identity centric so
this is where we have bring your own
device remote workstations which are
becoming more common uh we can't always
trust that the employee is in a secure
location we have uh identity-based
security controls like mfa or providing
provisional access based on the level of
risk from where when and what a user
wants to access and identity centric
does not replace uh but it augments
network-centric security so it's just an
additional layer of consideration for uh
security when we're thinking about our
database cloud workloads okay
[Music]
all right so we just loosely defined
what the zerotrust model is so let's
talk about how we would do zero trust in
aws and so zero trust has to do a lot
with identity security controls uh so
let's talk about what is at our disposal
on aws so on database we have identity
and access management i am this is where
we create our users or groups or
policies so time policy is a set of
permissions that allow you to say okay
this user is allowed to use
these services with these particular
actions
then you have the concept of permission
boundaries and so these are saying okay
these aren't the permissions the user
has currently but these are the
boundaries to which we want them to have
so they should never have access to
um uh ml services and if someone's to
apply them uh uh
permissions it'll always be within these
boundaries then you have service control
policies and these are organization-wide
policies so if you have a policy where
you don't want anyone to run anything in
the canada region you can apply that
policy at the organizational level and
it will be enforced
then within an ion policy there are the
concept of conditions and so these are
all the kind of like uh little knobs you
can tweak to say how do i control based
on a bunch of different factors so
there's source ip so restrict where the
ip address is coming from a requested
region so a restrict based on the region
as we were just mentioned as an example
uh multi-factor auth presence so
restrict if mfa is turned off uh current
time so restrict access based on time of
day maybe your employees should never be
really using things at night and so that
could be an indicator that someone is
doing something malicious so you know
only give them access during a certain
time of day and so that's where we're
going to figure out you know based on
all these type of control security
controls uh to our aws resources we can
kind of enforce the zero trust model aws
itos does not have a ready-to-use
identity controls that are intelligent
which is why abuse is considered not to
have a zero trust offering for customers
and third-party services need to be used
so what i'm saying is that technically
you know this check box is this thing
saying okay we can kind of do zero trust
on aws but there's a lot of manual work
and
you know if i was to say okay
i don't want anyone using this at
nighttime that doesn't really detect you
know what i'm saying it's not going to
say oh i think this time is suspicious
or malicious so then restrict access
only to these core services and anything
outside of the services can't be used it
just can't exactly do that without a lot
of work yourself and that's what i'm
talking about here where we have a
collection of services that can be set
up in an intelligent intelligent ish
detection way for identity concerns but
requires expert knowledge so the way you
might do that aws is that everything all
the api calls go through awes cloudtrail
and so what you could do is feed those
into amazon guard duty and guard duty is
an intrusion
[Music]
intrusion detection and protection
system so it could detect suspicious
from malicious activity on those
cloudtrail logs and you could follow
that up with remediation or you could
pass that on to amazon detective that
could analyze investigate and quickly
identify security issues
that it could ingest from guard duty but
i'm telling you that this stuff here is
not as easy
for the consumer
and so you of course you can do zero
trust model but it's going to take a lot
of work here and there are some
limitations which we'll talk about next
here
so now let's see how we would do zero
trust on a bus with third parties so it
was just does technically implement a
zero trust model but does not allow for
intelligent identity security controls
which
you know you can do it but it's a lot of
work so let's kind of compare it against
kind of a third party where we would get
the controls that we would not
necessarily get with aws so for example
azure active directory has a real-time
and calculated risk detection based on
data points than aws and this is based
on device and application time of day
location whether mfa is turned on what
is being accessed and the security
controls verification or logic
restriction is much more robust so you
know just as one particular example like
device and application is not something
that aws factors in uh with the
existing controls or at least not in a
way that is consumer friendly and you
know i can't say on a bus okay when you
think that this is the type of threat
only allow them access to these things
or if you think they're in a risky area
or risky uh location only give them
access to you know these things or where
there's not sensitive data you can't
exactly do that in a database very
easily and so this is where third-party
solutions are going to come into play so
you have azure active directory google
beyond corp jump cloud and all these
have more intelligent security controls
for real-time detection um and so the
way you would use these is these would
be your primary directories uh for
google beyond corp is just a zero trust
framework so i guess you'd use
google's uh cloud directory but the idea
anyway here is that you use single
sign-on to connect those directories to
your aws account and that's how you'd
access access those uh aws resources and
you get this more robust functionality
okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're looking at identity now we need to
know a bunch of concepts before we talk
about identity on aws so let's jump into
it the first is a directory service so
what is directory service well it's a
service that maps the names of network
resources to network addresses and the
directory services shared infrastructure
or information
infrastructure for locating managing
administrating and organizing resources
such as volumes folders files printers
users groups devices telephone numbers
and other objects a directory service is
a critical component of a network
operating system and a directory server
or a name server is a server which
provides a directory service so each
resource on the network is considered an
object by the directory server
information about a particular resource
is stored as a collection of attributes
associated with that resource or object
well-known directory services would be a
domain name service
so the directory service for the
internet microsoft active directory and
they have a
cloud hosted one called azure active
directory we have apache directory
service oracle internet directory so oid
uh open ldap uh cloud and identity and
jump cloud okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at active
directory now you might say well we're
doing a bus why are we looking at this
well no matter what cloud provider
you're using you should know what active
directory is
especially when it comes to identity
because you can use it with aws
so let's talk about it so microsoft
introduced active directory domain
services in windows 2000 to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple on-premise infrastructure
components and systems using a single
identity per user and since then it's uh
involved evolved obviously it's running
beyond windows 2000 as of today and they
even have a managed one called azure ad
which is on microsoft azure but just to
kind of give you an architectural
diagram here the idea is that you would
have your domain servers here
and they might have child domains and
the idea is that you have these running
on multiple machines so that you have
redundant ability to log in from various
places when you have a bunch of domains
it's called a forest and then within a
domain you actually have organizational
units and with them within
organizational units you have all your
objects like your users your printers
your computers your servers
all things like that okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're talking about identity providers
or ipds so
so
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are talking about identity
providers also known as idps
so an identity provider is a system
entity that creates maintains and
manages identity information for
principles and also provides
authentication services to applications
with a federation or distributor network
a trusted provider of your user identity
that lets you use authent lets you
authenticate to access other service
identity providers so this could be like
facebook amazon google twitter github
linkedin
uh federated identity is a method of
linking a user's identity across
multiple separate identity management
systems and so some things that we can
use for that is like open id so this is
an open standard and decentralized
authentication protocol allows you to be
able to log in to different social media
platforms using google or facebook
account open ideas about providing who
you are then we have oauth 2.0 this is
an industry standard protocol for
authorization oauth doesn't share
password data but instead uses
authorization tokens to prove an
identity between consumers and service
providers oauth is about granting access
to functionality and then we have saml
so security assertion markup language
which is an open standard for exchanging
authentication and authorization between
an identity provider and a service
provider and this is important to use
for saml which we use for single sign-on
via the web browser okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at the concept of single
sign-on so sso is an authentication
scheme that allows the user to log in
with a single id and password to
different systems and software sso
allows it departments to administer a
single identity that can access many
machines and cloud services so the idea
is you have azure active directory this
is just an example of a very popular one
you'd use saml to do sso you can connect
to all things slackly the best google
workspaces salesforce or your computer
uh the idea here is uh once you
log in
you don't have to log in multiple times
so you log into your primary directory
and then after that you're not going to
be presented with a login screen some
services might show an intermediate
screen but the idea is you're not
entering your credentials in multiple
times so it's seamless
[Music]
all right let's talk about ldap so
lightweight directory access protocol is
an open vendor neutral industry standard
application protocol for accessing and
maintaining distributed directory
information services over ip network so
a common use of ldap is to provide a
central place to store usernames and
passwords ldap enables for same sign-on
so same sign-on allows users to
use a single id and password but they
have to enter it every single time they
want to log in so maybe you have your
on-premise active directory and then
it's going to store it in that ldap
directory and so the idea is that you
know all these services like google
kubernetes
um jenkins is going to deal with that
ldap server so why would you use ldap
over sso which is more convenient or
seamless so most sso systems are using
ldap under the hood but ldap was not
designed natively to work with web
applications so some systems only
support integration with ldp and not sso
so you got to take what you can get okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at multi-factor
authentication also known as mfa and
this is a security control where after
you fill in your user's name and email
password you have to use a second device
such as a phone to confirm that it's you
that is logging in so mfa protects
against people who have stolen your
password mfa is an option in most cloud
providers and even social media websites
such as facebook so the idea is i have
my username or email and password i'm
going to try to log in this is the first
factor and the second factor or
multi-factor is i'm going to use a
secondary device so maybe my phone we're
going to enter in different codes or
maybe it's password list so i just have
to press a button to confirm that it's
me and then i'll get access so in the
context of aws
it's strongly recommended that you turn
on mfa for all your accounts especially
the aws root account
we'll see that when we do the follow
alongs
[Music]
let's take a look at security keys so a
security key is a second device used as
a second step in authentication process
to gain access to a device workstation
or application a security key can
resemble a memory stick and when your
finger makes contact with a button of
exposed metal on the device it will
generate and autofill a security token a
popular brand of security keys is the
ubi key and this is the one i use and is
looks exactly like the one that's right
beside my desk it works out of the box
with gmail facebook and hundreds more
supports fido 2 web auth n uh u2f it's
waterproof and crest resistance it has
variations like usb a usb
nfc dual connectors on a single key can
do a variety of things so when you turn
on mfa on your aws account you'll have
virtual mfa device so that's when you're
using something like a phone or using
software on your phone to do that then
there's the u2f security key so this is
what we're talking about right now and
there's even other kinds of hardware mfa
devices
which we're not really going to talk
about but you know just security keys
tie into mfa and this is a lot better
way than using a phone because you know
you can have it on your desk and press
it um and you know you have to worry
about your phone being not charged okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at aws identity
and access management also known as iem
and you can use this service to create
and manage database users groups uh use
permissions to allow and deny their
access to adab's resources so there's
quite a few components here let's get to
it so the first is i am policies so
these are json documents which grant
permissions for specific users groups or
a role to access services and policies
are attached to im identities then you
have impermissions or permission and
this is an api action that can or cannot
be performed and they're represented in
the i am policy document then there's
the i am identity so we have i am users
these are end users who log into the
console or interact with aws resources
pragmatically or via clicking ui
interfaces you have im groups so these
these group up your users so they all
share the same permission levels so that
maybe its admins developers or auditors
then you have i am roles so these roles
grant endless resources permissions to
specific database api actions and
associate policies to a role and then
assign it to an aws resource so just
understand that
roles are when you're attaching these to
resources so like if you have an ec2
instance and you say it has to access s3
you're going to be attaching a role not
a policy directly okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at iron policies a
little bit closer here and they are
written in json and contain the
permissions which determine the api
actions that are allowed or denied um
and rarely do i write these out by hand
because they have a little wizard that
you can use to write out the code for
you but if you want to you absolutely
can write it out by hand but we should
know the contents of it and how these
json files work so the first thing is
the version
which is the policy language version and
it's been 2012 for a very long time i
don't see that changing anytime soon if
they happen to change uh what or what
the structure of the json is then you
have the statements and these are for
policy elements
and you're allowed to have multiples of
them so the idea is that this is the
policies or permissions we should say
that you uh plan on applying then you
have the sid this is a way of labeling
your statements um this is useful for
like visualization or for referencing it
for later on but a lot of times you
don't have to have a sid then there's
the effect it's either allow or deny
then you have the action so here we're
saying give access to s3 for all actions
under it there's another action down
below where it's saying give access and
get my pen tool out here just to create
a service link role so it's a cross
account rule there
then there's the principal so this is
the account user role or federated user
to which you would like to allow access
or deny so we're specifically saying
this user named barkley um in our aws
account there
uh then there are the resources so the
resources to which the action applies um
so in this one up here we are specifying
a specific aws bucket here we're seeing
all possible resources in enables
account and then the condition so
there's all sorts of different kinds of
conditions so this is a string like one
it's saying look at the service name and
if it starts with this or that then
they'll have access to that so this
person even though it says all resources
they're really only going to have access
to rds okay
[Music]
so in this follow along we're going to
take a closer look at im policy so go to
the top and type in iam
and what we'll do is make our way over
here
all the way over to policies and what i
want to do is create a new policy that
only has access to
limited resources so
let's say we want to create an amazon
ec2 instance and that ec2 instance has
access to a very particular s3 bucket
so what i want you to do is make your
way over to s3 and we're going to create
ourselves a new bucket
and i'm going to go ahead and create a
bucket here
we're going to call this um
policy tutorial
and i'm going to just put a bunch of
numbers here
you'll have to randomize it for your use
case
and so now that we have our bucket what
we're going to do is go ahead and create
a policy
and the policy is going to choose a
service we're going to say s3 and what i
want to do is only be able to list out
actions i'm going to expand this so i
don't want everything so we're just
going to say list buckets
okay
and then what we'll do is
uh expand this here and i want to say
for a particular bucket
so we'll go back over here click into
our bucket
and
we're going to go ahead and set those
permissions
by finding that iron
we're going to paste that
we're going to paste that iron up there
sometimes it's a bit tricky it vanishes
on you
and we could set other conditions if we
wanted to but this is pretty simple as
it is
and so that's our rule here right so
we're saying
this policy allows us to list this
bucket for that okay
so what we'll do is go ahead and hit
next
we'll hit review and we'll just say my
bucket policy
and we'll create that policy
okay so
there's a few other things i think that
i'd like to do with this policy i'm
going to pull it back up here so
if we want to find it uh you used to be
able to filter these based on the ones
that you created
but um
yeah they should like the little icon so
these are ones that i've created up here
and so there's my bucket policy
and i feel like i want to update this
policy to have a
bit of extra information here so i'm
going to go edit this policy
no you know what i think this is fine so
what i want to do is now create a role
and we're going to create a new role and
i'm going to call this um
well before i do i need to choose what
it's for so it's going to be for ec2 so
we're going to go ahead and hit next
we're going to choose our policy so my
bucket policy there it is
and i want to add another one here
because i want to be able to use
sessions manager because i really don't
want to use an ssh key to
check that this works
and
so um for this
i i need
to use ssm so i'm going to type in ssm
here
and i'm going to just make sure this is
the new one so this policy will soon be
deprecated use amazon ssn managed core
instance should always open these up and
read them and see what they do
and so that's the one that's going to
allow us to access simpson's manager so
we can use sessions manager okay
and so we're going to say my ec2 roll4s3
and we go ahead and create ourselves a
roll
and so now that we have our role i'm
going to go over to ec2
and i'm going to go ahead and launch
myself a new instance
we're going to choose amazon linux 2
we're going to stick with t2 micro i'm
going to go over to configuration here
everything is fine here
i'm fine with all that storage is fine
we'll go to security group and i don't
want any ports open because i'm not
going to be using ssh
we're going to launch this instance i
don't even want a key pair
okay
and then we're going to go over here and
so what we're waiting for is this
instance to launch as that is going what
i want to do is go over to my s3 bucket
and i want to place something in this
bucket so i do have some files here
so what i'm going to do
is create a new folder here
whoops
i'm going to go back and i'm just going
to create a folder first create a folder
enter prize d
and i'm going to click into this and
then i'm going to upload all my images
here
so you'll have to find your own images
off the internet this is just the ones i
have
and we'll go ahead and upload those
give that a moment
okay and so we don't have access to read
those files we'll adjust our policy as
we go so that we can do that okay
so this instance should be running um it
has doesn't have the two status checks
passed we should be able to uh connect
to it so click on connect here and so we
have options like ec2 instance connect
sessions manager ssh client i want you
to go to sessions manager
it says we weren't able to connect your
instance common reasons ssm agent was
installed we absolutely have that
installed
the required item profile oh right so we
were supposed to attach
i forgot to do we were supposed to
attach an iron profile right
so an iron profile is the role
uh
it holds the role uh that's going to
give the permissions to that instance
and since we didn't add it we got to go
retroactively at it after the fact
and so i'm going to modify the i am roll
and we're going to choose my ec2 roll
for s3 and we're going to save that
and actually when that happens you have
to reboot the machine
you only have to do that if you have no
roll attached like prior no profile
attached and they're attaching it for
the first time
but after that you never have to reboot
the machine this is the only case where
you'd have to do that
that's why when i launch an ec2 instance
i always at least have the ssm role
attached the managed one that gets
sessions manager so that i don't ever
have to do a reboot in case i have to
update the policy
and so we will give that a moment there
it says initializing so i'm going to try
again to connect to it okay
and we still don't have that option
there um so i'm going to go back to my
instances
i'm going to check to see if the role
the role or policy is attached
or profile i should say
so i'm just looking for it here
there it is
and so if i click into this
into the role
we can see that we have the amazon ssn
managed instance core there so that's
set up
and the my
bucket policy
so this has everything
that it should be able to do it no
problem
okay so i'm going to try that again
okay so now the connection shows up aws
is finicky like that you just have to
have confidence in knowing what you're
doing is correct okay
we'll go ahead and hit connect
i didn't have to use ssh keys or
anything and this is a lot more secure
way to connect your instances when it
logs us in it's going to set us as the
ssm user but we want to be
the
ec2 user
okay
that's uh aws always makes their uh am
like their linux versions as the ec2
user and that's what you're supposed to
use
but it's just
you just that's how you have to get to
that you have to type that sudo su
hyphen ec2 user okay just once
and if you type who am i that's who you
are if you type exit you'll go back to
that user so if i type exit and i type
who am i and now this person so i'm
going to go back hit up go back in there
type clear
so now i want to see if i have access to
s3 so i have to do abs s3 ls
let's see if i can list buckets
it says axis denied
so
i mean that kind of makes sense because
if you have list buckets and we're just
saying only that bucket that might not
make a whole lot of sense
so i'm going to go back to my policy i
might just written a crummy policy but
we'll say i am here if we have that one
open we should just go here
and click
on this policy here
i'm going to edit that policy
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to change it i'm going to say all
resources review the policy save changes
and we'll see how fast that propagates
okay
because i'm pretty sure i don't have to
do anything here it should just now give
me full access to s3
i'm just going to keep on hitting up
here
so i'm going to do is i'm just going to
take like a three four minute break
gonna get a drink i'm gonna come back
here and see if this propagates i'm
pretty sure i don't have to do anything
for that to propagate
and i think that i've attached
everything correctly here okay
okay so i haven't had much luck here
it's still having the same issue so if
that is happening what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to reboot it because
maybe i didn't give it a good
opportunity to reboot there again i
don't think we should have to reboot it
every time we're changing um
things there but we will give it another
go here
and see if that fixes that problem there
so those sessions matter is going to
time out here which is totally fine
it's going to kill that session there
and so what we'll have to do is close
this out because there's not much we can
do with that
and we're going to go ahead and go back
to connect and so we're waiting for this
button to appear because it is rebooting
so
if we want to monitor that stuff usually
there is an option
here to monitor where it will show us
the system logs of what it's doing
so here it's just like restarting the
machine
i'm not sure if we expect to see
something after this
so i can click that there
and uh yeah it's so easy to get turned
around so i can connect to it again now
we'll type in sudo su hyphen ec2 user
aws s3 ls
and we still have
access deny for list buckets so if
that's the case it could be that um
sometimes you need other permissions
when doing list policy like list buckets
so if that's the case we're going to do
a sanity check i'm just going to say all
permissions here okay
and this way there's no way that i've
set this incorrectly
um it just has to work now so type this
in
there we go okay so there has to be
something more to it so just because you
say list
buckets you know like means there must
be more to it right so if i go here to
this
right and i say whoops
and i say uh list buckets here we'll say
copy
paste okay
here it's saying maybe i need get object
as well so
i just know from using it about a long
time that that's the case that it could
be more than one thing so you know that
was in the back of my mind that that
could be happening and i guess that is
but notice i didn't have to restart my
uh my server boot my server to get those
to work
um
but anyway let's go lock that down and
see if we can just kind of make this uh
more focused so let's say
all resources i'm going to specify
the condition
so i might want to just say for
particular buckets
so we'll say specific
when you checkbox everything then you
have to do this so for storage accounts
these are fine any
for objects
that could be something
we'll say
multi-region access bucket
any bucket but what i'm going to say is
i want to only allow them to access
things in a particular bucket
and so if i go to arn here
um what is our bucket name
our bucket name is policytutorial3414
whatever
right
and so we can actually give it a wild
card or we can say enterprise
d
and we learned this in the course that
you can provide orange with randomized
things there i don't know if i spelt it
wrong over here so i should really
double check
i should probably just copy it
oops
i still want to type it wrong and so
this
okay
means that we should only be able to get
stuff from there i'm going to review the
policy let's see if it takes save the
changes
and if i just view the json here
notice it says anything from here right
so allow s3 anything as long as it's
within here and then it also broke it up
into sub 1's 4 here okay
so anyway what i want to see is what
happens
if i upload something into the loose
area here so i'm going to say upload
and i'm going to say add a file
and we're just going to grab data here
and upload
it go back to our bucket
there's our file we have that stuff in
there and so if i go back over to my ec2
instance which i'm still connected to
uh who am i
okay great
clear
so i'm going to say aws s3 ls see if
that works still it does good and so
what i want to do is see if i can copy a
file locally so i'm going to do a bus s3
copy
i think it was s3 8 no it's just s3
copy polis uh s3 forward slash forward
slash
policy
tutorial
three four
one four one whoops three four
tutorial
hyphen
three four one four one four slash
enterprise d
data dot jpg i think it's a jpg let's go
double check
yeah it is okay
and then i just want to say data.jpg
and it downloaded it right
so i'm going to remove that one and so
now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to see if my policy is working or
maybe my permissions aren't exactly what
i think they are
and i was able to download it so
it's these policies can get kind of
tricky because like this one says allow
all actions for these but then these say
all actions and so
that makes it hard because i want get
object
so another thing we can do
and if that one doesn't work really well
i'm just going to write one by hand
it's not that scary to write these by
hand you just get used to it so i'm
going to say effect
um
is it disallow
or maybe it's deny
deny
action
s3
get object
i believe that's what it is
resource
and then i'm going to specify exactly
the resource i don't want it to allow so
we're going to say arn
aws s3 3 colons
policy tutorial
and just say data.jpg
now if this is not valid it's going to
complain and say hey you didn't write
this right
and it and it's fine okay so
we'll save those changes
and so that should deny access to that
right
hopefully i got the policy right
okay so that one doesn't work which is
fine
and that one's fine so that worked we
were able to deny that but you can see
there's a little bit of an art to
creating these policies
as you make more of them it becomes a
lot easier so hopefully it's not too
scary but that's all there really is
to it that i want to show you today so
what we're going to do is clear out this
bucket we're done with this bucket here
so we'll say delete whoops we got to
empty it first
and we'll just say permanently delete
here
okay
and we will exit that out we're gonna go
ahead and delete that bucket
grab its name here
and uh we'll go back over here
i think i forgot to delete this bucket
from earlier i'm just going to delete
that because i don't need that bucket so
that's okay with you
just going to go ahead and delete that
and we have that ec2 instance running so
we want to stop that
so we go ahead and we're going to
terminate that yes please
and then we'll go to im and do some
cleanup
i have some custom rolls i've been
creating um you know from prior things a
lot of those
usually there's a way to uh we've
redesigned it okay where's the redesign
this is the redesign that can't be it
because it'll be like roles that ada
best makes i think these are all roles
that i've made
um
i don't want to delete service roles
but i want to get rid of some of these
because i just have too many you know
it's getting out of hand for me
and i'm going to just see if it will let
me
delete
all of these let's delete those
there we go just clean up a bit i still
have a lot here but there's like service
roles that aws creates once and you
really don't want to delete those
because
you don't
um and then i have a bunch of these like
i'm never going to use these so i might
as well detach them delete detach
you really don't want to keep like rolls
that you're never going to use around
things like that like gauze we're going
to be using that again
delete
there's that bucket we just created
anyway you get the idea so yeah that's
uh that's i am okay
[Music]
principle of least privilege pulp is the
computer security concept of providing a
user role or application the least
amount of permissions to perform an
operation
or an action and the way we can look at
it is that we have just enough access so
jea permitting only the exact actions
for the identity performer task and then
we have just in time j-i-t permitting
the smallest length of duration an
identity can use permission so usually
when we're talking about pulp it's
usually a focus on here uh but now
these days uh there's a larger focus on
jit as well and so jit is the difference
between having long lived
permissions or access keys versus
short-lived ones
and the most progressive thing in polp
is now risk-based adaptive policies so
each attempt to access a resource
generates a risk score of how likely the
request is to be from a compromised
source so the risk score could be based
on many factors such as device user
location ip address what services being
accessed and when did they use mfa did
they use biometrics things like that and
right now at as of this time it was does
not have a risk-based adaptive policies
built into iam you can roll your own
what's interesting is cognito has
risk-based adaptive policies they call
it like adaptive authentication but
that's for user pools and not identity
pools
user pools is for getting access to an
app
uh that you built through an ipd where
identity pools incognito
is about getting access to itabus
resources so
uh you know maybe i'm sure about will
get it eventually but they just don't
have it right now and you have to rely
on third-party
identity solutions uh to get risk-based
adaptive policies now talking about just
enough access in just in time just in
time is like you think how would you do
that with aws you just add and remove
permissions manually but one thing you
could do is use something like console
me so this is an open source netflix
project to self-serve short-lived i am
policies so an end user can access
database resources while enforcing jea
and jit and so there's a repo there as
well
but the idea is they have like this
self-serve wizard so you say i want
these things and then the machine
decides okay you can have them or you
you don't need them and it just frees
you up asking people and worrying about
the length and stuff like that okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the edibus
root user uh and this gets confusing
because there's energies account root
user and regular users let's distinguish
what those three things are so here we
have an apes account and the account
which holds all the aws resources
including the different types of users
then you have the root user this is a
special account with full access that
cannot be deleted and then you have just
a user and this is a user for common
tasks that is assigned permissions so
just understand that sometimes people
say it was account they're actually
referring to the user and sometimes that
when they're saying this account they're
actually referring to the invoice
account that holds the users i know it's
confusing it just it's based on what
people decide the context is when
they're speaking so the in-apps account
user is a special user who's created at
the time of the invoice account creation
and they can do uh they have a lot of
conditions around them so the reuser
account uses an email and password to
log in as opposed to the regular user
who's going to provide their account id
alias username and password the root
user account cannot be deleted the root
user account has full permissions to the
account and its permissions and cannot
be limited and when we say cannot be
limited we're saying that if you take an
im policy to explicitly deny the user
access the resources it's not something
you can do however you can do it in the
case of innovative organizations with
service control policies because a
service control policy applies to a
bunch of accounts so it just it's one
level above and so that is a way of
limiting root users but generally you
can't limit them within their own
account
there can only be one root user uh per
aws account the real user is instead for
very
specific and specialized tasks that are
infrequently or rarely performed and
there's a big list and we'll get into
that here in a moment and the abyss root
account should uh not be used for daily
or common tasks it's strongly
recommended to never use the root users
access keys because you can generate
those and use them it's strongly
recommended to turn on mfa for the root
user and any of us will bug you to no
ends to tell you to turn it on
so let's talk about the
tasks that you should be performing with
the root user and only the user can
perform so changing your account
settings this includes account name
email address root user password root
user access keys other account settings
such as contact information payment
currency preference regions do not
require the root user credentials so not
everything
restore im user permissions so if there
is an i i am admin so just a user that
has admin access who actually revokes
their own permissions you can sign into
the root user to edit policies and
restore those permissions
so you can also activate im access to
the billing and cost management console
you can view certain tax invoices you
can close your aws account you can
change or cancel your aws support plan
register as a seller in the reserved
instance marketplace enable mfa
delete on s3 buckets
edit or delete an amazon s3 bucket
policy that includes an invalid vpc id
or vpc endpoint id
sign up for govcloud and something
that's not in here which this i took
this from the documentation but uh you
can use the aws account user to create
the organization you can't create that
with any other user so um you know the
ones i highlighted in red are very
likely to show up your exam and that's
uh why i highlighted them there for you
but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at adabus
single sign-on also known as aws sso and
so this is where you create or connect
your workforce identities in aws once
and manage access essentially across
your items organization so the idea here
is you're going to choose your identity
source whether it's
sso itself active directory saml 2.0 idp
you're going to manage user permissions
centrally to items accounts applications
saml applications and it uses it can you
get single click access to all these
things so you know just to kind of zoom
in on this graphic here
you know you have your on premise active
directory it's establishing a ad trust
connection over to uh it will single
sign-on you're going to be able to apply
permissions to access resources within
your abilities account so via aws
organizations in your organizational
units down to your resources you can
also use aws sso to access custom saml
based applications so you know if i
build a web app and i like the example
platform and i wanted to use saml based
uh
connections for single sign on there i
could do that as well
and even connect out sso access to your
business cloud application so office 365
dropbox slack things like that so there
you go
well let's take a look here at
application integration so this is the
process of letting two independent
applications to communicate and work
with each other commonly facilitated by
an intermediate system
so cloud workloads uh strongly encourage
systems and services to be loosely
coupled and so itabus has many services
for the specific purpose of application
integration and these are based around
common systems or design patterns that
utilize application integration and this
would be things like queuing streaming
pub sub api gateways state machines
event buses and i'm sure there are more
but that's what i could uh think about
that are the most common ones okay
[Music]
so to understand queuing we need to know
what is a messaging system so this is
used to provide asynchronous
communication and decouple processes via
messages and events from a sender
receiver or a producer and a consumer so
a queuing system
is a messaging system that generally
will delete messages once they are
consumed it's for simple communication
it's not real time you have to pull the
data it's not reactive and a good
analogy would be imagining people that
are queuing in a line to go do something
so for aws it's called simple queuing
service sqs it's a fully managed queuing
service that enables you to decouple and
scale microservices distributed systems
and serverless applications so a very
common use case in a web application
would be to queue up transactional
emails uh to be sent like sign up reset
password and the reason why we have
queuing to decouple those kind of
actions is that if you had a
long-running task
and you had too many of them it could
hang your applications so by decoupling
them
and letting a separate compute
service take care of that
that would be something that would be
very useful okay
let's take a look here at streaming and
so this is a different kind of messaging
system
but the idea here is you have multiple
consumers that can react to events and
so in streaming we call messages events
and then in a queuing system we just
call them messages but events live in
the stream for long periods of time so
complex operations can be applied and
generally streaming is used for real
time stuff whereas cueing is not
necessarily uh real time
and so adabus's solution here is amazon
kinesis you could also use kafka but
we'll focus on kinesis here so amazon
kinesis is the aws fully managed
solution for collecting processing and
analyzing streaming data in the cloud
so the idea is that you have these
producers so that are producing events
could be ec2 instances mobile devices
it could be a computer or traditional
server
they're going to go into the data stream
there's a bunch of shards that scale and
there's consumers on the other side so
maybe redshift wants that data dynamodb
s3 or emr okay but the thing you have to
remember is that streaming is for
real-time data and as you can imagine
because it's real-time and it's doing a
lot more work than
a
queueing system it's going to cost more
okay
[Music]
so we have another type of messaging
system known as pub sub so this stands
for publish subscribe pattern commonly
implemented in messaging systems and a
pub sub system the sender of messages
the publishers do not send their message
directly to receivers they instead send
their messages to an event bus the event
bus categorizes their messages into
groups then receivers of messages
subscribers subscribe to these groups
whenever new messages appear within
their subscriptions the messages are
immediately delivered to them so the
idea is you have publishers event bus
subscribers and event buses appear more
than once so it actually appears in
streaming appears in this pub sub model
and then it can appear
in other variations so you're going to
hear it more than once the word event
bus
so the idea here is the publisher has no
knowledge of who the subscribers are the
subscribers do not pull for messages
messages aren't said automatically
immediately pushed to the subscribers
and messages and events are
interchangeable terms in pub
sub all right
and so you know
the idea here with publisher subscribers
just imagine getting like a um a
magazine subscription right if you think
of that you kind of think of the
mechanisms that are going here in terms
of practicality it's very common to use
these as a real-time chat system or a
web hook system so you know hopefully
that gives you an idea there in terms of
aws's solution we're using simple
notification service sns this is a
highly available durable secure fully
managed pub sub messaging service
that enables you to decouple
microservices distributed systems and
serverless applications
so here
we have a variety of publishers like the
sdk the cli cloud watch aid with
services
you'll have your sns topic you can
filter things fan them out and then you
have your subscribers to lambda sqs
emails https looks very similar to
streaming but again you know um you know
there's not a lot of communication going
back between it it's just publishers and
subscribers
and it's limited to you know
these things here so it's a very managed
service right
whereas uh kinesis you can do a lot more
with it okay
[Music]
so what is api gateway well it is a
program that sits between a single entry
point and and multiple back-ends api
gateway allows for throttling logging
routing logic or formatting of the
request and response when we say request
a response we're talking about
https
requests and responses
and so the service for aws is called
amazon api gateway so api gateway is
just a type of pattern
and this is the few cases where aws has
named the thing after what it is and so
we have amazon api gateway which is a
solution for creating secure apis in
your cloud environment at any scale
create apis that act as a front door for
applications to access data business
logic or functionality from back end
services so the idea is that you have
data coming in from
mobile apps web apps iot devices and you
actually define the api calls and then
you say where do you want them to go so
maybe tasks are going to go to your
lambdas
and then other routes are going to go to
rds kinesis ec2
or your web application
and so these are really great for having
um this uh being able to define your api
routes and change them on the fly and
then and always write them to the same
place okay
[Music]
so what is a state machine it is an
abstract model which decides how one
state moves to another based on a series
of conditions think of a state machine
like a flow chart and for aws the
solution here is itabus step function so
coordinate multiple aw services into a
serverless workflow a graphical console
to visualize the components of your
application as a series of steps
automatically trigger and track each
step and retries when there are errors
so your application executes in order as
expected every time
logs the state of each step so when
things go wrong you can diagnose and
debug problems quickly and so here's
example of using a bunch of
steps together on the uh the abyss step
functions service and so you know this
is generally applied for service
workflows but it is something that is
very useful if in application
integration okay
[Music]
so what is an event bus an event bus
receives events from a source and routes
events to a target based on rules i'll
get my pen tool out here so we have an
event it enters the event bus we have a
rules tell it to go to the target it's
that simple and we have been seeing
event buses in other things like uh
streaming
and uh pub sub but aws has this kind of
event bus offering that is kind of high
level it's called eventbridge and it's a
service event bus service that is used
for application integration by streaming
real-time data to your applications the
service was formerly known as
amazon cloudwatch events they gave it a
renaming to give it a better
opportunity for users to know that it's
there to use and they also extended its
capabilities
and so the thing is is that a lot of aw
services are always emitting events and
they're already going into this bus and
so if you utilize this service it's a
lot easier than having to roll your own
thing uh with other services
so amazon event bridge will just define
an event bus so there is an event bus
holds event data defines the rules on an
event bus to react to events you always
get a default event for every single abs
account you can create custom event
buses scoped to multiple accounts or
other abas accounts you have a sas event
bus scope to third party sas providers
you have producers these are aidable
services that emit events you have
events these are data emitted by
services they're json objects that
travel the stream within the event bus
you have partnered sources these are
third-party apps that can emit events to
event buses you have rules these
determine what events to capture and
pass to targets and then targets which
are aidable services that consume events
so yeah it's all just this great
built-in um uh uh stuff that's going on
here and so you know there there might
be a case where you can use eventbridge
and save your time uh a lot of time and
effort uh doing application integration
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at application
integration services at a glance here so
let's get through them so the first is
simple notification service sns this is
a pub sub messaging system sends
notifications via various formats such
as plain text email https web hooks sms
text messages sqs and lambda pushes
messages which are then sent to
subscribers you have sqs this is a
queuing messaging system or service that
sends events to a queue other
applications pull the queue for messages
commonly used for background jobs we
have step functions this is a state
machine service
it is it coordinates multiple aimed
services into a serverless workflow
easily share data among lambdas have a
group of lambdas wait for each other
create logical steps also works with
fargate tasks we have a vent bridge
formerly known as cloudwatch events it
is a service event bus that makes it
easy to connect applications together
from your own application third-party
services and aws services then there's
kinesis a real-time streaming data
service creates producers which send
data to a stream multiple consumers can
consume data within a stream used for
real-time analytics click streams
ingesting data from a fleet of iot
devices you have amazon mq this is a
managed message broker service that uses
apache
active mq so if you want to use apache
activemq there it is manage kafka
service and this gets me every time
because it says msk and that is the
proper initialization but you think it'd
be mks
it is a fully managed apache kafka
service kafka is an open source platform
for building real-time streaming data
pipelines and applications similar to
kinesis but more robust very popular by
the way we have api gateway a fully
managed service for developers to create
publish maintain monitor and secure apis
you can create api endpoints and route
them to ada services we have appsync
this is a fully managed graphql service
graphql is an open source agnostic query
adapter that allows you to query data
from many different data sources so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are comparing virtual machines to
containers so i know we covered this
prior but i just want to do it one more
time just to make sure that we
fundamentally understand the difference
before we jump into containers so the
idea is that if you were to request an
ec2 instance it has a host operating
system that we don't really know much
about but we don't really need to know
and then the idea is you have a
hypervisor which allows you to deploy
virtual machines
and so when you launch an ec2 instance
you're actually launching a vm on top of
a hypervisor on a server uh with on uh
within the aws
data centers servers there and you're
going to choose an operating system so
like ubuntu and it might come with some
pre-installed packages or you can
install your own libraries packages and
binaries and then you decide what kind
of workloads you want to run on there so
it could be django
mongodb so your database and some kind
of queueing system like rabbitmq the
difficulties with virtual machines so
you're always going to end up with some
unused space because you're going to
want to have some headroom uh to make
sure that uh you know if you know django
needs more memory or or mongodb needs
more storage that you have that room
that you can grow into
but the idea is that you're always
paying for that even when you're not
utilizing it and so you know that can be
uh not as cost effective as you'd like
it to be so when we're looking at
doing this again and we are
using containers um instead of the
hypervisor we have container
virtualization a very common one would
be called docker daemon for docker of
course and so now you're launching
containers and so maybe you have alpine
and this is for your web app and then
you install exactly the libraries
packages and binaries you need for that
and then for
mongodb you want to have a different os
different packages and same thing with
rabbitmq maybe you want to run it on
freebsd and the idea is that uh you know
you're not going to have this waste
because it it's kind of changed the
sense that these containers are flexible
so they can expand or decrease based on
the the use case of what they need
uh and you know if you use particular
services like it was fargate
you know you're paying like for running
the containers not necessarily uh for uh
over provisioning okay so vms do not
make best use of space apps are not
isolated which could cause uh config
conflict security problems or resource
hogging
containers allow you to run multiple
apps which are virtually isolated from
each other launch new containers
configure os dependencies per container
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the concept
of microservices and to understand
microservices we first need to
understand monoliths or monolithic
architecture and the idea here is that
we have one app which is responsible for
everything and the functionality is
tightly coupled so i'm going to get my
pen tool out here and just to highlight
notice that there is a server and
everything is running on a single server
whether it's load balancing caching the
database
maybe the marketing website the
front-end javascript framework the
backend with its api uh the orm
connected to background tasks things
like that and that's the idea of a
monolith and that's what
a lot of people are used to doing but
the idea with microservice architecture
is that you have multiple apps which are
responsible for one one thing and the
functionality is isolate and stateless
and so just by
leveraging um various cloud services or
bolting it onto your service
you know you are technically using
microservice architecture so maybe your
web app is all hosted uh in containers
so you have your apis your your orm your
reports maybe you've abstracted out some
particular functions into lambda
functions you have your um marketing
website hosted on s3 you have your
front-end javascript hosted on that
three
you're now using elastic load balancer
elasticash rds
sqs and that's the idea between
monoliths and microservices okay
[Music]
well let's take a look here at
kubernetes which is an open source
container orchestration system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containers it was
originally created by google and now
maintained by the cloud native computing
foundation so the cncf
kubernetes is commonly called k-8 the
eight represents the remaining letters
for kubernetes which is odd because
everyone calls it kubernetes with the s
on there but that's just what it is the
advantage of kubernetes over docker is
the ability to run containers
distributed across multiple vms a unique
component of kubernetes are pods a pod
is a group of one or more containers
with with shared storage network
resources and other shared settings
so here is kind of an example where you
have your kubernetes master it has a
scheduler controller etcd you might be
using
it uses an api server to run nodes
within the nodes we have pods and within
the pods we have containers
kubernetes is ideally for micro service
architectures where company has tens to
hundreds of services they need to manage
i need to really emphasize that tens to
hundreds of services all right so you
know kubernetes is great but just
understand that it is really designed uh
to be used for
massive amounts of microservices if you
don't have that need you might want to
look at something just easier to use
okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at
docker which is a set of platform as a
service products that use os level
virtualization to deliver software in
packages called containers so docker was
the earliest popularized open source
container platform meaning there's lots
of tutorials there's a lot of services
that uh integrate with docker or make it
really easy to use and so when people
think of containers they generally think
of docker there's of course a lot more
options out there than docker to run
containers but this is what people think
of and so we said it's a suite of tools
so the idea is you have this docker cli
so these are cli commands to download
upload build run and debug containers a
docker file a configuration file on how
to provision a container docker compose
which is a tool and configuration file
when working with multiple containers
docker swarm an orchestration tool for
managing deployed multi-container
architectures docker hub a public online
repository for containers published by
the community for download and one
really interesting thing that came out
of docker was the open container
initiative oci which is an open
governance structure for creating open
industry standards around container
formats and runtimes so docker
establishes oci and it is now maintained
by the linux foundation and so the idea
is that you can write a docker file or
or do things very similarly and use
different types of um
technologies that can use containers as
long as they're oci compatible you can
use them so docker has been losing favor
with developers due to their handling of
introducing a paid open source model and
alternatives like podman are growing and
that's why we're going to talk about
podman next okay
[Music]
so let's take a quick look here at
podman which is a container engine that
is oci compliant and is a drop-in
replacement for docker i just want to
get you exposure here because i want you
to know about this um and that you can
use it as opposed to using docker there
are a few differences or advantages that
podman has so podman is daemon-less
where docker uses a container d daemon
podman allows you to create pods like
kubernetes where docker does not have
pods uh podman only replaces one part of
docker podman is is to be used alongside
builda and uh scopio so you know docker
is an all-in-one kind of tool
everything is done via a single cli and
everything is there but you know they
just wanted to make it more module and
so
these other tools anytime you say podman
it usually means we're talking about
podman builda and scopio so builda is a
tool used to build the oci images and
scopio is a tool for moving container
images between different types of
container storages palm is not going to
show up in your exam but you should
practically know it
just for your own benefit okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the container
services offered on aws
so we have primary services that
actually run containers provisioning and
deployment on you know tooling around
provisioning deployment and supporting
services so the first here is elastic
container service ecs
and the advantage of this service is
that it has no cold starts but it is a
self-managed dc2 so that means that
you're going to be always paying for the
resource as it is running all right then
he has aws fargate so this is more
robust than using abus lambda it can
scale to zero costs
and it's being managed by adabus managed
ec2 however it does have cold starts so
you know if you need containers
launching really fast you might be
wanting to use ecs then you have elastic
kubernetes service eks this is uh open
source it runs kubernetes um and this is
really useful if you want to avoid
vendor lock-in um which is not really a
problem but
batteries just you want to run
kubernetes then you have abs lambda so
you only think about the code it's
designed for short running tasks if you
need something that runs longer you'd
want to use that is serverless you'd use
abus fargate which is serverless
containers you can deploy custom
containers so prior aws lambda just had
pre-built runtimes which were containers
but now you can create any kind of
container and use that on it was lambda
for provisioning deployment you can use
elastic bean socks so
it can uh deploy elastic container
service for you um which is very useful
there now there's app runner which kind
of overlaps on what elastic beanstalk
does but it specializes it specializes
for containers um and i believe that it
can actually i don't know what it uses
underneath because it is a managed
service so elastic bean stock is um open
you can see what is running underneath
an app runner i don't believe you can
see what is running underneath is just
taken care of by aws
then there's abyss copilot cli so this
allows you to build release operate
production ready containerized
applications on app runner ecs enables
fargate for supporting services you have
elastic container registry this is repo
for your containers not necessarily just
docker containers but containers in
general probably oci compliant
containers x-rays so analyze and debug
between micro services so you know it's
distributed tracing then you have step
functions so stitch together lambdas and
ecs tasks to create um
a state machine and the only thing i
don't have on here would be you know
being able to launch an ec2 instance
from the marketplace that has
um a
a container runtime installed like
docker i just don't feel that that's
very relevant for the exam but it is
another option for containers not
something that people do very often but
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at
organizations and accounts so aws
organizations allow the creation of new
aws accounts and allows you to centrally
manage billing control access compliance
security and share resources across your
aws accounts so here's kind of a bit of
a structure of
the architecture of aws organizations
and we'll just kind of walk through the
components so the first thing you have
is a root account user this is a single
sign-in identity that has complete
access to all eight of the services and
resources in an account and each account
has a root account user so generally you
will have a master or root account and
even within that you'll have a root
account user and for every additional
account that you have you'll notice over
here we have a root account user
then there's a concept of organizational
units uh these are commonly abbreviated
to ous so they are a group of aws
accounts within an organization which
can contain other organizational units
creating a hierarchy so
here is one where we have called
starfleet and here's one called
federation planets and underneath we
have multiple
accounts it was accounts within that
organizational unit
and even though it does not show it here
you can create an organizational unit
within an organizational unit
then we have service control policies
scps and these give uh central control
over the allowed permissions for all aws
accounts in your organization helping to
ensure your accounts stay within your
organizational guidelines what they're
trying to say here is that um there's
this concept of aws
i am policies and all you're doing is
you're creating a policy that's going to
be uh organizational unit-wide or
organizational-wide or for select
accounts so it's just a way of applying
iron policies across multiple accounts
it was organizations must be turned on
and once it's turned on it cannot be
turned off it's generally recommended
that you do turn it on because basically
if you're gonna run any kind of serious
workload you're gonna be using awesome
organizations to isolate your abus
accounts based on workloads you can
create as many aws accounts as you like
one account will be the master or root
account
and i say root account here because this
is the new language here and some of the
documentation still calls it master
account so understand this is the root
account not to be confused with the root
account user so
another clarification i want to make is
an ito's account is not the same as a
user account which is another thing that
is confusing so when you sign up for aws
you get an aws account and then it
creates you a user account which happens
to be a root user account so hopefully
that is clear
[Music]
so aws control tower helps enterprises
quickly set up a secure aws multi
account it provides you with a baseline
environment to get started with a
multi-count architecture so it does this
a few a few different ways the first
thing is it provides you a landing zone
this is a baseline environment following
well architected and best practices to
start launching production-ready
workloads so imagine you wanted to go
have um you know the perfect environment
that you know is secure
is correctly configured and has good
logging in place that's what a landing
zone is and so itabus's landing zone for
control tower is going to have sso
enabled by default so it's very easy to
move between ips accounts it will have
centralized logging for aws cloud trail
so that you know they're going to be
tamper evident or tamper proof away from
your workloads where they can't be
affected it'll have cross account
security auditing
um so yeah landing zones are really
great to have then there's the account
factory they used to call this um
a vending machine but they changed it to
account factory the idea is it automates
provisioning of new accounts in your
organization it standardizes the
provisioning of new accounts with
pre-approved
account configuration you can configure
account factory with pre-approved
network configuration and region
selections
enable self-service for your builders to
configure and provision to accounts
using able service catalog able service
catalog is just pre-approved uh
workloads uh via cloud formation
templates so you created to say okay
you're allowed to launch this server or
these resources
and the third and most important thing
that ava's control tower comes with is
guard rails so these are pre-packaged
governance rules for security operations
compliance the customers can select and
apply enterprise-wide or to specific
groups of accounts
so abus control tower is the replacement
of the retired aws landing zone so if
you remember abel's landing zones which
was never a self-serve easy thing to
sign up for it required a lot of money
and
stuff that go in there they just don't
really have it anymore and it was
control tower is the new offering um
there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abs config
and to understand it was config we need
to know what compliance as code is and
to understand compliance as code we need
to understand what change management is
so change management in the context of
cloud infrastructure is when we have a
formal process to monitor changes
enforce changes and remediate changes
and compliance is code also known as cac
is when we utilize programming to
automate the monitoring enforcing and
remediating changes to stay compliant
with the compliance program or expected
configuration so what is adabus config
well it's a compliance code framework
that allows us to manage change in your
aws accounts on a per
region basis meaning that you have to
turn this on for every region that you
need it for and so here is a very simple
example where let's say we create a
config rule and we have an ec2 instance
and we expect it to be in a particular
state
and then in the other case we have a rds
instance and it's in a state that we do
not like so the idea is that we try to
remediate it to put it in the state that
we want it to be and those configurables
are just powered by lambdas as you can
see based on the lambda icon there
so when should you use database config
well this is when i want this resource
to stay configured a specific way for
compliance i want to keep track of
configuration changes to resources i
want a list of all resources within a
region and i want to use
analyze potential security weaknesses
and you need detailed historical
information so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this follow along we're going to
take a look at aws config so itaps
config is a tool that allows you to
ensure that your services are configured
as expected so i've already activated it
in my north virginia region so what i'm
going to do is just go over to ohio here
because it is per region activated and
i'll go over to config and then what
we'll have to do is set it up
so there is this one click setup and it
did skip me to the review step because
it's kind of piggybacking on the
configuration of my original one here
but the idea is that you'll just say uh
record all resources in this region or
things like that you'll have to create a
service role link if you have not done
so so this will look a little bit
different but here it's using the
existing one you'll have to choose a
bucket so or create a bucket uh it's not
super complicated so you get through
there you hit confirm and basically
you're going to end up with this so the
inventory
lets you see all the the resources that
are not all of them but most resources
that are in your aws account in this
particular region it this will not
populate right away so you will have to
wait a little bit of time for that to
appear one really nice thing are
conformance packs i really love these
things
when nativists first brought these out
there was only like a couple but now
they have
tons and tons and tons of performance
packs so you can go deploy a conformance
pack and you can open up the templates
i just want to show you look at how many
they have
so there's some you might recognize like
nist
cis things like that well architected uh
stuff and all these are
um and i'm not sure if it's easy to open
these up but all these are if we open
them up they're on github is these are
just cloud formation templates to set up
configuration rules so there's a variety
of suggested rules uh like around i am
best practices and things like that that
we can load in um but the idea is that
you're just going to create rules so you
go here and you add a rule and they have
a bunch of managed rules here
that we can look at but i think it might
be fun to actually run a
conformance pack i'll just show you what
it looks like to add a rule first so
let's say we wanted to do something for
s3
and it was making sure that we are
blocking public access so we go next
here generally you'll have a trigger
type you can choose whether it's
configured when it happens or it's
periodic this is disabled in this case
here and you just scroll on down
and then once you've added the
rule
what you can do
is
also manage remediation so if this
rule said hey this thing is
non-compliant we want you to take a
particular action you have all these aws
actions that you can perform and you can
notify the right people to correct it or
have it auto correct if you choose to do
so
for rules you can also make your own
custom ones so that's just you providing
your own lambda functions you're
providing that lambda iron and so
basically you can have it do anything
that you want whatever you want to put
in a lambda you can make aws config
check for
okay so it's not super complicated here
but
this one here is just going to go ahead
and check and so if we go and reevaluate
we might just take some time to show up
so they're gonna say that it's compliant
or non-compliant okay and i it should be
compliant but while we're waiting for
that to happen let's just see how hard
it is to deploy a conformance pack
because i feel like that's something
that's really important oh you just drop
them down and choose them that's great
so we might want to go to iam here
oops identity and access management
and hit next
and say
my
[Music]
im best practices
and you might not want to do this
because it does have spend and i want to
say spend it's not going to happen
instantly but the idea is that if you
turn this on and forget to remove it
you will see some kind of charges over
time because it does check based on the
rules it's not super expensive but it is
something to consider about
but anyway so it looks like we created
that conformance pack so if i refresh
it looks like it's in progress i wonder
if that's going to set up a cloud
formation template i'm kind of curious
about that
so make our way over to cloudformation
and it is so that's really nice because
once that is done what we can do is just
tear it down by deleting the stack so
i'm going to go back over to our
conformance pack here
let's take a look here
and so it still says it's in progress
but it is completed and we can click
into it
and we can see all the things that it's
doing so it says item groups have user
check performance pack
and so it looks like there's a bunch of
cool rules uh here so
what we'll do
is we'll just wait a little while and
we'll come back here and then just see
if um this updates and see how compliant
we are from a uh
a basic account okay
all right so after waiting a little
while there it looks like some of them
are being set so i just gave it a hard
refresh here uh and here you can see
that it's saying is root account um oops
we'll give it a moment here to refresh
but uh is the root account mfa applied
yes have we done a password policy no
and actually i never did a password
policy which is something i forgot to do
but here they're just talking about the
minimums and maximums of things that you
can do
okay so that's a conformance pack
but if we go to rules actually i guess
it's all the rules here
i can't really tell the difference
between the conformance pack rules and
our plane rules it's kind of it's kind
of all mixed
together here i think
yeah so it's a bit hard to see what's
going on there
if we go to the performance pack and
clicking again it might show the rules
yeah there we go so here's the rules
there we're seeing a little bit more
information so use a hardware mfa so you
know how they're talking about using a
security key like what i showed you that
i had earlier in the course things like
that
um i am password policy things like that
so you know
not too complicated but um i think i'm
all done here so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go over to
cloudformation and tear that on down but
you get the idea
well i might want to show you uh drift
so
there used to be a way
it's cause i keep changing things on me
here but there's a way to see
uh history over time
and so that was something
that they used to show
and i'm just trying to like find where
they put it because it is like somewhere
else
resources maybe
ah resource timeline okay so they moved
it over into the resource inventory
and so if we were to take a look at
something anything maybe this here
resource timeline
and there might not be much here but the
idea is it will show you over time how
things have changed so the idea is that
not only can you say what about config
is something compliant but when was it
complying and that is something that is
really important to know okay so very
simple example maybe not the best but
the idea is that we can see when it was
and was not compliant based on changes
to our stuff but anyway that looks all
good to me here so i'm going to make my
way over to cloudformation actually i
already already have it open over here
we can go ahead and delete that stack
um
termination protection is enabled you
must first disable it so we'll edit it
disable it
whatever
okay we'll hit delete there and as
that's deleting i'm going to go look for
and config my original
rule there
again i'm not really worried about it i
don't think it's going to really cost me
anything but i'm also just kind of clear
the house here just so you're
you're okay as well
and so if we go over to our rules
um the one that i spun up that was
custom
i think was this one here because these
are all grayed out right so i can go
ahead there delete that rule
type in delete
and we are good so there you go
that is
it all right
[Music]
aws quick starts are pre-built templates
by ada best and ebay's partners to help
deploy a wide range of stacks it reduces
hundreds of manual procedures into just
a few steps
the quick start is composed of three
parts it has a reference architecture
for the deployment a database cloud
formation templates that automate and
configure the deployment a deployment
guide explain the architecture
implementation and detail so here's an
example of one that you might want to
launch like the adabus q a bot and then
you will get an architectural diagram a
lot of information about it and from
there you can just go press the button
and launch this infrastructure most
quick start reference deployments enable
you to spend up a fully functional
architecture in less than an hour and
there is a lot as we will see here when
we take a look for ourselves
[Music]
all right so here is uh it was quick
starts where we have a bunch of cloud
formation templates uh built by aws or
amazon or a best partner networks apn
partners
and there's a variety of different
things here so i'm just going to try to
find something like q and a bot
q and a bot just type in bot here
and i don't know why it was here the
other day now it's not showing up which
is
totally fine but um you know i just want
anything to deploy just to kind of show
you what we can do with it
so you scroll on down we have uh this
graphic here that's representing what
will get deployed so we have cloudfront
s3 dynamodb
systems manager lex paulie all these
kind of fun stuff
and there's some information about how
it is architected and the idea is you
can go ahead and launch in the console
or view the implementation guide let's
go take a look here
um and there's a bunch of stuff so we
have solutions and things like that
conversational things like that
but what i'm going to do is go ahead and
see how far i can get to launching with
this it doesn't really matter if we do
launch it but it's just the fact that um
i wanted to show you what you can do
with it so if we go to the designer it's
always fun to look at it in there
because then we can kind of visualize
all the resources that are available
and i thought that that would populate
over there but maybe
we did the wrong things i'm just going
to go back and click
i'm just going to click out of this
oops cancel let's close that
leave yes
and we will launch that again
and so
this oh view in the designer hit the
wrong button okay
so now this should show us the template
it might just be loading
there we go so this is what it's going
to launch and you can see there's a lot
going on here i'm just going to shrink
that there uh and i don't know if you
can make any sense of it but clearly
it's doing a lot
and so if we were happy with this and we
wanted to launch it i know i keep
backing out of this but we're going to
go back into it one more time
we can go here and we go next
and then we would just fill in what we
want so you name it put the language in
and this is stuff that they set up so
maybe you want a mail voice
set the admin and stuff like that and
it's that simple really
um and every stack is going to be
different so they're all going to have
different configuration options but
hopefully that gives you kind of an idea
of what you can do with quick starts
okay
[Music]
let's take a look at the concept of
tagging within aws so a tag is a key and
value pair that you can assign to any of
this resource so as you are creating a
resource is going to prompt you to say
hey what tags do you want to add you're
going to give a key you're going to give
a value and so some examples could be
something like based on department the
status the team the environment uh the
project as we have the example here the
location
and so tags allow you to organize your
resources in the following way for
resource management so specific
workloads so you can say you know
developer environments cost management
and optimization so cost tracking
budgets and alerts operations management
so business commitments sla operations
mission critical services security so
classification of data security impact
governance and regulatory compliance
automation workload automation and so
it's important to understand that
tagging can be used in junction with i
am policy so that you can restrict
access or things like that based on
those tags okay
[Music]
all right i just want to show you one
interesting thing about tags um and it's
just the fact that it's used as the name
for some services so when you go to ec2
and you launch an instance uh the way
you set the name is by giving it a tag
called name and i just want to prove
that to you
just like one of those little exceptions
here so we choose an instance here
we go to configure storage and then what
we do is we add a tag and we say name
and my server name okay and then we go
ahead and review and launch
we're going to launch this i don't need
a key pair so we'll just say proceed
without key pair
i acknowledge
okay
and we will go view the instances and
you'll see that is the name so um that's
just like one of those exceptions or
things that you can do with tags if
there's other things with tags i have no
idea that's just like a a basic one that
everybody should know and that's why i'm
shown to you with the tags but there you
go
[Music]
so we just looked at tags now let's see
what we can do with resource groups
which are a collection of resources that
share one or more tags or another way to
look at it it's a way for you to take
multiple tags and organize them
into resource groups so it helps you
organize and consolidate information
based on your project and the resources
that you use resource groups can display
details about a group of resources based
on metrics alarms configuration settings
and at any time you can modify the
settings of your resource groups to
change what resources appear resource
groups appear in the global console
header
which is over here and under the systems
manager so technically it's part of aws
simple systems manager or systems
manager interface but it's also part of
the global interface so sometimes that's
a bit confusing but that's where you can
find it okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do is
explore resource groups and also
tagging so what i want you to do is type
in resource groups at the top here and
it used to be accessible
not sure where they put it but it used
to be accessible here at the top but
they might have moved it over to systems
manager so i'm going to go to ssm here
not sure why i can't seem to find it
today
and on the left hand side we're going to
look for
resource groups
you
all right so what i want to do is take a
look at resource groups and i'm really
surprised because it used to be
somewhere in the global now but
i think they might have changed it um
and what's also frustrating is if i go
over to systems manager it was over here
as well and so on the left-hand side i'm
looking for resource groups it's not
showing up so
i don't really the best you keep moving
things around on me and i'm i can only
update things so quickly in my courses
but if you type in resource groups and
tag editor it's actually over here
um i guess it's its own standalone
service now why they keep changing
things i don't know
but uh
the idea is we want to create a resource
group so you can create unlimited single
region groups in your abel's account use
the group to view related insights
things like that so i'm going to go
ahead and create a resource group you
can see it can be tag based or cloud
formation based but i don't have any
tags i don't really have anything tags
so what i'm going to do
is make my way over to s3 we're just
going to create some resources or a
couple resources here with some tags so
that we can do some filtration so i can
go ahead and create a bucket i'm going
to say my
bucket uh this like that whoops
and then down below i'm going to go down
to tags and we're going to say project
and we're going to say um
rg for resource group
okay and then i can go back over here
and then i'm going to just say
i can say exactly what type i want i'm
going to support all resource types
and i'm going to say project
rg see how it auto-completes
and we'll go down below
we'll just say
my rg
a test rg
we'll create that
and so now we have a resource group and
we can see them all in one place
resource groups are probably useful for
using in
policy so you can say say like resource
group
i am policies
that's probably what they're used for
okay so before i use i am managed to
actually realize groups you should
understand i am features things like
that
and so administrators can use json
policies to specify who has access to
what
and so a policy action a resource group
is used following the prefix resource
groups
so
my thought process there is that if you
want to say okay you have access to a
resource you can just specify a resource
group and it will include all the
resources within there and so that might
be
a better way to apply permissions at a
per project basis
um and that could save you a lot of time
writing out i am policies so
that's basically all there really is to
it also you kind of get an overview of
of the resources that are there
so that can be kind of useful as well
there's the tag editor here i can't
remember what you use this for you can
set up tag policies
tag policies help you standardize tags
on resource groups and your accounts use
to define tech policies and absorb to
attach them to the entire organization
um we're not in the org account so i'm
not going to show you this and it's not
that important
but just understand that resource groups
can be created and they are used within
i am policies in order to um
grant or deny access to stuff
you go ahead and delete that resource
group and really aws stop moving that on
me if you move one more time i'm just
never going to talk about resource
groups again okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at business
centric services and you might say well
why because an exam guide it explicitly
says that these are not covered but the
thing is is that when you're taking the
exam some of the choices might be some
of these services as distractors and if
you know what they are it's going to
help make sure that you um
guess correctly and the thing is that
some of these services are useful you
should know about them so that's another
reason why i'm talking about them here
so the first one is amazon connect this
is a virtual call center you can create
workflows to write callers you can
record phone calls manage a queue of
callers based on the same proven system
used by amazon customer service teams we
have workspaces this is a virtual remote
desktop service secure managed service
for provisioning either windows or linux
desktops in just a few minutes which
quickly scales up to thousands of
desktops we have workdocs which is a
shared collaboration service a
centralized storage to share content and
files it is similar to microsoft
sharepoint think of it as a shared
folder where the company has ownership
we have chime which is a video
conference service it is similar to zoom
or skype you can screen share have
multiple people on the on the same call
it is secure by default and can show you
a calendar of upcoming calls we have
work mail this is a managed business uh
email contacts calendar service with
support of existing desktop and mobile
email client applications that can
handle things like imap similar to gmail
or exchange we have pinpoint this is a
marketing campaign management service
pinpoint is for sending targeted emails
via sms push notifications voice
messages so you can perform um a to b
testing or create journey so complex
email response workflows we have ses
this is a transactional email service
you can integrate ses into your
application to send emails you can
create common templates track open rates
keep track of your reputation we have
quicksite this is a business
intelligence service connect multiple
data sources and quickly visualize data
in the form of graphs with little to no
knowledge definitely you want to
remember quicksite ses pinpoint
because those definitely will show up in
the exam the rest probably not but they
could show up as distractors okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at provisioning
services so let's first define what is
provisioning so provisioning is the
allocation or creation of resources and
services to a customer and its
provisioning services are responsible
for setting up and managing those awes
services we have a lot of services that
do provisioning most of them are just
using cloud formation underneath which
we'll mention here but let's get to it
the first is elastic bean stock this is
a platform as a service to easily deploy
web apps eb will provision various
adwords services like ec2 s3 sns cloud
watch ec2 auto scaling groups load
balancers
and you can think of it as the heroku
equivalent to aws then you have opsworks
this is a configuration management
service that also provides managed
instances of open source configuration
managed software such as chef and public
puppet so you'll say i want to have a
load balancer or i want to have servers
and it will provision those for you
indirectly then you have cloudformation
itself this is an infrastructure
modeling and provisioning service it
automates the provisioning of aws
services by writing cloud formation
templates in either json or yaml and
this is known as iac or infrastructures
of code you have quick starts these are
pre-made packages that can be launched
and configure your abus compute network
storage and other services required to
deploy a workload on the bus we do cover
this in this course but quick starts is
basically just confirmation templates
that are authored by the community or
by um
amazon partner network okay
then we have abs marketplace this is a
digital catalog for thousands of
software listings of independent
software vendors that you can use to
find buy and test and deploy software so
the idea is that you know you can go
there and provision whatever kind of
resource you want we have abs amplify
this is a mobile web app framework that
will provision multiple able services as
your backend it's specifically for
serverless services i don't know i
didn't write that in there
but you know like dynamodb um
things like uh whatever the graphql
service is called api gateway things
like that
then we have aws app runner this is a
fully managed service that makes it easy
for developers to quickly deploy
containerized web apps and apis at scale
with no prior information experience
required it's basically a platform as a
service but for containers
we have abas copilot this is a command
line interface that enables customers to
quickly launch and manage containerized
applications any bus it basically is a a
cli tool that sets up a bunch of scripts
to set up pipelines for you makes things
super easy we have aws codestart this
provides a unified user interface
enabling you to manage your software
development activities in one place
usually launch common types of stacks
like lamp then we have cdk and so this
is infrastructure as a code tool allows
you to use your favorite programming
language generates that confirmation
templates as a means of ic so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at aws elastic
beanstalk before we do let's just define
what passes so platform as a service
allows customers to develop run and
manage applications without the
complexity of building and maintaining
the infrastructure typically associated
with developing and launching an app and
so elastic bean stock is a pass for
deploying web apps with little to no
knowledge of the underlying
infrastructure so you can focus on
writing application code instead of
setting up an automated deployment
pipeline or devops tasks the idea here
is you choose a platform upload your
code and it runs with little knowledge
of the infrastructure and aws will say
that it's generally not recommended for
production apps but just understand that
they are saying this for enterprises and
large companies
if you're a small to medium company you
can run elastic beanstalk for quite a
long time it'll work out great elastic
being stock is powered by cloudformation
templates and it sets up for you elastic
load balancer asgs
rds ec2 instances pre-configured for
particular platforms uh monitoring
integration with cloudwatch sns
deployment strategies like in-place
blue-green deployment has security built
in so it could rotate out your passwords
for your databases and it can run
dockerized environments and so when we
talk about platforms you can see we have
docker multi-container docker
go.net java node.js ruby php python
tomcat go a bunch of stuff and just to
kind of give you that architectural
diagram to show you that it can launch
of multiple things okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
in this follow along we're going to
learn all about elastic bean stock maybe
not everything but we're going to
definitely know how to at least
use the service so elastic beanstalk is
a platform as a service and what it does
is it allows you to uh deploy web
applications very easily so here i've
made my way over to elastic beanstalk
open environment and app and then we set
up our application
we have two tiers a web server
environment a worker environment worker
environment's great for long running
workloads
performing background jobs and things
like that and then you have your web
server which is your web server and you
can have both and it's generally
recommended to do so um but anyway what
we'll do is create a new application so
let's say my app here and there's some
tags we can do and then it will name
based on the environment then we need to
choose an environment name so let's say
my environment and just put a bunch of
numbers in there hit the check
availability scroll on down and we have
two options manage platform custom
platform and i'm not sure why custom is
blanked out but it would allow you to
um it would allow you to i think use
your own containers so i'm a big fan of
ruby so i'm gonna drop down to ruby
and here we have a bunch of different
versions and so 2.7 is pretty pretty new
which is pretty good
and then there's the platform version
which is fine and the great thing is it
comes with a sample application now you
could hit create environment but you'd
be missing out on a lot if you don't hit
this configure more options i don't know
why they put it there it's a not very
good ui but
if you click here you actually get to
see everything possible and so up here
we have some presets where we can have a
single instance so
this is where it's literally running a
single ec2 instance so it's very cost
effective you can have it with spot spot
pricing so you save money
there's high availability so you know if
you want it set up with a load balancer
an auto scaling group it will scale very
well or you can do custom configuration
we scroll on down here
you can enable amazon x-ray you can
rotate out logs you can do log streaming
um there's a lot of stuff here
and basically it's just like it sets up
most for you but you can pretty much
configure what you want as well if we
have the load bouncer set if i go here
go to high availability now we'll be
able to change our load balancer options
you have different ways of deploying so
you can go here and then change it from
all at once rolling immutable traffic
splitting depends on what your use case
is
we can set up a key pair to be able to
log into the machine
there's a whole variety of things you
can connect your database as well so it
can create the database alongside with
it and then it can actually rotate out
the key so you don't have to worry about
it which is really nice what i'm going
to do is go to the top here and just
choose a single instance because i want
this to be very cost effective we're
going to go ahead and hit create
environment
and so we're just going to wait for that
to start up and i'll see you back when
it's done okay
okay so it's been uh quite a while here
and it says a few minutes so if it does
do this what you can do is just give it
a hard refresh i have a feeling that
it's already done is it done
yeah it's already done so and here it
says on september 2020 elasticity so i
can use etc default default i don't care
but anyway so this application i guess
it's an appending state
i'm not sure why let's go take a look
here causes instance has not sent any
data since launch
none of the instances are sending data
so that's kind of interesting because
um
i shouldn't have any problems you know
what i mean
so what i'm going to do is just reboot
this machine and see if that fixes the
issue there but usually it's not that
difficult because it's the sample
application it's not up to me
um as to how to fix this
you know what i mean so
i'm not sure but um what we'll do is
we will let the machine reboot and see
if that makes any difference okay
all right so after rebooting that
machine now it looks like the server is
healthy so it's not all that bad right
if you do run in issues that is
something that you can do
and so
uh let's go see if this is actually
working so the top here we have a link
and so i can just right click here it
says congratulations your first aws
elastic beanstalk ruby application is
now running so it's all in good shape
there's a lot of stuff that's going on
here in elastic beanstalk that we can do
we can go back to our configuration and
change any of our options here so
there's a lot of stuff as you can see
we get logging so click the request log
so if we click on this and say last 100
lines
we should be able to get logging data we
have to actually download it i wish it
was kind of in line but here you can
kind of see what's going on so we have
sdo access logs error logs puma logs
elastic bean stock engine so you could
use that to debug very common to take
that over to
support if you do have issues
for health it monitors the health of the
instances which is great then we have
some
monitoring data here so it gives you
like a built dashboard so that's kind of
nice you can set up alarms um you have
not defined any alarms you can add them
via the monitoring dashboard so i guess
you'd have to
you'd have to somehow add them i don't
think i've ever added alarms for um
elastic beanstalk but it's nice to know
that they have them
you can set up schedules for managed
events then this is event data so it's
just kind of telling you it's kind of
like logs it just tells you of things
that have changed
so there's stuff like that what i'm
looking for is to see how i can download
the existing application
because there's a version uploaded here
oh the source is over here okay
so
i think it's probably over here the one
that's running
so that's it
if it was easy to find what i probably
would do is just modify it and oh yeah
it's over here so if we go here and
download the zip
i wonder if it'd be even worth um
playing with us so let's i'm just going
to see if we can go over to cloud9
and give this a go quickly
so if we go over and launch a cloud9
environment maybe we can tweak it and
upload a revised version so we'll say
create new we'll say eb
um
environment for elastic beanstalk
we'll set it all the defaults that's all
fine it's all within the free tier we'll
create that environment
what i'm going to do is just take this
ruby zip file and move it to my desktop
and as that is loading we'll give it a
moment here i'm just going to go back
and i was just curious does it let you
download it directly from here no
the only thing is that you know if you
download that application
elastic beanstalk usually has a
configuration file with it and so i
don't know if they would have given that
to us
but if it did that would be really great
but we just have to wait for that to
launch there as well
i guess you can save configurations and
roll back on those as well
um but we will just wait a moment here
while it's going i might just peek
inside of this file to see what it is
this zip contains
just going to go my desktop here open up
that zip
so it looks pretty simple it doesn't
even look like a rails app it looks like
maybe it's a sinatra app i thought
before that they would it would have
deployed a ruby on rails application but
maybe they keep it really simple
um
i don't see
usually it's like yaml files they use
for configuration i don't see that there
so
it might be that the default settings
will work fine there's a config.ru and
stuff like that but once cloud9 is up
here we will upload this and see what we
can do with it okay so there we go
cloud9 is ready to go and so if we right
click here whoops right click here we
should be up be able to upload a file if
not we can go up here to the top
or it's here or there
where is the upload i've i've uploaded
things in here so i absolutely know we
can i just gotta find it
is that the upload
upload files cloud9
oh boy that's not helpful
that's not helpful at all
so let me just click around a little bit
here i mean worst case i can always just
bring it in via a curl oh upload local
files there it is
i was just not um being patient okay so
we'll drag that on in there
and we will
did it upload yep it's right there okay
great and so we need to unzip it so what
i'll do is just drag this on up here
i'll do an ls and we'll say unzip
ruby.zip
and so that unzipped the contents there
i think the readme was part of cloud9 so
i'm going to go ahead and delete that
out
not that it's going to hurt anything
and so now what we can do we'll delete
the original
original zip there
um and let's see if we can make a change
here so i'm just going to open up see
what it is so it's yeah it's running
sinatra so that's pretty clear there
we have a profile to see how it runs we
have a worker sample so that just tells
how the requests go
you don't need to know any of this i'm
just kind of clicking through it because
i know ruby very well we have a cron
yaml file so that could be something
that gets loaded in here so i think
basically a sinatra app probably just
works
off the bat here but if we want to make
a change we probably just mix up a
change over to here
so i'll go down here and this is your
second
aws elastic bean stock application so
the next thing we need to do is actually
zip the contents here
i don't know if it would let us zip it
within here but also look like zip the
contents of a directory
linux
just goes to show
google is everything
so the easiest way to zip a folder
um
zip
everything in the current directory
linux
okay that's easy so
we'll go back over here
and we will type in zip
and it wants hyphen r for recursive
which makes sense
and then the name of the zip so
ruby2.zip
and we'll do period
zip warning found is
who is
zip
oh
uh
yum install zip
maybe we have to install uh zip but
maybe it's not installed
pseudo yum install zip
since amazon likes to uses yum
and so package already installed so i'm
gonna type zip again so zip is there now
great oops don't need install twice
zip warning ruby two zip not found or
empty
okay so install zip and use zip hyphen r
you can use the flag to best
compensate
so if that's not working what i'm going
to do is just go up a directory
why is it saying not found or empty
hmm
maybe i need to use
okay so i think the problem was i was
using the wrong flag so i put f instead
of r i don't know why i did that so i
probably should have done this
okay and so that should have copied all
the contents of that file so what i'm
going to do is go ahead whoops make sure
i have that selected and download that
file
and once i have downloaded that file i'm
going to just open the contents to make
sure it is what i expect it to be
so we're going to open that up and oops
get out of here winrar and it looks like
everything i want so
what i'm going to do is go back over to
here i'm going to make sure i have my
ruby 2 on my desktop
and we're going to see if we can upload
another version here so upload deploy
choose the file we're gonna go all the
way to my desktop here and we're gonna
choose ruby two
and
um like ruby two will be the version
name or we'll just say two
and we'll deploy and we'll see if that
works
okay but there are like uh elastic being
stock configuration files like gamble
files that can sit in the root directory
and so generally you're used to seeing
them there but you know i imagine that
databus probably engineered these
examples so that it uses all the default
settings but once this is deployed i'll
see you back here in a moment okay
after a short little wait it looks like
it has deployed so what i'm going to do
is just close my other tabs here and
open this up and see if it's worked it
says your second awesome beanstalk ruby
application so
we were successful uh deploying that out
which is really great so what we can do
now is just close that tab there
and since we have that cloud no
environment it will shut down on its own
but you know just for your benefit i
think that we should shut it off for
right now so go ahead and delete that
i'm going to go back over to elastic
bean stock here and i just want to
destroy all of it so we'll see if we can
just do that from here terminate the
application
enter the name
so i think we probably have to enter
that in there
and so i think that
oh a problem occurred right
exceeded
what
let's say aws for you so it's not a big
deal i would just go and check it again
and maybe what we'll do is just delete
the application first
okay so that one is possibly deleting
let's go in here is anything changing
can't even tell
we'll go ahead oh can't take that one
out
delete application again
if it takes a couple times it's not a
big deal
it's aws for yes so
there's a lot of moving parts so it
looks like it is terminating the
instance and so we just have to wait for
that to complete
uh once that is done we might have to
just tear down the environment so i'll
see you back here when it has finished
tearing this down okay all right so
after a short little wait here i think
it's been destroyed we'll just double
check by going to the applications going
to the environments yeah and it's all
gone probably because i initially
deleted that environment and then took
the application with it so i probably
didn't have to delete the app separately
um but uh yeah so there you go just make
sure your cloud9 environment's gone and
you are a-okay there'll probably be some
like lingering s3 buckets so if you do
want to get rid of those you can it's
not going to hurt anything having those
around
but they do tend to stack up after a
while which is kind of annoying so if
you don't like them you can just empty
them out
as i am doing here whoops
i'll just permanently delete
copy that text there
then go back
to here and then just go
take out that bucket
let's delete that there
oh if you get this this is kind of
annoying but uh elastic beanstalk likes
to put in an imp permission or policy in
here so if you go down here there's a
bucket policy you just have to delete it
out it prevents it from being deleted
and we'll go back over here
and then we will delete it
okay
and yeah there we go that's it
[Music]
so let's take a look at several services
on aws and this is not including all of
them because we're looking at the most
purely serverless services uh if we try
to include all the server services it
would just be too long of a list
but let's take a look here so
before we do let's just redefine what is
serverless so when the underlying
servers infrastructure operating system
is taken care by the csp serverless is
generally by default highly available
scalable cost effective you pay for what
you use the first one is dynamodb which
is a serverless nosql key value and
document database it's designed to scale
to billions of records with guaranteed
consistent data returned in at least a
second you do not have to worry about
managing charge you have simple storage
service s3 which is a serverless object
storage service you can upload very
large and unlimited amounts of files you
can pay for what you store you don't
worry about the underlying file system
we're upgrading the disk size we have
ecs fargate which is a servless
orchestration container service is the
same as ecs except you pay on demand per
running container with ecs you have to
keep a ec2 server running even if you
have no containers running where aws
manages the underlying server so you
don't have to scale or upgrade the ec2
server
we have aws lambda which is a serverless
function service you can run code
without provisioning or managing servers
you upload a small piece of code choose
how much memory you want how long you
want the function is allowed to run
before timing out your charge based on
the runtime of the service function
rounded to the nearest 100 milliseconds
we have step functions this is the state
machine service
it coordinates multiple services into
serverless workflows easily share data
among lambdas
have a group of lambdas wait for each
other create logical steps also work
with fargate tasks we have aurora
serverless this is a serverless
on-demand version of aurora so when you
want most of the benefits of aurora but
trade you have to trade off those cold
starts or you don't have lots of traffic
or demand so things several services
that we could have put in here as well
is like api gateway appsync it was
amplify um and those are like the the
first two were application integrations
you could say sqs sns those are all
serverless services but you know again
we'd be here all day if i i listed them
all right
[Music]
all right let's take a look at what is
serverless and we did look at it from a
server perspective earlier in the course
but let's just try to abstractly define
it and talk about the architecture so
serverless architecture generally
describes fully managed cloud services
and the classification of a cloud
service being serverless is not a
boolean answer it's it's not a yes or no
but an answer on a scale where a cloud
service has a degree of serverless and i
do have to point out that this
definition might not be accepted by um
everybody because serverless is one of
those uh terms
where
we've had a bunch of different cloud
service providers define it differently
and then we have thought leaders that
have
a particular concept of what it is so
you know i just do my best to try to
make this practical here for you but a
servless service could have all or most
of the following characteristics and so
it could be highly elastic and scalable
highly available highly durable secure
by default it abstracts away the
underlying infrastructure and are built
based on the execution of your business
tasks a lot of times that that cost is
not
uh it's not always represented as
something that is like i'm paying x for
compute it could be abstracted out into
some kind of um credit that doesn't
necessarily map to something physical
then we have serverless can scale to
zero meaning when it's not in use the
serverless resources cost nothing uh and
these two last topics basically pull
into pay for value so you don't pay for
idle servers you're paying for the value
that your service provides
and my friend daniel who runs the
serverless toronto group he likes to
describe serverless as being similar to
like energy efficient rating so an
analogy of service could be similar to
energy rating labels which allows
consumers to compare the energy
efficiency of a product so some services
are more serverless than others and
again you know some people might not
agree with that where there's a
definitive yes or no answer but i think
that's the best way to look at it okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're taking a look at windows on
database so abs has multiple cloud
services and tools to make it easy for
you to run window workloads on aws so
let's get to it so the first is windows
servers on dc2 so you can select from a
number of windows server versions
including the latest version
like windows server 2019
for
databases we have sql server on rds you
can select from a number of sql server
database versions then we have aws
directory service which lets you run
microsoft active directory ad as a
managed service we have aws license
manager which makes it easier to manage
your software licenses from software
vendors such as microsoft we have amazon
fsx for windows file server which is a
fully managed scalable storage built for
windows we have the aws sdk which allows
you to write code in your favorite
language to interact with a database api
but it specifically has support for net
a language favorite for windows
developers we have amazon workspaces so
this allows you to run a virtual desktop
you can launch a windows 10 desktop to
provide secure and durable workstations
that is accessible from wherever you
have an internet connection about lambda
supports powershell as a programming
language to write your serverless
functions and we have abs migration
acceleration program map for
windows is a migration methodology for
moving large enterprises items has
amazon partners that specialize in
providing professional services for map
this is not just
everything for windows on aws like if
you want to move your sql server over to
rds postgres i believe they've like
created an adapter to do that
but yeah hopefully that gives you an
idea what you can do with windows on aws
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and i want to show you how you can
launch a windows server on aws so what
you're going to do is go to the top here
and we are going to type in ec2 and from
here uh what we'll do is we'll go ahead
and launch ourselves a new ec2 instance
and we are going to have
a selection of instances that we can
launch and so we're looking for the
microsoft
windows
server and this is interesting there's
actually a free tier
eligible that is crazy because if you go
over to azure they don't have a free
tier windows server like any bus does
so that's pretty crazy um and it runs on
a t2 micro no that can't be right
there's no way
it can run a tt micro that seems like
that's too small
let's try it okay i just don't believe
it because when you use azure you have
to choose a particular size of instance
by default
and it's a lot more expensive and there
is no free tier
so we'll go here
there are free tiers just not really for
windows in particular so we'll go here
this looks good security groups this
opens up rdp so we can get into that
machine we're gonna go next here
and launch this machine
says if you plan to use ami the benefits
the microsoft license mobility check out
this form
that's not something we're worried about
today
and
i mean i guess we can create a key pair
i'm not sure what it we would use a key
pair for here
um for windows amis the private key file
is required to obtain the password used
to log into the instance okay so i guess
we're going to need it so
windows key
great we'll launch that instance
and uh i'll see you back here when it
launches but i just don't believe that
it would launch that fast you know
all right so after a short little wait
here the server is ready and so let's
see if we can actually go ahead and
connect to this so i'm going to hit
connect here
and we'll go over to rdb client so you
connect to your windows instance using
your remote desktop client of your
choice and downloading and running the
rdb shortcut below so i'm going to go
ahead and download this and you're going
to have to be
on a
windows machine to be able to do this or
have an rdb client installed i think
there's one for mac that you can get
from the apple store
but all i'm going to do is just double
click the file so you probably can't see
it here i'm just going to expand this
trying to
oh my computer is being silly but anyway
there we go we moved it over there i'm
just going to drag over here and just
double click this image so you can see
that i'm doing it i'm saying connect
okay
and that's going to ask for a password
so i'm going to hope that i can just
click that and get the password so to
decrypt the password you will need your
key pair instance you'll have to upload
that
and i don't know if i remember having to
do that before but it's a great security
measure so i'm fine with it i'm going to
drag my key to my desktop so i can see
what's going on there as well
and we're going to go grab that and
decrypt the password
and so now
um
where's our password oh it's right here
okay so we're going to grab that
password there
we will paste that in
said okay
say yes
and see if we can connect to this
instance if this is running on a t2
micro i'm going to lose it because that
is just cheap
it just just doesn't seem possible to me
because again on azure you have to
launch an instance with a lot of stuff
and
it just uh seems uh crazy what's also
interesting is that itabus uh on windows
like launches so fast it's unbelievable
how fast these servers
spin up and it's just very unusual but
yeah so we are in here
um
it's not asking me to activate or
anything so i guess there's already a
windows license here
and
i'm not sure if there's any kind of like
games installed like do we have
minesweeper can i play minesweeper on
here
it's a data center server so i'm
assuming not
but yeah so this is a windows server and
it's pretty impressive that this works
i'm not sure if this is going to have an
outbound connection here um just because
we probably would have to configure it
let's just say okay i just i really
don't think it's going to go out to the
internet by default
yeah so you'd probably have to
do some stuff you know
oh no there we go so yeah we got to the
internet so it's totally possible but uh
yeah that's about it that's all i really
wanted to show you so what i'm going to
do is just go back to ec2 and we're
going to shut down the server here just
expand that there
and we will go here and we will
terminate that instance
good we'll give that a refresh that's
shutting down and we are done
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abyss
license manager and before we do let's
talk about what byol
or bring your own license means so this
is the process of reusing an existing
software license to run vendor software
on a cloud vendor's computing service
byol allows companies to save money
since they may have purchased the
license in bulk or a time that provided
a greater discount than if purchased
again and so an example of this could be
the license mobility provided by
microsoft's volume licensing to
customers with eligible server
applications covered by the microsoft
software assurance program uh and i
don't know what i was trying to do there
i guess maybe it was just sa and i
missed the parentheses there on the end
no big big deal
but aws license manager is a service
that makes it easier for you to manage
your software licenses from software
vendors centrally across aws in your
on-premise environments able's license
manager software that is licensed based
on virtual cores
physical cores sockets or a number of
machines this includes a variety of
software products for microsoft ibm sap
oracle and other vendors so that's the
idea you say what is my license type
it's it's bound to this amount of cpus
items license manager works with ec2
with dedicated instances dedicated hosts
and even spot instances and for rds
there's only for oracle databases so you
can import that license for your oracle
server
just understand that
if you're doing microsoft windows
servers or microsoft sql server license
you're generally going to need a
dedicated host because of the assurance
program
and this can really show up on your exam
so even though ava's license manager
works on dedicated instances and spot
instances
just trying to gravitate towards
dedicated hosts on the server or on the
exam okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
logging services that we have available
in aws so the first one here is
cloudtrail and this logs all api calls
whether it's sdk or the cli so if it's
making a call to the api it's going to
get tracked between aws services and
this is really useful to say who can we
blame who was the person that did this
so who created this bucket who spent up
that expensive ec2 instance who launched
the sagemaker notebook
and the idea here is you can detect
developer misconfigurations detect
malicious actors or automate responses
through the system then you have
cloudwatch which is a collection of
multiple services i commonly say this is
like an umbrella service because it has
so many things underneath it so we have
cloudwatch logs which is a centralized
place to store your cloud services log
data and application logs metrics which
represents a time ordered set of data
points a variable to monitor
event bridge or previously known as
cloudwatch events triggers an event
based on a condition so every hour take
a snapshot of the server alarms triggers
notifications based on metrics
dashboards creates visualizations based
on metrics and that's not all of the
things that are under cloud watch but
those are the core five ones you should
always know um absolutely there then we
have aws x-ray this is for distributed
tracing systems so you can use it to
pinpoint issues within your services so
you see how data moves from one app to
another how long it took to move and if
it failed uh to move forward okay
[Music]
let's take a closer look here at ibis
cloud trail because it's a very
important service so it's a service that
enables governance compliance
operational auditing and risk auditing
of your adwords account and the idea is
that every time you make an api call
it's going to show up as some kind of
structured data that you can interact
with or read through so this cloud trail
is used to monitor api calls and actions
made on the database account easily
identify which users and accounts made
the call to aws so you might have the
where so the source ip address the when
the event time the who the user agent
and the what the region resource in
action so i'm just gonna get my pen tool
out here for a moment and just notice
you have the event time so when it
happened the source the name the region
the source ip address the user agent uh
who was doing it so here was laforge of
the response element so you know it's
very clear what is going on here
um and then you know cloudtrail is
already logging by default and we'll
collect logs for the for the last 90
days via event history if you need more
than 90 days you need to create a trail
which is very common you'll go into aws
and make one right away trails are
outputted to s3 and do not have gui like
event history to analyze the trail you
have to use amazon athena and i'm sure
there are other ways to analyze it
within aws but here's just what the
event history looks like so right off
the bat you can already see that there
are information there i'm not sure if
they've updated the ui there they might
have uh
as even when i'm recording this i kind
of feel like if we go into the follow
along which we will um i bet they might
have updated that the idea here is that
you know you can browse the last 90 days
but anything outside of that you're
gonna have to do a little bit of work
yourself okay
[Music]
so we're not going to cover all the
cloudwatch services there's just too
many but let's look at the most
important ones and one of the those
important ones is cloudwatch alarms so
cloudwatch alarms monitors a cloudwatch
metric based on a defined threshold uh
so here you can see there's kind of a
condition being set there so if the
networking is greater than 300 for one
data point within five minutes it's
going to breach an alarm so
that's when it goes outside it's defined
threshold and so the state's going to
either be something like okay so the
metric or expression is within the
defined threshold so do nothing alarm
the metric or expression is outside of
the defined threshold so do something or
insufficient data the alarm has just
started the metric is not available not
enough data is available and so when the
state has changed you can define actions
that it should take and so that could be
doing a notification auto scaling group
or an ec2 action um so cloudwatch alarms
are really useful for a variety of
reasons the one that we will come across
right away will be setting up a billing
alarm
[Music]
so let's take a look here at the
autonomy of an alarm and so i have this
nice graphic here to kind of explain
that there and so the first thing is we
have our threshold condition
and so here you can just set a value and
say okay the value is a thousand or a
hundred whatever you want it to be and
this is going to be
for a particular metric the actual data
we are measuring so maybe in this case
we're measuring network in so the volume
of incoming network traffic measured in
bytes so when using five-minute
monitoring divide by 300 we get bytes
per second if you're trying to figure
out that calculation there you have data
points so these represent the metrics
measurement at a given point then you
have the period how often it checks to
evaluate the alarm so we could say every
five minutes
uh you have the evaluation period so the
number of previous periods and the data
points to alarm so you can say one data
point is breached in evaluation period
going back four periods so this is what
triggers the alarm
uh the thing i just want you to know is
that you can set a value right and that
it's based on a particular metric and
there is a bit of logic here in terms of
the alarm so it's not as simple as just
it's breached but there's this period
thing happening okay
[Music]
well let's take a look at cloudwatch
logs so to understand that we have logs
streams and log groups so a log stream
is a stream that represents a sequence
of events from an application or
instance being monitored so imagine you
have an ec2 instance running a web
application and you want those logs to
be streamed to cloudwatch logs that's
we're talking about here so you can
create log streams manually but
generally this is automatically done by
the service you are using
unless you were collecting application
logs on an ec2 instance as i just
described here is a log group of a
lambda function you can see the log
streams are named after the running
instance lambda's free frequency run on
new instances so the stream contains
timestamps so what i'm trying to say
here is that there's a variety of
different services lambda rds what have
you and they already send their logs to
cloudwatch logs and and they're going to
vary okay so here's a log group of an
application log running on ec2 you can
see here the log streams are named after
the running instance id here is the log
group for aws glue you can see the log
streams are named after the glue jobs
and so you know we have the streams but
let's talk about the actual data that's
made up of it the log events so this
represents a single event in a log file
log events can be seen within the log
stream and so here's an example of you
would open this up in cloudwatch logs
and you can actually see what what was
being reported back by your server you
can filter these events to filter out
logs based on simple or pattern matching
syntax so here i'm just typing in saying
give me all those debug stuff and you
know this is a very robust but awes does
have a better way of analyzing your logs
which is log insights which we'll look
at here in a moment
[Music]
so we're just looking at cloudwatch log
events and how those are collected but
there's an easier way to analyze them
and that's with login sites so you can
interactively search and analyze your
cloudwatch log data and it has the
following advantages more robust
filtering than using the simple filter
in the in a log stream less burdensome
than having to export logs to s3 and
analyze them via athena cloudwatch login
site supports all types of logs so
cloudwatch log insights is commonly used
via the console to do ad-hoc queries
against log groups
so that's just kind of an example of
someone writing a query
and cloudwatch log insights uses a query
syntax so a single request can query up
to 20 logs create timeout after 50
minutes if not completed
and queries results are available for
seven days so abras provides sample
queries that you can get started for
common tasks and and ease the learning
into the query syntax a good example is
filtering vpc flow logs so you go there
you click it and you start getting some
data you can create and save your own
queries
to make future repetitive tasks easier
on the certified cloud partitioner
they're not going to ask you all these
details about this stuff but i just
conceptually want you to understand that
in log insights you can use it to
robustly filter your logs based on this
query syntax language you get this kind
of visual and it's really really useful
let's take a look here at cloudwatch
matrix which represents a time ordered
set of data points it's a variable that
is monitored over time so cloudwatch
comes with many predefined metrics that
are generally namespaced by aw services
uh so the idea is that like if we were
to look at the ec2 it has these
particular matrixes so that we have cpu
utilization discrete ops disk write ops
disk read bytes disk write bytes network
in network out network packet in network
packets out and the idea is that you can
just like click there into ec2 and then
kind of get that data there and so cloud
metrics are leveraged by other things
like cloudwatch events cloudwatch alarms
cloudwatch dashboards so just understand
that okay
[Music]
all right so what i want to do in this
follow along is show you a bit about
cloudtrail so we're going to go to the
top here and type in cloudtrail the
great thing about cloudtrail is it's
already turned on by default so it's
already kind of collecting some
information and so it's here it says now
use i am access analyzer on cloud trail
trails that sounds pretty cool to me
but we shouldn't have to create a trail
right off the bat because we'll have
some event history and the event history
allows us to see
things that are happening within our
account in the last 90 days
but the thing is if you want something
beyond 90 days you're going to have to
create a trail
but if we just take a look here we can
kind of see
as we've been doing a lot of things all
the kind of actions that's been
happening so here we have an instance
that i terminated so if i go in here and
and look at it i can kind of see
more information about it so we can see
when it terminated who had done that
what access key they had used the event
source the request id
the source ip what whether it was read
only what was the event type that was
called the resource there and this is
the actual raw record so this is
generally how i would look at it or this
is how you had to look at it back in the
day but the idea is that you would have
that
user identity described the event time
the source the event name the region the
source ip the the agent
all the information there okay
and so this is a great way to kind of
find stuff so you can go through here
and try to debug things this way so you
can go to the event name
and so if you if you go here you can
kind of get
uh see a bit of stuff here so
if i was just trying to say like maybe
create
i'm just trying to find something that i
know that i've been doing like create
access keys i can see the access keys
that have been created within this
sandbox account here for the user and
things like that so it's a great way to
kind of find things but generally you're
going to always want to turn on
uh or create your own trail so if you go
here and hit create trail say my new
trail
and um you're gonna need an s3 bucket
for that you'll probably want encryption
turned on
which sounds good to me you'll
absolutely want log file validation and
generally you don't want to store your
your cloudtrail logs within the existing
account you want to have a isolated
hardened account that's that is
infrequently accessed or only by your
your cloud security engineers
away from here because you don't want
people tampering with it deleting it or
changing stuff
but let's take an existing one here
i don't want a customer manager don't i
have one that is managed by aws here
new custom
um let's choose that one i don't know
which one that is we'll just hit next
usually adamus gives you a managed key
there so i was kind of surprised
you can also include additional data so
if you do data events this would collect
information from s3 but the thing is you
might not want to track everything
because if you track to everything it
can get very expensive very quickly
but if you don't you just leave on
management events it'll save you more
money there's inside events uh this is
new i haven't seen this yet so i didn't
identify unusual activity errors users
of behavior that sounds really good but
these could come also at additional
charges but i'm going to hit next anyway
for fun i'm going to create that trail
okay
and uh the key policy does not grant
sufficient access to etc etc so i'm
gonna go turn that off even though i
should really have it turned on but i
just want to be able to show you this
okay so we have this new trail
and so this trail is being dumped to s3
so we might not be able to see anything
in here as of yet but i'm just going to
pop over here and just see
right
i probably have one in my other account
but it's not
it's not that important we basically saw
what the data would look like so we go
into here
there's a digest i don't remember there
being a digest so that's nice
so there's no data yet but when there is
it will pop into there
um i'm not sure if we're gonna be able
to do anything with insights here at
least not in this account
insights are events that are showing
usual api activity and things like that
so that's kind of cool i don't know what
cloudwatch insights looks like
uh inside events are shown in the table
for 90 days okay so i'm just curious if
we can see kind of a screenshot of what
that looks like
whoops
well at least on the article here
so i guess you could kind of get like
some kind of graphs or something saying
like hey
this looks unusual and they might select
it so
not pretty clear in terms of what that
looks like but i mean sounds like a cool
feature and i'm sure when i i'm working
on my security certification course i
will definitely include them there but
that's pretty much all there is to it
i'm going to go ahead and delete
that trail because i i just don't really
need it in this account
but generally you always want to go in
and create a trail
and what you can do is if you're in your
root account i'm not this is actually a
an account that's part of an
organization but if you're at that
organization level you can create a
trail that ex that spans all the regions
that spans all the interest accounts
with an organization and that's what you
should be doing okay
but that's about it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at ml and ai services on
aws but let's first just define what is
aiml and deep learning so ai also known
as artificial intelligence is when
machines that perform jobs that mimic
human behavior
ml or machine learning are machines that
get better at a task without explicit
programming
and deep learning or dl are machines
that are have an artificial neural
network inspired by the human brain to
solve complex problems and a lot of
times you'll see this kind of onion
where they're showing you that
you know ai
can be using ml or deep learning and
then deep learning is definitely using
machine learning but it's using neural
networks and so for aws their flagship
product here is amazon sagemaker it is a
fully managed service to build train
deploy machine learning models at scale
um and there's a bunch of different kind
of open source frameworks you can use
with it like apache mx net audios which
is an open source deep learning
framework that is the one that it has
decided to say hey we are going to back
this one and so you'll see a lot of
example code for that one we have
tensorflow that you can use pie torch
hugging face other things as well okay
and so there's a lot of services
underneath some that might be of
interest to mention right away is like
amazon sagemaker ground truth which is a
data labeling service where you have
humans that label a data set that will
be used to train machine learning models
or maybe something like amazon uh
augmented ai so human intervention
review services when sagemaker uses
machine learning to make a prediction
that is not confident that it has the
right answer queue up to predict for a
human review and these are all about
just labeling data um you know when
you're using supervised um
supervised learning but there are a lot
of services under sagemaker itself and
just ai services in general so we'll
look at that next okay
[Music]
all right let's take a look at all the
ml and ai services and there's a lot on
aws so the first is amazon code guru
this is a machine learning code analysis
service and code guru performs code
reviews and will suggest to improve the
code quality of your code it can show
visual code profiles to show the
internals of your code to pinpoint
performance next we have amazon lux this
is a conversation interface service with
lux you can build voice and text chat
bots
we have amazon personalized this is a
real-time recommendation service it's
the same technology used to make product
recommendations to customers shopping on
the amazon platform
then we have amazon poly this is a
text-to-speech service upload your text
and an audio file spoken by synthetic
synthesize voice
and that will be generated you have
amazon recognition this is an image and
video recognition service
uh analyze image and videos to detect
and label objects peoples and
celebrities
then we have amazon transcribe this is a
speech to text service so you upload
your audio and it'll be converted into
text we have amazon text extract this is
an ocr tool so it extracts text from
scanned documents when you have paper
forms and you want to digitally extract
that data
you have amazon translate this is a
neural machine learning translation
service so use deep learning module
models to deliver more accurate and
natural sounding translations
we have amazon comprehend this is an nlp
so natural language processing service
find relationships between text to
produce insights looks at data such as
customer email support tickets social
media and makes predictions
then we have amazon forecasts this is a
time series forecasting service and it's
you know uh i mean technically i guess
it's a bit of a database but the idea
here is that it can forecast business
outcomes such as product demand resource
needs or financial uh performance and
it's powered by ml or ai if you want to
call it
we have aws deep learning amis so these
are amazon ec2 instances they're
pre-installed with popular deep learning
frameworks and interfaces such as
tensorflow pytorch apache mxnet chainer
gluon uh horovod and kires
we have adabus deep learning containers
so docker images instances pre-installed
with popular deep learning frameworks
interfaces such as tensorflow
pytorch apache mxnet
we have aws deep composer this is
machine learning enabled musical
keyboard i don't know many people using
this but it sounds like fun it was steep
lens is a video camera that uses deep
learning it's more of like a learning
tool so again we don't see many people
using this airbus deep racer is a toy
race car that can be powered with
machine learning to perform autonomous
driving again this is another learning
tool for learning ml they like to do
these at re invent to have like these
racing competitions
amazon elastic interface so this allows
you to attach low-cost gpu perform
powered acceleration to ec2 instances to
reduce the cost of running deep learning
interfaces by 75 percent we have amazon
fraud detector so this is a fully
managed fraud detection as a service uh
it identifies potentially fraudulent
online activities such as online payment
fraud and the creation of fake accounts
amazon kendra so this is an enterprise
machine learning search engine service
it uses natural language to suggest
answers to questions instead of just
simple keyword matching so there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're going to do a quick review here of
the big data and analytic services that
are on aws but before we do let's just
define what big data is so it's a term
used to describe massive volumes of
structured or unstructured data that is
so large it is difficult to move and
process using traditional database and
software techniques so the first tier we
have is amazon athena this is a
serverless interactive
query service it can take a bunch of csv
or json files in an s3 bucket and load
them into a temporary sql table and so
you can run sql queries so it's one you
want to query
csv or json files if you've ever heard
of apache presto it's basically that
okay
then we have amazon cloud search so this
is a fully managed full text search
service so when you want to add search
to your website
we have amazon elastic search service
commonly abbreviated to es
and this is a manage elastic
elasticsearch cluster and elasticsearch
is an open source full-text search
engine it is more robust than cloud
search but requires more server and
operational maintenance
then we have amazon elastic mapreduce
commonly known as emr
and this is for data processing and
analysis it can be used for creating
reports just like redshift but is more
suited when you need to transform
unstructured data into structured data
on the fly and it leverages open source
um technology so like spark
um hive pig things like that
then we have kinesis data stream so this
is a real time streaming data service it
creates producers which sends data to a
stream it has multiple consumers that
can consume data within a stream and use
it for real-time analytics click streams
ingestion data from a fleet of iot
devices
then we have kinesis fire hose this is a
serverless and a simple version of a
data stream
and you pay on demand based on how much
data is consumed through the stream and
you don't worry about the underlying
servers
then you have amazon kinesis data
analytics
this allows you to run queries against
data that is flowing through your
real-time stream so you can create
reports and analysis on emerging data
and last on the kinesis side here we
have amazon kinesis video streams this
allows you to analyze or apply
processing on real-time streaming videos
on the second page here we have managed
kafka service msk
and it might be mks
now that i'm looking at it here so
just be aware that that might be
incorrect but a fully managed apache
kafka service kafka is an open source
platform for building real-time
streaming data pipelines and
applications it is similar to kinesis
but with more robust functionality
then we have redshift which is um
it was this flagship
big data tool it's a petabyte size data
warehouse the data warehouses are for
online
uh online analytical processing olap so
data warehouses can be expensive because
they are keeping data hot meaning that
we can run a very complex query and a
large amount of data and get that data
back very fast but this is great when
you need to quickly generate analytics
or reports from a large amount of data
we have amazon quick site this is a
business intelligence tool or business
intelligence dashboard bi for short you
can use it to create business dashboards
to power business decisions it requires
little to no programming and connect and
adjust to many different types of
databases have you ever heard of tableau
or power bi this is just the aws
equivalent
we have aw data pipelines this automates
the movement of data you can reliably
move data between compute storage and
services
we have abs glue this is an etl service
so it allows you to move data from one
location another where you need to
perform transformations before the final
destination it's similar similar to dms
but it's more robust
we have abus lake formation this is a
centralized curated and secured
repository that stores all your data so
it's a data lake it is a storage
repository that holds a vast amount of
raw data in its native format until it
is needed and then last on here we have
aws data exchange this is a catalog of
third-party data sets you can download
for free
or subscribe or purchase data sets so
they might have like the kovid 19 foot
traffic data the imdb tv movie data
historical weather data and sometimes
this is really great if you're just
trying to learn how to work with these
tools okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at amazon
quick site which is a business
intelligence dashboard or bi dashboard
that allows you to ingest data from
various database storage or database
services to quickly visualize business
data with minimal programming or data
formula knowledge so here's an example
of a quick site dashboard
and so the way quicksite is able to make
these dashboards super fast is via spice
the super fast parallel in memory
calculation engine
and the thing is you don't have to use
spice but generally it is good to use it
and there are some caveats when getting
your data into quicksite sometimes it
can't ingest it directly from a
particular data store so you might have
to dump it to s3 first but it's not too
bad because you can use it with glue to
transform that data over um there are
additional features sometimes marketed
services but we have quick site ml
insights this detects anomalies perform
accurate forecasting it can generate
natural language narratives so basically
like
you know describe it as if you're going
to read it out as a business report you
know then there's amazon quick site
queue this allows you to ask questions
using natural language on all your data
and receive answers in seconds so there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and let's go take a look at amazon quick
sites which is a or quick site which is
a business intelligence tool so when you
go here you have to sign up because it's
kind of part of aws but on its own
separate thing and then you have to
choose what you want so we have
enterprise and standard
um i do not want to pay that much so i'm
going to go to standard over here i'm
not really sure what the difference is
it's not really telling me what
between standard and enterprise
but i'm going to assume standard is more
cost effective but here we it says
user use i am federator identities which
is fine use i am federal identities only
um we can stick with the top one there
that seems fine to me
we need to enter a name so we'll just
say
my quick site
account
and we probably have to fill something
in there so let's say andrew example co
and these are the services that are
going to integrate with athena s3 rds
things like that i guess we could select
some of those buckets i'm not too
worried about doing that right now the
provided account name is not available
that is a terrible ui but that's
aws for you so i'm just going to dump
some numbers there
i'm going to put my email in here again
um we probably want some s3 buckets
i'm going to
make a new bucket
because i think that's how we're going
to do this we're going to have to make a
bucket here and say
quick cite
data
okay
and we're gonna create ourselves a
bucket here
i'm gonna go back and hopefully that
shows up
uh
it does not so what i'll have to do is
just back out
and i'm just gonna give it a hard
refresh here and we'll hit quick sign up
for quick site again
and we'll choose standard
and we'll say my quick site account a
bunch of numbers there
android example.co i don't really care
about ingesting data from everywhere
else i just want it from s3
there's my data
sure we'll give it right permissions
even though i don't plan to do anything
with athena here today
and we'll give it a moment to load
so what i'm thinking is
so what i'm thinking is just making like
an excel spreadsheet here
and just filling in some data so
oh it says our account is set up here so
we'll go to quick site
because i bet i can import like a csv or
something
um i'm more of a tableau or power bi
kind of person um but uh you know for
the purpose of the cloud practitioner i
am going to show you this amazon quick
set lets you easily visualize data and
etc that sounds great next next next i
know what i'm doing
oh do we have some examples great so i
don't even have to make a spreadsheet
okay so what we'll do is just click on
that
and we have stuff it looks like they've
really improved this since the last time
i've seen it which is quite nice
but i could try and make my own
i'm just trying to think how do we do
this again
yeah we have the spice there so it's a
lot easier from starting from scratch
i'm just gonna say close
and
[Music]
these are analysis we want data sets in
here
oh we already have some data sets these
are coming from s3 i think that's the
old s3 logo i'm not sure why they're
using that one
we can go here and create a new data set
oh we can upload directly so i don't
even have to use s3 that's great so what
i'm going to do is just have some values
in here so i'm going to just say um
type
value
so we'll say banana
125 123 we'll say apple
orange
nobody likes oranges
i shouldn't say i'm sure it's like lots
of people like oranges
oh we gotta put pears on there
i actually really like paris people
think i like bananas which is not true i
actually like pears
that's what i like so i'm going to go
ahead and save this save as
and i'm just going to save this to my
desktop here so just give me a moment
just doing this off screen
and i'm going to save this uh data set
quick site
csv it can even take an xls so i don't
have to save it as a uh
i'll just save it as an xls
okay and so we're going to just upload
that so there is that data set
it's going to scan that file it's going
to see that sheet
you can even preview it
there's the information we're going to
add that data
i get added as a data data set
well how do i
where do i it's like it says add the
data i just want to add it as a data set
so they set up here maybe save and
visualize
up here and is it autographing it
maybe if i drag in is it working is it
thinking okay it's 100
so i'm going to just drag that onto
there
and
it says pear orange banana
just kind of trying to make sense of
this here is it taking in count the
value maybe put the value down there
wow that's so much easier i haven't used
this for like a year and um i'm gonna
tell you this has gotten a lot easier to
use so i'm quite impressed with this but
yeah i mean this is pretty much what
quicksite is if you want to visualize
things in different types you can drag
them out you can probably like click on
the wheel here and change it
again i'm not sure
exactly how all the
uh the dials and knobs work here but i
mean another thing we could do is just
drag out like another object and do the
same thing so maybe i'd want a pie chart
um so
add a visual
yeah it's not as nice as power bi but
like it's still great that it's here you
know type
value
so we got a nice pie chart there
uh let's try something weird
let's give this one a go
doesn't color it which is not very nice
um there's probably some kind of way to
color it but
focus on banana only
i don't know i don't know the point of
there but anyway that's quick site so
um i really don't want to pay for this
so what i'm going to do
is go up here
um there's you have to deactivate i'm
just trying to remember how
because they change the interface again
they change everything on you
so there we go i'm on a trial for four
days here maybe
quantity four just the four 29 day trial
so if i want to get out of this trial
what do i do
i don't
want to use it anymore
um so
how to delete
aws quicksite
canceling your subscription
so before you can unsubscribe uh you're
assigned in the im account
your quick site administrator you're the
root i am administrator sure
you deleted any secondary namespaces to
find the existing namespace etc so
choose your username in the application
bar to quick site account settings
unsubscribe
so i was almost there i thought i was in
the right place
uh this one no
i was just there
manage quick site
your subscriptions
edit
there's no unsubscribe option
so i'm not sure
can i cancel
unsubscribe
button does not
appear in quick site
okay just because we're on trial and so
maybe after the end of the trial it will
uh it will vanish there
they are not making this easy for me
account settings ah delete accounts this
is what we probably want to do
permanently delete the account yes
i mean that has to get rid of the
description because it gets rid of
everything
there we go
we'll say confirm
delete account
unless you're using them in the services
blah blah blah
successful okay great so now i should go
back
to adress.amazon.com and just to confirm
that it's gone
i'm going to
go to quicksite again and just see if
it's trying to ask me to
sign up again so it is so i've gotten
rid of my account so we're all in good
shape and uh yeah that is that is quick
site
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the aws well
architecture framework so this is a
white paper created by aws to help
customers build using best practices
defined by aws you can find this at
adabus.amazon.com forward slash
architecture forward slash well
architected this idea is not unique to
aws the other providers have it but i
believe aimbots was the first one to
define this and they have a really good
uh a good approach to this and this is
pretty much essential knowledge that you
have to have four certifications when
we're looking at the cloud practitioner
the system architect associate and
professional
because
there's a lot of principles here best
practices that adabus uses themselves to
architect their infrastructure okay so
the framework is divided into five
sections called pillars which address
different aspects or lenses that can be
applied to a cloud workload so imagine
you have your cloud workload you're
going to want to adopt that as well
architect framework some things that you
know people don't consider outside the
five pillars is that you need to know
general definitions uh general design
principles and the review process
and then from there you have your five
pillars so you have operational
excellence security reliability
performance efficiency and cost
optimization and all these have major
sections in this white paper but outside
of just the main white paper each of
these have their own white papers that
go even into farther detail so if you
really want to
really focus on security and get a lot
more information they have that as well
okay
[Music]
let's take a look at the general
definitions for the well architecture
framework starting with the pillars so
the operational excellent pillar is
there to run and monitor systems the
security pillar is to protect data and
systems to mitigate risk the reliability
pillar is to mitigate and recover from
disruptions the performance efficiency
pillar is about using computing
resources efficiently or effectively and
the cost optimization pillar is about
getting the lowest price and this is
where you're going to find all the
business value and i put an asterisk
there because
you know you might obsess saying we need
to meet the requirements for all these
pillars and that's not the case you can
trade off pillars based on the business
context so you know don't take it as
literally implement every single thing
but just consider that uh you know you
might have to adapt it based on your
workloads then we have some general
definitions that we will come across so
there's components so code configuration
it was resources against a requirement a
workload so a set of components that
work together to deliver business value
milestones so key changes of your
architecture through the product
lifecycle
then there's architecture itself so how
components work together in a workload
and then we have technology portfolio so
a collection of workloads required for
the business to operate okay
[Music]
so the well architected framework is
designed around a different kind of team
structure so when you're looking at
enterprises they generally have a
centralized team with specific roles
where adabas structures their teams as
being distributed with flexible roles
and so this new kind of methodology of
distributed teams uh has some major
advantages but it does come with some
risks and so aws has baked in some uh
practices or uh things that they do to
mitigate these issues okay so let's
compare on-premise enterprise uh to what
abuse is proposing for your team
structure so on-premise what we'd see is
a centralized team consisting of
technical architects solution architects
data architects network architects
security architects and you kind of see
that they all have a specialized
vertical and they are usually managed by
either
togaf or
zac
uh man framework so those are just ways
of structuring your teams those are very
popular and so what a bus is proposing
here is that you have a distributed team
and the way you're going to make that
team work because obviously just
thinking about a distributed team
they're going to be a lot more agile but
to make sure that they effectively work
you have practices like team experts who
raise the bar
making sure that you know in any areas
we can always say how can we do this
better
then there are mechanisms in place for
automated checks for standards so that's
the great thing about cloud can all be
automated to say hey does it meet our
regulatory compliance or what have you
and then there's the concept of the
amazon leadership principles which we
will cover on in the next slide in
detail and so um you know itabus is not
obviously using uh these other
frameworks because it has its own which
is this one here but the mechanism to
which they stay organized and up to date
is they are supported by a virtual
community of subject matter experts
principal engineers so that what they'll
do is they'll engineer things like
lunchtime talks and then recycle that
into their onboarding material or into
this framework itself okay
[Music]
so we're taking a look here at amazon's
leadership principles and these are a
set of principles used during the
company's decision making problem
solving simple brainstorming and hiring
all right um and so i can't say that i
like all of these but uh definitely some
of them really stand out as being great
especially the first one which is
customer obsession so instead of
worrying about what your competitors are
doing think about what the customer
wants work your way back and you know
really focus on the customers needs then
there's ownership so if you're going to
go do something you know try to be your
own mini boss uh and take responsibility
for whatever it is you're building event
and simplify so you know always look for
the simplest solution don't try to
engineer something super complicated if
it's not necessary
are right a lot so you know try to
be right uh learn and be curious so
that's pretty self-explanatory hire and
develop the best insist on the high
standards aws always refers to this as
raising the bar think big bias for
action frugality and abuse is really
frugal if you didn't know that but not
just for like themselves but also for
their customers they want customers to
spend the least amount of money possible
when using their infrastructure earn
trust
dive deep have a backbone disagree and
commit deliver results strive to be the
earth's best employer success and scale
bring broad responsibility and if you
want to read these in detail because
they have a big block of text for each
of these
you can go to amazon.jobs
for en forward slash principles and read
all about it okay
[Music]
all right let's talk about some general
design principles that you should be
considering when you are designing your
infrastructure no matter what pillar
that you are looking to adopt the first
is stop guessing your capacity needs so
the great thing with cloud computing is
you use as little or much based on
demand whereas on premise you would have
to purchase a machine and you'd have to
make sure you have additional capacity
so that you could grow into it right and
so here with uh cloud you do not have to
worry about that
test systems at production scale so be
able to clone your production
environment to testing tear down testing
while not in use to save money so a lot
of people will have a staging server
that they run all the time but the great
thing here is that with cloud you know
it's you can just spin it up and have it
right away and then tear it down and
save money
there's automating to make architectural
experimentation easier this is talking
about using infrastructure as a code so
for aws it should be using cloud
formation creating change sets which
kind of um uh say exactly what is going
to change stack updates drift detection
to see if your stuff is
being changed over time by developers
through manual configuration things like
that then we have allow for evolutionary
architectures so this is about adapting
ci cd um doing nightly releases or if
you're using serverless if you adopted
lambdas they deprecate over time forcing
you to use the latest version
and so that is evolutionary
architectures then we have drive
architectures using data so um when
you're using cloud there's a lot of
tooling in there to automatically start
collecting data so cloudwatch will be
collecting some things by default and
cloudtrail will as well so you know that
is another thing and then improving
things through game day so this is about
simulating traffic on production or
purposely killing ec2 instances or or
messing with your services to see how
well they recover all right
[Music]
before we jump into each of the pillars
let's go open them up and take a look at
what structure we should expect to see
so we have design principles definition
best practices and resources all the
pillars follow this to a t so let's just
talk about what these are so the design
principles are a list of design
principles that needs to be considered
during implementation and that's where
we're going to focus a lot of our energy
then you have definition so this is an
overview of the best practice categories
then you have the best practices
themselves these are detailed
information about each practice with
various aws services and then you have
resources these are additional
documentation white papers
and videos to implement this pillar and
i just want to tell you that if you're
doing the certified cloud practitioner
we're really just going to cover the
design principles but for the solutions
architect associate or anything uh
that's associated or above that's we're
gonna actually dive deep into the
implementation of the best practices
because there is a lot of stuff there so
yeah there we go
[Music]
let's take a look here at the design
principles for operational excellence so
the first here is perform operations as
code supply the same engineering
discipline you would to application code
to your infrastructure so by training
your operations as code you can limit
human error and enable consistent
responses to events generally we're
talking about infrastructure
infrastructure as a code here so this
would probably be like things like cloud
formation there's other things you could
do like policy as a code and a bunch of
other ones then we have make frequent
small reversible changes so design your
workloads to allow components to be
updated regularly uh this could be
talking about doing rollbacks
incremental changes blue green
deployments having a ci cd pipeline
refined operations procedures frequently
so look for continuous opportunities to
improve your operations
here you use game days to simulate
traffic or event failure on your
production workloads anticipate failure
so perform post modems on system
failures to better improve write test
code kill production servers
there's a small spelling mistake it
should have an r here so servers to test
recovery learn from all operational
failures so share lessons learned in a
knowledge base for operational events
and failures across your entire
organization but you know if you can
just remember these headings here
and be able to categorize what would be
under operational excellence you'll be
okay all right
[Music]
all right let's take a look at the
design principles for the security
pillar so the first here is implement a
strong identity foundation so implement
the principle of least privilege or polp
that's a very popular concept meaning
giving people only the permissions that
they need use centralized identity so
that would be using database iam avoid
long link credentials then we have
enable traceability so monitor alerts
and audit actions and changes to your
environment in real time integrate log
and metric collection and automate
investigations and remediation then we
have apply security at all layers so
take defense in depth approach with
multiple security controls for
everything from as networks vbcs load
balancing instances os application code
we might have a slide in this course on
defense and uh depth where basically you
see like a ring of things and you can
kind of see how like there's layers that
go from outward to inward and that's
what they're talking about when they're
listing out all these things here
automate security best practices
protect your data in transit at rest
keep people away from your data
the reason i don't have descriptions
there is because those are pretty
self-evident prepare for security events
so incident management systems and
investigation policies and processes
tools to detect investigate and recovery
from incidences and uh there are a lot
of security tools out there and they all
have funny initialisms i didn't put any
of them in here but i'm sure there are
some there
but yeah there you go for security
[Music]
all right let's take a look at design
principles for reliability and the first
here is automatically recover from
failure so monitor kpis and trigger
automations when the threshold is breach
test recovery procedures so test how
your workload fails and you validate
your recovery procedures you can use
automation to simulate different
failures or to recreate scenarios that
led to failures before
scale horizontally to increase aggregate
system availability so replace one large
resource with multiple small resources
to reduce the impact of a single failure
on the over overall workload distribute
requests across multiple smaller
resources to ensure that they don't
share a common point of failure so we're
talking about multi-az
high availability okay stop guessing
capacity we've seen this multiple times
so in on-premise it takes a lot of
guesswork to determine the elasticity of
your workloads uh
workload demands with cloud you don't
need to guess how much you need because
you can request the right size of
resources on demand that's going to give
you better reliability okay manage
change and automation so making changes
via infrastructure as a code will allow
for a formal process to track and review
infrastructure they're going to see iac
show up a lot in this framework okay
[Music]
let's take a look at design principles
for performance efficiency so the first
here is democratize advanced technology
so focus on product development rather
than procurement provisioning and
management of services because if you're
on prem you'd have to order those
machines set them up and so take
advantage of advanced technologies
specialize and optimize for your use
case with on-demand cloud services
because again if you're using on-prem uh
you you know
you might not have the option to have
sage maker right it's just going to be a
vm and you're going to do all the work
yourselves whereas aws has all these
specialized things so you can move
quickly
go global in minutes so deploying your
workload in multiple abs regions around
the world allows you to provide lower
latency and a better experience for your
customers at a minimal cost we have used
serverless architecture so serverless
architecture removes the need for you to
run and maintain physical servers for
traditional computing activities removes
the operational burden of managing
physical servers and can lower
transactional costs because managed
services operate at cloud scale and aws
can be a lot better at
running them
efficiently then you will uh experiment
more often so with virtual and
automatable uh resources you can quickly
carry out comparative testing using
different types of instances storage or
configurations to make the best choice
we call this right sizing choosing the
right size consider mechanical sympathy
so understand how cloud services are
consumed and always use technology
approach that aligns best with your
workload goals for example consider data
access patterns when you select database
or storage approaches
[Music]
let's take a look here at design
principles for cost optimization so the
first one here is implement cloud
financial management so dedicate time
and resources to build capacity via
cloud financial management and cost
optimization tooling statements is
saying hey take advantage of all our
tooling that makes it easy for you to
know exactly what you're spending adopt
a consumption model so pay only for
computing resources that you require
an increase or decrease using uh
depending on the business requirements
we're talking about on-demand pricing
measure overall efficiency so measure
the business output of the workload and
the cost associated associated with
delivering use this measure to know the
gains you make from increasing output
and reducing costs so stop spending
money on undifferentiated that's a hard
word to say
undifferentiated heavy lifting so aws
does the heavy lifting of the data
center operations like racking stacking
and power servers it also removes the
operational burden of managing operating
systems
and applications with managed services
this allows you to focus on your
customers and business projects rather
than your it infrastructure
and the last one here is analyze and
attribute expenditure so the cloud makes
it easier to accurately identify the
usage and cost of systems which then
allow transparent attribution of it
costs to individualize workload owners
this helps measure return on investment
and gives workload owners an opportunity
to optimize the resources and reduce
costs so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the aws well
architected tool so this is an auditing
tool to be used to assess your cloud
workloads for alignment with the aws
well architected framework and so what
it is it's essentially a checklist
but it also has nearby references so you
know as you're reading through it it
will show you information uh and
resources so that it can help you with
this checklist here and the idea is when
you're done you can generate out a
report and then you can provide that
report to your executives and key
stakeholders to prove uh you know how
well architected your workload is on aws
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this video i want to show you two
things the well architected framework
and the well architected tool so first
let's go look for the well architected
framework
so we're going to look up white papers
aws
and so if we go here to about amazon.com
white papers we have a bunch of pages
here and so i'm going to just check box
on white paper so that we can kind of
reduce the amount there and i'm going to
check box well architected framework if
we scroll all the way top here one of
these you think it'd be right at the top
but one of these is the well architected
framework and here it is and so if we
open it up i used to just directly open
up as a pdf i'm sure you can still
download it as is but generally you're
going to open up as this html page and
you can basically read through it see
all the stuff see the multiple pillars
we can click into here see the design
principles read the definitions and then
start reading about uh the best
practices and they have these things at
the bottom of each one
uh very boring very very boring but um
you know when you get to the solutions
architect and things like that you're
going to need to know this stuff inside
and out it's going to really help you
out this cloud practitioner we only need
to know surface level information
uh but that's a little arctic framework
let's take a look at the well
architected tool so we're going to type
in well here we'll get the well
architected tool and if we go here you
can see that i've created a couple
before probably demos
for
our videos and so i'm going to go define
a new workload i'm going to say my
my workload here
my workload
whoops my workload it is messing up
because i probably have grammarly
installed so it does not like grammarly
so i'm just going to turn it off for now
so my workload
and it's still not typing correctly so i
have to kill a kill of grammarly here
which is kind of frustrating so that's a
bug that that's not grammarly's fault
that's adabus's fault for not playing
well
with grammarly and that's something i
will definitely report to them because
it's very annoying
so i'm going to go ahead and refresh
this page
my workload my workload
um
and this is andrew brown
production or pre-production doesn't
matter pick your regions us east
or usc's 2 sure
i'm selecting it
there we go uh optional optional
optional optional you go to next
and then you can choose your lens
serverless lens ftr lens so that's the
foundational technical review sas lens
we can go with architected framework and
then once that is there we can start
reviewing
okay and then we get this big checklist
and so we can go through this and read
each one so we say
ops one how do you determine what your
priorities are and all these things like
ops and stuff like that these are all
the summaries in each of the well
architected framework sections
so you pretty much don't need to really
read the dock and just go through this
so everyone needs to understand their
part in enabling business success
have shared goals in order to set
priorities of resources this will
maximize the benefit of your efforts
so select from the following evaluate
the customer's external needs
external customer needs evaluate
internal customer needs if you click
info it's going to highlight each one
here so of all key stakeholders
including business development
operations teams this will ensure etc
and so you just go through this and uh
you know once you have that
and you save and exit
okay
you'll have
the questions that are answered it'll
say what's high risk what's not things
like that
very simplistic it's really just a way
of making a very organized report or
checklist and proving that you went
through it uh to the executive level or
to the management level there so
hopefully that makes sense to you it's
not too complicated but there you go
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we are looking at the aws architecture
center so the architecture center is a
web portal that contains best practices
and reference architectures for a
variety of different workloads and you
can find this at
adabus.amazon.com for slash architecture
so if you're looking for best practices
in terms of security they have a huge
section on that and they have it for
pretty much every kind of category on
aws or if you're looking for practical
examples you can view the large library
of reference architectures so here's one
to make an aws q and a bot and it will
have an architectural diagram but you
can also
deploy via cloud formation or possibly
cdk
and this way you can get a working
example and then tweak it for your use
case so this is a really great tool um
when you are done the awesome
architecture framework and you're saying
okay how do we apply it can we get more
concrete examples and i wouldn't be
surprised if a lot of the resources
within the well-architected framework
white paper are just pointing to the
center okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the concept
of total cost of ownership also known as
tco so what is tco well it is a
financial estimate intended to help
buyers and owners determine the direct
and indirect costs of a product or
service so here is an example of you
know tco for maybe like a data center so
we have hardware monitoring installation
i.t personnel training software
uh security licensing and taxes but
that's not just the limit of it it's
just kind of the examples we show here
the idea of creating tco is useful when
your company's looking to migrate from
on-prem to cloud and we will have a
better kind of visual here to kind of
understand how you would contrast
against on-premise to cloud but let's
just talk about how it actually works in
practicality which i think gets kind of
overlooked when cloud service providers
are selling you on tco so the idea is
that gardner um you know they
uh they were they wrote this article
based on this research where an
organization had moved uh 2500 virtual
machines over to amazon dc2 and so what
you're seeing here is that there is a an
additional cost that we're not
considering which is the migration cost
see this bar up here um so the idea is
that the company was paying around 400
000 and so they started to move over and
as you see their costs initially went up
for a short period of time here uh but
then once that migration cost was over
uh you can notice that they had a 55
reduction so it's uh totally possible to
save money uh and clearly there is great
savings uh now is it exactly what aws
promises probably not and that's that
could be the reason why they update
their tco calculator but let's now just
do that contrast against the two so we
have on-premise on the left and aws on
the right or any cloud service provider
and what i want to do is help you think
about what costs do people generally
think about because if we have like
iceberg the idea here is that these are
the costs that we always think about
above the iceberg and then there's these
hidden costs that we just don't consider
when factoring in our move and that's
the idea of tcos to consider all the
costs not just the superficial ones and
so people say these look like teeth and
that's why i add penguins and a whale
here um and so when we're talking about
on-premise what we generally think are
software license fees and subscription
fees but when you compare those against
each other they might look the same um
aws might just look slightly cheaper or
even more and so the idea is you need to
then factor in everything so on on
premise there's implementation
configuration training physical security
hardware id personnel maintenance and on
the aws side you know you are you don't
have to do as much of that stuff so you
just have implementation configuration
and training and so aws with their tco
calculator their old one used to make a
promise of 75 percent in savings um
again you know
this is going to really vary based on
what your migration strategy looks like
um but you know it's totally possible
you could save 75 percent or you could
save 50 percent over a third year
three-year period and there's a initial
spike so that's just something you have
to consider but the nice thing though is
that once you've moved over all the
stuff over here on the left-hand side
will be eight of us's responsibility
okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at
capital versus operational expenditure
so there's capex and opex so on the
catholic side the idea here is you're
spending money upfront on physical
infrastructure deducting that expenses
from your tax bill over time
a lot of companies that are running
their own data centers uh or have a lot
of on-premise stuff understand what
capex is because
it's something that a lot of times they
get tax breaks is on and that's why we
see a lot of people that have a hard
time moving away from the cloud because
you know they keep on thinking about
that money they save from the government
but capex costs would be things like
server costs storage network costs
backups and archives disaster recovery
costs data center costs technical
personnel so the idea is with capital
expenses you have to guess up front what
you plan to spend okay with operational
expenditure the idea here is the cost
associated with an on-premise data
center that has shifted the cost to the
service provider the customer only has
to be concerned with non-physical costs
so leasing software and customizing
features
training employees and cloud services
paying for cloud support
billing based on cloud metrics so
compute usage storage usage and so the
idea here is with operational expenses
you can try a product or service without
investing in equipment so basically apex
is what we think about when we think of
on-premise and then opex is what we
think about
you know we're thinking about cloud or
aws okay
[Music]
all right let's ask a very important
question about cloud migration so does
cloud make it personnel redundant so a
company is considering migrating their
workloads from on-premise to the cloud
to take advantage of the savings there
is a concern among the staff that there
will be mass layoffs does cloud make it
personnel redundant and that's a very
important question to to have an answer
to and this all talks about shifting
your i.t team into different
responsibilities so a company needs i.t
personnel during the migration phase as
we saw with that gardner research report
that there was a period
at least like a year where they needed
that for you know depending on the size
your company so you're still going to
need those people around a company can
transition some roles to new cloud roles
so a very traditional example would be
you have your traditional networking
roles or people have like their ccna and
now they're moving over to cloud
networking they have a reduced workload
but there's other things that they could
be doing in the cloud
a company may decide to take a hybrid
approach so they'll always need to have
a traditional it team and a cloud it
team
um and the last one and this one you'd
actually see on the exam which is a
company can change employees activities
from managing infrastructure to rev
revenue generating activities okay so
the idea is that you know if you're a
company why would you get rid of all
your staff and you just put them all
into rev regeneration i suppose you know
you could uh you know uh lay them off
and some companies might do that um or
you know you could just retrain them
because
if that it personal team has uh
technical expertise i'm sure they can
translate that to the cloud
[Music]
let's talk about the database pricing
calculator and this is a free cost
estimate tool that can be used within
your web browser without the need of a
database account to estimate the cost of
a various items services and this is um
available at calculator.aws
and the reason we're bringing this up is
because there used to be a tco
calculator but now this is the
calculator that you use
so the abs pricing calculator contains
100 plus services that you can configure
for cost estimate and so you can just
click through a bunch of knobs and
boxes to
uh you know
exactly figure out a very accurate cost
so the idea here is that to calculate
your tco an organization needs to
compare that existing cost against their
abuse costs and so the ibis prices
calculator can be used to determine uh
you know the aws costs and obviously the
organization knows its cost so we can
compare it against that
and the way you can get data out of this
is you can export it as a final estimate
to a csv okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the aws
pricing calculator so to get there it's
calculated.aws what you're going to do
is hit create estimate and then here you
have a bunch of services so you just
choose what you want so you type in ec2
we're going to configure that
and from there we can do a quick
estimate or an advanced estimate so
choose this option for fast and easy
route to ballpark an estimate choose
this option for detailed estimate for
accounts workloads and stuff so notice
down below very simplistic we hit
advanced
and we get all
sorts of stuff okay so you know it's
really up to you i'm very comfortable
with the advanced options so i might be
running a linux machine what is my usage
it's going to
have uh daily spikes of traffic because
of the use cases you could say it's not
busy on saturday and sunday that it has
a baseline of one a peak of two eight
things like that then you can choose
what you're using um
t4 g i don't even know what that is uh
but let's just say like t
uh
t to uh micro which is not that big two
three micro
and you could say we're doing on demand
because a lot of people would be doing
that and
you see like seven dollars a month it's
not a lot of money then you're looking
at your storage data in data out
okay so we can add that
another thing that we might see is
something like rds
so we go to rds and we add postgres and
not all of them have the simple and
complex sometimes they're simple so
production database
we'll have one here and we're just going
to be
say a db t2 micro
t3 micro there we go
a hundred that's fine we're not going to
have multi-az we'll have single lazy on
demand show the calculation 13 a month
add that to our estimate
so you're kind of getting the idea there
right
and so you know we have our summary
that's our monthly 391 dollars
um oh sorry over 12 months so our
monthly cost is 32
okay you can go back there clone the
service edit it stuff like that you can
export the estimate i think it goes out
as a csv you can also hit share
and then hit agree
and so then you have a public link
and if i have that link we can just see
what happens if i paste it okay and it
just brings them to the same estimate so
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at migration
evaluators so it was formerly known as
tcl logic and then abus acquired the
company and it is an estimate tool used
to determine an organization existing
on-premise costs so it can compare it
against its aws costs for planned cloud
migration uh so the idea is that you can
get a very very detailed information and
the way it collects information is via
an agentless collector to collect data
from your on-premise infrastructure to
extract from your own on-premise costs i
don't know if you can see there but you
can see that it works with a lot of
different kinds of on-premise technology
like vmware microsoft
tsql all sorts of things okay
[Music]
one migration tool that we can use with
aws is the vm import export and this
allows us to import virtual machines
into ec2 so itamus has import
instructions for vmware citrix
microsoft hyper-v
windows vhd from azure and also linux
vhd from azure and so the way this works
is that you prepare your virtual image
for upload and adabus has a bunch of
instructions for that once it is ready
you're going to upload that to an s3
bucket and once it's uploaded to an s3
bucket then what you can do is use the
aw cli to import your image
um and so that is the cli command down
below
and once it is produced it will generate
out an amazon machine image and so from
an ami you can then go launch your ec2
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the database
migration service which allows you to
quickly and securely migrate one
database to another dms can be used to
migrate your on-premise database to aws
and that's why we're talking about it
and so here's a general diagram where
you have your source database which
connects to a source endpoint goes
through a replication instance so that's
an ec2 instance that's going to
replicate the data to the target
endpoint onto the target database
and so we have a bunch of possible
sources so we have oracle database
microsoft sql mysql mario db postgresql
mongodb sap at asc
imdb
db2 azure sql database amazon rds
amazon s3 and i'm assuming these are
database dumps
amazon aurora amazon document db and so
for possible targets it's very similar
we got oracle database microsoft sql
mysql mario db post sql redis sap se
amazon redshift amazon rds amazon
dynamodb amazon s3 amazon aurora amazon
open search service amazon elastic cache
for redis amazon document db amazon
neptune apache kafka i'm just showing
you the list to give you an idea of how
flexible this service is uh but you can
tell that these are very different
databases so how can it uh move them
over right and so in not all cases can
it easily do it like it's very easy to
go from mysql to postgres um but you
know for ones that are like relational
to
uh nosql uh this is where the innova
schema conversion tool comes into play
it's used in many cases to automatically
convert a source database schema to a
target database schema or semi-automate
it so that you can kind of like you know
figure out how to map the new schema
each migration path requires a bit of
research since not all combinations of
sources and targets are possible and it
really comes down to even versions of
these things so but i just want you to
know about that it's an option as a
database migration service and i've
migrated a very large database before
and it's super fast so and it's not that
hard to use so something you definitely
want to remember when you're
[Music]
migrating hey this is andrew brown from
exam pro and we are taking a look at the
cloud adoption framework so this is a
white paper to help you plan your
migration from on premise to aws at the
highest level the aws caf organizes
guidance into six focus areas we've got
business people governance platform
security and operations and this white
paper is pretty high level uh so you
know it doesn't get into granular
details on how that migration should
work but gives you kind of a holistic
approach and i believe that probably
through the aws
amazon partner network there's people
that specialize in using this particular
framework to help organizations move
over and i believe that anybody has
professional services through the apn
but let's just kind of break down what
these six categories are we're not going
to go too deep into this but let's do it
so the first is the business perspective
so these are business managers finance
managers budget owners strategy
stakeholders so it's how to update the
staff skills and organizational
processes to optimize this value as they
move ops to the cloud you have people
perspective so human resources staffing
people managers so how to update the
staff skills and organizational
processes to optimize and maintain the
workforce and ensure competencies are in
place at the appropriate time you have
governance perspectives so cios program
managers project managers enterprise
architects business analysts so how to
update the staff skills and
organizational processes that are
necessary to ensure business governance
in the cloud and manage and measure
cloud investments to evaluate the
business outcomes we have platform
perspectives so ctos it managers
solution architects so how to update the
staff skills and organizational
processes that are necessary to deliver
and optimize cloud solutions and
services security perspectives so ciso
i.t security managers i.t security
analysts so how to update the staff
skills and organizational processes that
are necessary to ensure that the
architecture deployed in in the cloud
aligns to the organization's security
control requirements resilience and
compliance requirements we have
operational or operations perspective so
i t operations managers i t support
managers so how to update the staff
skills and organizational processes that
are necessary to ensure system health
and reliability during the move of
operations to the cloud and then to
operate operate using agile ongoing
cloud computing best practices so this
just
taps the surface of what the caf is
and i think for each of these they
actually have a more detailed breakdown
so you know business is going to break
down to even more uh finite things there
okay
[Music]
so aidabus has free services that are
free forever unlike the free tier that
are up to a point of usage or time
um and so there are a lot here this is
not even the full list there's
definitely more and we have iem amazon
vpc auto scaling cloud formation elastic
bean stock ops works amplify appsync
code star organizations consolidate
billing it was cost explorer
sagemaker systems manager there's a lot
of them okay
but the thing is is that these services
are free but some of these
can spin up other resources so the
services are free themselves uh however
ones that provision services may cost
you money so cloudformation which is an
infrastructure as a code tool could
launch virtual machines those virtual
machines will cost money right opsworks
can launch servers that can cost money
amplify can launch
um lambdas that can cost money so that's
something you just have to consider um
but yeah there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the aws
support plans so we got basic developer
business and enterprise and you
absolutely absolutely need to know this
stuff inside and out for exams they will
ask you questions on this okay
so basic is for email support only uh
such as billing and account so if you
think it got over billed and that's
something you should do if you've uh
misconfigured something and you end up
with a big bill just go
open up a support ticket under basic for
billing and they're likely to refund you
but if you do have questions about
billing accounts that's we're going to
be using for everything else that is for
tech support um and so for developer
business enterprise you're going to get
email support which they'll
roughly reply within 24 hours i believe
this is business hours so if you message
them on friday um or sorry saturday you
might be waiting till monday for it okay
in terms of third party support the only
one that doesn't have third-party
support is developer so if you are using
something like ruby on rails or azure or
something that has interoperability
between
aws and something else business
enterprise will absolutely help you out
with it same with enterprise but the
developer one not so much uh if you like
to use the phone or you like to chat
with people um that's available the
business enterprise tier this is the way
i end up talking to people if you are um
you know like if you're in north america
and you're calling between nine to five
on a monday friday you're likely to get
somebody that is in within north america
if not it'll be one of uh
one of the supports from some other area
so just be aware of that that can also
affect the time they pick up uh
sometimes it's five minutes sometimes
it's 30 minutes to to an hour uh you
know it just depends on what service
you're asking for and you know what time
of day okay
in terms of
responsiveness uh for general guidance
everything is 24 hours or less for
developer business enterprise if your
system is impaired it's within 12 hours
or less with production system impaired
it's four hours or less with production
system down it's one hour or less and if
you're for enterprise um it's going to
be business critical system down less
than 15 minutes so just notice who has
what for these things um i've definitely
waited like
three days on general guidance before so
just take these with a grain of salt
that they're not you know they don't
really stick to these that or maybe i'm
just not paying enough for them to care
okay um in terms of uh getting actual
people assigned to you this only happens
at the enterprise level where they have
their concierge team so they uh help
your
organization uh learn how to use adabask
ask them any questions personally and
then you have a tam a technical account
manager that is somebody that knows um
awsi inside and out and they'll help you
architect things and make correct
choices or they'll check your bill and
help you try to reduce that bill things
like that okay
in terms of trusted advisory checks at
the basic developer you get seven
advisor checks once you're paying for
business you get all the checks the cost
here for business is zero um for
developer it's starting at 29 a month
for businesses starting at 100 a month
and then for enterprise it's 15 000 a
month so i said starting yet because
it's dependent on your usage okay
so let's just look at developer business
enterprise here because basic's not
going to be applicable here so for
developers 29 usd a month or three
percent of the monthly database usage
which whichever is greater on the exam
they're only going to ask you like is it
29 100 like generally do you know the
tier of expensiveness but they're not
going to ask you the percentage of usage
okay there's not going to be formulas
here
when you get into business it's a little
bit different where they have it in
different brackets so it's going to be
10 for the first uh 10 000 and the next
is going to be the next 7 000 stuff like
that similar for enterprise as well so
let's just do some math so we know that
we understand how this works so
if you if you had a monthly spend of
500. at the developer tier that's three
percent of five hundred is fifteen
dollars so they go okay what is greater
twenty nine dollars or fifteen dollars
so you're paying twenty nine dollars if
your spend is a thousand dollars that
comes up to thirty dollars uh so you're
gonna end up paying thirty dollars
because that's greater than 29 okay for
business if your monthly spend is a
thousand that's ten percent of a
thousand that's a hundred dollars if
your spend is five thousand then you're
going to be paying 500 if your monthly
spend is 12 000 then the first 10
percent of a 10 000 is a thousand and
then the next is seven percent of two
thousand so your total bill is 140 usd
we're not going to do a calculation for
enterprise because the same for business
but hopefully that gives you an idea
there okay
[Music]
hey it's andy brown from exam pro and we
are taking a look at a technical account
manager also known as a tam and these
provide both proactive guidance and
reactive support to help you succeed
with your aws journey so what does atam
do and this is straight from a database
job posting
what they would do is build solutions
provide technical guidance and advocate
for the customer
ensure aws environments remain
operationally healthy while reducing
costs and complexity
develop trusting relationships with
customers understanding their business
needs and technical challenges
using your technical uh acumen and
customer obsession you'll drive
technical discussions regarding
incidents trade-offs risk management
consult with a range of partners from
developers through the c-suite
executives collaborative with adwords
solutions architect business developers
professional service consultants and
sales account managers proactively find
opportunities for customers to gain
additional value from aws
provide detailed reviews of service
disruptions metrics detailed pre-launch
planning
being a part of a wider enterprise
support team providing post-scale con uh
consolidative expertise
solve a variety of problems across
different customers as they migrate
their workloads to the cloud
uplift customer capabilities by running
workshops brown bag sessions brown bag
sessions being a sessions that occur at
lunch time something you can learn in 30
minutes an hour and so one thing that's
really important to understand is that
tams follow the amazon leadership
principles especially about customer uh
being customer obsessed and we do cover
the amazon leadership principle
somewhere in this course and tams are
only available at the enterprise support
tier so hopefully that gives you an idea
what a tam does
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along i'm going to show
you um database support and in order to
use ada support or to change your level
of support you're going to need to be
logged into the root account i should
say you can use support with im users
but if you want to change the support
plan you're going to have to be the root
user so the top right corner i'm going
to support
and notice here on the left hand side
right now i have a basic plan
and so before we look at changing our
plan i'm just going to go create a case
and we're going to just take a look
at some of the options that are open to
us so we have account billing support
service limit increase technical support
notice this is grayed out so we cannot
select anything here
i can go to here and increase our
service limit
and this is something that you might
have to do pretty soon earlier in your
account you might say hey i need more of
something like ec2 or a very common
thing is ses
so for ses you might say hey
i need to have this amount of emails for
etc okay
so um if we go over to account and
billing support uh we can go here and
ask anything we want so if it's about
the free tier i could say
ask the general question getting started
and saying
uh what is free on aws
um
i want to know
what is free on aws
and you can attach three attachments
there you can choose via web
and phone which is really nice um but
today i'm just going to do web here and
submit that just to kind of show you
that as an example and so what that is
going to do is open a case and then we
will see probably respond
in 24 hours to 48 hours just depends on
whether it's the weekend or not because
it's based on business hours of course
so now that we have an understanding of
basic let's go take a look at what the
other tiers look like so we have basic
developer business and enterprise
enterprise being extremely expensive
developer being affordable and then
business being um you know affordable
for businesses so i would say developer
is okay it gives you um
it gives you better support but it's all
via email and so you know if you really
want good support you're gonna have to
pay the business one and that's the one
that i use quite a bit so if i change my
plan i'm gonna go over to business and
this is gonna cost me 93 bucks just to
do to show you here today
so i'm going to go ahead and click that
and so it's now processing it
and so what's going to happen is
i'm going to have to wait for this basic
to switch to business because if i go to
the case here it hasn't happened as of
yet
so notice i cannot select this so i'm
going to see you back here it may be
like four or five minutes or however
long it takes and we'll take a look then
okay great so after a few minutes it
says my plan is now business and what i
can do is go ahead and create a new case
and so i can go over to technical
support and ask a question so if i was
having issues with anything it doesn't
matter what i could go over to ec2
linux and then i could choose my
category so i could say i'm having an
issue with um
systems manager
and
a lot of times they like you to provide
the instance id it's going to change
based on what service you choose here
but you'll get different information
i'll just say
i need help
with
[Music]
logging into my ec2 instance managed by
ssm
so i could say i created an ec2 instance
and i am attempting to access
the instance via
sessions manager
but it is not working
i think i have a role issue and then i'm
just going to go down here and say
this is not a real question
i
am filming a demo video for a tutorial
video
on how to use support okay and so once
we do that we have the option of web
chat and phone so if you use phone
you're going to enter your phone number
in and they're going to call you back
usually you'll be on hold for
anywhere for five minutes to an hour it
just depends usually it's within 15
minutes so it's very good of course it
depends on the time of day and your
location things like that and the
service because there's different
support engineers for different types of
services and the the balance of those
are different but generally chat is
pretty good so i can go here and i'm
just going to hit submit and it's going
to open a chat box and so you just wait
okay
and sometimes it's super fast and
sometimes it takes uh minutes okay so
we are going to just sit here for a bit
and um you know i'll just pop back here
when there is somebody to talk to okay
okay so after waiting a little while
looks like uh we've been connected here
so it took a bit of time so we're just
going to say hello hi umair
this is andrew brown
i am recording a video to teach people
how to use aws
and i wanted to show them
how it was support works
so i'm just showing them
how the chat system works
say hello
and hopefully they'll appreciate or they
won't it just doesn't really matter
we'll give them a moment
there we go
that's it
thanks for your help
okay so that's pretty much it um so
you know there's nothing really uh
special about that but the idea is when
you are typing with them it will appear
in the correspondence there so i'm just
going to end the chat
okay
and then i'm just going to mark that
case as result sometimes they will ask
you to resolve it
if i go to cases i probably have some
previous ones here um and i have a lot
but i don't know why they don't all show
up here so you can see this one is
pending this one is resolved i go back
to this one you can kind of see that the
history of a conversation is kept and
you can go back and forth
with the people there
um yeah that's pretty much it you can
also do screen sharing so they might
send you a request to go on zoom or
download this piece of software that
shares your screen and so that is
another option as well so they can get
pretty hands-on to help you
with your problems there but that's
pretty much all i wanted to show you
with support i'm going to downgrade this
and i'm not sure if they're going to
give you back my money sometimes they'll
prorate it for you but i'm going here
and go back to basic
um so we will also refine your credit
card directly in the month's remaining
fees on your old plan which you
previously paid you're obligated to pay
a minimum of 30 days of support each
time you register so i'm not going to
get any money back which is totally fine
because i just wanted to show you how
that works but business support is
definitely worth it
and uh you know that's it
[Music]
so the aws marketplace is a curated
digital catalog with thousands of
software listings from independent
software vendors uh easily find buy test
and deploy software that already runs on
abs the product can be free to use or
can have an associated charge the charge
becomes part of your abs bill and once
you pay database market pays the
provider the sales channel for isv and
consulting partners allow you to sell
your solutions to other awes customers
products can be offered such as amis it
is confirmation templates software the
service offerings web acls ableist laugh
and rules so it sounds great um if you
want to sell here i think you need like
a u.s bank account to do it um and you
know sometimes database marketplace is
just part of aws so like when you're
using the ec2 marketplace you are
technically using the aws marketplace
but they also have like a dedicated page
for it so it's integrated with some
services and it's also standalone okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
in this follow along we're going to take
a look at the adabus marketplace so what
i want you to do is go to the top and
type in marketplace and that will bring
us over to here the marketplace can be
found in a variety of different places
on the platform here you can see that uh
previously it was using something called
guacamole bastion host to launch a
server
but the idea is that um you can discover
products and subscriptions that you
might want to utilize so if i go over
here there's a variety of different
things
and so it could be like i want to have
something like a firewall that might be
something that we might be interested in
so we can search there and there's like
bring your own license firewall so maybe
you have a license with this and you
want to run it on an ec2 instance
something like that
again it's not like super complicated uh
what's going on here but a lot of times
you know when you're using services
you're accessing the marketplace anyway
so like when i'm launching an ec2
instance
noticeable on the left-hand side is
8-bit marketplace and so i don't have to
go to the marketplace there i can just
kind of like check out the thing i want
and that's pretty much all there really
is to it okay so you know hopefully that
makes sense
[Music]
well let's take a look here at
consolidated billing so this is a
feature of abuse organizations that
allows you to pay for multiple accounts
via one bill
so the idea here is we have a master
account and we have member accounts and
i'm pretty sure that we probably call
this root account now i don't think
account might be a dated term but it's
still showing up in the documentation
the idea is that if you have member
accounts within your organization
they're all going to be consolidated
under the single account if you have an
account outside of your organization
you know this is not going to give you
this is going to be basically a separate
bill
as if it's like a standalone
organization or what have you okay
so
for billing aws treats all accounts in
an organization as if they were one
account you can designate one
master or root account that pays the
charges for all the other member
accounts consolidate billing is offered
at no additional cost you can use cost
explorer to visualize usage for
consolidated billing which we can see i
have the icon here
you can combine the usage across all
accounts in the organization to
to share the volume pricing discount
which we did cover in this course
separately if you want an account to be
able to leave the organization you do
have to attach it to a new payment
method so if let's say you had an
account and you want to give it to your
friend or whatever they have to hook up
their cred their credit card but you can
totally have
an account leave an organization but you
have to deal with that billing aspect
okay
[Music]
all right so there's a really cool way
to save an aws and that's through volume
discounts and it's available for many
services the more you use the more you
save is the idea behind it um and so
consolidating billing lets you take
advantage of volume discounts this is a
particular feature of database
organization so if you do not have the
orgs turned on you're not going to be
able to take advantage of that okay
so one example would be something like
data transfer where it is billed for the
first 10 terabytes at 17 cents or sorry
point 17 cents and then the next 40
terabytes it will be at point 13 cents
okay so if we had two accounts um such
as odo and dax and they're not with an
ableist organization we can calculate
those and see what they are
unconsolidated and just so you know one
terabyte equals 1.024 gigabytes and
that's what we're going to see in these
calculations so for odo uh you know if
he has four terabytes and that is uh
we calculate the gigabytes there we
times it by
uh the um set value there we're going to
get 696 dollars okay
for dax we're going to end up with uh
about 13.92 there and so if we were to
add those up the bill would come out to
okay so the idea is that there's an
organization and they like your company
and they created two accounts but
they're just not within an organization
by having them in the organization
you're gonna save um about almost eighty
dollars there so
um that is a reason why you'd want to
use volume discounts okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from example
and we're taking a look at abyss trusted
advisor so trusted advisor is a
recommendation tool which automatically
and actively monitors your aws accounts
to provide actual recommendations across
a series of categories so this is what
it looks like i personally prefer the
older dashboard but this is what they
have now and you can see along the side
we have a bunch of categories and then
we have some checks here saying uh you
know what are we meeting what are we not
and you can go in and read each one and
they'll tell you so much information
they'll even show you like what things
are not meeting that requirements in
some case you can easily remediate by
pressing a button not in all cases but
the thing with the ambush trust advisor
is think of its trusted advisor like an
automated checklist of best practices on
aws
and they kind of map to
the pillars of the well-architected
framework not exactly but pretty close
but there are five categories of aws
trusted advisor
so we have cost up to imagine station
how much money can we save
performance so how can we improve
performance security how can we improve
security fault tolerance how we can we
prevent a disaster or data loss and
service limits so are we going to hit
the maximum limit for a service
and so the next thing we need to discuss
is
um there is a variation of the amount of
checks that are available to you based
on your support plan so you know if
you're using basic or developer you have
seven trusted advisor checks and if you
have business enterprise you have all
the trusted advisor checks so
if we're talking about just the ones
that are available to you the ones that
come for free is mfa on root account
security groups specified ports of
unrestricted amazon s3 bucket
permissions amazon ebs public snapshots
amazon rds public snapshots imu so
this is just about alerting you about
discouraging the use of the root account
service limits so all service limits
checks are free um it's weird because
they call it the like seven security
checks but if you counted all the
service limits it'd obviously be too
large of a number but notice that one
through six are all security checks so
you're not getting anything from the
other tiers just the security tier and
what i want to do is just go over
a bunch of available checks out there
it's probably not the full list because
i couldn't even be bothered to update it
if they've added more but it'll give you
a general idea of what you could expect
under each category so for cost
optimization
it could be things like looking at idle
load bouncers so you know if you have
load balancers you're not using you're
paying for them so get rid of them
unassociated elastic ip addresses so for
every ip that's not associated you're
paying for as well maybe under
performance you have high utilization of
amazon ec2 instances so maybe you can
save money by switching to smaller
instances under security we saw mfa on
root account very popular one making
sure you turn on key rotation could be
something as well there
under fault tolerance
it could be making sure that you're
using backups on your amazon rdes
database maybe that's turned off uh for
service limits there's just a ton of
them and so uh one that that you know
might be pertinent to use vpcs or ec2
limits so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at
trusted advisors so what i want you to
do is go to the top and type in trusted
advisor
and once you're there you're going to
notice on the left hand side we have
cost optimization performance security
fault tolerance and service limits right
now there are no recommended actions
because there's not much going on this
account and when you uh have the uh free
level of support the basic support
you're not going to have all these
checks but if we go in here we can still
see kind of what they do
so we have like performance security
things like that so these are the ones
that we actually can see and they
generally work all the same way if you
expand here it's going to say amazon ebs
public snapshot so check the permission
settings for the ebs volume snapshots
and alert you if the any snapshots are
marked as public
and so if you scroll on down if there
were ones that were an issue it would
tell you right here
okay
then down below here we see like check
buckets in amazon s3 that have open
access permissions or allow access to
authenticated database users
so yellow the acl allows
list access for everyone
a bucket policy allows for any kind of
open access bucket police statements
have public grant access so maybe what
we can do is to see if we can get this
to trigger
and so what i'm going to do here is go
over to s3 and what we're going to do is
make a
bucket that has a full axis okay
so i'm going to create a new bucket and
we'll say my exposed bucket
we'll scroll on down here and we'll just
check box that off and create the bucket
let's say i acknowledge that is totally
fine
okay so now i have a bucket that is 100
exposed if we go back to trusted advisor
give this a refresh
i'm not sure how fast it will show up
here but if i expand
so it says the bucket acl allows upload
delete for everyone the trusted advisor
does not have permissions to check the
policy
uh bucket policy statements that grant
public access
so what we could try to do is make a
policy
and try to grant all access here so
i'm not writing these every single day
but i'm sure we could try to figure this
out
um
we'll say s3 bucket policy public access
public read
and so that one might be a good example
so i'm going to go ahead and copy this
one granting read only permission to
anonymous users
i don't recommend you doing this i'm
just doing this to show you to see if we
can get the trusted advisor to check
because i don't want you to
do this and forget about it and then
have a serious issue but the principle
is set to anybody so anyone can read it
here it's saying get object etc then
it's saying what particular resource so
this one is going to be for
the bucket in question here which is my
exposed
bucket
we're going to scroll on down save the
changes
okay so this bucket is publicly
accessible we're going to go back over
here refresh and see what we can see
okay so checks buckets in s3 etc so it
should appear under here
and it could be that it's just going to
take some time so what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to hang tight for a
little bit oh there we go okay
so it's showing up and i guess it just
took some time to populate and so here
we can see we have a yellow symbol it's
a warning saying hey there's a problem
here if we go back to the dashboard i
wonder if that shows up so this one's
for investigation and recommendation
so you know hopefully that kind of makes
sense to you i think in some cases you
can do remediation from
from here or at least you can go and
check box and say okay um
excuse me ignore
gonna swore there's remediation for some
of these
but in any case you know that's
generally what trusted advisor does
i think that you probably can have it so
it gives you alerts
so yeah you could set recipients for
particular things like if there's a
security issue that i could email a
particular person on your team and they
could deal with it but that's pretty
much it so what i'm going to do is go
ahead and delete this bucket i'm all
done with it
we'll go delete
and say my delete my exposed bucket here
to delete it
and that is it okay
[Music]
let's cover the concepts of service
level agreements also known as slas so
an sla is a formal commitment about the
expected level of service between a
customer provider when a service level
is not met and if customer meets its
obligation under the sla customer will
be eligible to receive compensation so
financial or service credits and so when
we talk about slas then we talk about
sli so at sli service level indicator is
a metric or measurement that indicates
what measure performance a customer is
receiving at a given time
a sli metric could be uptime performance
availability throughput latency error
rate durability correctness
and if we're talking about sli's then
we're talking about slos service level
objectives so the objective that that
the provider has agreed to meet as wells
are represented as a specific target
percentage over a period of time
and so an example of a target percentage
would be something that says
availability sla of 99.99
in a period of three months all right
and let's just talk about target
percentages in the way they can be
represented very common ones we will see
is 99.95 percent 99.99
uh then we have 99 followed by nine
nines and so commonly we just say we
call this nine nines okay and then
there's one
nine elevens so if somebody says we have
an sla guaranteeing of of 911s it's
going to be the 99 followed by 0.911s
all right
[Music]
let's take a look at abus service level
agreements and so there are a lot of
them and i just wanted to show you a few
services to give you an idea how they
work
on the exam they're not going to ask you
like oh what's dynamodb's sla for global
tables
but generally we should just go through
this because it's good practice so let's
take a look at dynamodb sla so abyss
will use commercially reasonable efforts
to make dynamodb available with a
monthly uptime percentage of each aws
region during any monthly billing cycle
so for a at least
99.999 percent if global tables sla
supplies or 99.99 if the standard sla
applies in the event dynamodb does not
meet the service commitment you'll be
eligible to receive service credits
described below so we have monthly
uptime percentage and the service credit
percentage we get global tables standard
tables so let's take a look here
so if less than 99.999 but equal to or
greater than
99.0 percent is met so if if the service
ends up being this you'll get 10
back of what you spent as service
credits
if it drops between
99.0 and 95.0 you get 25 percent back if
it's less than 95
percent
um then it's a hundred percent back
okay and you get the general idea here
sla is going to be slightly different
with their drops now let's take a look
at um a compute so compute is going to
apply across a bunch of compute services
probably because they're all using ec2
underneath so that's probably the reason
for it so we have ec2 ebs ecs eks and
abus makes two sla commitments for the
included services so we have a region
level sla that governs included services
deployed across multiple azs or regions
and an instance level sla that governs
amazon ec2 instances individually
and again we have our monthly up time
percentage our service credit percentage
region and instance level so you can
just see the same thing it's like it's
going to change based on uh what it can
meet then we'll take a look at one more
like rds so relational database uh
service so abs will use commercially
reasonable efforts to make multi-az
instances available with monthly uptime
percentage of 99.95 during any monthly
billing cycle
and again you know if if they don't meet
those requirements you're gonna get
service credits back which basically
equal usc dollars on the platform and so
for this it looks like that so just
notice that you know with comp like
compute it was for a a bunch of services
for dynamodb it was based on uh
particular features like global standard
tables sla it's very straightforward uh
we didn't do s3 because i just did not
want to show you that one it's just too
complicated but my point is is that it's
going to vary so you have to look up per
service okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at amazon's
service level agreements and so the way
you find slas is you're pretty much just
typing sla for whatever it is so if
you're looking for compute you type in
sla or you look for a particular service
so maybe you say sage maker
aws i don't think there's like a generic
sla page at least i don't know where it
is i always just type in sla to find
what it is and through that you can just
kind of read through and try to find out
uh the things that that matter to you
for your business okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at the service
health dashboard and so the service
health dashboard shows general status of
aws services it's really simple the idea
is that you can check based on
the geographic area so you'd say north
america europe etc and what you'll see
is an icon that says whether the service
is in in good standing and the details
whether the service is operating
normally etc notice they also have an
rss feed the reason i'm talking about
service health dashboards is because i
want to talk about personal health
dashboards and because they're both
called health dashboards it's confusing
so i wanted to tell you about this one
first so now we'll jump into the aws
personal health dashboard
so we saw the service health dashboard
now let's take a look at the adabus
personal health dashboard so this is
what it looks like and it provides
alerts and guidance for it events that
might affect your environment all airbus
customers can access the personal health
dashboard the personal health dashboard
shows recent events to help you manage
active events and show proactive
notifications so that you can plan for
scheduled activities you you can use
these alerts to get notified about
changes that can affect your invoice
resources and then follow the guidance
to diagnose and resolve the issue so
this is very similar to the service
health dashboard but it's personalized
for you
um and it's you know i i don't see it
crop up very often but if you had to
create alerts or be reactive to uh
things that are happening within your
bus this is where you do it okay
[Music]
so there's a team called aws trust and
safety that specifically deals with
abuses occurring on the abyss platform
and so i'm going to just list of all the
cases where you'd want to be contacting
them as opposed to support so the first
is spam so you're receiving unwanted
emails from an abus owned ip address or
abus resources are used to spam websites
or forms port scanning your logs show
that one or more aws owned ip addresses
are sending packets to multiple ports on
your server
you also believe this is an attempt to
discover unsecured ports uh dos attacks
so your logs show that one or more
italy's owned ip addresses are used to
flood ports on your resources with
packets you also believe this is an
attempt to overwhelm or crash your
server or the software running on your
server intrusion attempts so your logs
show that one or more adidas owned ip
addresses are used to attempt to log
into your resources
hosting prohibited content so you have
evidence that abyss resources are used
to host or distribute prohibited content
such as illegal content or copyrighted
content without the consent of the
copyright holder distributing malware so
you have evidence that abus resources
are used to distribute software that was
knowingly created to compromise
or cause harm to computers machines that
it's installed on and so in any of these
cases you're not going to it with
support you're going to open up an abuse
ticket and so you got to contact abuse
at
amazonatabus.com or fill out the
amazon abuse form so and this is whether
it's coming from
an outside ableist account or even your
internally if you think that somehow
someone has a compromise your account
and it's being used any of these ways
this is what you're going to do okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at awsw so uh we were
saying that database has the itabus
trust and safety team and what you'll
want to do is if you find that there's
an issue you're going to report it to
this email at abuse at amazon.com or
you're going to use this form which is
the report amazon it was abuse so you'll
go down here you'll sign in you'll put
your email in your first name last name
org phone number um the source ip the
the details uh
in here you can even select the type of
abuse so you say if it's this kind or
that kind things like that it's very
straightforward and that's pretty much
it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the aws free
tier and this allows you to use database
at no cost um and when we say free tier
there there there's the idea of the
first 12 months of sign up there's going
to be special offerings or it's free
usage up to a certain monthly limit
forever
and then there's just services that are
inherently free which we have a total
separate slide on but let's talk about
just the free tier stuff and this is
absolutely not the full list but it's a
good idea like it gives you a good
overview of stuff that is free so for
ec2 which you use for a web server you
get a t2 micro for 750 hours per month
for one year
and so
there's about 730 hours um in a month
and so that means you could have a
server running
the entire month for free
and an additional server for a bit as
well
so for rds which is a relational
database service for either mysql or
postgres we can do a t2db micro for 750
hours for free so there we get our free
database and you would be surprised how
far you can get with a uh a t2 db micro
um you know even for a medium sized
startup you can run it on a t2 db micro
with no problems then you have your
elastic load balancer you get 75 hours
per month for one year um so that is a
really good thing uh load bouncers
usually cost 50 a month so that's great
actually all these pretty much cost 15 a
month so that's about um 15 30 45
month over month for a year that's uh
free then you have amazon cloudfront
this is where you'd have your home page
caching your videos things like that so
you get 50 gigabytes data transfer out
for the total year then there's amazon
connect you get your toll-free number
there 90 minutes of a call time per
month for one month or for one year
sorry amazon elastic cash so you could
launch a redis or um elastic cash server
you get 70 hours on a cash d3 micro for
a year um elastic search service so it's
full text search so again 70 50 hours
per month for one year pinpoint campaign
marketing email so you can send out 5
000 targeted users per month for one
year scs so simple email uh service so
this is for um transactional emails um
so that you send out from your web app
so 62 000 emails per month forever
airbus code pipeline so one pipeline
free it was code build so this is for
building out
projects or things like that so 100
build minutes per month forever it was
lambda service compute 1 million free
requests per month 3.2 million million
seconds of compute time per month for
free
and you know i like to highlight these
ones because for traditional
architecture you're always going to have
a web server a database a load balancer
um and you might even have cloudfront in
there as well but uh yeah again there's
a huge list and this does not even tap
the service of what's free on aws
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abyss
promotional credits and these are the
equivalent to usd dollars on the abyss
platform abs credits can be earned
several ways this could be joining the
database activate startup program
winning a hackathon participating
surveys
and any other reason that database wants
to give credits out
once you
have
a promotional code you click the redeem
credit button in the billing console you
enter it in and then your credits will
be shown there you can monitor them via
it was budgets or via cost explorer and
probably even billing alarms it was
credits generally have an expired day
attached to them could be a few months
to a year immense credits can be used
for most services but there are
exceptions where it is credits cannot be
used like purchasing a domain via roe 53
because uh that domain costs money
outside of aws's cost like for their
infrastructure and virtual stuff and so
for things like that uh you know they're
not gonna be you're not gonna be able to
use credits for that okay
[Music]
the adams partner network also known as
apn is a global partner program for aws
so joining the apn will open your
organization up to business
opportunities and allow exclusive
training and marketing events so when
joining the apn you can either be a
consulting partner so you help companies
utilize database or a technology partner
you build technology on top of abs as a
service offering and a partner belongs
to a specific tier so it's either going
to be select advanced or premiere when
you sign up it's free to sign up but
you're not going to be able to do much
until you start uh committing to an
annual fee so that's it's like a certain
amount of money to uh be able to be part
of that tier and it starts in the
thousands okay so i think the first tier
is like something like a thousand or two
thousand dollars and it gets uh more
expensive as you go up as a tier and you
also have to have particular knowledge
requirements so this could be holding uh
particular edible certifications at this
at the foundational level at the
associate level things like that um or
it could be uh aws apn exclusive
certification so training that um it's
not in certifications but there's
certifications that are only available
to partners saying like how do you it
could be like something like how do you
uh talk to customers or communication
things like that
you can get back promotional database
credits so you know if you say oh man i
spent uh two thousand dollars on just
being able to
get into the apn at least the idea is
that you can generally get back that uh
that spend on aws so it's like you
committing
if you give like two thousand dollars
like you're going to commit to keep
using aws i'm not showing the annual fee
commitments here and the promotional
credits that you get back just because
they've changed it a couple times on me
and i just don't want this slide to go
stale in case they happen to change it
again so you'll have to look that up to
find out what they actually are right
now uh you can have unique speak
speaking opportunities in the official
awesome marketing channels like the
blogs or webinars being part of the apn
is a requirement to be a sponsor with a
vendor booth enables events so when you
s when you go to re invent or any aws
event all the vendors are part of the
apn all right so they've paid their fee
and now they paid an additional fee to
get their booth
but um yeah the bus partner network is
very good for
helping you find new business and
connecting with other people that are
building workloads in aws but hopefully
that gives you an idea of how that works
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at ibis budgets
so abs budgets gives you the ability to
set up alerts if you exceed or
approaching your defined budget create
cost usage or reservation budgets it can
be tracked at the monthly quarterly or
yearly levels with customizable start
and end dates alert support ec2 rds
redshift elasticast reservations
uh and so the idea here is you can
choose your budget amount so it could be
like a hundred dollars it'll even show
you what was the last amount if you're
resetting the budget
it's something new you can choose based
on a different kind of unit so if you
wanted to be based on
running hours on ec2 you could totally
do that is budgets can be used to
forecast costs but is limited compared
to cost explorer or doing your own
analysis whether it was costs and uses
reports along with business intelligence
tools budgets uh based on a fixed cost
or or you can plan your cost up front
based on your chosen level can be easily
managed from the aws budgets dashboard
via the aws budgets api get notified by
providing email or chat bot and
threshold uh how close to the current or
forecasted budget um so you'd see a list
of budgets here uh current versus
forecasted the amount used things like
that you can see your budget history you
can download a csv uh it'll show you the
cost history right in line there which i
can't show you it's hard to see there
you get the first two budgets are free
so there's no reason not to set a budget
when you first get into aws and each
budget costs about 0.02 cents a day so
it's like 60 cents
um
usd per month for a budget so they're
very cheap to use and you've got a limit
of 20 000 budgets they're going to be in
good shape okay
[Music]
well let's take a look here at airbus
budget reports which is used alongside
abs budgets to create and send daily
weekly or monthly reports to monitor the
performance of your abus budgets that
will be emailed to specific emails so
it's not too complicated here you say
create the report budget choose your
frequency
the emails you want um an administrative
report serves as a more convenient way
of staying on top of reports since
they're delivered to your email instead
of logging into the management console
so it's just for those people that just
can't be bothered to log in okay
well let's take a look here at abyss
costs and uses reports so generate a
detailed spreadsheet enabling you to
better analyze and understand your abs
cost so this is kind of what it looks
like and when you turn this feature on
it will place it into an s3 bucket you
could use something like athena to turn
the report into a queryable database
since it's very easy to consume s3 csvs
into athena you could use quicksite to
visualize your billing data as graphs so
quicksite is a business intelligence
tool similar to tableau or power bi you
could also ingest this into redshift
but the idea here is when you turn it on
you can choose how granular you want the
data to be hourly daily or monthly if
you turn on daily you'll be able to even
say spikes of uh of of
of costs for ec2 instances which is kind
of nice the report will contain cost
allocation tags um which i think we have
a separate slide on that type of tags
and the data is stored in either as
either a csv it will be zipped or it
will be a par-cat format it just depends
on how you want it
for that okay
[Music]
let's talk about cost allocation tags so
these are optional metadata that can be
attached to aws resources so when you
generate a cost and uses report you can
use that data to better analyze your
data so what you'd have to do is make
your way over to cost allocation tags
and need to activate the tags you want
to show up there are two types of tags
so we have user defined so whatever
you've previously tagged will show up
probably there
you turn it on so if you made one with
project you turn on project and there's
a lot of aws generated ones
that you can turn on so there's a huge
list there
but uh yeah that's particular with
cost
usage and reports if it says like cost
allocation reports it's just that's what
costs and usage reports used to be
called
and some of the documentation is a bit
old there but yeah there you go
[Music]
so you can create your own alarms in
cloudwatch alarms to monitor spend and
they're commonly called building alarms
and so it's just a regular alarm but
it's just focused on spend but in order
to do this you have to turn on building
alerts first in order to be able to use
it
and then you'll go to cloudwatch alarms
and you can choose billing as your
metric and then you just set your alarm
however you'd want build alarms are much
more flexible than aba's budgets and are
ideal for more complex use cases for
monitoring spend and usage
in terms of alerting
so you just have to decide what you want
to do uh before it was budgets this was
the only way to do it and so this is the
way i'm used to doing it and i still do
it this way today but you know both
options are valid and just have to
decide what is your use case okay
[Music]
let's take a look at about cost explorer
which lets you visualize understand and
manage your aws costs and usage over
time so here's a big graphic of aws cost
explorer and you can specify time and
range and aggregation it has a lot of
robust filtering
what's really nice is that they have a
bunch of default reports for you so i'm
just gonna get my pen tool just to show
you where that button is it's over uh
here
uh if you can see my marker there but
but you know you can look at things like
monthly cost by service monthly cost by
linked account daily cost savings
marketplace r utilization so there's a
bunch there you could also notice that
you can create your own report so if you
do find something that you like you can
save it for later um you can you could
have access to forecasting here so you
get an idea of the future costs and
whether it's been it's gone up or down
just to kind of zoom in on some of those
filtration options you can choose
um either monthly or daily level of
of how you want the data to be grouped
together
and you have a lot of filter control so
if i want to just have ec2 instances for
a particular region then i can get that
filtered information over here and you
can see you have a breakdown of the
different types so it's very detailed
and cost explorer shows up in us east
one i'm pretty sure if you click on
class explorer we'll just switch you
over to that region but just understand
that's where it lives okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and in this video i want to show you aws
cost explorer so what we'll do is go to
the top here and actually on the right
hand side we're going to click on the
right and go to my billing dashboard and
from there on the left hand side we're
going to look for cost explorer and then
click launch cost explorer and this is
where we're going to get to the aws cost
management dashboard where this is where
we find savings plans reservations
things like that on the left hand side
click on cost explorer and you can get
this nice chart and so the idea is you
can change it from monthly to daily if
you if you uh prefer
okay you can change the scope here maybe
we don't need six months we can just go
back
three months here so there's less data
it is a bit delayed when i'm clicking
here so it also could be just because
i'm doing the daily instead of monthly
so you just have to be a little bit
patient when uh using this interface
you can change it to stack line graph
you can kind of see the details there
it's not always clear like what others
is or things like that and so
uh you can drill down and there's like
ways of applying filters and things like
that
i always forget how to do this because
it's bringing everything in so you have
to hit clear all first i think
and
oh you have to click into it so like if
you wanted to click into it and pick a
particular service we could go here and
type in ec2
and say
ec2 instances
and then apply that filter so now we can
just see exactly that cost or if we want
to
choose like maybe just rds
okay
so
you know that could be useful for you to
see but yeah sometimes it's not always
clear and so what i recommend is just go
back to your billing dashboard
and from there just go to bills
okay bills is really really useful
because here it shows you exactly every
single little service that you're being
billed for you can expand it and see
exactly where if there you have other
accounts you can go into this side here
as well and find spend that way
but cost explorer is very useful just
it's useful in a different way okay so
there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at the database
pricing api so with adabs you can
programmatically access pricing
information to get the latest pricing
offerings for services this makes sense
because database can change them at any
time and so
you know you might want to know exactly
what the current price is there are two
versions of this api so we have the
query api known as the pricing service
api and you access this via json and
then there's the batch api also known as
the price
list api via html what's odd is that the
batch api returns json but you're
accessing it via html so
you can literally paste those links in
your browser for the query api you're
actually sending an an application json
request
so you'd have to use something like
postman or something uh you can also
subscribe to sns uh notifications to get
alerts when pricing for the services
change database prices change
periodically such as when aws cuts
prices when new instance types are
launched or when new services are
introduced so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i want to do here is show you
savings plans and savings plan is going
to be found under the it was cost
explorer so just type in cost explorer
at the top here or if you want you can
type in savings plan as well and once we
are here on the left hand side we are
going to have a savings plans option so
we're going to go to the overview
and here it just describes
what our savings plans if you want to
read through it but down below if you
have already some spend happening it's
going to make some suggestions and in
this particular account it's saying that
i could save some money on compute
before we take a look here i'm just
going to go to the form here and see
what we can see so up here we can say
commitment two three years by the way
you have compute savings which applies
to ec2 fargate or lambda then you have
the ec2 specific one where
uh we can select a very particular type
of instance family and then there's the
sagemaker savings plans um but if we go
here and we just enter in like two
dollars
all up front
i don't really understand it from here
because it doesn't make it clear what
the savings are
um but uh what it does make it very easy
is probably if we go over here and then
click down on the compute
so kind of feel like here would auto
fill it in for you and so here i filled
it in or sorry it's filled in for me and
so here it's saying with a one-year plan
all up front for based on the past 30
days
that it's going to see that i'm going to
see a monthly savings of 25 and 36 cents
and then i can add it to the cart that
way and i kind of feel like that is the
easiest way to
um figure that out where with um
with how it was going that form i just
couldn't figure it out myself what the
savings were
there are some utilization reports and
coverage reports honestly i've never
really looked at these before
um but uh i'm just curious like what
we're looking at monthly daily
the last
let's go a few months here i've been
running stuff in this account for a
while so there should be something
apply
so
nothing nothing of interest but um i
mean i guess you have a lot of use and
coverage report
utilization report could be interesting
but i imagine it's maybe you have to be
using you have to have a savings plan
before you can see this so that's
probably the reason why
um but yeah hopefully that gives you a
clear idea that you know you can just go
down to those recommendations and
and see exactly what you can save and
you just add it to your cart and then
once you want to pay for it you just
choose to submit that order and you're
all good to go
all right so that's savings plans
[Music]
let's take a look here at defense in
depth to understand the layers of
security aws has to consider uh for
their data centers for their uh virtual
workloads and things that you also have
to consider when you are
uh thinking about security for your
cloud resources
so in the most interior we have data so
this is access to business and customer
data and encryption to protect your data
then we have applications so
applications are secure and free of
security vulnerabilities then you have
compute so access to virtual machines
ports on premise and cloud you have the
network layers so this limits
communication between resources using
segmentation and access controls you
have the perimeter itself so distributed
denial of service protection to filter
large-scale attacks before they can
cause denial of service of users you
could say that's part of the network
layer and that's when i say there are
variants on this but we're just
separating it out
explicitly there we have identity and
access so controlling access to
infrastructure and change control and
then there's the physical layer so
limiting access to data centers to only
authorize personnel you'll notice i
highlighted identity and access in
yellow it's because that is considered
the new primary um
perimeter from the customer's
perspective of course ida best has
concern about the physical perimeter and
things like that but as a customer
that's what you're going to be thinking
about especially with the zero trust
model and when you see these depths the
idea is that in order to get here you
have to pass through all the stuff so if
this um
if this outward one is protected pretty
well then you generally don't have to
worry about the interiors but of course
you should um but yeah there you go
let's take a look here at
confidentiality integrity and
availability also known as the cia triad
is a model describing the foundation to
security principles and their trade-off
relationships so here is our triad so we
have confidentiality so confidentiality
is a component of privacy that
implements to protect our data from
unauthorized viewers and practice this
can be using cryptographic keys to
encrypt our data and using keys to
encrypt our keys so envelope encryption
then we have integrity so maintaining
and ensuring the accuracy and
completeness of data over its entire
lifecycle and practice utilizing
acid-compliant databases for valid
transactions utilizing tamper evident or
tamper proof hardware security modules
hsms availability so information needs
to be available when needed in practice
so high availability mitigating ddos
decryption access so the cia triad was
first mentioned in this publication in
1977 there have been efforts to expand
and modernize or suggest alternatives
the cia triad so one was in 1998 for the
six atomic elements of information uh or
in 2004 we have the engineering
principles for uh for information
technology security so it has 33
security principles but this is still a
very popular um
model for security uh and it's just to
kind of tell you like you know you don't
always get everything you don't get all
three of them sometimes you have to
trade off in your scenario um you know
and hopefully some of the terminology
here will resonate as we go through more
security content
[Music]
what i want to do here is just to find
the term vulnerability so a
vulnerability is a whole or weakness in
an application which can be designed a
design flaw or implementation bug that
allows an attacker to cause harm to
stakeholders or applications and uh
there's a lot of great definitions of
vulnerabilities but owasp has a ton of
them and we talked about oats when we
talk about abuse waff but it's an
organization that creates security
projects that help you know what you
should protect uh or gives you a working
example so that you can understand how
to get better at security and so they
have a lot of ones here but maybe you
might notice some here like using a
broken or risky cryptographic algorithm
maybe there's a memory leak least
privileged violation so that's um uh
least privilege is something that is a
thing that you're always worried about
in security improper data validation
buffer overflows so you know just to
kind of set the tone of what a
vulnerability is and things you should
be thinking about okay
[Music]
let's understand what encryption is but
before we do we need to understand what
is cryptography so this is the practice
and study of techniques for secure
communication in the presence of third
parties called adversaries and
encryption is the process of encoding or
scrambling information using a key and a
cipher to store sensitive data in an
unintelligible format as a means of
protection
an encryption takes in plain text and
produces produces a cipher text so
here's an example of a very old
encryption machine this is the enigma
machine used during world war ii
and it has a different key for each day
that it was used to set the position of
the rotors and it relied on simple
cipher substitution
and so you might be asking what is a
cipher and that's what we're going to
look at next
[Music]
so what is a cipher it is an algorithm
that performs encryption or decryption
so cipher is synonymous with code
and the idea is that you use the code to
either unlock or or lock up the
information that you have so what is a
ciphertext a ciphertext is the result of
encryption performed on plain text via
an algorithm so you lock that up you
scramble it it doesn't make sense and
you need that code to unlock it to get
the information so a good practical
example back in the day was a code book
and this was the type of document used
for gathering and storing cryptographic
codes or ciphers so the idea is if we
zoomed up on here notice where we have
cannot so
and it would be zero zero and then there
would be give them authority so the idea
is
zero zero
or if you had the word cannot it would
translate to zero zero and then you use
zero zero to match that up to say what
does that actually mean and so that is
kind of a very practical example of
ciphers in action
so we just took a look at encryption but
what are cryptographic keys so a a
cryptographic key an easy way to think
of it is a variable used in conjunction
with an encryption algorithm in order to
encrypt or decrypt data
and there are different kinds of um ones
we have so we have symmetric encryption
so this is where we have the same key
that is used for encoding and decoding
and a very popular one and the one
you'll see on aws is called advanced
encryption standard aes so just take a
look at that graphic very closely so we
have one key
and it is used to encrypt so it produces
the cipher and then or cipher text we
should say and then it will decrypt and
we will get our plain text so one single
key
then we have asymmetric encryption so
two keys are used one in code and one to
decode and a very popular one here is
rsa
if you're wondering what those those
words are it's three people's names put
together who helped
invent this type of algorithm and so
here we have
one key for encrypt and one key for
decrypt and there are two different keys
all right
[Music]
all right let's look at the concept of
hashing and salting so for hashing we
have a hashing function and this accepts
arbitrary size values and maps it to a
fixed size data structure hashing can
reduce the size of a store value and
hashing is a one-way process and is
deterministic so a deterministic
function always returns the same output
output for the same input so if we have
something like john smith and we pass it
to the hash function it's going to
create something that is not human
readable but it'll say something like
zero two f a e x x y whatever um and it
will always produce the same thing if
the same key or you know value is being
inputted there so the reason we use
hashing functions or hash in general is
to hash passwords so hash functions are
used to store passwords in a database so
that the password does not reside in a
plain text format so you've heard about
all these data breaches where they've
stored the password in plain text this
is the thing that helps us avoid that
issue
and the thing again is because it's one
way you can't take that hash and unhash
it
well there are some conditions to it but
so to authenticate a user when a user
inputs their password it is then hashed
so the one that was inputted at the time
of you know login and then that hash is
compared to the stored hash in the
database and if they match the user is
successfully logged in so in that case
we never ever had to know what the
original password looked like uh popular
hashing functions are md5 sha-256 or
bcrypt
if an attacker knows the function you
are using
and
and stole your database they could
enumerate a dictionary of passwords to
determine the password so they'll never
see it but they could just keep on going
through that so that's why we salt our
passwords so a salt is a random string
not known to the attacker that the hash
function accepts to mitigate the
deterministic nature of a hashing
function so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at digital
signatures and signing so what is a
digital signature is a mathematical
scheme for verifying the authenticity of
digital messages or documents and a
digital signature gives us tamper
evidence so did someone mess or modify
the data is this data from someone we
did not expect it to be is it from the
actual sender and so we kind of have
this diagram where we have a person who
sends or is going to send a message so
they sign it and then uh bob verifies
that it was for the person who it's from
so there are three algorithms to a
digital signature the key generation so
generates a public and private key
then there is signing the process of
generating a digital signature with a
private key and the inputted value so
signing which is what is happening up
here signing verification verifies the
authenticity of the message with a
public key so remember the private key
is used for signing and the public key
is used for verifying
ssh uses a public and private key to
authorize remote access into a remote
machine such as a virtual machine it is
common to use rsa and we saw that rsa is
a type of algorithm earlier
and so ssh hyphen keygen is a well-known
command to generate a public and private
key on linux i know this one off the top
of my head i always know to do this
and so what is code signing so when you
use a digital signature to ensure
computer code has not been tampered
and so that's just a like subset of
digital signaturing so you can use this
as a means to get into a virtual machine
or you can use signing as a means to
make sure that the code being committed
to your repository is who you expect it
to be from so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about in transit versus at
rest encryption so encryption transit
this is data that is secure when moving
between locations and the algorithms
here are tls and ssl then you have
encryption at rest so this is data that
is secure when residing on storage or
within a database so we're looking at
aes or rsa which we both covered
previously these algorithms so ones that
we did not cover was tls and ssl so
we'll cover them now so tls transport
layer security is an encryption protocol
for data integrity between two or more
communic communicating computer
applications so 1.0 and 1.1 are no
longer used but tls 1.2 and 1.3 is the
current best practice then we have ssl
secure socket layers so an encrypted
protocol for date integrity between two
or more communicating uh computer
applications so
1.0 2.0 and 3.0 are deprecated um and
honestly i always get these two mixed up
and i always figure uh
get confused which is being used but um
you know they're always changing on us
but just understand generally what these
concepts are and that you're familiar
with the terms okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at common
compliance programs so these are a set
of internal policies and procedures for
a company to comply with laws rules and
regulations or to uphold business
reputation so here we have a bunch of
different compliance programs and so
some popular ones are like hipaa or
pci dss the question is should you know
these yes you should generally know the
most popular ones because you're going
to see them throughout your cloud career
and so just getting familiar now is a
good time so let's jump into it okay so
the first one i want to introduce you to
is for ia iso and they have a bunch of
different ones so iso is the
international organization of
standardization and their other one
called iec which is the international
electro technical commission one deals
with uh you know like uh virtual things
the other one deals with hardware things
but they have a lot of overlapping
compliance programs okay
and so the most popular absolutely most
popular one that i know of is the 270100
i know a lot of organizations that are
going for their 2701 so this is for
control implementation guidance you have
the 27017
this is enhanced focus on cloud security
the 27018 this is protection of personal
data in the cloud then you have the
27701 this is privacy information
management system so pims framework this
outlines controls and processes to
manage data privacy and protect pii so
that's personally identifiable
information then you have system and
organization control sock and this is a
very popular thing that organizations go
for especially the sock too so sock one
is 18 standards and report on the
effectiveness of internal controls at
the service organization relevant to the
client's internal control over financial
reporting we have stock 2 evaluates
internal controls policies and
procedures that directly relate to the
security of the system at a service
organization and stock 3 a report based
on the trust
service services criteria that can be
freely distributed
then we have pci dss a set of security
standards designed to ensure that all
companies that accept process store and
transmit credit card information
maintains in a secure
environment we have a federal
information procedure standards or fips
so 140 hyphen 2. this is u.s and
canadian government standard that
specifies the security requirements for
cryptographic modules that protect
sensitive information then we have a ph
ipa this is more relevant to me because
i'm actually in ontario and canada but
it's also very
well known
one out there outside of hipaa so this
regulates patient protected health
information then you actually have hipaa
this is the u.s federal law that
regulates patient procedure health
information then we have a cloud
security alliance so csa star
certification independent third-party
assessment of a cloud provider's
security posture if you never heard of
csa they have a very uh well-known
fundamental uh security certification
called the cssk or ccsk i always get
that mixed up then we have
fedramp which we covered earlier in this
course or in the future depending on
where we put it but fedramp stands for
federal risk and authorization
management program it's a us government
standardization approach to security
authorizations for cloud service
offerings if you want to work with the
u.s
government or places that sell the us
government you need fed ramp that
similar to criminal justice information
services any u.s state or local agency
that wants to access the fbi's cgis
database is required to adhere to the
cgis security policy
then we have gdpr
the general data protection regulation
everyone knows what this is in europe
maybe not so much in north america or
other places a european privacy law
imposes new rules on companies
governments agencies nonprofits and
other organizations that offer goods and
services to people in the european union
or that collect analyze data try tied to
eu's residents there's a lot of
compliance programs out there one that's
also very popular is fips but we'll get
to that when we talk about kms
but yeah there you go
[Music]
so i just wanted to quickly show you
here the aws compliance programs page
where they list out all the types of
compliance programs that aws is uh
working with and that it has different
types of certification and attestments
which we can use it was artifact or
amazon artifact whichever
prefix they decide to use for the name
there to
ensure that it was has in order to meet
those regulatory compliance so you can
see them all there and if you want to
know a little bit more about any of
these you just go ahead and click them
and you can read and they have
additional information so you have a
better idea okay
[Music]
let's talk about pen testing so pen
testing is an authorized simulated cyber
attack on a computer system performed to
evaluate the security of the system and
on aws you are allowed to perform
uh pen testing but there are some
restrictions so permitted services or
ec2 instances nat gateways elbs rds so
that's relational database service
cloudfront aurora api gateways lambda
lambda edge functions light cell
resources elastic bean stock
environments things you cannot do or you
should not be doing
is dns zone walking via rough d3 hosted
zones
then there's ddos simulation testing so
you should not be doing ddot or dos
ddoses
or simulated dos or simulated ddos is
okay and that doesn't mean that you
can't necessarily do them uh again
there's a lot of exceptions to the pen
testing they have a whole page on this
but generally you're not allowed to do
ddosing
port flooding protocol flooding request
flooding can't do any of those things
for other simulated events you need to
submit a request to a bus a reply could
take up to seven days you know again
there's a lot of
little intricacies here so you'd have to
really read up on it if you're
interested in doing this okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at pen testing
on the aws platform so they have this
page here that tells you what you're
allowed to do what you're not allowed to
do
um and there's some additional things
you can read into like the stress test
policy the ddos simulate simulation
testing policy which i didn't cover in
detail
in the course content but for whatever
reason you're interested in it i just
want you to be aware of that kind of
stuff if you want to simulate events
there is a simulate events form that you
have to fill out so yeah open it up and
you can kind of read about it and it
gives it eight of us a heads up of what
you're going to be doing stress test
fishing malware analysis other so that
way that if you are doing it you're not
going to get in trouble they're aware of
what you are doing okay so that's pretty
much it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at ibis
artifact which is a self-serve portal
for on-demand access to itabus
compliance reports so here's an example
of a bunch of different compliance
reports that aws could be meeting and
the idea is that when you go to this
portal within the database management
console you'll have a huge list of
reports that you can go and access so
here i'm searching for canada to get the
government of canada partner package and
then i go ahead and i download that
report as a pdf and then within the pdf
we can click a link to get the
downloadable excel and that's pretty
much what it is it's just if you want to
see that databus is being compliant for
different programs
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at
adobe's artifacts so at the top here
we're going to type in artifact
and not to be confused with code
artifact which i guess is a new service
there's just always releasing new
services eh
and so here we have a video and some
things but it's not too hard all we got
to do is go to view reports
and from here we have all the types of
compliance programs or regulatory
compliance programs that aws is meeting
and we can do is search for something so
we type in canada
and that's the government of canada
partner package and i can go ahead and
download that report so when you
download it you really want to open this
up in
um you're going to really want to open
this up in
adobe acrobat because if you don't open
it up in adobe acrobat you're not going
to be able to access the downloadables
within it i know that's kind of odd to
say but that's just what it is you do
have to install adobe acrobat reader and
once you have it open
and i'm just moving it over here this is
what you're going to see and
it's going to say like hey um oops
no i don't want to do that so please
scroll to the next page to view the
artifact download and so i think that
if we go here
you know they say scroll to the next
page but i'm pretty sure we can just go
here on the left hand side and this is
what we're looking for that excel
spreadsheet so we're going to save that
attachment
or actually we just can open it up
open this file
okay and we'll give it a moment i have
excel installed
and there we go
there it is okay so i know it's a little
bit odd way to get to those um
certificates or reports but that's just
how it works um but yeah i mean that's
the idea is like if you need to prove
that database is meeting whatever those
standards are you can just type them in
whatever it is i mean like maybe there's
like fedramp right whatever it is and
download those certificate attestments
whatever um and just double check that
aws is meeting those standards okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at abs
inspector but before we can answer what
it does let's talk about hardening so
hardening is the act of eliminating as
many security risks as possible
hardening is common for virtual machines
where you run a collection of certain
security checks known as a security
benchmark so aws inspector runs a
security benchmark against specific ec2
instances and you can run a variety of
security benchmarks and you can perform
network and host assessments and so
here's an example of those two check
boxes there which you'd say which
assessments you want to do so the idea
is you have to install the adobe station
on your ec2 instance you run an
assessment for your assessment target
you review your findings and remediate
security issues and one very popular
benchmark you can run is the cis which
has
699 checks so if you don't know what cis
it stands for the center of internet
security uh and so they are this
organization that has a bunch of um
uh security controls or check marks uh
that are published that they suggest
that you should check on your machine
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at ddos so ddos is a
type of malicious attack to disrupt
normal traffic by flooding a website
with a large amount of fake traffic so
the idea is we have an attacker and the
victim the victim is us and it could be
our virtual machines our cloud services
the idea is that it's some kind of
resource which
can take in uh incoming requests over
the internet so the idea is the attacker
is utilizing the internet and so they
may control a bunch of virtual machines
or servers they're loaded up with
malicious software and the idea is that
the attacker is going to tell them all
to send a flood of traffic over the
internet
at your computing resource and this is
where your website is going to either
start to stall or it's going to become
unavailable for your users and so the
idea here is that you know if you want
to protect against cdos you need some
kind of ddos protection traditionally
those used to be like third-party
services that you uh would have to pay
for and the and it would sit in front of
your load bouncer or your n server but
now the great thing with cloud service
providers is that generally their
networks have built-in ddos protection
so the idea is just by having your
compute or your resources on aws you're
going to get
built-in protection for free via aws
shield and we'll talk about that next
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at it with
shield which is a managed ddos
protection service that safeguards
applications running on aws so when you
route your traffic through refu3 or
cloudfront you are using it with shield
standard so here's a diagram to kind of
show you that it's not just those
services but these are the most common
ones where you'll have a point of entry
into aws
so here we could also be including
elastic ip it was global accelerator but
the idea is that when you go through
these services into the airbus network
it has shield built in and so you're
going to get that protection before
those
uh before that traffic reaches your
cloud services and in this case we're
showing uh ec2 instances so it was
shield protects against layers three
four and seven attacks
uh layer three four
and seven is based off the osi model
which is a um a fundamental networking
concept so
seven is for the application layer four
is the transport layer three is the
network layer
um there are two different types of
plans ready with shield we have shield
standard which is free
and then shield advance which starts at
3000 usd per year plus some additional
costs based on usage of the size of the
attack or what services you're using how
much traffic is moving in and out
so protection against the most common
ddos attacks is what shield standard
does
you have access to tools and best
practices to build ddos brazilian
architecture it's automatically
available on all above services
for additional protection against larger
and more sophisticated attacks that's
where she'll advance comes into play
it's available for specific database
services so refugee 3 cloud front elb
able global accelerator elastic ip
and some notable features here is
visibility reporting on layer three four
and seven you're only going to get seven
if you are using it will swap with it uh
you have access to team and support so
these are ddos experts but you're only
gonna get it if you're paying for
business or enterprise support as you're
paying for this as well uh you also get
ddos cost protection just to ensure that
you know your bills don't go crazy
and it comes with an sla so you have a
guarantee that it's going to work
both plans integrate with aws web
application firewall so waff to give you
that layer 7 application protection so
understand that if you're not using waff
you're not going to be having that layer
7 production okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at amazon guard duty
so before we look at that we need to
understand what is an ids ips
so an intrusion detection system and
intrusion protection system is used as a
device or software application that
monitors a network or systems for
malicious activity or policy violations
so guard duty is a threat detection
service which is ids ips that
continuously monitors for malicious and
suspicious activity and unauthorized
behavior it uses machine learning to
analyze the following database logs your
cloud trail logs your vpc flow logs your
dns logs and what it will do is report
back to you and say hey um there's this
issue here and this is actually one
that's very easy to replicate it's just
saying somebody is using the root
credentials and it's suggesting that you
should not be doing that right because
you're never supposed to be invoking api
calls with the root credentials or you
should be limiting that
you might also notice that if you want
to investigate you can kind of follow up
that with uh amazon detective or aws
detective which
ever
prefix they decided to put on that
service it will alert you of findings
which you can automate an incident
response via cloudwatch events which
this uh it's been renamed to eventbridge
as you know or third party services so
you can
follow up a remediation action
and here is a graphic of amazon guard
duty just a bit up closer so you can see
all the findings and you can just see
you have a lot of detailed information
there okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at guard
duty so guard duty is
an intrusion protection and detection
service and so what i've done is i've
done some bad practices purposely so
that i can show you some information in
there so i'm gonna go over to guard duty
okay and you do have to turn guard duty
on and so once scar duty is on you're
going to start getting reports coming in
so notice here that we have some
anomalous behavior eight days ago and so
uh that's bako he's my co-founder he's
also named andrew as well and so we can
kind of see some details here about
who's accessing what and what they were
doing he's not doing anything malicious
but we can have an idea where they're
from even shows uh generally where he is
which he is near thunder bay and his his
provider would be tbaytel
um and you can see that he is making uh
api calls the scribe account attributes
and things like that then the other
issue is the root account so there's mfa
i turned it off so that we can or maybe
it's just usage here i actually do have
it turned on i suppose but here we see
root credential usage and so it's saying
hey you used it 77 times because
sometimes i go in and and use the ruby
account for tutorials but saying you're
using this way too much you've got to
stop doing that okay so that's something
that is uh pretty interesting with guard
duty and it's really cost effective and
easy to turn on so you can turn it on
looks like they have a new thing for s3
have not looked at that as of yet but
that's kind of cool kind of feels like
that would overlap with amazon macy but
whatever and here we get a breakdown of
cost so we see cloudtrail vpc full logs
dns logs and this is where it would be
ingesting data if you want to use that
s3 protection you'd have to probably be
turning or creating a custom cloud watch
trail that has data events to consume
that information um
you know so you know hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea of things you
can do and you can also centralize guard
duty into one account so you can have
one thing that takes care of everything
and move all the data across all your
accounts into a single place
so that's kind of interesting and you
can set up follow follow-ups um it's
possible that
i don't see this
this here but generally it would show
you
uh it would show you a way of like
triggering into cloud watch probably
could do it pragmatically this is
something interesting like the list
management you can add trusted ips or
threat list so if there's people that
you know are fine you can just white
list them or if there's people that you
know that are bad make sure that they
are never allowed to get through so
that's pretty much it with guard duty
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at amazon macy so
macy is a fully managed service that
continuously monitors s3 data access
activity for anomalies and generates
detailed alerts when it detects risks of
unauthorized access or inadvertent data
leaks so macy works by using machine
learning to analyze your cloudtrail logs
and macy has a variety of alerts so we
have anomalized access config compliance
credential loss data compliance file
hosting identity enumeration information
loss
location anomaly open permissions
privilege escalation ransomware service
disruption suspicious access and mac
will identify your most at-risk users
which could lead to compromise so here's
just one little kind of tidbit from the
app itself where
you have the total users and they
categorize them into different uh risks
i can't remember which flag means what
in here
uh amazon macy is an okay service
it's very important if you're storing
things in s3
but i don't i don't use it very often to
be honest
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at aws virtual
private network also known as vpn so aws
vpn lets you establish a secure
and private tunnel from your network or
device to the aws global network it's
very important to emphasize the word
secure here
because when you're using direct connect
that will establish a private connection
but it's not using any kind of protocol
to secure that data in transit whereas
database vpn will be using a secure
protocol there are two options here we
have abyss site to site vpn so securely
connect on-premise network or branch
office site to vpc
and it was client vpn so securely
connect users to aws or on-premises
networks
one thing that we need to understand
alongside vpns is ipsec
this stands for internet protocol
security and is a secure network
protocol suite that authenticates and
encrypts the packets of data to provide
secure encrypted communication
between two computers over an internet
protocol network and it is used in vpns
and it was definitely uses it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at aba's web
application firewall also known as waff
which protects you
protects your web application from
common web exploits so the idea here is
you write your own rules to allow or
deny traffic based on the contents of an
http requests you use a rule set from a
trusted image security partner in the
abyss waff rule marketplace
waft can be attached to either
cloudfront or an application load
balancer so here is that diagram the
idea is you see cloudfront with the waf
or alb with the laugh
and what it does is it can protect uh
web applications from attacks covered
and the owasp10
uh top 10 most dangerous attacks if you
don't know owas they're the open web
application security project and they
basically have all these security
projects which are things to say hey
these are things that you should
commonly protect against or they might
have like example applications that
serve as a means to learn security so we
look at the top 10 it's injection broken
authentication sensitive data exposure
xml external entities so xxe broken
access control security
misconfigurations cross-site scripting
so xss
insecure deserialization using
components with known vulnerabilities
and insufficient logging and monitoring
so there you go
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a quick look at
adabus web application firewall also
known as waff and so in this account i
happen to have a waf running
so we don't have to create one we
already have something we can take a
look here so i'm going to go to waff and
shield and then on the left hand side
you'll notice it's a global service but
on the left hand side we're going to be
looking for our web acls and so the idea
is that when you want to waff you create
a web acl and then when then within that
web acl you have uh the overview and
then you have you can kind of show you
kind of the traffic that's going on here
we can have our rules and so there's a
lot of different kind of managed rule
groups that you can use so these are
ones that are provided by aws so
and a lot of these some of these can be
paid some of these are free so you see
there's these free rule groups where
you're like hey
i don't want any anonymous ips you
checkbox that on you know or i want to
protect against sql injection now the
interesting thing is that abyss has this
capacity unit so
you can't add all of these you can add a
certain amount of capacity before you
have to
uh pay for more or something like that
it's just kind of a way to
um
uh kind of cap the amount of stuff that
you can put in in terms of rules um but
there's a lot of other um rule groups
from third party services like security
companies that know what they're doing
so if you like fortinet's os top 10 you
can subscribe to that in the marketplace
and be able to use it
but uh yeah so that's how you apply
rules
there's something called bot control
i've never used this before get
real-time visibility into bot activity
on your resource and controllers what
bots allow and block from your resources
that sounds really cool i cannot stand
bots so i might turn that on myself or
take a look at the cost there and see
what we can find out but that's pretty
much it with waff
one thing i would say is that you can
block out specific ip addresses or white
list specific ip addresses
and you might do that through rules i'm
just going to see yeah like maybe the
bypass here
and so these ip addresses are some of
our um
cloud support engineers where they're
using our mid panel and um
waff is being too aggressive in terms of
protection and so sometimes you have to
say hey allow this ip address and let my
um
you know let my cloud
support engineer be able to use the mid
panel because they're not malicious okay
so that's one little exception there but
that's pretty much it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at hardware
security modules also known as hsm and
it's a piece of hardware designed to
store encryption keys and it holds keys
in memory and never writes on the disk
so the idea is that if the hsm was shut
down that key would be gone and that
would be a guarantee of protection
because nobody could you know take the
drive and steal it so here is an example
of an hsm these are extremely expensive
so you definitely don't want to have to
buy them yourselves uh they generally
follow fips so fips is the federal
information processing standard so it's
a u.s and canadian government standard
that specifies the security requirements
for cryptographic modules that protect
sensitive information fips is something
you want to definitely remember
and there are two
different
protocols here there's actually a bunch
of different fips versions but we have
fips
142 level 2 and then fips 143 level 3 so
let's talk about the difference here so
hsms that are multi-tenant are going to
be using fips 142 hyphen 2 level 2
compliant
where you have multiple customers
virtually isolated on the hsm
and then there are hsms that are single
tenant and so they're going to be
utilizing fips 140 hyphen 2 level 3
compliant so a single customer on a
dedicated hsm
and so the reason why we have these two
levels is that when you have multiple
tenants you can say oh right this thing
is uh has temper evidence so we can see
that somebody was trying to break into
it but there's no guarantee of tamp it
being tamper proof where level three is
tamper proof there's also fips 140
hyphen 3 which is the new
uh the newer
standard but not all cloud resources can
meet that standard just because of how
they offer the service
so
again fips 142 is really good but just
understand that there are other ones out
there and it's very easy to get fips 142
level 3 mixed up with pips 140 iphone 3
something that i always had
a hard time remembering the
distinguishing between those two so for
multi-tenant this is where we're using
adabus key management service and for
single tenant we're using aws cloud hsm
and the only time you're really using
cloud hsm is if you're a large
enterprise and you need that regulatory
compliance of getting fips 140 heaven to
level three okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at key
management service also known as kms and
it is a managed service that makes it
easy for you to create and control the
encryption keys you use to encrypt your
data so kms is a multi-tenant hsm so
it's a hardware security module
and many aws services are integrated to
use kms to encrypt your data with a
simple checkbox and kms uses envelope
encryption so here's that example of a
simple checkbox in this case it's for
rds and what you'll do is choose a
master key a lot of times aws will have
a default
key for you that's managed by them that
is free to use which is really great
so for kms it's using envelope
encryption so when you encrypt your data
your data is protected but you have to
protect your encryption key when you
encrypt your data key with a master key
as an additional layer security so
that's how it works so just to make this
really clear i have my data i use this
key to encrypt this data and now i need
to protect this key so i use another key
to encrypt
this key which
forms an envelope and then i store this
master key in kms and this one's
considered the data key all right
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look at key
management service also known as kms so
type in kms on the top here
and we'll pop over here and kms is a way
for you to create your own keys or you
can use abyss manage keys so up here and
not all these appear right away but as
you use services um you will itamas will
generate out manage keys for you and
these are free
you can create your own keys um and
these cost a dollar each so if i go
ahead here and create a key i can choose
whether it's symmetric or asymmetric
which we definitely learned in the
course which is nice for asymmetric you
can make it encrypt and decrypt sign and
verify and they're just kind of
narrowing down the type of key you would
use
for this you know if i went to symmetric
i go here
i'm just kind of seeing if i can enter
the actual material into the key here
so i'm just going to keep clicking
through here my custom key
generally you don't really need to do
this but you know if it's interesting
you can set up administrators to say
who's allowed to administer the key and
then you have someone that
is allowed to use the key and you
usually want to keep those two accounts
separate you don't want the same person
administrating and using the key
okay keep those two separate and so we
would have a key policy so you can
change this to say the rules that is
allowed to use
and then we can go here and hit finish
and so there we now have our own custom
key
and
one thing we can do
is it's possible to rotate out these
keys when you need to be
um but anyway
when we use kms it's built into
basically everything and we've seen it
multiple times throughout this course
when we've gone over to ec2 we'll just
go take a peek at a few different places
here
so when we've gone to go launch an ec2
instance and we go over to storage so we
say select
and review
or next
and we go over to storage notice that
here this is using encryption right so i
can choose that or even my custom key if
you're in dynamodb or anywhere else it's
always something like a checkbox and you
choose your key so that's pretty much
all there really is to kms it's very
easy to use and there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are going to take a look here at
cloud hsm it is a single tenant
hsm as a service that automates hardware
provisioning software patching high
availability and backups so here's the
idea is that you have your aws cloud hsm
you have your developers interacting
with it your application interacting
with it you have an hsm client installed
in your ec2 instance so that it can
access uh the cloud hsm keys
so aws cloud hsm enables you to generate
and use your encryption keys on fips 140
hyphen 2 level 3 validated hardware it's
built on open hsm industry standards to
integrate with things like pk
cs 11 java cryptography extension so jce
microsoft crypto and g libraries you can
transfer your keys to other commercial
commercials hsm solutions to make it
easy for you to migrate keys on or off
aws configure aws kms to use aws cloud
hsm
cluster as a custom
key store rather than the default kms
keystore uh so cloud hsm is
way more expensive than kms kms is like
free or a dollar per key where cloud hsm
is a fixed cost
per month because you are getting a
dedicated piece of hardware
um and there's not a lot of stuff around
it so other than the aws kms integration
a lot of times it can be really hard to
use this as well so the only time you're
really going to be using cloud hsm is if
you're an enterprise and you need to
meet
fips 140 hyphen 2 level 3 compliancy
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at know your
initialism so a lot of aws services and
concepts and cloud technologies use
initialisms to just kind of shorten uh
common things that we need to use on a
frequent basis and it's going to really
help if you learn these because then
what you can do is substitute them when
you are
seeing a service name or something
particular and that's going to get you
through content a lot faster and in the
wild you're going to see these all over
the place because people aren't going to
say the full name they're going to say
the initialism so let's go through them
so for iam it's identity and access
management for s3 that's simple storage
for swfs it's uh swf that's simple
workflow service sns is simple
notification service sqs is simple queue
service scs a simple email service ssm
is simple systems manager but uh you
know when we see the name it's usually
just systems manager but we still use
the uh initialism ssm then there's rds
relational database service vpc virtual
private cloud vpn virtual private
network cfn cloud formation waf web
application firewall and that is a very
common initialism uh not just databus
but outside of it as well mq for amazon
active mq asg for auto scaling groups
tam for technical account manager elb
for elastic load balancer alb for the
application load balancer nlb for the
network load balancer gwlb for the
gateway load balancer clb for the
classic load balancer ec2 for elastic
cloud or cloud compute ecs for elastic
container service ecr for elastic
container repository ebs for elastic
block storage emr for elastic mapreduce
efs for elastic file store ebs or eb for
elastic beanstalk es for elasticsearch
eks for elastic kubernetes service
msk for managed kafka service and if you
think i got the s and k backwards i did
not for whatever reason it's msk
uh then uh there's resource manager
which is known as ram acm for amazon
certificate manager popl for principle
of lease privilege which is a concept
not a service iot internet of things
this is not a service but is a tech
concept or cloud concept ri for reserved
instances and i'm sure there are more
but these are the ones that i know off
the top my head uh and they're in my
usual use case uh for what i'm doing day
to day but a lot of times you'll
probably just end up needing to remember
asg elb
um ec2 s3 things like that okay
[Music]
all right let's compare aws config and
app config which both have configured
the name but there are two completely
different services so aws config and app
config so abs config is a governance
tool for compliance as code you can
create rules that will check to see if
resources are configured the way you
expect them to be if a resource drifts
from the expected configuration you are
notified or aws config can auto
remediate correct the configuration back
to the expected state for app config it
is used to automate the process of
deploying application configuration
variable changes to your web application
you can write a validator to ensure uh
the changed variable will not break your
web app you can monitor deployments on
automate integrations to catch errors or
rollbacks so config is for compliance
governance app config is for uh config
application configure configuration
variables so there you go
[Music]
well let us take a look at sns versus
sqs and these things have something in
common and it's they both connect apps
via messages
uh so they're for application
integration so let's take a look at sns
so simple notification service and then
simple queue service okay so sns is
intended to pass along messages via a
pub sub model whereas sqs queues up
messages and has a guaranteed delivery
so the idea with sns you send
notifications to subscribers of topics
via multiple protocols so it could be
http email sqs sms and sns is generally
used for sending plain text emails which
is triggered via other services the best
example here is building alarms i know
we mentioned this but i like to repeat
it so that you absolutely know
it can retry sending in the case of
failures of https so it does have a
retry attempt but that doesn't mean
there's a guarantee of delivery it's
really good for web hooks simple
internal emails triggering lambda
functions if you had to compare these to
third-party services it's similar to
pusher or
pub nub so sqs is uh the idea here is
that messages are placed into a queue
applications pull the queue using the
itabus sdk you can
retain a message for up to 14 days you
can send them in sequential order a
sequential order or in parallel you can
ensure only one message is sent you can
ensure messages are delivered at least
once it's really good for delayed tasks
queuing up emails um comparable uh stuff
would be something like rabbit mq or
uh ruby on rails sidekick okay
[Music]
hey this is danny brown from exam pro
and we're doing variation study with sns
versus ses versus pinpoint versus work
mail and so sns and scs get confused
quite often but all of these services uh
have something common they all send
emails but
the utility of email is completely
different for each one so the first one
is simple notification service is for
practical and internal emails so you
send notifications to subscribers of
topics via multiple protocols so it's
not just for email it can handle http it
can send to sqs it can send sns or sms
messages so um messages to your phone
but it does send emails and so sns is
generally used for sending plain text
emails which is triggered via other aws
services the best example of this is a
building alarm so most exam questions
are going to be talking about sns
because lots of services can trigger
sns for notifications and so that's the
idea it's like oh um you know
did somebody spin up a server send off
an email via sns uh did we spend too
much money here you know all sorts of
things can go through sns to send out
emails and you need to know what are
topics and subscriptions regarding sns
then you have ses so simple email
service and this is for transactional
emails and
when i say transaction emails i'm
talking about emails that should be
triggered based on in-app action so sign
up reset password invoices
so a cloud-based email service that is
similar to this would be like send grid
scs sends html emails
sns cannot so that is the distinction is
that scs can do html and plain text but
sns just does plain text and you would
not use sns for transactional emails sas
can receive inbound emails
scs can create email templates custom
domain name emails so when you use sns
it's whatever amazon gives you it's
going to be some weird address but ses
is whatever custom domain you want you
can also monitor email reputation for
scs
then you have amazon pinpoint and so
this is for promotional emails so these
uh when we say promotional we're talking
about emails for marketing so you can
create email campaigns you can segment
your contacts you can create customer
journeys via emails um it can do a to b
email testing and so scs and pinpoint
get mixed up because a lot of people
think well can i just use my transaction
emails for promotion emails absolutely
you can it's not recommended because um
you know pinpoint has a lot more
functionality around promotional emails
they're built differently
and so you know just understand that
those two have overlapping
responsibilities but generally you
should use them for what they're for
then you have amazon workmail and this
is just an email web client so it's
similar to gmail or outlook you can
create company emails read write and
send emails from a web client within the
database management console so there you
go
[Music]
let us compare amazon inspector versus
adabus trusted advisor so both of these
are security tools and they both perform
audits but what they do is slightly
different so amazon inspector audits a
single ec2 instance that you've selected
or i suppose you could select multiple
ec2s it generates a report from a long
list of security checks um and so
trusted advisor has checks but uh the
the key difference here is that it
doesn't generate out a pdf report though
i'm sure you could export csv data if
you wanted to and then turn that into a
report
it gives you a holistic view of
recommendations across multiple services
and best practices so for example if you
have an open port on the security groups
that can tell you about about that you
should enable mfa on your root account
when using trusted advisor things like
that
one thing though is that trust advisor
isn't just for security does checks
across um
five different things
but they both use security and they both
technically do checks okay
[Music]
so there are a few services that have
connected the name you'd think they'd be
related in some way but they absolutely
are not and they don't even have similar
functionality but let's take a look here
so we know the difference the first is
direct connect it is a dedicated fiber
optics connection from your data center
to aws it's intended for large
enterprises with their own data center
and they need an insanely fast and
private connection directly
to aws and you'll notice they give
private and emphasis because if you need
a secure connection you need to apply a
database virtual private network
connection on top of direct connect then
you have amazon connect this is a call
center as a service get a toll-free
number accept inbound and outbound calls
set up automated phone systems uh so if
you ever heard of an interactive voice
system at ibs this is basically what
amazon connect is you have media connect
this is the new version of elastic
transcoder it converts videos to
different video types so if you have
let's say a thousand videos you need to
transcode them into different video
formats maybe you need to apply
watermarks insert introduction videos in
front of each one this is what you use
media connect for okay
[Music]
just in case you see elastic transcoder
as an option i just want you to know
what it is compared to media connect so
both these services are used for
transcoding and technically elastic
transcoder is the old way and it was
elemental media convert or just media
convert is the new way so elastic
transcoder was the original transcoding
service it may still have chromatic apis
or workflows not available in media
convert so this could be reasons why we
see legacy customers still using it or
you know it's just too much effort for
them to
upgrade to the new one it transcodes
videos to streaming formats
media convert is more robust transcoding
service that can perform various
operations during transcoding so it also
translates videos to streaming different
streaming formats but it overlays images
it inserts video clips extracts captions
data it has a robust ui so generally
it's recommended to use the uh media
convert in terms of costs they're
basically the same so there's no reason
not to use media convert okay
[Music]
so it was artifact versus amazon
inspector get commonly mixed up all the
time but both
artifact inspector compiler pdf reports
so that's where the confusion comes from
but let's talk about what is different
about the reports so abus artifact
enables inspector so for artifact you're
answering why should an enterprise trust
aws it generates a security report
that's based on global compliance
frameworks such as sock or pci or a
variety of others where amazon inspector
is all about how do we know the cc2
instance is secure can you prove it so
it runs a script that analyzes your ec2
instance then generates a pdf report
telling you which security checks had
passed
so the idea here is it's an auto tool
for security of ec2 instances so there
you go
[Music]
so let's compare elb versus alb versus
nlb versus jwlb versus clb uh because
you know when i was first learning aws i
was getting confused because there was
elastic load balancer but there was
these other ones so
what gives right so what's happening
here is that there is a main service
called elastic load balancer elb and it
has four different types
of possible load balancers so we'll go
through all the types so the first is
application load bouncer commonly uh
initializes alb and so this operates on
layer seven for https so this makes
sense because that is the application
layer and it has some special powers in
terms of routing rules so the idea here
is you can create rules to change
routing based on information found
within the https request so let's say
you wanted some
routes to go that have a particular
subdomain to this server and a different
subdomain to another one you could do
that
and because it is an application load
bouncer you can attach a web application
firewall for protection you can't attach
this on the nlb or other ones because
they're not application based so that is
just a little caveat there
then you have network load bouncer uh
commonly abbreviated to nlb this
operates on layer three and four so
we're talking tcp udp this is great for
when you have extreme performance that
requires tcp and tls traffic it's
capable of handling millions of requests
per seconds
while maintaining ultra low latency it's
optimized for sudden and volatile
traffic patterns while using a single
static ip address per availability zone
if you're making video games this is
what they like to use is the network
load balancer but it has other utilities
outside of that then you have gateway
load bouncer gwlb this is where you need
to deploy a fleet of third-party virtual
appliances that support uh i don't know
how to say that in abbreviation but i'll
just say it's
g-e-n-e-v-e
um and there's not much we need to know
outside of that okay then there is the
classic load bouncer uh commonly
initializes clb this operates on layer
three four and seven it's intended for
applications that were built within the
ec2 classic network it doesn't support
target groups so albs at nlbs
use target groups which is just an
easier way of grouping together
a bunch of
targeted resources like compute
that we're going to load balance to and
with classic load balancer you just
directly assign ec2 instances
and it's going to be retired on august
15th of 2022 so yeah it looks like it
can do a lot of stuff but it also
doesn't have any of the superpowers of
these specialized ones and so
there's no reason to keep it around and
generally you should not be using it
and so yeah that's about it